in this complete angular course for
beginners you will first learn the
basics of typescript and then you will
learn how to use angular you will learn
about important angular concepts such as
binding dependency injection forms
routing and more
suntash is your instructor for this
course he is a google developer expert
for angular a github star and an active
contributor to both angular and ngrx so
he is the perfect person to teach you
angular hi welcome to this course on
angular getting started in this video we
are going to introduce angular so we
will talk about what is angular we will
talk about framework versus libraries
and at the end we will see some of the
features of angular so we'll see a tiny
to-do app and we'll go through some
features
so let's go through what is angular
which is really important before you go
ahead and choose angular as your
framework so angular is actually a ui
framework built by google and it is
actively maintained by a team with uh
within google which is the angular team
and uh it has like around 30 members who
are actively working on it
angular
had a previous version so uh there are
some confusion regarding that so let me
just clear it
there was a framework called angularjs i
am saying pause because it will just
reach its end of life it was created
back in 2009
and it was created using javascript so
it was a pure javascript framework
around 2014 angular team decided that
they will be rewriting the framework and
they'll be creating a new framework they
initially named it as angular v
angular
v 2.0 but later they decided to drop
that v 2.0 they said
it's angular so we have angularjs and
now we have we had
angularjs and now we have angular that's
it and every so after uh the initial
release of angular they decided to set a
set uh set a release cycle for the
framework so every six months there
there will be some new additions
new feature requests new enhancements
some bug fixes which will be released so
it happens every six months at the time
of recording this video
angular version 13 just released so
if you are wondering we will be using
v13 for this particular course no
because we want the stable version so we
will be going with angular v12 but at
the end we can actually
provide a video which will
walk you through how you can upgrade
from angular v12 to v13 so that will be
covered
so that's about the framework and one
important thing
when the team angular team decided to
rewrite the framework they chose
typescript as the language to rewrite
the framework we will go through uh
typescript in upcoming videos so we'll
not talk more about it here
what else so angular is a component
based framework for building scalable
apps so it's
almost first choice for all the
enterprise applications because they
want to release faster which you will
see in this course once we start
implementing new features you will see
how
uh
first we can actually do and deliver
things so that's why it has been the
number one choice so if you're thinking
about what's component of course we are
going to talk about component there will
be an entire section which will talk
about it but
just let me tell you a little bit about
what component based is so you use lot
of websites in your daily life so you
might have visited let's say if you were
trying to learn angular you might have
visited angular dot io or let's say you
use facebook twitter every day
so if i have to tell you what components
are on those websites so you might have
seen there is a sidebar there is a
header there is a footer and there are
some content areas right so for example
in facebook you will see cards on
twitter it's like totally different so
those are small components which we
talked about and all the frameworks
which are out there for example react
vuja angular they're all component based
so you can create components and then
you can build small small components and
attach them together and build your
application
angular being a framework it provides
you set of libraries and uh it has a lot
of features included as part of
framework so you have routing you have
forms you have pwas uh which
and uh many more right so you have
data binding so we'll we'll talk about
those features
let's talk about framework versus
libraries
what is framework so frameworks
generally condensed set of libraries so
what i mean by that
you might have used for example in case
you have never used it that's absolutely
fine but in case you have used some
technologies like java.net in past
you may have seen we use something
called using or we do something called
import in java so what you do we
actually require or in case you have
written lets you know node.js code you
may have seen require or now
the latest version support dsm so you
might have used import so what we do
right we actually import some libraries
so
if i talk about frameworks those
libraries are part of your framework
itself for example in.net so all the
namespaces you which you import or you
use are part of the framework itself you
don't go outside similarly in angular
framework also you have a lot of
features for example
i spoke about routing forms those are
part of the framework so you can just
import it with from the framework itself
you can extend the framework of course
uh you can build something on top of
your framework
linux dev tools is a good example uh you
have ionic framework also which uses uh
some of the features provided by angular
uh so as we said there are some some
examples of labels are you have
angular.net you have java you have any
express
js so those are some examples
now let's talk about libraries
so libraries when we talk about
libraries which we talk about some
specific functionality for example let's
say if i have to use uh low dash right
so which is a really good uh
uh blackberry out there so what low dash
contains low dash contains a lot of
utilities function which you can use uh
to
uh avoid a lot of code in your in your
existing code face right so if i have to
let's compare to
objects i can just uh import something
or use something from load as rather
than adding my own so you can actually
combine multiple libraries for example
let's let me take an example of react in
case you
know about react right sorry in case you
want to create an application using
react so what you will do you will take
react you will take react router you
will take for
some some of the form library which is
available which suits your uh
requirements so you will combine all
those libraries and build your
application that's what you do
so that's that's libraries so some
examples of course react moment js
in moment.js has been deprecated but
yeah it's a date time library now you
can use late fns which is a replacement
for moment.js and you have low dash
let's talk about some of the features
which is available we are not actually
going to go into detail because we are
going to go into more detail in the
upcoming videos so uh there are a few
features which is provided bangalore for
example it has its own template engine
uh it provides your data binding so you
can find the data
on your front end it has forms routing
it provides you observables which is
which is actually another library but uh
heavily used inside angular and pws
right so let's see an app
so it's a small to-do app don't worry
about the command as of now
so i'll start this to-do app and we will
see some of the features in action
so here is our to-do app so
you can see i'm whenever i click on this
urls i'm actually being redirected to
another url so this is routing so this
is routing functionality you can see
this is a form where i can input some
values so let's add
a
bills
as a task
or
by
groceries
as another task
so these are two tasks which i've added
now i can also mark this task as
complete so and then i can go to
completed task and see what are the
tasks which are which has been completed
so what we have seen here is you have
data binding functionality you have
forms you have routing
let me show you pwa as well because
it's being
talked about a lot
and
let's see what actually pw is so
whenever you visit some website you
might have seen this symbol which says
install app this is pwa functionality so
what you can do is you can install your
website as a native app it will behave
like a native app in case you install it
on your mobile in case i install it on
desktop it will behave like a desktop
app so that's that's about bwm
so that's it from this particular video
and
we'll
move to the next video now
hi in this video we will talk about
typescript
as we said in previous video while
introducing angular that typescript is a
language in which the entire framework
is written and we need to write our code
in typescript as well so we are going to
go through of course we will introduce
you to typescript we'll talk about some
basics i mean how
the language came and who invented it
and then we will talk about why should
you learn typescript of course the one
reason being you have to write your
angular code
using typescript but yes there is more
then we'll talk about type safety and at
the end we will see
uh we'll install typescript and then
we'll also write our first code and
we'll execute that code so let's go
ahead and get started
so what is that what is the typescript
right so let's
talk about that first so it's a strongly
typed programming language
now you might be wondering what is
strongly typed programming language so
in case you are new to typescript just
hang on we will be talking about it in
more detail but in case you are coming
from
languages like java.net or in case you
learned java.net in past so you might
have seen that whenever you declare a
variable you say okay it is integer it
is a string
it means you are already defining or you
are telling the program that okay this
is the data type of
this particular variable and
it should only hold the value of that
particular data type that's what types
of days
and it is created and maintained by
microsoft so initially a lot of people a
lot of new developers thought that it is
created by google which is totally which
is wrong of course because uh
as angular was the first to adopt
typescript that that's why people think
about uh
or thought about that
it is created by google but it is not so
it is created by microsoft back in 2011
and i think around 11 around 12 there
was some
public release which which was available
but it didn't got so much recognition
until unless google team decided that
they will be writing their new framework
which is known as angular v 2.0 that as
we uh learned about in previous video
that they will be rewriting the entire
framework in typescript and then people
started
talking about typescript and now
typescript also has many uh versions
right right now i think the version 4 is
there the major version but i think
minor version is 4.4.4 so we'll see that
i mean we'll of course learn typescript
before we move into angular that's the
whole idea about this particular section
that where you will learn about
typescript you will write your first
program and
we'll learn more about it
it's a superset of javascript so let's
talk about this
thing uh before i i'm sure before coming
to angular in case you have written uh
your front-end code you might have used
javascript and you might be wondering
where is javascript and why why should
uh we use typescript
so you don't have to worry about it so
most of the content com concepts which
you have learned
is actually same because if you see this
diagram it says okay javascript is
nothing but
it's a subset of typescript so
uh every javascript program which you
have written so far is a valid
typescript program
and um you can actually go ahead and
convert them to typescript by just
renaming the file most of the cases it
will work without any issue and then
some type safety issues that's it but it
should work
so let's
see what happens what uh
why typescript right so why should be
using typescript so as we mentioned it's
a it's superset right it's a super set
of javascript so
almost uh learning curve is very much
smaller it compiles down to javascript
now this is this might be something
which is confusing to you so we are
saying that okay typescript is superset
of javascript and then it compiles back
to javascript yes that's the whole idea
so
script only provide your type safety so
once you write your program most of the
time what you see whenever you write a
program or you write a code in
javascript there is no type safety i
mean we will talk about time safety com
uh which will be coming up but yeah so
the whole idea is to provide time safety
to your program which will be compiled
down to javascript by using which
once you
actually run your program or you compile
your program you get all those errors
related to type
in your bra in your let's say in your
development environment we before going
to production that's a good idea it
keeps your code work evergreen now what
we mean by keeping your code evergreen
there are many version of javascript in
case you are not aware the es5 was there
for a long time
es5
is supported by most of the browser even
including i11 and older browsers now
with latest browsers we have es6 or es
but that that's not it right so the uh
the thing is it's going on the the
development is going on the features are
being added tc39 is the community which
finalizes all the features which will be
added into javascript and
all the browsers implemented so yes uh
2015 is 2016 17 18 19 20 and then you
will find 21 20 and then next those are
the versions so that it's named by year
and then next is of course all those
experimental features
but in case i want to i have written a
code which now as of now uh works with
es2015 and all the browser support most
of the browsers support es2015 nowadays
all the modern browsers
now let's say all the browsers started
supporting is 2016. if i have written a
code using esp2e using javascript what i
have to do is i have to actually go
ahead and adopt to the new features
right or new syntax but using typescript
you don't have to you can just say okay
compile down this javascript or compile
this javascript to es2016 and then you
are done that's it
that's what i mean by keeping your code
evergreen it is supported by all the
major frameworks and libraries
all the javascript
code or all the javascript libraries you
which you will find on nvm they do have
something called types
if they are not written in typescript or
most of them are actually written by
script written in typescript
so of course here you can see react
loves typescript react is one framework
which is oh sorry one library which is
not written in typescript they use
something called flow and but you can
write your code so now a lot of react
developers are adopting typescript and
writing their code in typescript angular
written in typescript
who
the new version which is vo3 actually is
rewritten in typescript so yep all the
major frameworks supports even you can
write your back-end code using
typescript so express.js you have nesjs
and all those frameworks can be written
in typescript
coming back times type safety so what is
type safety
in case uh you have written your
javascript code in past you might be
familiar with one error which we get a
lot
undefined cannot find or cannot read
something or undefined
or probably null errors
why that happens because
there is no types right i mean we you
don't define that okay this particular
variable will be integer and it will
have a default value of something let's
say 0
or it's a string and default value will
be let's blank you don't do that you
don't do that in javascript
and when we don't do that do that
and we write try to compile our code in
our browser and we try to access those
properties or let's say access those
variables and we try to access the
properties of that variable
what will happen in case there is
nothing no value is defined or no value
is assigned or there is no data type of
course you will get an error
but in case i can get those errors the
undefined and null the
most widely uh introduce error or
most widely seen error in your
javascript code while compiling your
code
what i mean by compiling your code
nowadays you have lot of compilers which
is available
type
typescript also comes with its own
compiler so it's known as csc
so
what if we can do is we can capture
those errors during compilation time
that's that's what type safety does for
you
languages like c sharp and java they are
they have been doing from a long time
but
now types type script is trying to solve
that problem while writing your
front-end code or as i said you can also
you use it for your back-end because of
course thanks to node.js you can run
your javascript code anywhere browsers
uh you can run on your os
windows local machines right
it's uh
but one thing
[Music]
now
as we said typescript will be compiled
down to javascript
you cannot run typescript code directly
into the browser that's not possible uh
typescript code
is something which is just for your
purpose for development purpose
and it will give you the output of
javascript code right so once you get
javascript code you can go ahead and
execute in browser your browsers cannot
understand typescript there is a new
runtime environment called deno uh which
supports typescript you can write your
typescript code and you don't have to
actually compile it down to javascript
it will just run
we will see some code where we will talk
about type safety but before that
let's go ahead and create our first
program and see how we can run create
sorry create and compile our first types
of code back to javascript code
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
create a new folder uh which we which i
will name it as typescript demo
and we will keep the entire board which
is related to typescript in this
particular folder and this code will be
shared with you so
you can either
just follow the video or follow the code
write the code by yourself or you can
download the code and play around it
that's up to you how you prefer so let's
create a
new folder
so i'm using vs code
uh as my editor you can use whatever you
want to but the preferred ps code i
think it uh
i mean it is available for all the all
the os
let me show you the link from where you
can download it so you can just go to
google and
type vs code
and
code.visualstudio.com you can go ahead
and download the latest version which is
available right now i'm using windows
and it gets automatically updated so i
don't have to download it again but in
case you are using other browsers just
go to other platforms and
install it
so now our
folder or our workspace is available so
let's follow the steps to create our
first program
so what we need is we first need to
install node node is required
in case you have already installed mode
just go ahead and verify the version we
are going to use a node above 14 because
that's what is supported by the angular
latest version angular 12 and 13 also
supports node 16 but as i said i'm not
going to use node sorry angular 13 as of
now
so let's install or just first check the
version so
i'll use windows terminal
to verify the version which you have
installed you can just say note icon v
it will give you the latest version my
latest version is 14.15.5 which is okay
because i want to use angular 12 and it
supports it
in case you don't have node installed
doing it for first time so you can go to
node.js.org
and uh you can see latest table version
is 16.13 as i said and you can download
it as per your os by default it is
giving me windows option because i'm
using windows but in case you have mac
os or linux it will probably prompt you
with that particular setup
okay so once uh you have installed node
let's see what we have to do so you
need to do npm in it to create a
package.json file uh we will talk about
a little bit about package.com later and
then we have to install typescript and
then we need
some uh dna to initialize typescript so
let's talk about the steps
so this is my terminal and uh now first
thing which we wanted to do is we wanted
to create a package.json file so which
is npm init this is the command and it
will ask you a few questions you can
just
press enter and move on we just wanted
a few things which is like name and
version that's it and main index.js is
fine
so this once we have this package.json
file now we need to install typescript
so this package.json file
will keep track of all the packages
which you use
and which is installed in your uh
workspace
so that's why we we are going to use
this package.json this package.json is
really important file because once you
publish your code on npm uh npm actually
uses all the information from this
particular file what are the packages
you depend upon what is your name what
is the name of that package what is the
version of that package so everything is
actually taken from here
so now we have our
uh file we have our package resistance
file now
uninstall typescript so i'm going to run
this command npm installed
type
script and it will probably give us
probably let's see 4.4.4 yes as i said
that's the
exact question which is available right
now
and now it gives you node modules folder
this is where all the packages which you
installed
will be kept
nothing which you should check in
so
this is only for your development
purpose
now we have our typescript installed we
uh have our package.json file we need
typescript configuration files so we
need to run dsc
let's see what has double hyphen get
so we have to do tsc iphone in it iphone
fm internet and you will get a file
called dsconfig.json really important
file this is the configuration file
which remember i spoke about you need to
change your version and then you can
compile your javascript to es 2016 and
2015 that's the file so this is where
all the magic happens right
so uh right now we are going to just
talk about the first two properties
which is target and module
so target by default is es5 es5 is as i
said the javascript version which is
supported by all the browser all the
modern browsers though they support
es2015 so i'm going to change it to
years 2015.
module is something which tell which is
for where you want to actually run your
code with whether you want to run it on
browser whether you want to run it on
your
os or your command prompt or from your
machine local machine so sorry not local
machine but yeah on your uh os not on
browser so
common js we are not going to
we will let it be common js right now in
angular you will see
it will use es next which is of course
for browsers
so that's it so i changed my target to
use 2015 and module just kept it common
js there are few more properties which
we will discuss about later on
now let's write our first file so
i'm going to create a file i'll name it
as data types dot ts
right so all the typescript files will
have extension dot yes but before we do
that let's create a
js file and see what's the problem i
mean why there is no type safety so in
typescript sorry in javascript whenever
you declare a variable what you do so
you do let let's say
i want to create a variable called fnm
and probably you will be saying okay
this is
test right
but
javascript also allows this
so as you can see actually i declared a
variable called f name and then assigned
a value a number it works doesn't give
you any issues
but it causes a lot of issues once we
once we have hundreds of lines of code
and
now
we lost the track okay what was the
variable type and then we tried to read
or let's say use some function which is
actually for a string but the values
number what will happen of course it
will give you some errors that's that's
what the problem is
now let's go to typescript so i'll
create
a variable
i'll call it as a name
and let's
say it is sean
which is not last name welcome
and now try to give it us the numeric
value
so in typescript it will give you an
error it will say okay this type number
is not assignable to typestring because
of course i mean this is uh you file
initializing the variable you said okay
this is string
and how this is happening uh we will
talk about it i mean
we are not if you see we are not giving
any data type but somehow it is saying
okay this type of string so we'll talk
about that as well but yeah this is just
to introduce you that okay this is what
type safety is i'll recommend this out
and see how to compile this code
so here uh
what we will do is
uh typescript comes with its own
compiler.tsc so run tsc
now once you do tsc it will compile down
this code to javascript code so it will
create another file with same name so
you can see its name
types.js and almost it contains the same
wood but i mean it's a js file so this
this is the output which is generated
but we will be doing a few more things
with are this data.ts5 this
code was just to introduce you how you
can compile your code and how you can
write your typescript code and how you
can get the es25 es2515 version as your
output or javascript version as your
output so that's it from
this video and we'll move on to the next
video now
in this video we are going to talk about
single page applications
i am sure in case you are
going through some job requirement or
you are going through some
development uh using new frameworks they
all support single page applications
right so it's it's one of the widely
used word nowadays in technology so
every framework all the major framework
which we have they support sp
so let's see what we are going to do in
this video so we will be talking about
what is pa and we will also talk about
how angular actually helps you to build
single page applications
so
as i mentioned spa stands for single
page application and all the modern
frameworks angular java you are sorry
angular java and react
and vujs so all those frameworks
supports creating single page
applications
so what's the difference
so in older days whenever we used to
create a web page we used to create
multiple pages for each and every view
the problem is of course we are actually
rewriting most of the htmls we cannot
reuse
and
another thing was whenever we used to
switch between the urls for example
let's say you have page called about
this you have page about home or home
page so what used to happen is there
used to be page refresh
the reason was
whenever you click on a url the entire
compilation of that code used to happen
on server side so it's like i'll give an
example of a spx pages which were like
uh
which will uh which were used long back
and it was created by dominant framework
or dot using.net framework so we used to
create aspects pages where like uh for
each url we will be creating each page
and whenever you click on a page it
request goes to server server will
identify okay this is the page which is
which is requested and then it will
compile down all the pages and then it
will give you the html then
a lot of developers thought okay i think
this is not the most efficient way what
we can do is we can just give the static
pages as it is
rather than actually compiling
everything on servers we can actually
send all the resources to the client
browser and then
it can render it
no compilation needed so that's where
others how spa came into picture so in
spa what will happen is all the
resources actually to render everything
will be sent on browser's machine or on
your clients browser machine and that's
it that's the only request will have
which will happen and whenever there is
some page uh data which is which will be
requested for example if you have some
apis
to get the data from there will be a
request but it will not reload the
entire page that's the difference in
spm even though i have multiple urls
in
frameworks like react or angular or vu
it will be like
a bunch of javascript code which will be
required to re-render something so in
case let's say i have form i have a
powders and i click on about us
so some javascript code which is already
which will be rather either downloaded
or which is already present
will just go ahead and change that
particular view so it will render
whatever information is required on that
particular view so that's that's how spa
works
how angular helps so angular has its own
routing routing engine so whenever you
click on some urls angular knows which
view to render and that's how it happens
angular has its own library called
angular slash router which we will learn
about and see how it how you can
actually do everything you can
request for url you can create your
multiple urls friendly urls i would say
or html5 urls now which is used
and then angular also offers ssr server
side rendering yes it's available but
again it's not like the older days where
the request goes to server and then
there is a full reload which will never
happen so it's not the full reload which
happens but here angular will actually
go to server and then compile and it
will give you
whatever data which is required with the
entire page so it's not like
the difference between ssr and spa is
ssr is good for seo search engine
optimization in case you
for you your focus is more on seo
go for ssr or there are other
tools available to
create your static pages for example
there is something called skully which
you can also use
so this is it from spa and now
let's move on to the next
so before we go ahead and learn about
of course typescript in angular we need
some software to be installed so what we
are going to need is we are
so what we are going to need is we are
going to need nodejs and we are going to
need an editor
editor is your choice i am going to show
you how you can install vs code and i
use vsco personally
so lets go ahead and
so before we go ahead and uh
start learning about typescript and
angular we are going to need some
softwares to be installed and that's
what we are going to do in this
particular video
we are going to need vs code and we are
going to need node.js as well
so uh
editor is your choice vs code is the
editor which we are going to use but we
node.js is mandatory
and you can use any editor of your
choice apart from vs visual studio don't
use visual studio because it's it's like
heavyweight and
it has a lot of things right which we
don't need generally so
what we are going to do is let's go
ahead and install node.js and then we
will see how we can use install uh how
we can install vs uh code
or uh
and if you prefer any other reader
please feel free to install that
particular so let's go ahead and see
node.js first
to install node.js you have to visit
this site called node.js rg and there
are always two versions which are
available so you have lts which is long
term support and you have current
current is where you have some uh
experimenting features which probably
you never need so don't install current
because in case you are using it for
development
there may be some breaking changes
so we will go with the latest stable
version
uh
which is 16.13.0 so it says okay this is
lts long term support and
let's see first how you can
so let's uh open a command prompt and we
will see how we can actually
verify which version of node.js is
installed in on our machine and then we
will go ahead and install the latest
latest version so i actually updated uh
node.js two days ago for my
laptop so we will see the latest version
which is available is 16.13.0
but let's go ahead and install it
anyways
so i'll just download the setup
so uh let's start the wizard and uh
right now as i have already have 16.13.0
available it is saying do you want to
change
or do you want to repair or do you want
to remove so i click on change and i
will change nothing so that's that's
what we are going to do right now so you
have a node.js runtime which is required
we need a node npm package manager we
will talk about npm in few seconds and
of course i need all the other features
so i'll just click on
next
automatically install necessary tools if
this is something which if you are
probably installing it for first time go
ahead and do it but i'm
going to skip it right now so let's go
insta uh click next and
it is asking me if uh
okay so it is asking me to allow to
change change
on my application which is okay
and this is it finish right so in case
you get some error
just let us know uh we will try to help
or uh
you may find some
widely asked questions on step off
in case something goes wrong now next
thing which we need is npm
why npm npm is a node package manager
which will be used to install any
packages which will be required for you
so we are going to use it for to install
typescript we will also see npm being
used uh to install angular clm and we
will also see npm being used when we
want to install any other packages
in case we are coming from dotnet or
java background in
dot net you already have some you have
already have something called nougat
which is the package manager in uh
java or mobile world you have maven to
install packages
so it's similar so the only thing is
no npm comes by default with node so you
don't have to install anything you don't
have to install it separately earlier in
older days node.js and pm were two
different things but
people started using so much that node
just decided to make it as part of the
node build itself so you don't need to
install again there are a few other
package managers available uh which may
you uh which you may use in your day to
work day to day work in future so you
have
uh yarn and you also have pnpm so those
are two other package managers which is
which you can use
npm as i said is already installed so
you can see npm hyphen v which is 8.1.0
right now
and
how to use it we will of course feed
while installing type
the next thing which we need is uh we
need editor as i mentioned you can use
anything any editor you want but we are
going to see vs code
so i'll search for vs code
and this is the website and you can see
there are
multiple version for mac os windows
linux you have unstable and insiders and
you may ask okay what is insiders so
insiders is something where uh vs4 team
may give you some access access or some
beta releases some features which is not
still available for everyone and that's
what insiders is recently windows 11 was
launched
for insider's program first and then it
was launched for general purpose so
stable is that's what general purpose is
i mean you can go ahead and install and
uh you don't have you get access to any
beta features but it's okay right i mean
uh probably you will be using it in
product uh day-to-day development if
you're comfortable going any use
insiders otherwise stable is fine we
will be using stable
and
to update visual studio code you don't
have to actually do it manually uh it's
it gets updated in background so when
once you install it that's it that's the
only thing which you need to install and
then it will be updated in background
regularly whenever there is a new
release
so let's go ahead and download the
stable version as of now
so it says the current version is 1.62.2
so let's see
and in case we you want to use visual
studio i think visual studio 2022 will
be available soon but
as i said i don't use it so it's really
happy
you can use webstorm
or any other editors which you like so
let's see so i'll say accept agreement
and create desktop icon i'll just click
on all
and let's go ahead and install i already
have the latest version available i'm
just doing it to show how to install it
and again in case you get some issues
while installing vs code
generally uh the problem which you get
during installation is related to the
access so make sure that you are running
all the setups as an administrator just
to avoid error in case you still get
some error just let us know we will try
to help as much possible uh and before
you uh
like wait for the response just check it
on stack or for flow as well probably
you will get your solution there and
that's it so let's launch visual studio
code and we are done so in
in upcoming videos we will be using vs
code for all the code which we'll try
previous video we saw how you can create
your first file how you can use tsc
typescript compiler now let's talk about
data types so whenever you start
learning any new programming language
you learn about data types i mean how
what are different data types it has and
how to work with those so that's what we
are going to do now
so in day types we will talk about
data types we will talk about uh
inference type inference which is really
important we will also talk about union
and intersection types we will talk
about generics and literal types
so let's start with data so
as we said typescript is a typed
programming language and so it has lot
of data types which is available and we
will go through each one by one
and
let's go ahead and do that so we already
have our program our workspace ready and
the first stereotype which we are going
to
talk about is string
[Music]
so if you remember this code from the
previous video we already declared
something called lname and then we said
equals to john which is a string value
but how
actually typescript knows that okay this
is string
we'll come to that but let's uh so let's
let's uh
so we'll talk about that i mean how
angular sorry how your typescript knows
that okay this type of string and this
is where type inference come into
picture
typescript has the ability to determine
the type from the value which is being
assigned
it's amazing right i mean you probably
don't need to define the a type because
typescript can actually guess it for you
but don't try to do that i would suggest
always use the type
because sometimes sometimes it gets it
wrong when you are writing complex code
and it may give you some
data which is
not you want so here
that's time difference so it can
actually determine the data from its uh
the value which is assigned so here it's
a string so it is saying okay its type
of string which is
okay
but in case you have to declare a new
variable
this is what you will be doing most of
the time so you will say okay this is
last name which is type of string
and then you can assign a string value
to this
so it's my name
[Music]
last name
and then
the advantage is now i can actually if
you say l name dot
generally you don't get all the methods
in case you're writing a javascript code
and just declare a variable and press
dot you will get list of functions for
sure
but it doesn't give you that okay this
is only string function or numeric
function it doesn't give you that
here all the functions which you can see
are actually
uh can be applied on string that's it so
you have to upper string to string
so let's say if i do two upper string
right and i'll say let
new
name
equals to and name dot uppercase so i'm
just updating or
i'm updating the name to uppercase and
now let's do console.log and see the
output of this particular
value
now
here you know type
script compiler tsc can be used to
convert or typescript the tsc compiler
can be used to convert or compile your
file to javascript code
but how you will run it so we will be
using node but there's something called
ts node which you can also use but we
are going to use tsc and node so let's
see so we'll run dsc first which will
compile this code to javascript which is
right data.js and you can see your code
available here and now i can just say
node and
data
and you can see okay uh
the uppercase function was applied to
this value and then you have this output
so you are running this locally because
we are able to run this on my command
prompt because i am using node as i said
node can be used to run your code on
your local machine you don't have to
actually run the javascript in browser
so this is string i mean
let's see uh the
the next attempt
so
it also has something known as number
so let's talk about numbers so whenever
you have some numeric value to a sign
quite unused number for example let's
say let h
equals to
let's say 20 right
but
you can you can do this because of type
inference thing but in case you have to
create a variable and you don't have a
default value you can say type colon
number uh sorry not
not the and capital but yeah lower so
you can see it says okay now you have
let age
ah okay i'm writing code in javascript
file
my bad
and you can see i can say let age which
is type of number and now i can say h
is equals to
25 let's which is a value numeric value
but if i say age is equals to
25 it will give me an exception it will
say okay this is
string but i am expecting number so yeah
this is something which you can do you
can also do uh decimal numbers so in
case you have like
uh
decimal numbers you can say 25.5 that's
also applicable
that's uh and you here right so you can
see h dot so you can see you will be
only able to see the function which can
be applied on number so you have to fix
to precision but what in case let's say
you want to type cast which happens
right sometimes so yes that's that's
possible as well so i can say let the
result
uh equals to
so let's say if you want to you have a
numeric string value and you want to
pass it to in this is a normal
javascript function this is something
which is not coming from typescript yep
this is something which is available in
your
javascript as well so you can say pass
it and uh
string value and it will work so let's
uh create
select
dob equals to
25 right so it's
it infers the value so i don't have to
do anything so it says it's a string and
then you can pass this string here
and using percent you can convert it to
number and let's see the magic here so
it says result will be type of number
because as i said due to time type
inference functionality type script
knows what what will be the return type
so person returns a number and that's
what out that's what the output is
we will see some uh
fun i mean we will see functions as well
where we will of course try to play with
uh these relatives
and let's see the next so
after seeing bull a number there is
boolean as well which is available in
almost um
in most of the programming languages so
let's talk about boolean so boolean is
something which can hold true and false
values right this is what we know
this causes a lot of confusion when we
come from a type safe language like
dotnet or java
it i was actually i got into a lot of
issues initially when we started with
typescript because i was coming from a
document background let's see why
so in java or dotnet whenever you say
boolean it has a default value
it's false
right so let's see
sensitive is
valid
which is type of boolean
and in our types of language like dotnet
and java we have habit of doing this is
valid of type boolean because we know it
will return the default value as false
but let's see what happens here
i am going to do console.log
result
and uh
not result is valid sorry
and you can see here there is one
error so it says variable is valid is
used before being assigned
it is telling you that okay this value
is not assigned and it is just giving
you a quick warning here but let's see
let's see what happens when we run the
board so i'll say tse
it will uh
of course bring this warning here error
this uh this error sorry it will print
this error here as well and why i will
just come back to that in a second but
let's run the node and data
and you will see you will get the value
as undefined
so where is the default value going so
actually
just let's go back to uh earlier video
where we said
that java type script will be compiled
down to just
javascript doesn't know anything about
times
so if i go to
typescript.js you will see
is valid that's it and
if you write this code in javascript
it's it will be undefined because you
have not assigned any value
that was the error which is printed here
so it says it's not assigned so of
course it was expecting that it will
fail you have you are trying to access a
variable but you have not assigned the
value so it will be undefined why we are
getting this error because of t is
config and there is a property called
strict true
so if you keep this in if you use a
district mode by default which which is
by default
you cannot or you you can but you will
get an error if you try to access any
variable which is not defined
so while working with typescript keep
district more true so it's like uh it
enables all strict type checking options
so you can see it says enable alt
type checking option we will discuss
about few of this
stick type modes but right now let's go
with
the strict mode i mean where all the
strict strict options are enabled so
yeah that's why it was giving enough so
whenever you are working in boolean make
sure you define the default value so
either true or false whatever you refer
i mean whatever
fits of course into your workflow or in
your code so use default value false
order and now you can see the error is
gone itself
so you might have seen one more
advantage that you don't have to
actually most of the time run the code
you can actually see this types uh type
related error inside your terminal
itself so it saves a lot of time during
the development
now
let's talk about the other day type
which is ally again i will uh um
go back and refer for example.net.java
where you have
list types available right so you have
list
which is available in type in java's
java as well as starting
in javascript world we use aries and
generally we do something like this so
let's say if you have
emp
list this equals to this
this is generally
how your array looks like in javascript
so here if you see the type so let's say
it says any of array what is any so if
you see here in the database list
there is any as well so we are going to
talk about any let's
come back to that later
let's talk about arrays so in
typescript you can declare a
as
as an array of some data so you can say
string l for example if i just want all
the values
sorry
or i want this array to only hold the
values of type string what i can do is i
can say string and then box
there there is another syntax which is
available as well so i can say let
i can say department list
which is you can also use this syntax
which is known as array and then you can
use this rectangle boxes this is known
as
generics so that we will also talk about
generics in uh
[Music]
we will also talk about generics but as
of now let's just see the syntax so yeah
these are two ways in which you can
define an array
feel free to use any one so it's same
because once it is compiled down to
javascript you don't you will not have
this particular type slider because it
will be removed
and then uh let's see i can say emp list
is equals to i can create some arrays
and i can have string right so if i try
to add a number
you will see uh i have we have an error
so it says number is not assignable to
type string so yep this is string array
and let's change this to
numbers list
and we can say number of array of
numbers
right so i can just hold numbers
here uh let's create a number list
equals one two three four five these are
five numbers
there are few functions which you can
apply i will i will talk about few
functions as of now and then we will
talk about few functions when we talk
about interfaces because um
you can do lot uh while uh with
interfaces so here you can see num list
so let's try to use some function right
which we generally use in javascript
so here let's try to filter all the
values which is greater than 2
so i can say let result
is equals to i can say num list i'm not
using my i'm not going to use map but
i'm going to use some
function called filter
okay so this filter function by using
this filter function i can say okay each
number
i'm accessing each number and then i
will say
num
is greater than 2
and
this is closing
so let's see uh here i think result is
already declared above that's why it is
giving me errors so i can say results
and i think this is extra
so now here let's see the output so it
says okay result will be number of array
so this filter function which is of
course coming from javascript is same
it here what we are doing is we are
filtering all the values within this
array where number is greater than two
so if i print this output i can say okay
the system is so
dot log results
and let's compile using type compiler
and then run node
you can see we have output 345
also we can
use few more so i can say results
is equals to i can let's use some other
function
and
find let's use find
so i want to find a
number which is equals to
okay
so here is a catch
so if you see this results it was
expecting a number of array here if you
see this it says number or undefined
because uh find method returns only one
value so
it doesn't return an array so just
that's why we are getting that error
because array it was array and then we
cannot assign it number so that's not
possible so i can just
print console.log number and you will
see that we will get the number i mean
of course number two number equals to
two which exists so
let's see we have pse and then
[Music]
node
so of course two is available in the
array and we get that output so this is
fine you can also use find function in
case you are trying to find a single
value for example let's say uh
this
in employee right so i think that's
that's the best use case where i can say
uh
if this employee exists or not right i
want to find that particular that
particular employee
so i can say emp list
dot find then i can say emp and then
equals to
emp
goes to this and then select
and then we can the node and then we
found that particular value so
this is how you can use find you can
also use i let me show you in simple
example of sorry let me uh let me show
you another example of reduce function
which you may have uh heard about a lot
in javascript with how you can use it so
i'll use it to calculate the sum of
number list
let's see so i'll say let's sum
is equals to
you can see i mean if you can see this
magic which is happening here this is
something because of github copilot
which is a product by github and right
now it is in beta and
you can apply for vert list
so you can also use it so it says num
list dot reduce so this is reduce
function and here is accumulator and the
number
the way it works is it will calculate
the sum
till it reaches the end of the array so
let's see and i'll just do console.log
some
so the output should be one plus two
which is three then three plus three six
six plus four four six plus four ten and
ten plus y fifteen so let's see if i'm
right i mean if i'm good at map or not
so let's go to node and fifteen oh yeah
so i am good at maths
just kidding it's a simple math so yeah
so this is how you can use reduce
function uh to actually go through
entire
number
uh this is reduces really useful in case
you have area of some
object and then you want to calculate
let's say
you have products right and then you
want to calculate the sum of your card
you can use reduce
so these are few functions and we as we
said we will come back to the areas when
we talk about interfaces so let's
move on and let's talk about the other
area type which we have this is xenon uh
enums are really um
[Music]
handy
and it is available in most of the
programming languages which we use let's
see how you can actually use those so
here you can use enum and i'll take a
classic example of color so let's say i
have a enum
color and then i what i need is red
green blue so
red green
blue
so let's say you have some um
probably design system where you want to
restrict the
colors which your team can use what you
can do
of course you can give them the list of
colors that okay these are the colors
which can be used what in case you can
give them a typed list
of course this is enums right so you can
give them enums and you can say okay
these are the these are the colors which
can be used so let's say if i want to
create a new color so i can say c which
is type of color and then i can choose
color
dot
and i can say okay which color i want
green blue or red so this is how you can
use enums
let me show you a magic
as a as we said right as sorry as i said
in previous video that whenever you
compiled on your typescript
this
types are actually removed they are not
used that's only until you write the
code and with enums in most of the cases
you are not going to use enums on
production i mean once your code is
compiled you won't need
this
enums
but let me show you what happens when
you do dsc
so this
how many six lines of code is actually
generated for that you know
but on production i what i need is this
line
i don't need to know about this
because of course i cannot change this
value once in production right once my
bundle uh once my code is compiled
so
how to uh how to take care of it
typescript allows you to declare enums
as const
and
this const will do the magic so let's
see what happens
that's it c equals 2 that's it this is
the code which will be available on your
production so
what this cost will do is it will just
stream down everything it will remove
all the information because uh if you
see enums enums actually have an index
value so you can see here 0 1
2 so it will just keep those those index
values and that's it it will trim down
all the type information so in case you
are not going to use this enums values
on your production remove it by using by
declaring them as const so you can
actually let's say uh the example which
i gave you are creating your design
system and then your
developers need to only select the
colors from this
but that doesn't need to be known once
you are once your code is deployed on
protection
just declare it as a constant that's it
so that's a very good use case and in
case
you want to trim down some bytes from
your protection
i mean when i was using.net i used to
use it a lot i mean i think that
when i was writing that dotnet code it
was really
the new feature which was introduced
in uh dot net and it it is there from
long time in python and very useful so
let's see i mean
uh what what we can do is
let's use
tuples to swap two numbers
let's see how many lines of code feel
right
so i'll create let uh
swap numbers
[Music]
which is
type of
integer
sorry not integer so
which is type of number common number
so this is my tuple
and i'll write a function right now so
it's a function uh swap
numbers
and uh what this sharp numbers does is
it takes to parameter so i'll say um
it takes
num one comma num two so these are two
values it takes and it returns
num
to command num one
now let's use it so what i'm going to do
is i can say swap
numbs
is equal to swap numbers 10 comma 20. so
let's see it says inning cannot be
assigned
okay so here
number one
so here uh i'm have to just assign the
return type as well now let's see what
it returns so it says okay it returns
number common number
and you must be wondering this looks
similar to arrays what what is the
difference so let's me let me show you
that so here if i try to access swap
numbers of zero
okay
here you can see i mean you must be
wondering okay this looks similar to the
aries but okay what's the problem here
so if you can see okay i was okay
the variable
name was incorrect so he here you can
see okay i can access this
start numbers with zero i mean this is
something which you can do with arrays
as well
here let's try to do that right
so
for example here num list
so i can say let
new
num is equals to
num list
of
zero
and it works so uh if you
know arrays index starts with 0 so 0 1
3 4. so 4 is the maximum index which we
can access let's try two
and
five
you don't get any uh
any issue here i mean it's okay uh the
value problem will be once you compile
your code it will probably throw you an
error right
because there is no element at fifth
index
but still but let's try to do something
similar here
so we have two numbers available inside
this swap
function right so you have first number
and second number
so if i try to access swap numbers of
two
let's see
again i just entered wrong variable name
so here you can see it says this tuple
has length of 2
has no element at index 2 of length 2
has no element index 2. so it is saying
that this tuple only has two values
that's it i cannot see any value at
index 2 if i try to access the value at
it will just give me
the value that's it it will not give me
any exception
so
what what do you think
this doubles can be helpful at
so let's say you have an api call which
gives you let's say employee list and
department list as well
in most of the cases what you have to do
is of course you have to
uh go ahead and create two separate apis
or probably you have to go ahead and
find the objects and then you have to
assign it to two different properties to
return it from your function but using
tuples you can actually easily do that
right you can just return first
first value and second value
so you can probably say this is
department and this is employee and
your
variable can be of type employee and
type of department and it can just
fetch the value by index using zero or
one so you can say of employee or zero a
zero will be let's say employee and one
will be your department so that's what
you can actually do using the tuples
react has a lot of use cases for tuples
i have not seen that much use cases in
angular but uh probably some advanced
cases so we which i have never been
across but yeah this tuples are really
useful in case you have a function which
returns multiple values
you can use triples
let's see uh other data so now next day
type which we have is ini
we actually saw any data type
we actually saw any data when we were
going through errors remember so
uh any is uh kind of let's say in
javascript if you remember it just you
don't have any data types so any is kind
of equivalent so if i create a variable
i'll select the
department
which is type of any
so if i create a variable
with
type as any
here so i have department of variable
which is type of any i can assign any
value to this particular variable so
i can say department is equal to yt
uh department equals to 10 and it will
accept it will not throw any exception
the first thing which you should do is
do not use any in your code base so try
to avoid any in case you have an
existing code base try to
move away from any and use the uh
correct data types in case you can
otherwise uh there is there is something
called implicit any true flag available
here as well which stops you from using
any by default so if i just enable this
let's see
and i try to act like try to say um
let's take this similar previous example
right so where we had boolean
remember this one
it says is valid is used before being
assigned so here and let's see
what else we can
let's see if this gives an error
let's say some
numbering let's try to create a function
so it's a function add
and here let's see
implicit any
because we are actually saying number so
it will not give a semi error
but yeah and i don't try to use any uh
probably i'm not able uh not able to get
the error because we are saying this is
any but
even though if you don't give any right
so if you just create a
variable without mentioning any real
type you will also see that okay this is
also type of thing so let's try to
compile this code tsc
and
let's see the output
right so it will work is a work as a
design
if there is no data types assigned
so you don't have any type check and
your application or your code may fail
in production right because you are not
using the time safety feature so first
thing which you should do is not do not
use
uh type any anywhere
in case you have an existing code base
try to actually
incrementally do it i mean you of course
if you have a large code base you cannot
do it at once you can do it slowly
slowly in iterations that's what you
should target about
so this is amy and now
the other day types which we have we
have void and
never
so let's go ahead and see
but before that i mean before discussing
about these two types we will go through
functions
so uh in functions uh functions are what
click some some uh set of instructions
which you write uh for example let's say
if i want to add two numbers what i can
do is i can write
a function
which will have the instructions on
getting the input how to add those
functions and then return it so it's
kind of uh probably a reusable thing
which you can actually go ahead and
reuse wherever you want or it can be
your business logic as well right so
probably getting the api data that can
be a function
so uh in this
particular video we are going to talk
about different ways to write functions
so we will talk about
how you can write your function in
typescript then we will talk about
generic function we will talk about
optional parameter required parameter
and rest parameter so let's
let's go ahead and do that
i'll create a new file for functions
i'll call it as function start is
so first let's talk about the ways in
which you can write a function in
typescript there are multiple ways the
first first is of course named function
for example i can say function and then
function keyword and then i can say add
and
this is functions dot d is right
so you have add functions and now you
have two parameters and it returns a
plus b
this is generally what we write in
javascript right
but in typescript as we said
we will be using type saved so i can
remove this and that's okay this is
number one which is type of number so i
will be mentioning
the
type of
parameters which it can accept so i'll
say okay this is number
which is type of number and this is
actually as i said this is github
copilot which which is being used here
and then i can return
num1 plus num2
so in
typescript you always have type save
functions so
uh in if i have to actually add a
function in java if i have to create a
javascript function for add
and i don't define any uh types right
generally i don't then i can accept
strings as well and it can break your
code as well but here we are saying okay
this function this that function can
only add two numbers so that's it that's
taken care of and due to inference due
to inference this add function knows the
written type as well
but i will suggest always
have
the written type
let me tell you the reason why of course
one reason is for compiler and what in
case you try to add two numbers but you
miss the written keyword which happens a
lot of time i mean of course it happens
with me
sometime i just miss the written keyword
and i just keep thinking why this
function doesn't return anything
let's see the return type
so it says it's void remember the
written type void which we spoke about
or saw in the previous slide
so void it means it will void it means
it will not return anything right so
this function will not written anything
just to make sure that okay uh you don't
get into such issues if i define the
return type now you will start getting
an error so it will say okay the
function whose declared type is neither
void or any must return a value because
we are saying that this should written
number then we have to put in return
number
that's th this is this is your first way
to write function and then you can say
okay let
or let's do console.log
add to comma 3
right so i can just run dsc to compile
the files and then you can use node
functions
and you will get the output as five
let's see another way to write a
function so you can also write a
function like
let's just use subtract
is equals to
or
remove this uh this uh
and i'll say return
or you don't have to return such number
one minus ten
so this is also another way to write the
function you can see uh same right so
you have just you don't have function
keyword that's it so here we are saying
this is something which uh we know as
arrow function right so you have error
function have used here and then you are
saying the sub function takes two
parameter number one and number two and
returns a number and uh within this it
will say number one minus number so this
is another way and let's try this out
and see
subtract two minus three of course which
will we should return minus one so let's
see run dsc and then
[Music]
known functions and we have minus one as
output
there is one more variation to write a
function let's
use constraint multiply
and rather than using arrow function you
what you can do is you can actually use
a function keyword here and then you can
say return number
and
here you can say okay ah sorry you don't
have to use a function now
you can say uh return
num1 into num2 so this is another
variation the way of writing a function
you can use
i mean whatever type you want to let's
see the output right so if you run tsc
let's go to
functions.js so you can see uh this is
your subtraction this is a
multiplication
so all the types are stripped and this
is your normal name function for so this
is name and
this is
a named function
a function expression and this is arrow
function so this is uh three types in
which you can write a function
and there is more to it but you don't
have to worry about it this is this is
the minimum information which we need to
start working on our angular code base
now
after this let's
see some example of
optional parameters required parameters
and rest parameters
so let's say uh now you have this add
function but what you need is you need
this
functionality where you want to add
three numbers
but third number should be optional
so how you can do that so here
in typescript you can see number three
and you can put a question mark and
say type of number so now you can see
num3 is optional and your add function
still
works
if i remove this
you will start getting an error because
this add function requires three
arguments we have just passed to
so
this is this is known as required or
sorry optional parameters so i can use
it with two
values and three values as well but i
mean you must be wondering what how
about here right so how to use it here
uh i'm just adding num1 plus num2 you
can use uh the
optional chaining here so you can say
num3
if num 3 exist
so i will say num
1 plus num 2 plus num 3
else num 1 plus 1
so this is
a false statement in a single line so
here you can see so it says if num three
exists num uh add three numbers if
otherwise just add two numbers
uh this is not optionally changing and
i'll talk about optional channel
changing
probably in next videos in upcoming
videos this is not optional channels
sorry sorry for that
uh here uh you can also use so as i said
this is optional parameter there is
something called require parameter as
well
so here let's say i need three numbers
but third number is required so
i mean
you can still go ahead and avoid that so
i can
create third parameter number three and
i can assign it a default value
so if no one passes this value
10 will be used so i can say num1 minus
minus num
3 right so num3 has
like default value of 10
if no one passes then will be used but
in case i pass the third value
this value will be used so this is
required and so this one is required
parameter
and this is
sorry this one is optional parameter and
this one is your required fact
so we also have something known as rest
parameters what is that
let's let's go ahead and see that
so now uh
this function has had a requirement that
okay third parameter can be optional
and this is where it is required but
let's write a function so let's say
uh function
and
two
okay i'll just
i'll say add two
and here
the thing is i can pass and number of
arrays n number of values after this
so i have two numbers but after that i
can just pass the n number of arrays
that's the requirement how you can do
that so i can say number three
which is number array
so i'm saying uh this
you can see i mean so
thanks to go github co-pilot it is
writing code for me now so here you must
be wondering what is happening here so
here the third parameter is array so i'm
using reduce
to make sure that it come it actually
sums everything and then adds in number
one and number two let's see how to use
it so i can say console
dot log so i can say com to comma three
but i can also do
five six
seven
format
argument of type number is not
assignable to type
let
me numbers is equals to
and let's try to use this numbers
variable here
should be okay
yeah so we are using this rest operator
right so i have to pass like this
rest of numbers so here
it will be 2 3 2 plus 3 and whatever the
sum of this number is let's see dac
and then we can say node
and yeah so it's it comes to 20. so
this is how you can use the rest
parameters so in case you want to pass
n number of numbers after this you can
do that
i mean in previous uh thing and previous
without doing this you can also do this
but you have to say dot dot and
five six seven and
i mean you can go as much as you want
right so this is how you can actually
pass this rest parameters or rest
values
so these are three uh
ways how you can actually play with the
parameters make sure that you always
define the written type and always
define the parameters type as well
we will talk about generic function as
well if you remember in previous video
we saw an
different variation of arrays remember
array and then angle brackets and then
we can define what data type it will
have area of saying rf number so generic
functions are like it can be like a
function which can have
return type
based on what you pass
so it will it will be like it will act
like a placeholder so whatever you pass
will be removed and
uh will be returned at the runtime
so let's go ahead and see that but
before
before going to that let me show you one
more way to pass the data here for in
the rest parameters we saw you can
actually pass three dots but you can
also do
this
you can just say
five
comma six comma seven comma eight i mean
so the way it works is there is
parameters it will take these two as
first and second parameter and
rest of the values will be passed here
num 3 which is really cool about
respects right so you don't have to go
ahead and define 10
parameters or
10 different parameters to actually hold
those values
now let's go ahead and create our first
generic function so what we
will create
so what we can do is let's create a
function which will take the
array of
string or area of number and then it can
concrete all the values and give it to
you as a new
array
let's see let's see how we can build it
so here is the function so it uh
function name is get items so we are
saying this t is our placeholder you can
call it anything you want so generally
this was very confusing when i started
learning generics i used to think t some
t mean something because everywhere
everywhere you go you will find t or
every programming language you go for uh
generics you will find t so it's not
like that you can also make it type
and then just change everywhere from d
to like
the official website of typescript which
has a typescript handbook they use this
pattern so they don't call it t to avoid
this confusion they use time
so we know okay what we uh
what we mean is this is a placeholder it
doesn't mean anything
so uh let's try to
pass some values and use this function
so okay i'll call it as com get result
is equals to we'll call get items and
right now let's see what we are doing
here so we are passing the array of
numbers
and it knows that okay we are saying
okay as this number all the types are
replaced and it is replaced with numbers
so you can see this is how generics work
so i can also do this
is equals to get
items and now i can pass abcd and now
you can see it will say okay the return
type is string you can also do this you
can pass the written type i mean the
type t here so you can say okay it will
be i'm expecting to pass number and
everything which will be returned should
be of type number array
and same here
so it can infer the values i remember we
we spoke about inference so it can infer
the values and it can give you the
proper proper return type so this is
really useful in case you want to create
some reusable function which
apart from its type right uh it can uh
we can take any type and it can work so
you can do this you can actually go
ahead and create that function as
generic function so you can replace this
type with whatever you want whatever you
are working with
now we are going to talk about classes
if you have very any prior experience in
programming you might have heard about
classes because object oriented
programming starts with classes you have
like inheritance or polymorphism
everything is around classes
in
javascript there was no concept of
classes for a long time
am i wrong yes i'm wrong so there was a
way to create classes in javascript but
the syntax was little bit different and
it was uh
it was kind of you may know this
something called iffy immediately
invoked function expression so that was
equivalent of class in javascript
and
with es6 thanks to a6 we have class
syntax available
so thanks to es6 we have this class
syntax available and typescript had it
actually before before even that it was
introduced in esx
so
uh earlier typescript actually you
should like we used to write class
syntax in types then it used to
transpile into es5 and then used to give
a cp function but when es6 introduced
classes it started actually giving you
class class syntax so you will see when
we write classes the syntax are pretty
much similar in javascript
as well as
uh typescript so let's go ahead and see
what we are going to see so we will see
of course we'll talk about classes we
will see how you can create classes we
will talk about properties and
constructor we will
talk about the how you can create
methods how you can create instance of a
class
we will also talk about member
visibility and then static members so
let's go ahead and get started and let's
create a new
file so we'll call it as
class
yes
so how you write class so you will use
of course class keyword and let's name
it as employee so uh for naming
convention uh prefer this uh pascal case
employee so let's say employ if i have
employee information so i will be
capital so right this is your possible
case
so right now we have a class called
employee so this is how you create class
and
let me go to ts config.json right now
remember we changed this target es1015
we are saying uh we are going to support
modern browsers but what in case i want
to support older browser so let's see
how it used to create classes or we used
to create classes in older days right in
es5
i can say tsc and
it will transpile and give us this
height so you can see this this is known
as the immediately invoked function
expression or iffy but if i change this
configuration to use the es2015 version
which is now supported by all the modern
browsers
and you can run dsc again
and you can see okay same syntax right
so class employee
now let's uh go ahead and see how
[Music]
let's add some properties to this
particular class how so let's say if we
want to have some properties and some
constructors which we generally do let's
see how we can do that so to define
properties you can create let's say id
which is type of you have to give type
to each property you should and
right now as we are in stick mode you
will get this
error it says id has no initializer and
it's not definitely assigned in the
construct so
in case you have default values go ahead
and do that otherwise
just put this
exclamation mark which will uh which
will avoid this error
and we can say name and we can say
address
so this is how you can create properties
but in case i want to use constructor
and i want to actually assign all these
properties using constructor
typescript has a default constructor so
let's go ahead and see how you can
create an instance of this class first
so i'll say okay this let
emp is equal to new employee i will call
this employee as
uh john
right so this employee name is john and
then we can define or we can assign some
properties so i can say okay this one
name is sean
and address this is 71 okay so this
these are the properties these are the
values which we have assigned to this
particular prop
and let's see how it looks like so you
can just say console.log john and
let's transpile this file tse
and
let's run it using node
and you can see it gives you a employee
object right and it's it is giving you
all the values id name address so this
is how you can create a class and assign
its values here
now let's talk about constructors so
constructors are something which will be
which will be responsible for creating
an instance of this class so how you can
use constructor of course by default
there is a default constructor which is
available you don't have to in case you
don't want to
or you can have parameterized
constructor so in other programming
languages you can actually have
parameterized constructor as well as
default constructor in typescript you
cannot have both you can have either
default constructor or parameterized
constructor
so here let's try to actually do that
i'll create another constructor function
i'll constructor
[Music]
so you will get an error so here you can
see it says multiple constructor
implementations have not allowed so you
cannot do this
by using constructor of course we we can
avoid this
in case we have default values right we
can do something like this
i can say okay this dot
address is equals to
address you can see as soon as i do this
the error will be gone
and then i can set this dot id
equals to id and this dot
name equals one
but once we do this i mean what we are
expecting is we are supposed to pass
this properties by creating the instance
so where we are getting the instance you
can see at line number 15 and we
started getting the error as well
because we are not passing those values
and it is expected that whenever you are
creating an instance you have to pass
the value so rather than actually
passing this
values here on line number 17 18 and 19
we can go here so we can say one comma
john and
address is
highway 71
and we can remove this
otherwise that will just overwrite the
values which we don't want to and let's
run it again so i can say tse
and now i can just note and you can see
you have the properties right so same
values which was assigned here is
available so this is how you can
actually add properties and this is
how you can create a constructor
function
now let's talk about uh methods how you
can add methods to your class
to create methods you can just give a
function name you don't have to use
function keyword so i can say okay get
name
with address
and
what i can do is i
i want to actually have a written type
as we said we should
have a return type here string
and i will say okay this is written
uh this dot name plus this this dot
address here actually i want to
introduce one more
uh
syntax to you so here we can see okay we
are passing this dot name and then we
are passing we are concatenating two
strings basically
so we have this dot name and then there
is a name will be john and
then his address which is is highway 71
let's try that out right so i'll say let
address
is equals to john dot get name with
address and then we'll just do
console.log here on line number 27
and let's do tsc
and we have this john highway 17 but
this way of concatenation is really uh
buggy sometime because your
you may miss this so it happens it
happens it happens with everyone uh it
happens with me it happened fit me uh in
past as well
so what you can do is you can actually
uh use the
another you use another syntax
which is a string literal uh you can
actually do something like this so you
can say
uh in single quotes so you can
use this
this key which is filled which is known
as
tilt you can press this
without shift
right so
looks like single quotes but it is not
and then you can
put it inside
the dollar and curly brackets so
variables you can replace with curly
brackets
and here also
i can do same so i can say dollar
curly brackets
and
now you can see i have a space here
i don't have to manually put a
concatenation sign which we did earlier
and
do that so i can say
uh john stays
at hyper 71 and let's see the output
and this is something which you can do
in angular as well so it's not like
something specific to typescript i mean
uh
you can do where you can actually go
ahead and utilize this code in your
real-time application so using this
string literals so
you can see john stays that have you
seen even no need to actually go ahead
and concatenate using plus sign or uh no
and you don't miss your spaces right
that's that's the cool thing about it
now let's talk about
creating instance we so what we learned
so far is we created a class we created
uh
properties and constructors uh we added
properties we uh also added constructor
we added a method we created an instance
of class this is how you do it
right so using new and class name uh
let's talk about visibility right member
visibility here
uh you can see you have properties id
name address but before that i i think
i'm used to actually talk about why to
create classes
that's really important right so in your
application what you are going to do is
you are going to create a lot of you are
going to create a lot of
code which will contain your business
logic how to actually write those
business logic or where to write those
business logic that's where class is
coming comes really handy so a class
will be responsible for like uh handling
some business business logic which you
will be writing for example let's say in
angular we are going to use classes for
writing services which can have like
getting data from your backend and
displaying it on your front end we will
be using it for components which will be
kind of your view so
it needs some back end right i mean it
needs some
glass to actually give the data back to
your html that's where we will be using
classes so it's it's it will just wrap
your entire business logic you are going
to write your business logic into
classes and you will have like tons of
classes right different classes where
you can have different logic for example
if i'm writing some logic related to
uh getting the data from
my back end
for all the
rooms i want for example if i take an
example which we are going to go
and implement in our this course we are
going to create an hotel management
application so well let's say you have
like lot of rooms available so you can
write the class to get those room data
and display it on your front end and
assign or you can have like logic to
assign your rooms those are the
different logics which we will have
so those logics will actually go into
your classes
so it classes makes like
splitting your logic
uh into
smaller chunks right that that that is
what your classes are going to make it
possible
and you can do lot of stuffs with
classes which we'll see uh here let's
say uh we have right now id
you can actually create blog uh this is
private uh keyword which is introduced
in
new version of javascript and now
supported by typescript as well or
you can also use private keyword but i
just think you should not anymore
because it's
the native one is supported so you can
say hash id let's see what it says
so it says hash id is declared but its
value is never read because it says okay
it's a private value sorry private
variable you can see now we have
actually started getting
this error here as well so
i can say private
or i can just use hashtag
in case you want to keep it private so
here you can see private id and then uh
with private
uh
sorry private variables you can actually
assign them into your constructor so if
i keep the this one hash id so what i
have to do is i have to go ahead and
change it here as
so i can assign this inside my
constructor if i try to access
the properties you can see i'm not able
to access id because it's a private it's
private to the class and we won't be
able to access whenever we create a new
instance of that particular class so
that's the private property for you
and prefer now if uh as you will be
using probably android 13 in future i
mean by the time this course gets
released i prefer hash id which is like
the native syntax for creating private
variables in javascript
so this is private by default all the
properties and all the classes are
public you don't have to mention that
you can also make it protected
so you can see okay now i have made it
protected so why uh
what protected does
it is useful in case you want to extend
this particular class so let's create
another class i will call it as
class
manager which
extends employee
so ah here it says uh constructor for
derived class okay this is this is
something which is required in case we
are extending so we have to call superb
and this is it now
here uh we can actually access all the
properties so you can see i can
get address and name
uh properties
which will be accessible here
and
[Music]
but you can see uh whenever you create a
new object you won't be able to get
i mean so protected is something which
will be
available within class and
the classes which extends this class so
right now i can go ahead and access uh
this name inside my class as well as the
class which extends it but once you
create the instance you can see it's not
available it's uh something which is not
visible to my instance a public instance
which is created so this is how you can
actually use protected classes between
like in case you are trying to extend
this is also known as inheritance in uh
other oops concept so you can you also
call it as inheritance
so
you can also get access to all the
members i'm sorry methods as well so i
can actually create
uh this
get name with address but here i can say
this manager
this uh whatever name is a manager at
this particular branch right so this is
really nice so i can say okay this let
create let's create a new mic
so mike is a manager who stays at cherry
stripe and i can do
console.log
and get name with address now let's see
we created an instance and then we have
actually
a new i mean we have implemented this my
manager class actually implements its
own method which is called get name with
address but for in case i don't do this
let's do that
you can see i can still call get name
with address what happens now
[Music]
so in this case what what will happen is
your manager class knows that okay this
method exists in my parent class so it
will call the parent class so this is
this is something which is really nice
about inheritance you can achieve this
and let's roll it back so we have its
own function as well and we have
implemented by manager so this is from
member visibility and you can have
static members as well now it is allowed
so let's see uh static members probably
let's talk about
i can say static and
should i create a method let's create
another
and i'll say return
50 right i'm just returning a number so
with static members static members are
something which can be accessed
with the class name
so here let's see what i am referring to
so i can say john dot
you can see it it has address and gate
get name fifth address where is this
particular function
which is get employee count
so you can
do is employee dot get employee count so
you will be able to call this particular
method on the name itself without
creating a new instance so this is what
happens in static
i wanted to show you one more thing
yeah i wanted to show you getters and
setups right so this is something which
is widely used in programming languages
like java and dotnet you can use skaters
and setters you can also use getters and
setters in typescript
so here i can say get
emp
id so as of now you if you remember emp
id is a private variable so it cannot be
used outside you can it cannot be
accessed outside but in case i want to
access it so i can do is i can say okay
this is a getter method
and i can say return this dot hash id
similarly i can have a setter with same
name
and here
i can say this will be id which is type
of number
and i can say this dot id is equal to id
i'm just assigning it so i i don't want
to return anything
i can say okay this
right so this is the setter which will
assign the value and this is the getter
which will get the values here so now uh
let's say
let's do this
and i just said john
dot emp id is equals to 100 so i'm just
then changing this employee id which was
assigned as 1 200
by using
setters
and
here you have john
dot
um
[Music]
it says will be available on the
instance itself so i think we already
have
console.log no we don't have let's add
console dot log john dot emp id
so what we are supposed to get it here
so as we are calling it it will call the
getter so we will get the employee id
which is entered
so let's clear
and
call dc again
and i'll call node
which is
some
node class and you can see i we are
getting hundred so getters and setters
it is also possible in case you have
like hang off using getters and setters
they are useful as well in case uh we
will be using it in angular you will see
some examples where we use getters and
setters so
this is it for from the classes we will
now
talk about interfaces so
interfaces are really important i mean a
lot of time you will be writing
interfaces when you write a new code in
angular or even uh you you use it
outside
why interfaces are important
let's see
so here we will be talking about of
course how you can create interfaces how
you can create uh
use interfaces type you how you can
implement interfaces yes that's possible
how you can extend interfaces we will
talk about optional properties with
interfaces we will talk about object
destructuring and array destructuring
that's uh something which is really
useful i mean
you can actually avoid a lot of
unnecessary code using object and direct
structure and we'll see that
so let's create a new file
i'll call it as interface on these
so to create an interface you can use
interface
uh keyword and then
there is a naming pattern so a lot of
developers
i before interfaces i don't like it i
mean even angular's uh documentation
says don't use i so what i can do is
let's create a user interface right so
what a user can have so it can have a
name okay it can have let's say it can
have
id
and your user can have email
so these are the properties so uh
most of time you will be using
interfaces as uh to create your own user
defined data type so this is now a data
type for eco so you have user
it you uh interfaces can also have
a function definition
we will talk about what function
definition is soon but here right now
let's talk about interfaces as your user
defined data
so let's say you want to use complex
object right so you have like name age
id email
and
what we generally do in javascript is
something like this
so we create where
users for example equals to
and then you you just give all the
property names i mean
in
of course in javascript you don't give
type so you say
uh it has name
which is like blank
age which is let's say one
ide has one the default values right so
and then
you can say maybe less something blank
this is generally i mean we have an
habit of like creating an object in
javascript
but in typescript you can rather than
doing this you can actually create an
interface and then you can use this
interface as a type so we have type
safety that's the whole idea right so we
can have type safety by using this
values
let's see
what we can do so here
remember uh so we have this user here
and let's try to create another
interface i will talk about let's go
back to class
here address
do you think we can actually uh
have a complex object as an address yes
we can for example we have at this line
one address line to zip code or country
or city whatever those are the
properties which uh your address can
have but right now is it possible yes i
mean i can just go ahead and do
something like we discussed we saw right
so we can have your street i mean city
you have your state and pin
so i can say okay this is pin and string
so i can do something like this and you
you can see we already have an error
here because this
type does not match
but i mean writing this in
your class breaks the purpose i mean
what in case i want to use this address
type somewhere else what you will do
of course copy paste the code right
which is like
uh which brings the single
responsibility principle when we are
talking about writing a better code
what we can do we can create an
interface rather than this so what they
can do is i can just create here
i'll just move on top
i can create an interface called
address
and
and i can have all these properties as
part of this interface now i can just
say okay this address is type of this
address
and while assigning the values uh here
also we'll say okay this address is type
of this address and now us while
assigning the value you will see that we
are getting intelligence to provide all
the values so you can see it says okay
straight uh abc city bangalore state
karnataka
and
you have your bin code so all this are
the properties which you can pass as an
address
and
this is
typed right time so whenever your users
try to actually use this particular
class they will get the intelligence
okay these are the types which needs to
be provided in case they provide
something which does not match the type
but they will get the error so
that this is where you can actually go
ahead and utilize interfaces
what in case i want to use the interface
but
i don't want all the properties to be
provided let's try to create a value
here so i can select
user
which is type of
user equals to i mean i'll provide all
the values
email
so we have
john age
sorry name age id and email but in case
i want to make age optionally let's
remove this i don't want to pass it
what we have is
an error it says it's it's missing a
property which is age
so in typescript
you can actually make it optional by
putting a question mark in front of the
property so it will of course you will
get phase the scenario a lot where you
want to actually
make some properties optional
while creating you your own type or
creating while creating your interface
this is how you can do it so just put a
question mark and that's it
now
let's see one more thing you can also
extend interface you can also implement
interface so let's say i have a new
interface
i'll call it as employee
and it needs to have all the properties
of users so i can do is extend
so
i think employee already exists that's
what
employee
name is protected property name
okay so this was actually we already
have an employee class right so it was
just name you cannot have actually this
same name for two different
classes and interfaces
so here we can see employees extend user
so
we have all the properties which is part
of user and you can also add your own so
let's say a name age
id email and i can add let's say salary
as extra property
so if i create a new
value or create a new variable let's say
i'll call it as of course let's call it
as something else
let employee okay
so i'll call it as employee which is a
type of employees now you can see you
have name
id email of course age is
optional and then you have salary as
well so if i remove salary now you will
start getting an error that salary is
missing so this is how you can actually
extend
an interface
it is also possible that your interfaces
can have
method definition what do you mean by
that so let's create an interface
and i'll call it as
login
and it has a login method
which returns boolean for example or
let's say which returns type of user
so this is method definition you are you
are not responsible for implementing
this method who can i mean of course the
class so let's go back to
class.ds
and we want to use this interface
how we can do that
this class exists in different file this
interface exists in a different file
this is where we will also talk about
one concept which is known as module cs
modules
in typescript or now available in with
javascript as well
you can actually import
uh sorry
let's not jump to the con
the terms right now but what you can do
is you can refer to some object which is
which is defined in different file into
another file how
so
whichever object needs to be used
outside you have to mark them with
export keyword
once you add export keyword
these
whenever it is compiled your code knows
that okay this particular interface can
be used outside of the class
now where we want to use this particular
class what we have to do is we have to
import we have to use import statement
and then we use calibrate brackets from
and give the relative path of that
particular file so that right now the
relative path
path is interface
don't have to give the extension
remember i'm not using extension yet
thanks to bs code uh
you get 10 deletions so once you
press ctrl space bar you will see how
what are the things which can be used
outside of this particular module out of
interface so interface is a module and
then you can use login from here now i
can just go to employee and say i will
implement because i want to implement
this particular function so i can say
okay implements login and you can see
there is a of course uh
option which says uh there is an alert
which says
you are not implementing this um
login uh sorry interface properly so
let's implement it
and you can see here so i have login and
which is type of user
and probably you can return a new user
and let's copy the user from here
we already had a user defined right so
you can just return
and okay so here uh this is interesting
so uh we have said uh we are saying that
okay this is the date and type which is
user
so what we have to do is we have to also
mark
user with export keyword yes you're
right so we have to say okay export and
now i can just go ahead and use in class
so i can if you can please click here
and you can say add user to existing
import
which is available here
and this is it so we have implemented
our login method as well
you can
export in sorry you can import in
multiple ways so here we can see we are
saying import each object right login
user there are some other uh ways to
write import statement which i generally
should not use but just in case you get
across this particular syntax just
remember that this is possible so you
can also say info star as
i'll say this is
user login
from
dot slash interface
and once you use this syntax you have to
refer everything like this user login
dot login
and uh here as well user login dot user
so that's that's the only syntax so it's
a it's an alias we are saying okay
whatever this particular module
gives to me i use it as alias user
use user login as an alias and then i
can access every object by using dot
so don't use this i mean this is
something which you should not just use
whatever you need and
that's it so this is how you can also uh
import and export which is known as es
modules and this is also you can how you
can use interfaces
now we will talk about object
destruction and led structure
let's see
so let's say we have a function which
returns the user information right so
let's rather than function let's have
this object so you have this user object
and uh
what we need is i need to access name
and email that's it i just need two
properties
how you generally do that
so this is the way so you will of course
create this user object and then you can
say
user dot name password
i want to access it so i can say user
dot name and user dot email
right so this is how you would generally
access all the of all the objects
but in case we actually can write this
in a single line of output yes that's
possible
so here what we can do is we can
do something like this i can say user
comma
email
sorry
name
so we i can say uh this is known as
object destructuring so we can just
access name and email
out of this three properties i don't
want to read id that's absolutely fine
you can also
rename it for example i just don't want
to use it as name i want to use it as
username i mean i want to access this
name property but not as name property i
mean i want to rename it as a username
so what you can do is name colon
whatever new property name you want and
that's it
right and for example email also i don't
want to name it as email probably i want
is
uh
user login
right so now if you see here next line i
can just go ahead and use user login as
a as an property that's available
so this is object destructuring which we
can generally use
let's talk about
let's talk about led structuring now so
we have
this object destructuring and
to create or do you
learn about parity structuring let's
create an array first so
i'll create lit users
which is type of
user and then
so as mentioned you can use both syntax
array with like
brackets which is a generic syntax or
this syntax and let's create few records
so we'll say name
you know email
let's copy from here i think we have
this
and
let's format this and that let's add one
more few more records so i'll put this
as
so i can say 1
this is 2 and this is three and change
the id and john
one
two
now to
learn about our uh led structuring let's
say i want to access the user one and
user two how we can do that
any idea
so of course we need array syntax so i
will say
box
and then i can say user
one
command user two
and this is it so
you will get the first record in this
secondary button this let's let's try to
write console.log and see if we what we
are talking is correct
so i'll say console.log user2
sensor dc
and then we will run node this is
interface so it'll say okay there is
some typing issue
this should be changed
it's okay so anyways it says
but the files will anyways compile so
not a problem here so it's a node
interface
um
so you can see you have like first
record here second record here and
you can also
have all the values the rest of the
values like this you can see you request
users
so let's say if i have a few more
records right so let's say look at this
as user john
v and id is four
and let's do console.log user3
awesome console.log rest
users so let's use tsc again to compile
the files and then we will use node
and you can see our rest of the values
are available as part of this particular
array and you can see these are objects
you don't have to actually go ahead and
get it as object array and then you have
to access the values it's not so you
don't have to do
index of zero index of one that's
something which we don't have to in case
you are using this
array destructuring syntax and you can
get the rest of the values like this all
the rest users
so this is a really handy in case you
are working with arrays and
there are a few more functions uh let's
few uh let's talk about few
uh let's say if i want to filter
uh
a value like so i can say uh
[Music]
result
is equals to
[Music]
this users
yeah let's use the rest users and
here
you can use filter for example and then
you can say user id is greater than two
so what are the values which is the list
three and four sorry uh we all only have
three and four interest users so i can
say okay greater than three three so i i
will get one one record with like
this id four
i think we are we already discussed
about few array methods so let's not
talk let's not uh
go ahead and talk about them so that's
it that's fine
and this is this is it about
yeah so this is it about uh interfaces
one more thing uh before we move back so
we need to talk about decorators
and but before that before we move into
decorators one more thing which we uh
let's talk about so interfaces actually
does not exist in javascript so let's
see the output so we have this user
interface which is created right so
let's go ahead and see interface.js you
will not find that particular interface
anywhere
so
remember
at runtime all the interface i mean once
you compile your code all the interfaces
will be removed they won't be part of
your production bundle so you have to
decide whether you want to use
interfaces or classes this is generally
which people do ask that when to use
interfaces of when to use classes
in case you want to actually retain the
type by uh like once you create the prod
build go ahead and use classes because
uh
generally used in like backend
programming so if you are creating your
apis it is preferred that you should use
classes for written types
not interfaces for example if you uh
come across an sjs or you use
expressions where you have to actually
give some
take some input you cannot use
interfaces there because of course once
you create your build the types are gone
so you can use classes and then you can
retain the type and you can also verify
if you are using uh if you are getting
the correct information or not so
[Music]
just keep it in mind so
this is something which uh
which is really confusing for someone
who is coming from java dot and
background but yeah this interfaces does
not exist really inside
typescript or javascript
so
decorators are
one experimental feature which is
available in typescript and it is not
going to go anywhere because a lot of
users a lot of
frameworks libraries already use
decorators a lot it was initially
suggested as part of javascript
but it was lit dropped
so that's how they still exist inside
typescript
they can be applied on like
um
what what is a decorator so it's it's
like uh
[Music]
you can also you can actually go ahead
and modify the behavior of your class or
method or a property
at runtime by using decorator so
are we going to write the decorator the
answer is most of the time no that is uh
some advanced code where you may need it
why we are talking about decorator here
because it is used internally by angular
and you will come across multiple
decorators when writing your angular 4
so
let me go to code base so
some
examples which we'll see is for example
class
let's say component
and
you will come across let's say
decorator called component
so what this particular
component meant
so generally whenever you see something
on top of class or property or method
with starting with at the rate and
having some curly brackets and some
properties those are decorators so it
can change the behavior of your class at
runtime once they are executed
we will not be writing our own as we
said uh we will be using the one
provided by angular that's why that's
the reason we are talking about
uh decorators here you can actually
write your own decorators in some to
handle some advanced cases in case you
want to do something at runtime uh but
that's that's really advanced use case
you probably will never come across that
as i said these are experimental
features so there are two flags which is
used uh this one experimental decorators
and experimental decorator metadata this
needs to be enabled so you here you can
say okay enable this experimental
support for es7 decorators
this needs to be enabled here in case
you are writing your own typescript code
outside of angular but inside angular
these are already enabled so you don't
have to do that
so
this is it
from
so this is it from decorators we will
not go we are not going to go into much
detail let's talk about es module uh we
already saw the example while working
with interfaces and classes you remember
import and export keywords that's what
we uh this this is what es module is all
about
and let's see uh we also went through
actually this is also covered we also
went through typescript to a different
version you remember we change the
target to es5 and es2015 you can change
it to whatever version you want
and
let's see some properties of this ts
config.json file and then we will end
with
our typescript section and we will start
with the angular section so here as i
said we uh we already
went through target and module we saw
strict no implicit any uh just enable it
as well but if you see say strict true
you have enabled all the strict flags
here you don't have to actually enable
one by one
apart from that you can
use some some of the uh
properties for example here
put output output can we see output here
yeah out here for example let's say i
want my all our output which is
generated right now let's see
so if you notice this and this file is
not saved somehow
if you notice right now all the js files
are just created
next to our ts file but in case you have
a lot of files it will make your life
really tedious to actually go ahead and
figure out which
file is your output so using root diff i
can just say okay this is dist folder
and now i can just to
plc and once you do tac all the outputs
will be generated inside dsd folder you
can see here all js files all the output
is a part of dsd folder
uh source map which is really uh
interesting because
remember i said we
can when only run javascript on browser
what in case you want to
debug your code
what you what code we are going to write
of course typescript
what code we are going to get on browser
javascript
how to debug
it not possible right
so yes this is possible uh by enabling
the source map this is also something
which you don't have to because on in
angular the in development mode you will
find this property to be true but let's
see what happens when you do source map
true
so let's run the ac file again so once
we say source map true a new file
another file will be generated
called map file this map file contains
the information that from where this
code is getting generated so you can see
uh there is a property called sources so
it sources it says it is coming from
class.ds
right so at runtime this file will be
actually
used by your browser to redirect you to
the correct ts file rather than
js file
so this is
source map and
i don't think so you need to know more
about
yeah this is really interesting i'll
just
i'll just remove all the dst folder
all the js files
so let's see uh once you do no emit
you can see there is no output generated
let's go back and fix this
and just say this is type of
address
to fix this issue
and then we will say this
address i think we can get
let's comment this as of now let's run
psc again
right so if you say no emit there will
there won't be any output which will be
generated
there is another flag
see selection
[Music]
and sources
so let's move it back to false
and let's say tse
now you have your output generated one
more thing which i wanted to show you is
let's go back to
interface class.ts
here we were getting errors right so if
you remember if you see this we are
getting an error and once we
run psc
we are getting the error but it still
generates the output let's see i mean
earlier it was already there so we are
not sure if it is generated or not so
let's see i mean you can see even though
we are getting the error we are still
getting the output so remember one thing
typescript cannot stop you from
compiling your file
it can only give you errors warnings
those are like really your warnings it
is saying that okay you have some type
issue but it will not stop your code
from compiling keep this in mind so uh
in case you are like you are relying on
this error and considering that your
code is actually not compiled yes it is
not it is not true your output will be
always generated it will give you some
typing issue in case it has but yeah it
will also give you the output
so this is it from typescript section
now we can go ahead and learn about
angular all the concept which you have
you uh which we have learned which you
have learned sorry
all the concept which you have learned
so far related to typescript will be
used inside the angular and they are
really important so don't skip anything
hi
so far we have completed with typescript
we learned the basics of typescript now
we are going to apply those concepts so
let's start with
angular so here we will first go through
the setup and installation we will set
up our workspace and we will install the
necessary
applications or necessary
programs
we will install the necessary softwares
required to run our
to run and create our first application
so let's see what we are going to see
here in this video so we will see how we
can install angular cli we will see how
you can create a workspace using angular
cli we will create a workspace and then
we will talk about the files which is
available in that workspace and finally
we will also talk about monorepo which
is really important so let's go ahead
and get started
in previous video we mentioned that we
won't be probably using angular 12 but i
think
sorry
in previous video we mentioned that
we probably won't be using angular 13
but uh
we will use angular 13 i have seen there
are not many breaking changes so let's
go ahead and use angular 13 which is the
latest
version and which will be
uh
the version for next six months so you
will use the same version and it will be
easy to even migrate in future so
first thing which we have to do is of
course go ahead and
the first thing which we have to do is
go ahead and install angular cli
which will help us to create the
application so
we will open the command prompt
so this is the folder where actually i'm
keeping all the files related to this
course but you don't have to worry about
it you can just open a command prompt
and run this format npm
install at the rectangular slash cli
hyphen g so hyphen g is for global so we
will be
installing the latest
version of angular cli globally in our
machine so you can use the angular cli
from anywhere
so you can use
angular cla from anywhere on your
machine so
you can also verify if which version is
installed
let's right now let's install it
and then we'll see how you can verify
the version
it will take few seconds based on your
internet speed
so
so it's installed now you can see this
is the very this is the version
so it says angular version
13.0.1 is installed as of now
to
see which version is already available
on your machine you can run ng hyphen fn
version which will give you this version
angular cli version and it will also
give you note version as said 14 is
absolutely fine angular 13 support
[Music]
our application in case you don't want
to install the global version you can
also use nbx i'll show you how you can
do that but let's go ahead and now
talk about creating our workspace
angular cli allows you to create an
empty workspace where you can add
multiple projects and libraries
sorry
angular cli allows you to create
multiple projects within your workspace
so you can create an empty workspace and
then add projects later or you can
create
an workspace with a default application
that's choice is yours
what we are going to do is we will be
creating an application with the default
application which we need
so let's see how we can do that i mean
how you can create and workspace
empty sorry how you can create an empty
workspace and how you can create a
workspace with default application
this is the so move to any folder where
you want to create your project
right now i use i have created a folder
called angular and i create all the
angular related projects in this
particular folder angular folder but
choose as per your convenience
so you can use engine new command to
create a new application
awesome
you can create a new
workspace
so engine you and then you can give your
workspace name i can say hotel
hotel inventory
app
as we said i can create an empty
workspace in case you want to create an
empty workspace you can
pass a flag called create
application
is equals to false
i want to create and work space with
default project so
i won't be
let's do that so i'll say
engineer hotel inventory app and hyphen
fn create application equals to false
this will create an empty workspace for
us
we will delete it and then we'll create
again with default project
so right now it is installing the
packages i'll just cancel it here
because i don't want the packages to be
installed i can because i want to delete
this folder and then create a new
[Music]
so we want to create a new application
with
with a default project so here we'll
just open this and
open with code so we'll see
what we get
when we create an empty workspace so you
can see we don't have much
uh files available here you have
dsconfig.json which we have seen
we have package.json which we have also
seen angular.json which is like
angularjson angular's configuration file
and rest of them are just read me and
get ignore and editor configurance so
this is it this is what you get once you
create and workspace without a default
application
now you can add a application as well
let me show you how
and that will require us to install the
packages so let's go ahead and do that
i just don't want you to do it but let's
see
so
to install the packages you can run npm
i and it will read all the packages
which is required from package.json
and it will installed and then we'll see
how you can add a project
into this empty workspace and then we'll
delete it and then we will create a new
workspace with a default project
okay so uh now it is installed so let's
see how to create
a new
so what we want to do right now is we
want to create a new application
so you can use ng generate
app which is short for application and
your application name which is let's say
hotel
in when
so this is
our application name hotel inventory app
is our workspace name
and it will ask if you want to actually
share this information
with
i mean this is just for like usage of
the commands
so it's up to you
so this will ask some question whenever
you create an app
let's see those questions so it says
would you like to add angular routing as
we are going to use angular routing
later on i'll say yes don't worry about
it right now uh which styles it you want
to use i will go with this sas
and this is it so you can see a new
project has been created here
uh called hotel inventory and it has
some files these are the files which
we'll talk about later on later once we
finalize our workspace
and now we can just skip this installing
packages thing
yeah so this is how you can create an
empty workspace and add project later on
in case you want to and now let's see
the other way where we will create a
workspace with a default project
so first i will go ahead and delete this
folder
so now
once that folder is created now let's
create a new workspace with and default
application as result
we can say engine new and
you have to just mention the project
name so i can say hotel
in when
app and that's it you don't have to
mention hyphen fn create application
flag
and this will create
it will ask you the same question
whether you want to add routing i i we
want to actually use routing in future
so we'll say yes which style should we
want to use i'll say css and
that's it now
it will create your workspace with
default application or default project
so
now all the files are already generated
so you can see hotel inventory app and
now only the installation is going on so
meanwhile let's go ahead and open this
project in
our vs code
okay so now
the first step is completed we have
learned how to install angular cli and
how to create an application with
default project without default project
i mean an empty workspace where you
don't have any project or a workspace
where you have a default project
so now next what we need to do is we we
will learn about what are the files
which is available within the workspace
we just created so we'll start with the
last one we'll start at the
bottom and then we'll go up so let's see
what are the files which is available
so the first file which is available is
tsconfig.json you might be wondering why
i'm not saying
tsconfig.spec.json because that's the
first file which is here right so these
two files tsconfig.spec and tsconfig.app
they both extend these config.js and you
can actually verify here the first line
extends
and even if i just open app it will also
save extents so what is the purpose of
this two files so let's first talk about
ts config.json so this is your ts
configuration file which we learned
during typescript you may see there are
few things like strict
no implicit
returns so these are all flags which is
available in typescript
and source map
then we had target remember so now uh we
said we we were using es2015 now angular
saying es2017 is safe to use so
that's it module we said es next but
yeah here it is to es2020 so which is
absolutely fine
and then there are some angular related
flags
which will
uh
which will be used in terms of angular
you don't have to worry about it right
now and then you have out here as we see
as we have seen right where all the
outputs gets generated
and
now
whenever you write code in angular you
will be writing two types of code most
of the time so you will be writing
application related code and you will be
writing unit test
angular says all the unit tests which
will be automatically generated for you
uh we will be seeing some command which
will generate all the files you don't
have to generate files manually so
everything will be generated will be
created using angular click
both files will be generated by angular
cli for us
and this
spec.json will be used by all the unit
test files so angular generates all the
unit test file as named as
spec.ds so you can see here it says
include spec.ts so all the unit test
file will be named as spec.ds and this
configuration file ts configure
spec.json will be used to compile those
pack.ds files and
you will be writing
rest of the code which is like dot ts
files which is your which is our
application code
that will be compiled using ts
config.type.js so that's the value
difference
so now as we know about ts config files
let's move up so readme.md is something
which will be used only for like your
repositories for example if you upload
your project on github github actually
displays all the information from your
readme and
on your
like on your repository let me show you
quickly
so this is ngrx codebase so you can see
here
this all this information is actually
coming from readme.md that's that's the
purpose of readme.file where you can
give some information about what project
what your project is what are some
commands for example building your
command testing your computer sorry
building your application testing your
application so you can mention all those
to make
contribution to your project easier
then you have package.json so here we
will have all the packages
which we are using and there is two
things i mean dependencies and dev
dependencies which is available here
and there are a few commands which will
be used for example how to run your
application locally how to build it how
to run tests and
you can also run it in watch mode in
case you want to so
it's up to you but
so lot of developers get confused
between dependencies and dev
dependencies so
it's easy to actually identify any
packages which will be used and needed
for your production build goes into
dependencies you need packages which is
just for your development purpose and
it won't be part of your production
build goes into dev dependencies so for
example all the packages related to test
karma karma chrome launcher all these
packages are actually your dev
dependencies even type script
even though we will be writing our code
in typescript typescript is not your
dependency because we are not going to
deploy typescript on production on
production we will be of course
deploying javascript right because your
browsers only understand samsung
lock file is something which is used by
ci in case
log files are generally used by uh your
ci environment
it is it is optional it's up to you
whether you want to use log file or not
in big teams
it's always good practice to use log
files but in case you have a small team
i think prefer uh
deleting this file it's absolutely fine
uh the problem in last teams is that so
many developers will be like
uh adding new packages removing new
packages so look log file make sure that
you all are on the same version in case
someone changes the version they have to
commit log file
the only overhead is in case you add new
packages or you update any packages log
file needs to be updated updated as well
otherwise it will your ci will fill
then you have karmaconf.js file which is
anything with con phase configuration
not conference so
karma.confor.js is it is
it's a karma is actually a task as a
task runner to run your tests
and angular comes with a default unit
testing uh framework which is available
which is jasmine and karma so you'll be
writing your all test cases in jasmine
and then you will be using karma to run
those tests you don't have to
change anything here until you need to
for example you can change your
threshold values
and you can add more
uh this coverage
or coverage reporters it's up to you i
mean you can read more about it from
karma website itself you don't have to
go anywhere else
angular.json will have information
related to your workspace for example
right now in my workspace there is one
application which is hotel inventory app
in case you add more projects
this
config this angular.json file will have
all this information about every project
each and every project
git ignore is a file to ignore some
files which should not be checked in
and you can see here we have node
underscore modules because this node
module should not be checked in never do
that i mean it's like some node module
should be
installed every time whenever you are
running it on ci or if someone takes
the latest project so it should not be
checked in
and then you have editor config it's
like uh you can
the advantage of having enter config
file is
the advantage of having editor config
file is you can actually
set up your environment your local
editor
based on some settings from any other
editor for example you are a big fan of
some other editor right adam or webstorm
you can bring some configurations here
so that's the purpose of having editor
config browser list rc this is really
important file because based on this
your output will be generated you can
see uh
you can run this command npx browser
list and it will tell you which are the
browsers you are supporting right now so
you can see it supports chrome 95 wedge
94.95
and some other versions right so this is
this is the uh browser list which will
be generated if you are wondering where
is i11 no i 11 is not supported anymore
angular 13 has dropped the support for
i11 in case you want to support just go
ahead and add or remove something from
uh refer to this browser support section
on angular.io and you can also go to
github.com to see all different browsers
right which is available and then what
needs to be done to add those browsers
here so this is browser list rc
now apart from that what we have here is
src folder this is src folder is where
we are going to have fun it means we are
going to write our code here
node modules has said all the packages
which is installed will be available in
node underscore modules folder and
it should not be checked in
so let's see and now let's go back and
talk about src folder what we have again
we will start from the bottom
so first file which we have is test.ts
and again this file is something which
where you don't have to do anything so
this is used by your karma config karma
control gs5
it actually just loads all the files
recursively that's it to all the dot
spec files right so it loads all all
those files and give it to karmacon.js
that's it so you can execute then you
have
style.scss file which is your global
style sheet file so in case you want to
add any global styles you can actually
add it here styles.css
polyfills very important file so you can
see something some some text is written
here and then you have only one import
called zone.js
what is this polyfill.ts
to understand polyfills you have to like
we have to talk a little bit about
javascript
so remember when we were talking about
uh remember when we were talking about
typescript we said typescript can be
compiled down to any version of
javascript we need
does
all the browsers support all the version
of javascript
probably es2017 yes es2015 yes but what
in case we have is 2018 or 2019
even not all the browsers supports a
free feature from es2015 or es2017 so
how to take care of those features
so what you can do is
you can add folly fills for those
features for so what polyfills does is
it will make sure that your code which
you have written are backward compatible
with
some older browser
so for example let's say animations so
when
uh there is one package let me see if i
can find it here
okay this that's removed now we don't
have that anymore but earlier in earlier
version of angular there were few
packages which we need to install in
case you want to support animation on
i11 so of course now i11 support has
been dropped so that is removed
but in case you want to support some
features which is not supported on one
of the browser you can add polyfill so
polyfills will just add some extra code
remember it will always add some extra
code so it will always add some extra
bundle or extra
lines of code to your final bundle so
you may like get
some
performance not performance it but yeah
you may get some larger bun bundle uh if
you add polyfills that's that's the only
thing
why imports zone.js here zone.js is
needed to
run all the code which is
so
zone.js is something which actually
patches a lot of features or a lot of
code which is not supported by some
browsers
uh and used internally by angular that's
it that's the purpose in future angular
team is planning to remove zone.js but
that's uh something which is in
which is still in development so
right now we cannot we cannot remove it
so that's polyfill for us
main.ts what comes in your mind after
hearing this file name main dot is
of course in case you are coming from
java or any uh programming background
you may have heard about main static
public static void main so whenever we
talk about main function which says okay
this is where our execution starts so
this is the same file for angular this
main.ts is entry point where our
application execution starts so whenever
you
like create a new application run it
this is where everything starts so you
have something called if it is running
in production mode this is environment
variables so
it says okay in case i am running in
production mode go ahead and enable prod
mode in case we are not we will run in
development mode first all the
development we are going to do and we
are going to run everything in
development mode and then finally we
will create broad bundle which will be
deployed on our production server
here also we have something called
bootstrap app module we will talk about
this in shoes
in upcoming
section right now
don't worry about it the only thing
which you want to understand here is
this main dot ts is our main entry point
then you have index.html which is our
main index.html which will be served
remember we said
sorry
so this is main index.html which will be
served to your user
so angular is sba single page
application
and i'm sure you uh so most of you are
already aware of this concept called spa
because
all the frameworks which you use
nowadays we talk about sp single page
applications
we will talk about spas in detail once
we go to routing
this is fair icon this is something
which you see on all the websites
this icon which is you can see github
icon here that's fair icon
then you have uh environments folder
where you can actually create your
environment variables based on different
environment you have so right now there
is two environment.ts which will be used
for development
environment.ts which will be used for
production we will create some more
environment variables in future just to
give you some idea how you can create it
right now you can see there is only one
property called production
so make sure whenever you add more
properties you should add it in both
files otherwise your
product build may fail or any
environment very environment based
uh
file which you have created may fail
assets this is where we are going to
keep our keep
our assets so what is assets in
programming right so whenever you work
with front end of course you will have
images some static files everything goes
into assets so
just don't give keep it anywhere else
make sure that you are adding into an
asset folder
then you have app this is now finally
this is the folder where we are going to
write our app
sorry this is the folder where we are
going to write our code
so you have an app module here
component.ts pack.ts then you have a
style
stylesheet file says css file
html this is where you are going to
write your html files and then you have
app routing why this file is here this
is related to routing so don't worry
about right now we will talk about this
while so when you once you say
do you need routing module
remember the question which we had do
you need a routing module when you said
say yes this file will be created and of
course in case you need routing
functionality
you should say yes
so these are the files so you have
modules component
and
now let's
move ahead
before we go ahead and
write our code or we just talk about
this
module which is available here
component.ts files which is available
here let's talk about important thing so
we said in angular you can create
multiple projects
within your workspace
that's something called monorepo
so what is monorail so
mono repose is something where you can
actually
have multiple applications so in angular
you
by
when i say multiple applications
you can have multiple application and
libraries both you can actually create
angular applications as well as
libraries and inside a single
workspace
you can also deploy
multiple applications from your
monoreport that's advantage for example
let's say you have
a client who has like the admin
dashboard and then there they have a
client facing in client-facing
application what you can do is you can
just have both the application in a
single monorepo and you can also create
libraries which will like be shared code
between or between both the applications
and then you can also deploy both
application from the
mono repo itself
it also makes sharing the code between
multiple projects easy so you uh you
have like a separate team which is
working on admin application a separate
team which is working on your client
facing application or public facing
application
what they can do is they can create like
extract the common codes keep it in
library share it across and then use it
saves a lot of effort lot of time and
it makes like
collaboration between multiple teams
much easier
so this is uh it from here
uh the the workspace and monorail now
let's talk about
few things a few files again main.tas
and other files
i'll show you the
connection between this files and your
angular.json file how they are connected
so let's go to angular.json file and
this is our project right now hotel
inventory
it has project type so this is how you
can identify if a project is library or
application application is of course
your
application which can be deployed
somewhere and then which has like your
visual visuals or front-end application
kind of thing so that's application
library something which is which will
have your reusable codes
and you can use those libraries build
those use it or publish it on nvm those
are libraries
so let's go ahead and see
so there are few properties so first
this
hotel inventory app what is the source
route for this application so it says
src so this is this is the folder in
case we create a new application we will
see that later on you will see the
source route will be a different folder
prefix will come back to this
before that let's see some more options
here
so here uh the first property which you
have is output path this is where all
the final bundles or final code to be
deployed will be created we'll talk
about this then you have index file so
remember we said okay this is the
default index.html which will be served
to the consumer
do
does it need to be index.html the answer
is no you can name it whatever you want
but
mapping should be here so you have index
which will
uh which have a path to index.html so
this file
similarly main main.t is again so this
is referring to this file so it can be
any file name i'm just saying okay this
is the mapping this is how they are
mapped
once you start building your application
then polyfills of course it is defined
here so in case you want to add like
uh you want to have a common polyfill
for let's say you have monorepo with 10
applications now
do i need to actually have multiple
polyfill.ts the answer is no you can
actually go ahead and just create a
polyfill.ts somewhere
in a common folder and then use it
that's possible
ts config as we mentioned for app ps
config.json will be used
and there is a new property called
inline style language you can earlier uh
writing in line sas was not supported
now this so that's this is the property
which is used
and what will be uh
actually
available inside your assets folder so
you have fab icon and then assets folder
so once you uh let's say keep some
images uh in your let's say separate
folder right generally try to move them
into assets folder but in case you are
keeping it somewhere you can actually
just pass a path here
style.scss this is your global styling
global style.css
and in case you want to include more
styles you can actually mention it here
for example let's say you want to add
bootstrap you want to use angular
material you can apply or add all those
paths here
this scripts uh you can actually load
some js files as well so you can
actually give path here in case you have
some requirement to load some external
javascript otherwise just don't
so these are the files which is related
now
let's go back to main.cs
so here you have your main.ts and let's
run this application and then we will
see the flow how it actually
goes to this
what is this module and then how you get
your first page
so to do that i'll just open
so we go inside hotel inventory yeah let
me zoom in a little bit
now here you have to run a command
called ng serve
hyphen o
to run this application locally so i'll
say
i don't want to actually share this
information
it's up to you you can just change it to
yes if you are
working on some side project
so meanwhile it is getting compiled
let's go back here so here
as we said so this is your main entry
point to the application and it goes to
so it goes to this bootstrap model so
whenever use your main.ts
executes it goes to this bootstrap
module and it bootstraps and module
which is app module
and let's see what is available here
and it has something uh called app model
class actually and then on top of app
module there is something called add
three ng module so what is this let's
let's talk about this and then we will
move on to next topic
in angular everything is a class right
so you can see this app module it's a
class
component it's a class
but to bootstrap your application you
need a minimum one module remember this
so in angular we call this as a root
module
in future it may be possible that you
don't need modules anymore but right now
we need modules what we do using module
we will also talk about that so right
now let's talk about this so
uh this class this is your root module
which will actually have information
about all the components which will be
created
what is component yes we will talk about
that as well
it will also contain the information of
any third party library or any angular
specific library which is being used
so if you see this import section
it has something called browser module
and app routing module so this
browser module is actually an angular
module which is available as part of
angular platform browser library and app
routing module is created by us when we
started our
when we create a created r application
so when any angular module which needs
to be used
needs to be imported into imports array
any uh components directive and pipes
remember these three words we will talk
about all these three any component
directives and pipes needs to be
registered by declarations array
and this ng module will have all the
information about different components
different angular modules which is being
used or any module which you have
created by your own
it means i can have any number of
modules i can create n number of modules
in my application
but it needs at least one root module
and that's why angular creates one by
default
and this will be loaded once you
start your application or once you build
your application
so this is from where your execution
starts so now it gets uh goes to app
module app module knows everything about
my application it knows what are the
different components what are different
modules i am using
and it gives that information to your
compiler
now after this
let's go ahead and talk about
this at the retention point
now your compiler needs to know that
whatever class i am actually uh
compiling what type of class is that
what is this at the rate engi model
remember just
in typescript we discuss something about
decorators so and we mentioned that
angular uses lot of decorators
so this at the right ng module is a
decorator so what decorator does it
modifies the behavior of your class so
what this add that ng module is doing
here it is giving all this metadata
information that okay what are the
different components i am using what are
the different modules angular modules i
am using to the compiler
then you have something called bootstrap
app component so now
once you compile all the files your
angular application needs to know that
okay which component
will be loaded first what is component
now let's go ahead and talk about what
is component
so it
goes to this app component.ts right so
you can see you have component.ts and
whenever you create a component you will
get four files so let's talk about those
four files so you will get a ts5
you will get a spec.ts file where you
will write your unit test you will get a
css file or css file or whatever type
style sheet you have selected
third and you will get an html file your
where you can write your html code so
these four files will be great
now coming component
so components are actually your views
which will be actually rendered to the
end user so here this is my first
component so similar to my root module
which is we said app module
we
will have one root component this is our
root component that's why also the
selector is named as approach we'll talk
about what this selector means and what
that template you are in cellular is but
that's why they are it is named
mentioned as as root because we need a
root component as well now let's come
back here so bootstrap we have mentioned
that okay this is my root component and
this root component will be loaded on
your index.html
it means
in case i want to load any other view or
any other component in future where i
can load it i can load it within this
app component.ts so
now let's talk about all other files so
now we are aware that okay this
component this is the component of view
which will be available for us
now and these are the four files so html
is where we will be writing our our
html code and in case you create new
components and it needs to be rendered
you will add that into app component or
testimony
let's talk about this properties first
so we have this first property which is
named as selector
so
when you create component actually what
you do is you create a view how it will
be rendered it will be rendered using an
html tag if you go to index.html this is
your html tag and that's what you will
be creating so you will be creating
multiple reusable html tags which i can
go ahead and use anywhere i want to
those are components so you go to any
library or any framework ui framework
they will give you this custom html tags
this is what you will be creating you
will be creating those custom html tags
and then you can render it anywhere you
want to
so here the selector becomes your html
tag
then of course it needs to render some
html so
you can do it in two ways in angular you
can either have a separate
html file separate where you can write
your html or you can also use inline
html as well so this template url now
points to this html it says okay
whatever html is rendered right now it's
coming from this html so if i go to this
as low plus four to double zero all this
information is actually available here
so let's remove it and
i'll create an h1 i'll say
hello
what
right so
and you can see as soon as i press
save
this will be automatically compiled so
this uh
in angular
the ng surf command
runs in a watch mode what i mean by
watch mode it keeps
and watch on all the changes which you
make in your file just on your file
system or in
your workspace
not everything is washed so
let's say if i make some changes to
angular.json or package.json it won't be
actually washed are you make any changes
inside your src folder most of them will
be watched and it will just restart the
server which is running here so you can
see
let's
press ctrl s and you can see compile
successfully because of course there
were
there were not any changes so it was so
fast that we didn't even realize but it
says okay the build time was this
so we have hello world here but let's
see how you can actually make it
inline as well i'll remove this i'll
comment this uh template url property we
will be using template url i always
prefer having another html file
to write our template
in case you want to do it in line you
can use template property
so i can just say
hello world
from
inline
template
all right
let's save and
you have hello world from inline
template
and i can also of course add
h1
and you can also see
uh
i have installed angular inline uh
angular language services i'll talk
about that as well
i was getting an intellisense whenever
right whenever i was writing the inline
html tag so let's let's let me tell you
you can go to uh extensions and you can
actually go ahead and install angular
language service this is the angular
language service
it's
created and maintained by angular team
itself so it gives you all the
intelligence inside your vs code even it
gives you all the errors inside vs code
so you don't have to worry about like
getting those errors while compiling or
building your application most of the
errors you will actually get inside your
editor for example let's try this out i
think
okay this works
yeah but here you can see it is giving
me option that okay there is
open h1 tag
so uh this is
inline html template but but in case you
have multi-line htmls
sometimes you may don't want to actually
create a separate file for your template
but it's multi-line so you cannot do it
in a single line
that's possible as well so what you have
to do is you have to rather single
quotes you have to use the stick
operator
remember we use this in typescript as
well so i can mention p
let's use p tag and i can say
angular is
awesome
and now you have multi-line html right
so
just add the this tick operator and then
move your html
here so you can see the output is
available here so this is how you can do
it in multi-line html as well i'll just
keep this here so you can refer it in
future
you have style urls same so i either i
can have another file
to create all the style sheets sorry all
the styles related to this component
and
or
i can just have inline styles as well so
it's up to you whatever whatever you
prefer i'm not that good in those
styles i mean i can
probably
yeah i can write some css but i mean i
that not that advanced right so it's up
to you which styles you want to use
let it be a separate file or you can
also use styles property to give you
or to write your inline styles so i can
say okay the such one will have
let's see
i'll commend this one and then we can
use inline styles where we are saying
this h1
if we have one yeah we we do have
and it will have the color red so this
is how you can write it in
inline
and as we said
now you can also use inline sas
code as well here earlier it was not
supported so just keep that in mind with
angular 12 it is supported now
i'll just comment this as well
okay so this is about component and we
also discuss about module so now what we
can do is
we can create our new component and then
we will start learning about
the next topic or next concept
which is template syntax because of
course this is uh important whenever you
want to start working on a new ui
framework you the first thing which you
have to
understand is of course the language
which we have learned about which is
typescript and the next thing is the
template engine how to write your
templates and let's get into that
so first thing first i mean first what
we are going to do is we will be
creating a new component and we will be
writing our code inside that particular
component
okay before we move up before mo uh we
go ahead and create a new component
i want to again talk about the selector
property remember uh
there was
in angular.json there was a prefix
called app
so this prefix is actually used whenever
you create a new component in your html
tag name so here app root is your html
tag name and app is a prefix angular
says whenever you are creating a new
component have some prefix
just to avoid conflict with any other
html element which may exist so if i
just keep it root there is possibility
that root may be another html tag
defined somewhere
it can be native it can be created by
some other library
or it may be created in future
inside
let's say inside html as well so have
some prefix generally
it should be
it should start with whatever your
application is or let's say some people
also some some companies also keep it on
based on the company name right so or
the application name whatever you prefer
so right now we have app but we can
change it to whatever
we want so here let's say uh
[Music]
i can change it to hotel inventory
right so hotel inventory app
so i can say h i
i know it sounds really bad
hinv for example hotel inventory right
so short for every inventory
or let's say if you uh have some
specific hotels right for whom you are
creating this particular app you can
keep the select prefix based on that now
if you change it here you have to
actually go ahead and change it
here as well and
once you do this you have to go ahead
and change into index.html as well so
you have to say okay this
won't be
abroad but hotel inventory management
hotel inventory road right so
uh or
you can also do it while you're while
you are creating your app so you can say
create engineer your application name
hyphen fn prefix equals to whatever you
want
but up to you i mean whatever way you
want to do it
so let's see if it still works
yeah as i mentioned we made changes
right now to
angular.json and
any angular.json related changes are not
watched so we have to stop our server
and run it again so let's do that
here and we'll draw and serve again um
and meanwhile let's go ahead and
start
preparing or start talking about the new
the next topic which is
template uh syntax right so we will talk
for template engine and you have hello
world again but if you see hello world i
mean just let me show you one more thing
here
i can go to
[Music]
inspect and here
you will notice
this is your html tag
hi nb root right and then you have h1
tag available here so this is
the html tag you created
right now
time to create our own component so here
uh what we will be doing is we will be
creating
will be creating a hotel inventory
management app so let's create some
views
around that right so
first
what is important if uh
hotel wants to manage his inventory what
is the most important inventory
rooms right so room seems the most
important inventory they have so what we
will do is we will create a component
so how you can create a component is you
can say ng
g
which is short for generate so you can
also write generate if you want to
we'll be using shortcut and then you
have component
which is also there is a shortcut to
write we can write c
and then your component name or your
view name whatever you want to give it
so let's say uh i want to
now create a component called rooms
so which can have information about all
the rooms the
uh what it has right now
and whenever you do that as we mentioned
this will create four files you have
html css pack.ts and then your tsl ts
file is where you will be writing your
code html file where you will be writing
your views
to get the list of all
commands
you don't have to remember those
remember just just keep that in your
mind you don't have to remember all the
commands all the options you can just go
to docs and at the end of the docs you
have the cli command reference
and you can read all the commands in
case there are some changes in future
there that will be updated in case you
get a new command in future that will be
added here as well so you have all the
information related to cli commands
and this is our application
so let's close this
so now we have created our first
component
let's try to
right now just uh see what is here it
says room works
let's go back to our application on
sorry let's go back to the browser and
see what is available here so we just
have hello world
so in case i want to render this
rooms component or any information
related to rooms component right now
i have to
add this html tag here because this is
our entry component
and you will see okay it says rooms work
it means the new component which we have
created is getting rendered perfectly
fine you don't have to do anything
let's go ahead and add some information
so
let's talk about templates
first question why you create front-end
application
okay if you're wondering you get paid
for it yes you that's that's the
different uh answer but what else right
so we create front end because we want
to display some information to the end
user
that's the whole purpose i mean of
course i can create apis and i can ask
my users to just hit those api and get
information right that
that's uh that's developers that's that
information is relevant to developers
but for end users the information which
is available on some some front-end
application that's what matters so you
get paid for that
and it means whatever code we have to
write we have to eventually go ahead and
bind that data to our html our view
that's where it will be available so
let's now let's see how you can actually
do that in angular every
language every library has their
different syntax to work with templates
so how you will do it in angular so here
we have already
discussed about component introduction
we have also already already discussed
about how great you you can create a
first component
so we'll just skip here and then we'll
come back come to just binding syntax
so let's see
so how you can bind that information to
your friend
let's close this
so there are three ways uh to bind your
information which is available in your
ts5
to your html so you have interpolation
you have property binding you have even
event binding
so let's see first interval
interpolation
you can use interpolation syntax with
any basic data for example if you have
date
if you have a string you have number
those information can be binded using
interpolation even uh you can work with
objects
using interpolation so
uh let's see
what we will do is we will create um
uh let's say hotel link so this is my
first property
and
i'll just print hilton hotel right so
this is the hotel name for like if let's
say this hotel name we want to display
on our view right now
using interpolation syntax so you can
just go to html
i will put an h1 tag here
right
and i'll say welcome
welcome to and you can put double curly
brackets
and put your variable name so hotel name
is my variable name right
and just save
let's go back to the browser
and it says welcome to return so this is
how your interpolation syntax textbooks
so this is string of a variable of type
string
you remember we said
inference so it is able to infer that
okay this property should be string and
then we are displaying it using the
interpolation syntax
angular allows you to
also use
so let's talk about the second way
which is property binding so angular
allows you to actually use
native html attribute properties
for binding as well
so what i mean by that
so
actually i can have a div
and i can bind
a value directly to this this div
to any valid property of this particular
tube so remember do you remember any uh
valid property of div
so in case uh
you don't it's absolutely fine you can
just go to uh mozilla docs right msdn
and read about all the html tags and
basic javascript
so i'll
use one property which is known as inner
text so there is a property called inner
text
equals to
i'll say
here
i
i'll create another property i'll say
this is number of rooms
so let's say we have 10 10 rooms
available in this hotel
and then i can just use number of firms
here
so what is the difference so gen
generally uh you use this in a text
property something like this
this is this
javascript code so generally we do
document
dot get element by id and then you get
an element by id and then you are
applying a text this is normal
javascript this is how you do it in
javascript but in angular you can
actually just avoid all this code and
just directly do it here so you have
inner text remember this box that's the
extra layer of syntactical sugar which
we are adding which angular is adding
and then you are just saying okay this
variable name should be bound to this in
a text property and i can say okay this
is
a number of rooms
right
and you will see number of rooms
available 10. so this is property
binding uh remember you can only use it
with any valid html property of any
valid html tag
if i try to use
inner text
i'm getting inline error remember i said
angular language service can give you
that that's it if i save this you will
also get this information everywhere so
you are getting this here you will be
getting it in your command line and as
soon as you fix this
and say okay this is the property it
will be gone from here it will be gone
from your
[Music]
view so it's back and that's it
now
once you create front end of course you
need to display information but you need
to do one more thing as well you may
need to actually collect information
so how to collect information so
of course in
uh you may want your user to interact
with your application it means you may
want your user to raise the events i
mean probably us
save some information or
probably in some cases retrieve some
information based on some filters
so you need those right so you need to
need a way to actually raise the events
as well
so the third way is something which is
known as event binding
right so let's talk about even binding
now
in plain javascript we just do something
like this so let's create a button
and we use click equals to a function
name so here you probably will be using
a function name in javascript
in angular you will do some just little
bit extra so here
um sorry in
javascript you say on click so you'll be
some doing something like on click goes
to your function name in angular as i
said every programming languages or
every
framework has their own
different
template syntax or template engine
in angular you have to just put it in
this banana syntax so this this is known
as banana syntax and this is known as
box syntax
so it's
put any event just remove on put a
banana syntax and that's your angular
event
now on click equals to i can create a
function so i'll create a function
called toggle
and i'll say this is toggle
so right now we are getting an error
because this toggle function does not
exist let's go ahead and implement it
let's go to ds and write a toggle
function
and what this toggle function will do is
let's say it will hide show hide the
rooms
so i'll create another property hide
which is equals to false
and whenever we click on toggle and set
this dot height rooms is equals to not
this dot height rooms right so we want
to toggle the value
and here
i'll create a div here
and i'll move this information
here
and then we will be using
a property binding syntax so
hidden is a property which i think all
available on almost all the html tags
which exist so hidden equals to
hide rooms
it's a boolean property right so true or
false also true
let's see
so let's go back
so right now we have number of rooms
click on toggle and they are gone so
remember but uh this
this div still exists here right because
hidden is a property and i can just
remove it and then display this
information again so toggle
uh what we are doing is we are raising
an event which is going and going ahead
and updating a property and then
our viewer is updated accordingly
i'll show you one more thing how you can
actually debug your application because
that will be uh beneficial for
for upcoming uh videos and in case you
get into some issues you will be able to
figure those as well
so here in sources panel you will be
able to see all the components all the
files which you have written this is
your code
right so i can just go to
not here
so go to pages and you will be able to
see all the files in dot folder so you
you will be able to see localhost for
double zero and then you will be able to
solve them back
and then dot folder is where your code
exists
so
app and then you have your rooms
and
you have your dot ts file let's add a
breakpoint here click on toggle and you
have your breakpoint available right so
your debugger available here so you can
see okay uh right now the hydro property
is true and we are upgrading it to true
to false and now it is available here so
this is how you can actually add
breakpoints find files you can also use
a shortcut so you can press ctrl p
and open any file so you can just type
app dot so let's say
i want to open app modules so you can
hear it do that here or let's say
rooms right so i can just say room start
component.ts and that's it so you can
also search in case you have a lot of
files of course you won't be wasting
your time going through it you can just
open the sources panel press ctrl p this
is on windows i in i'm sure probably
this will be the same across all the uh
different os for chrome so control p and
then just type the file name
the same
command control p works for your vs code
as well so let's say if you have
thousands of files how you will search
for a file we can press ctrl p
start typing the file name and that's it
so you can move to any file by using the
shortcuts
so this is uh it from the binding syntax
you will learn about interpolation you
learn about property binding you learn
about event binding and this is what we
are going to use for
all our
upcoming tutorials
in this video we are going to talk about
directives
so we will see types of directives and
we will also see built-in directives in
this particular video and later on in
this course we will also see how you can
build your own custom directives yeah so
let's go ahead and see what directives
are so directives are something which
can change behavior or appearance of
your dom element
they are kind of like
and uh you can say that they are a
reusable function which you can apply on
any dom element which you have in your
application and then if you want to
change that behavior of your dom or
let's say appearance of that dom you can
achieve that via directive
directors can implement all life cycle
look we have not
learned about lifecycle hooks right now
it will be in upcoming videos but just
remember this
while implementing you can also
implement all the lifecycle loops
because we will be using that later on
the one difference between your
components and directives are
they cannot have templates remember we
when we uh went through all the
components we said
there will be four files every time
and there was one template one style
sheet uh then we have your you'd uh
sorry your spec.ts and then your dslr in
directives you will be having
you won't be having
a template file so it will be just have
uh your directives will just contain
your logic
so let's talk about types of directories
which we have so there are two types
which is one is structural directives
and one is attribute based directive
structural directives are always
costlier because they are going to
implement
uh sorry
structural directives are always
costlier because they are going to
change the behavior of your dom which
may give you performance
uh
performance issues as well
attribute directives you will be using a
lot of the time probably most of the
time you will be creating your own
attribute based directive rather than
structured directive
so let's go ahead and use some built-in
directives which we have available and
later on
uh and we will also talk about what are
the structured directives and attribute
based directive which we have while
going through each built-in directives
here so first we will
we will go through ng if ngif directive
and let's see what we can achieve using
ngif directive let's go back to our code
this is our code
here
so uh what we will do is we will also uh
we'll create on one interface where we
will have some
information about our rooms
so let's go ahead and do that let's
create the interface i'll call it as
rooms
so this is our interface name
then we can say
export interface remember the typescript
section where we created our interfaces
and i'll call it as room
and let's see uh
what this room uh property is going to
have
it will have as of now we will we will
keep adding more properties as we
go but right now let's say we have
label rules
which is number
then we have
book
rules
and
let's have these two properties as of
now and then we'll
see later on
and here i'm going to create a rooms
property
which will be type of
room
which is imported from you can see
actually due to
angular language service it auto it can
actually auto import out this is
something which is also enabled in vs
code so
you can just go to room
and uh it's not going to be arrayed
it's an object
and here
i'll say available rooms is 10 and
booked rooms is five
and let's
have
total rooms as well
so let's say you have total rooms as 20
but you're just
booking for
15 right so where you have five
available and five booked and five
probably
somehow something on hold or something
like that right or
going through construction so
you have this now you you have this data
available and what we are going to do is
let's first see in the spelling i think
i'm not sure why i keep
rooms
somehow
so you have total rooms available rooms
and book room so what we are going to
achieve using this property is we will
be using nge if directive we will see an
example of
directive
and let's say if available rooms is
greater than zero
we want to display a section where uh
probably you can see which which rooms
are available right list
of rooms which are available in future
right now we don't have the rooms list
so here let's see how we can achieve
remember we said
we can also use all the valid properties
of
html while doing property binding and we
saw an example of hidden but there was
one problem with hidden attribute
so he
so the problem was if you inspect this
element and see this
number of rooms and just let's click
toggle
even though uh that particular div uh
element is hidden it is still available
on your dom and
when you have lot of dom elements on
your you
your view
it will cause performance issues
so what we can do
but in case
i don't display this storm element until
unless i need it
or i can just remove it whenever
i don't have any rooms available so in
that case my dom dom element will be
fewer than what we can expect in case we
display all the elements
so let's go ahead and try to achieve
that
so i'll create a new div
here
and here i'll say
for example i am going to display rooms
list here in future when we have a list
of rooms
let's see if okay remove this breakpoint
first
and we get this rooms list
now
the cases in case rooms are available i
want to display this entire thing i mean
i can have anything here right i can
have a list i can have whatever i want
to
in future we are going to have list
basically so here what we will do is i
can just access this rooms
property here and using the ng if
directive so star ng
if
is equals to
i can say rooms
dot
total sorry available rooms
if it is
greater than zero
i want to display this so rooms list
right now of course our available rooms
are greater than zero so we will get
this rooms list and it is available here
now let's go ahead and change
the
available rooms to zero
and let's come back here okay so that
particular div is gone but let's inspect
the element this is this is where it
gets interesting right so you can see
that div entire date is gone it's not
available in your dom so something which
let's say there are some some
secure information which you don't want
to display to all user but let's say you
want to
enable that particular
area or you want to display that
particular section
in some particular case
that's it you have
the perfect use case for ngf try to use
ngif as much as possible don't rely on
the hidden attribute so
that's one thing
now let's go ahead and change this
to
them
so we have learned about ng if directive
now
let's
let's go ahead and see what our what
else is there so we have ng4 okay before
we go to ng4
before we go to ng4 i'll i want to show
you some
some more
i can say syntax which you can use so
here
in a typescript this is something uh
uh this is known as optional chaining
and there are two two
uh sorry there are two features which
are actually enabled in typescript which
is optional chaining and null knowledge
collision collision you can actually use
both inside template as well let me show
you some example so let's say if
my rooms
my room's property right
if my room's property is not available
what i can
also do is i can say no rooms
so let's see
so what i will do here is
i'll say rooms
is this
and i'll just
have to make it optional let's do that
quickly so
question mark question mark
question
and i will commend
this
i'll keep it here so i can we can go
ahead and use it later on but let's see
so we have we don't have any uh data
available for rooms
let's see what we get here
so we are getting an error so it says
rooms dot available rooms is greater
than zero and it says object is possibly
undefined
but in this case now what we can do so
of course this will be taken care by
knowledge pollution operator but you can
also use the
optional chaining here
you can put a question mark
and
let's see
sorry
i can do something
rules
and
if rooms and
rooms
dot available rooms is greater than zero
let's see if it works
uh-huh
let's uh let's see uh we have made some
changes so we are saying rooms dot
available rooms so in case rooms is
available we will display only rooms
list
here let's see what it displays okay it
is showing object object which of course
makes sense because
we have to change
we have to check for an individual
object right and so here
i can say
i can just use the same so i'm saying if
uh
rooms dot available rooms
is available
then uh it's okay otherwise just go
ahead and display no rooms and it should
work yeah so you have no rooms available
in case there is uh the available rows
available rooms does not exist so this
is something which you can use which is
null collision operator and this is
optional chaining so you can say okay
before accessing this variable go ahead
and check if this exists or not so this
is really useful in case you want to
bind some object you don't have to worry
about it i mean
whether this object exists or not so we
generally do write if uh and else that
so you don't have to do if an else here
you can just put a question mark and try
to access an object if object exists it
will print it if doesn't exist it will
just leave it right i mean for example
this rooms list right now available
rooms does not exist so it is not
displaying room list that's it so these
are two uh operators which is really
useful while working in angular template
they are available inside your
typescript file as well so feel free to
use them there also
now once uh now we know about these
operators and we know about ngif let's
go ahead and do some uh extra stuff
right so rooms list we said uh we want
to
display rooms list in case we have
available rooms now let's go ahead and
put this code back
let's see it breaks the template it
doesn't so we we still have rooms list
and it displays the number of rooms
which is available so
which is
this this line of code
so rather than this dip i could have
just used this which will take care of
yeah i mean in case my rooms does not
like uh there are no available rooms it
will also show norms
so let's
see this
available rooms is greater than zero
object is possibly undefined i can just
remove let's see
dot available rooms okay do i need to
check if it is undefined
let's see
so available rooms not equals to
undefined and
rooms
okay i'm still getting this set up
somewhere
because of this question mark which
let's remove it
which make it makes the value as
undefined as well so you should not be
getting it anymore
numbers html
okay let's
change
rooms dot available rooms greater than
zero
right first
so we have like our uh now we want to
display here groups list now we need
rooms data so we need uh rooms list data
so what we will do is we will create an
interface
and we will call it as
room
list
let's add some properties so first thing
which we will do is room type
right so you can have like
there are multiple room types
which is let's say right now string
and uh what else we can have
well
our room can have amenities right
we will say this is amenities
which is as of now string
then the price of this particular room
which is
number
and
what else what else room can have
i can of course i mean it is the the
room type is there it can have an image
right so photos
which is uh which can be string area of
string but let's let's say we right now
we have only one one photo so
this is
and
uh
available
i want one daytime property as well
so we can have check-in time
right so we will also
have one date property
and
check out time so we have string number
date
so yeah i think this is enough this is
more than enough uh information
now let's go ahead and create some data
so i'll say room
list let's just type of
chrome
list
and uh this is going to be adding so
just
and let's say room type uh amenities
price
and then we have
photos let's take some something from uh
unsplash second time let's say we have
uh
[Music]
let's put some date
uh 11th
11th
november 2021
and check out time this
and we have to say new date
and then
in your application just try to use some
uh
date
time from daytime uh library for example
state data finance whatever your uh
you have decided for your
application so when it is
price let's say i'll just increase to
increase 2 000
sorry
photos
let's take the same photo
as of now
and then we have chicken time and
you have chicken time so
and this won't be deluxe room but let's
say
private
suit
and
rest of the things are almost same
let's increase the price to 15
okay so we have this list of records
available here now let's
try to bind it
now we know how to bind
values like string number boolean we
also know how to bind objects now
but what about arrays so let's try
binding areas here right so rooms
list i can say rooms
list so just let's place it here as it
is
and we have something called object
object object so it says okay there is
some object which has three records so
you can see it actually printed it
thrice so it means okay there are three
records but i'm not sure how to read it
so what's uh the way to read it yep that
is this is where we our next directive
will come handy which is ng ng4 we will
be using ng4 so it's like for loop
which will look through each and every
record and display this information
in the way we want to
so generally uh what how you display uh
area of information right on your web
page the
in if i have talked about in html
probably we will be using some data
table right
so right now let's use table and in
future what we will do is we will remove
this table and we will use something
from third party ui library because in
your real-time project you are not going
to create table
probably never
you will be using some ui library so you
should learn about that and that's what
we will do in
probably in upcoming video where we will
remove this table and then we will
replace it with uh with angular material
table
why we are learning it right now because
angular material table will uh
will actually avoid or
you can say uh it will it will give you
a wrapper where you don't have to write
this code so you should learn about ng4
in case you have to work with area of
records
but
as you said angular material table takes
care of everything so it will do it do
internally all those things you know you
won't be actually writing this code
but this ng4 directive will be useful
for a lot of other cases where you have
actually era of data and you want to
bind it so let's uh
use
table
and
we'll say okay first uh there is a tr
and then dh
we have room number room okay not room
number
but
we are okay viral number can be on
property which we missed
and let's add it here
so it's room number one
[Music]
number two and
so number three so okay so we have a
room number property as well so let's
see uh the headers so we have room
number room num room type
then what else
so this will be our table headers room
price
then we have uh
room status we don't have but let's say
we will
have amenities right we have amenities
so we have room number room type
amenities price is there
photo we will use later on check in time
checkout time because uh we want to
actually uh see some
[Music]
date time pipe as well and just talk
about it later let's see so right now
let's display this checkout and chicken
and check out time
check
time so let's use only one chicken time
here
this is it so this is our
header
and now we want to display the
information so let's come back here and
have another tr
and now we want to what we want to do is
we want to create multiple rows remember
so dr means of course your table rows
which will be created for each and every
record so this is where you will be
applying your ng for
so i'll say okay this is ng 4
is equals to let's see how the syntax is
so you can select
room
of
rooms
list
okay what happened here
okay it's not rooms list it's long list
okay so now this will this uh for loop
will run for each record inside room
list so we have three records right now
and now let's display the information so
we have room number type price
room dot
okay room
what's wrong here
see this
what's wrong yes td
room dot
okay let's
generally we should get intelligence but
somehow the intelligence is not working
okay so we have price then we need
amenities
so let's
copy the properties right now amenities
and then we have check-in time and
that's another property check-in time
okay so now we have our room list
available let's go ahead and see
so let's go ahead and see that on the ui
here you can see all the information is
available in a tabular format so i think
check-in time
okay we have to change
it is what happened to this it is not
just number two i mean it is
you get a change something here i'm
going to teach them when it is now this
is a string
okay i think i just copy pasted
something
hmm checking time
which will be
here
so let's go ahead and see the ui and
this is uh this is the information which
we have available in tabular format so
we have a room number we have room type
we have room price
but then we have amenities and then this
is your date format so by default the
you can see angular displays the long
date format which we can change we will
change this date format later on
right now let's uh go ahead and see
what happened here so we have ng for
loop available which like works for each
record which is available in your array
there are a few more properties which ng
for us let's talk about those
rather than uh actually uh ng4 can also
give you access to two few more things
which is
uh even and odd values so in case i want
to find out which row is even and which
row is odd ng4 gives you that so i can
say let
e equals to even
and let o equals to r
and let's print it here right so i'll
say this is
one more header
even
[Music]
and
let's see
i mean if it's even display even or
display out simple logic right so you
can see even odd even so this is how
your information is getting displayed so
using even or not values
what else we also have an index value
available so in case you want to get a
hold of an unique value for your row and
you don't have any unique values you
just want to display a running number
while actually displaying your records
that's possible you can say let
i equals to index
and here let's say
i will add one more
[Music]
ph
we can say dd and this is display i
remember this is an index value so it
starts from zero so don't uh
don't be shocked once you see okay it's
why it is giving
zero because of course this is index so
starts from 0 you will say 0 1 so this
is it so you have this few values which
is available
we will talk about one more um
a very important property or of ng for
let's
do it later because uh that will require
some extra code to be written like we
need services and all
uh to see an example
ng for every every time uh the thing is
whenever you have ng for a
directive used
in case something gets changed it will
re-render all the records within this
data you can actually improve the
performance of this particular ng for
which we will see in a separate section
how you can improve that
but right now this is it this is the
basics which you need to know about
while working with ng4
so we are done with ng if and we are
done with ng4 but we we didn't discuss
about one thing you remember this star
what with this star is
okay we uh we have been discussed about
it so let's let's uh let's talk about
that star
remember we said there are two types of
directives attribute-based directive and
structural directives
so how you will differentiate between
structural directives and attribute this
directive so that's the star which
actually lets you know
or
there is one more way
generally in all the built-in directives
which has star or structural directives
yes that's uh that's what that's true
and
other uh like ng class and ng style they
are attribute based directive
so your structural directives can modify
your dom remember this
here
if you see your
uh
list on your
view right now
you can see actually we just on in our
code base we just have dr manley once
who is creating these three tiers or
four tiers
one two three four okay first one is
headers anyways so one two three three
records right who is creating that so
that's the task of ng for star ng4
and it is actually a structural
directive so it can add and modify uh
sorry it can add or remove the dom
element from your view
similarly if you see i mean we had used
ngif it was actually adding the div for
removing the tip
you can actually do that on button click
as well of course by changing the
properties
so that also does the same thing and ge
is also able to add or modify the tom
element so
any directive which can uh
modify your dom element is structural
directive attribute best directives are
something which will probably add some
attribute to your
uh
element or remove something or add some
extra logic to your element based on
some properties but they cannot modify
entire dom that's the difference
so sorry they can modify the dom let's
they can modify the dom but they cannot
add or remove the element from the dom
that's
what your
attribute directives does most of the
time
so let's see
uh
let's talk about ng switch we'll take an
example of ng switch and then we'll talk
about the
rest of two class uh two attribute based
directives which we have
ng switch is something which is uh i
have used very rarely but very useful so
let's see an example what we can do i'm
sure you you might have learned about
switch case statement so ng switch is
kind of
similar
which is available here so
let's see what we can achieve i'll take
an example
simple example here and
let's see so here what we want to do is
for example if i am an user i'm normal
user i don't want to display this room's
information to the user but in case i am
an admin i want to display this rooms
so let's see how we can achieve that
using ng switch
so first what we will do is we'll create
a property here
i'll say this is login type we don't
have login page right now so we'll just
start with mock data
it's a login type and i'll say this is
admin right now
and let's go to our company testimony
here i'll use a div
and i'll use star
ng switch
is equals to
i'll say this is login
type
just
uh
oh let's name it rolled right which
makes more sense
and now
based on
whether the role is admin or
if it's simple user we want to display
different views so here what i will do
is i will say a div
and we will use star ng switch case
is equals to i'll say this is uh
user this is user rule
i want to display you want to actually
use it as string so what i can do is i
can put single quotes inside it remember
if i just remove single quotes it will
treat it as variable as we have seen so
far while binding the data so here i am
i want to treat it as string so i'll say
okay this is a user
and here i can say uh
this is let's say welcome
user right so
this is what you want to display to the
user
if it's not
it's admin
i want to display this room's
information
and uh switch case like uh switch case
statement this
this also has ng switch case uh will
also have
a default one so you can use that
so default i can say you don't
you're not at risk to be this page right
so
let's see right now our
role is admin so we should be able to
see everything
let's change our role
to
user
so we will see that welcome user
thing
so you can now have welcome user and
let's
type users which will say you are not
authorized to view this page so this
your ng switch case
works
so you have like your ng switch where
you are assigning the value and then and
you switch case based on which you can
toggle your view you can display
whatever you want to here
so in this which case uh and ng switch
case default these are the different
uh attributes or you can say
different directives which you have
available you can use those
we'll keep this code here because we are
not going to use it anymore
so
let's see an example of ng class and ng
style and then we'll wrap up with
built-in directives
so can you guess what ng class and
energy style is related to
yeah if you if your answer is related to
style cs that's that's the correct
answer
so what we need is uh there are two ways
right so i can just apply some style or
i can apply some
some
class directly so let's see how we can
do that
so here i'll create two classes
even
where we have let's say background color
and
color
let's change to
this is looks white so i'll say this is
still blue
and color is
white
and then there is an odd class
which has
background color of
light still blue and
let's use tomato
and white
so let's see how we can use ng class to
toggle the class between even or not we
can do that here so
[Music]
i can apply this ng
not here let's not apply on td if we
want to apply it on tr so i can say
ng
class is equals to so if i am if my
class is even
then i can say okay the
if it's even row i mean my class will be
even
else
i'll say use odd class
there are multiple syntax remember you
can also just uh
use a variable name directly here that's
absolutely fine right now we are saying
okay based on even value switch
uh have different uh class let's change
this to even
let's go to view
and you can see we have different rows a
different background color
for different different uh even an odd
rows right so this is how you can use ng
class also as discussed you can also
have a variable for example let's say
you have a class name which is saved for
some user user preferences right they
they prefer some different class to be
used so you can save those those class
and then load it by a variable that's
also possible
ng style is something where you have to
give the style so let's see where i
where we can do that
uh in a text
here let's try to do here
so i'll say if ng
ng if
um
zero
and
use the style
and say
rooms
well let's remove it right i mean we can
directly do this as well so we can say
here ohms
greater than zero then we can say
color
then
color is
green so we will just see this one
let's see if this works because i
generally don't use ng style
okay it is expecting something at
language
rooms uh color green uh
missing expected curly brackets
on line number seven
this is close
this is okay okay this is an extra rate
so you can actually we can do something
like this so we can say color which is a
property and then we are saying if rooms
there are available rooms make it green
otherwise make it red red
let's see how it looks like
you can see this is green color which is
coming here so
let's make it some other color which
looks visible so i'll say steel blue
okay so this is still blue now you can
see of course that it is different from
the
the black
or you can just keep it
green
so this is how you can also use ng style
ng style also
accepts variable so you can also pass a
variable here that's absolutely fine
so this is from the directives part now
we will move on to pipes
so we know how to do data binding we
also learn about few
useful directives
next thing which we are going to talk
about is pipes
what is pipe
so
in uh
so we are going to see what is pipe and
then we will talk about some built-in
types so let's first talk about what is
pipe
so in your day-to-day uh work of course
what you will be doing is you will be
finding some data on your
front-end screen or your view
and there will be times that
a requirement may come that okay this
particular date object should not be
displayed in the long
date format which we have seen
probably it needs to be shown in some
other day format
or there might be requirement to display
amount in let's say dollars inr or any
other
uh currency right so by default
the currency is
dollar of course
but we may need to actually show it in a
different format for uh the same goes to
numbers
what to do i mean of course we cannot
ask the api to change the date format
they will be like okay this same api is
getting used at multiple places why
should i do that for you
so the pipes are the answer so pipes are
used for data transformation so
when i mean transformation
it has a meaning so transformation means
my original object remain as it is i'm
not going to change that object but
while presenting that object i am
displaying it in different format
so it means the pipes don't actually uh
pipes actually don't change the ocean
object they keep it as it is but while
presenting it on your view you may
actually change the format in different
different format so there are few
built-in pipes which we have and there
are a few uh you can actually write your
own bypass which we are going to do in
future
here we will go through all the built-in
pipes which we have so you we have date
by buffer case lower case we have
currency we have decimal we have percent
pipe as well we have json pipe slice and
then we have a simple so let's go
through them uh go go so let's go
through them one by one and we will see
uh we will apply and then see how your
view looks like so let's switch back to
the ps code
and this is the same view which we uh
wrote last so remember rooms and then we
created a list
so let's start with the first pipe which
we have which is great pipe
so we already have a property called uh
chicken time right so here let's see how
we can apply
so you can give use this particular
symbol which is available just below
backspace
and above enter so you can just save
shift and press this which is pipe
operator and then you can write okay i
want to use date
and let's go ahead and see this and
let's see it on our view so you can see
your date time format is actually
changed to something else earlier it was
a long date format now once you apply
date it is short date format by default
you can also change it
with specific format as well
all the formats are available on
angular.iodox so you can just go to
angular.io and
in docs section you will see uh
references
so you can see all the formats which you
can use here so you can also use
text short medium long or you can also
specify the format you want as well so
it's up to you
so let's say if i just say date
and then in case you want to change you
have to put colon and then you can write
okay short
so this is the format which i need short
which is the equivalent to let's see m
d d y by h m m a so it's like something
like this this if this is the example
right so
uh
the one which is by default is this one
short date
you can specify the format as well so i
can say dde uh mmm and
so it will be a date month in the first
three characters so you can say 11th
november 2021 so this is how you can
actually change the formats and you in
case you need time uh so you can also
pass the hmm ss
and uh
this one two three four four sets is
actually for time zone in case you want
to display the time zone
so this is an example of date format
let's see what else we have so
let's go back to slides we have about
case lowercase let's see both and then
we also have title case
okay which i missed here
right so i want to display this in
lower case
we can say lowercase
so everything will be displayed in
lowercase characters
right so you can see air conditioner
free wi-fi tv bathroom kitchen or
everything is in lower case right now
and up and i can just change this to
uppercase
and everything will be in camps
and
if i'm not drawn okay so i missed it in
slide but we do have title case as well
where the first character will be in
capital so you can see air conditioner
free f
and then we have tv bathroom kitchen so
every the first character is in capital
that's titled
now we also have currency so we can use
currency
and by default the default currencies in
is based on the en us which is dollars
so you can see dollars available here
500 thousand dollars and 50 000
you can change currently by passing the
value for example for
indian currency the co-designer
so you can see uh it will now give us
request symbol remember
the uh
currency uh code to its equivalent uh
display uh
is not available for all the currency
types it is available for all the major
currencies but you may actually find
some currency which is missing so in
that case it will just display whatever
you pass here
so here you have inr for example if i
want to display euro i can say eur
and it will display you the hero symbol
and uh of course great britain bound g b
g b
and it will display the pound symbol
saved
and you will get this pound symbol here
so by default it's euro but let's keep
it as an inner right now indian rupees
so we are done uh we saw how did pipe
works how we can use lowercase uppercase
title case then currency pipe we have
decimal and percentage pipe so
let's see percentage five first
percentage is uh something which will
display your value in percent so one is
hundred percent remember this
so in case uh you want to actually uh
convert some
some some numbers in percentage make
sure that it is
uh in decimal right
so let's go ahead and see so you can see
it is zero percent is 100 percent this
is 200 percent so in case you have 0.5
it means 50
which is of course true right
so this is percent pipe we'll come back
to decimal and then we have json uh and
uh slice and and we have a sync pipe so
here we are going to say jsonpipe of
course we will see slice paper as well
as pipe we will not discuss right now we
will discuss it during uh
http and api calls so we have to wait
for that
let's see how to use this input so here
uh
room from list
so jsonpipe is useful uh mostly for
different but was for example let's say
this room list right and it has a lot of
objects okay a lot of other properties
as well and what you want to do is we
want to just check what is the value
available here so if i just
or just apply these uh
just apply this binding you will see
this is object object but what in case i
want to actually see the value so i can
just go ahead and write my power based
on that it happens because of course in
case you have large largest object you
need to find okay which property exists
and which property doesn't so useful for
debugging don't keep json types on
protection so let's see what how json
helps here so i can just use python
symbol and you can say json remember
it's all small
and
now you can see okay these are the
values which are available so it says
okay there is a room number there is a
room type these are the values then you
have photos object available as well
then you have chicken time checkout and
these are all the properties which is
available within this particular json
property it can be applied
it can be applied on object it can be
applied on an array so you can apply it
for everywhere
remember again i am saying this is
something which should be used for
debugging purpose only should not use on
production
so this is jsonpipe i just keep it here
i'll comment this
then we had slice pipe so slice is
similar to slice
property or you can say slice function
which exists in javascript so here uh
let's try to apply
a slice
here
and you can pass
how many records you want to display so
i guess is zero to one
let's go ahead and see our view
and you can see it says okay it displays
first record because the pipe which we
are using the slice or let's talk about
slice function which exists right so
slice function accepts through parameter
first index and the last index it will
display the value between
those two so we here we are saying start
from the zeroth index and display one
value you can also change of course uh
the first and then you can say okay uh
go to two right so start from first and
take the next two values but
doesn't exist there are no other two
values which exist only there are zero
one two so it is only displaying me uh
the uh id2 right so room number two
which is third record so zero uh one two
so between one and two there is only one
record if i say zero to two let's see
so it will always skip if i am not wrong
here it will always keep 0 and it will
give you 1
sorry
sorry i am wrong
here let's see the values so you have
room number 1 and 2 right so it will
start from 0 until 2 0 1 2
so here uh
so room number one and room number two
uh it will skip the last one if i'm uh
okay so let's reiterate again so when
you pass slice and some numbers so here
what we are saying is
starts from 0 and go to go till 2 so
you have 0 and 1
it will not consider the last number
similarly when we say 0 and 1 it will
again skip the last number so 0 and 1
and if i say 0 to 3 let's see what
happens it will
display all the records right so 0
because third index 0 0 1 2 3 so third
index is fourth value so of course there
is nothing which exists there and it
will always
not consider the last last value so we
get 0 1 2
similarly when we passed 2 what it did
did is so 0 1 and skip the last value so
zero and one so this is how it works so
generally you won't be using slice a lot
of time because
in case you are working with large data
set it is not
suggested that you should use slice pipe
to
filter out the records so general i mean
the use case to use slice pipe can be
filtering without the records
but don't use it
are you
not filtering sorry the general use case
to use slices pipe sorry generally use
case to you uh use slices pagination so
don't use uh this slice pipe for
pagination unless you have some like
fixed records so let's say you have some
master table where
your records are not going to go above 5
15 or let's say 100 it will always be
like that
which generally doesn't happen right i
mean most of the cases you will get more
i mean you don't know how many records
we are supposed to get
so don't use
slice for pagination in a real-time
application always rely for server-side
pagination or server-side filtering
in case you are working with large data
set
so this is a slice
and then we have number as well so let's
see
if we get
any
type and i don't have decimal numbers
here
decimal pipe example right so we are
what we will do is we will add one more
property so let's add a rating property
because that's something which can be
decimal
so here i'll say
[Music]
reading and
we will say this is type of number uh
you don't have float you had this uh
beacon does exist in typescript but
begin days like for big numbers so for
rating i don't think so we need uh begin
and now let's add this property so i'll
say this rating
is
4.5
and here
let's say it's 3.4
this is output 5 for example
and it is 2.6
so what we can achieve using decimal
points so let's say you don't want to
actually round off these values or you
don't want to round off these values to
some specific numbers so this is
something which you can achieve using a
decimal pipe
so here i'll just add a last property
and i'd say this is written
so let's apply decimal um sorry not
decimal the name is decimal but the pipe
name is number
so let's uh apply this and see
how it looks like so you have this four
point five three point five point six
for example uh so this is the values
right and now we want to actually
display this in different format so what
we want is uh
there are three properties uh
there are three properties which you can
pass
first is
how many number we want to display
before decimal so i am saying okay we
want to display one number before the
estimate
then
how many decimals after uh sorry how
many uh numbers you want to display
after decimals for example if it says 0
and 0
so it will uh let's see what it does so
it says okay this
five
is closer to five so it goes to five
three point i think uh what were the
other values let's see
so we had three point four and two point
six so three point four is closer to
three so it goes to three
two point six is closer to 3 so it goes
to 3 so this is how this particular
value works let's see how we can change
the values
so this uh
two values right so this is minimum uh
you can actually see the definition here
so it says uh this is the value and this
is digits info
and you can also pass local but this is
not we are looking at right now decimal
pipe
and
here so you can see uh
let me show you the shortcut so you can
actually go ahead and say control plus
click it will
take you to this particular pipe in case
it happens right so
i generally don't use number five so if
i forget about the definition of course
the docs is one place where i can see
look for it but you can also open this
inside vs code
control plus control plus click here or
you can also do f12 so press f1 and it
will also take you to the definition
file where you can see some example for
example let's see here so it says 3.6
number and then we are saying first it
will we want to display one number
before the decimal point and after that
we want to display uh minimum 0
so you can see minimum number of digits
after decimal point so it says zero and
maximum number of digits after a decimal
point so it says zero so this is what we
are saying uh so let's say if i
do it like this so i i want to display
one and one
right so you we said okay we want to
display uh at least one minimum digit
and one maximum digits which is four
point but in case we had a running
number right so let's say if i change
this to three point
four
where we have
a few more numbers available now let's
see what happens
so you have 3.5 because it actually said
okay 3.4 and we want to display only one
number so it actually four is closer to
five so it says okay let's go to five
and
let's go to
[Music]
i want to display two maximum numbers
let's see what happens here so you have
three point four six
so uh this is uh
two decimal numbers and we can of course
increase whatever maximum numbers you
want to so now you have three point four
point four five seven
so this is this is how you can actually
uh use this number type
and you can also pass local uh local uh
which is like
you remember
the numbers are actually different in
different different uh
countries so for example here in india
we use decimal points but if you go to
europe
sometimes they use comma
or probably uh some other countries
might be using some other different uh
different uh
separation uh
uh value right so separate different
separator which you got you can also do
that using this let me show text
sees that we have some samples
so let's try to display this number in
france dfr is local for france let's see
okay there is some error
okay this is not something which is
valid
local invalid pipe argument missing
local data for
okay
missing local data so we have to add
local first and then
it's okay
[Music]
let's see enus is available yes this is
available and this is the default one
so right now of course the front uh the
thing is with local is you need to add
the support for those locals so that's
that is something which is not added
probably we'll see an example of
later on but yeah i mean you can pass
the locals here and then it will display
the number based on that particular
local so
for example this number may be different
or in a different format in france which
is possible and it is possible it's
too
so you can see thousand decimal support
separators right so
uh in canada you uh we use space
in danish we you are we are using space
so in different currencies
there are different separators which are
used so this is what i was referring to
so thai you have comma then dot
here also you have comma spanish there
is no comma there is just spaces
sorry space you have dots and
then dot here you have comma so these
are different uh numbers formatting
different locales
and angular supports different locals as
well i mean that's another topic
which is not part of this course but in
case you want to refer uh angular does
support
converting your
uh
like
text to a different format which is
known as internet internationalization
and localization
it is a feature which is which is
supported by angular
so that's it from the pipes as we
mentioned the sig pipe will be used
while talking about http in later
section
hi in this video we are going to talk
about lifecycle looks
but before we do that
let's do one more thing
right now if you see this particular
view
it it's missing something it is missing
the styling if you think about it right
so there are multiple options which you
can choose from
you can either go with bootstrap
you can go with angular material or you
can also use
something
[Music]
or you can also use
television css which is also supported
by angular
so what we will do is let's add
bootstrap right now and
then we will add angular material later
on
and probably at the end we will see how
you can configure
television css probably later in the
video
so to add bootstrap there are multiple
options which you have there are
multiple libraries which actually
supports bootstrap
so we have ngx bootstrap and ng
bootstrap both are same
uh even contains lot of similar
components i mean you can choose any one
they both support bootstrap 4 as of now
they don't have support for bootstrap 5.
so let's see okay so nzx bootstrap
actually came with suppose it came up
with the support for bootstrap 5 also so
let's add
you can add this command you can see
how you can install so there are
instructions given on this page uh you
we can we will use the angular cli way
so let's go ahead and do that
and before you do that
and before you do this make sure you
stop the server which is running so
i have stopped the server because it is
going to impact the
angular.json and we need to restart the
server so
i already stopped it in case you are
running just stop and run this command
ng add ng export start which will
install bootstrap 5 and it will give
access to some components which comes
with it so if let's go back to the page
so you can see it has accordion alerts
button carousel collapse
so these are all components which you
you can use inside your
angular page
or angular application
so
we will
come back to this later on right now we
just want to install ng export strap so
let's see
it says uh the package engine bootstrap
6.2.0 will be installed and executed
somehow okay
let's see what's wrong
so this ng
engines bootstrap the current version is
7.1.2
but it is saying for us the compatible
version is seven six point two point
zero
and
we have angular 13 which is being used
so there is some problem with the
release so let's use the uh latest
version whatever it is offering right
now 6.2.0 and
meanwhile i'll check what's wrong with
this so
it is
released on silence
september 24th
since
cannot find schematic
angular utility config
okay looks like this particular package
is not compatible with angular 13 as of
now so that's that's the problem here
tell
what we can do
even they are not compatible with
angular 12
this is strange
okay let's try with the uh
[Music]
this version which is
7.1.2
okay let's see
7.1.2 and then this one has package.json
which supports
angular 11. this is really strange
because it should be either
angle 12 or 13 so let's
look for
the tax
7.1.1
and this also uses angle
let's check if ng
there is another package ng input strap
let's see if that supports it
mg
but
beta support for bootstrap 5 is
available with angular 11 with 11.0 beta
and this is the command so let's see
i'm getting started
and
this is for angular 12
bootstrap css5
let's try let's try this one
and you put strap is added
okay let's see if this works ng add ng
bootstrap
so it also supports in case you have
multiple projects so you can pass which
project you want to add this bootstrap
library to but let's see
okay so it is saying bootstrap 10 will
be installed
okay this is also
just not working so let's try with this
one so what i'm going to do is i'm going
to
[Music]
enter it next
so uh remember as of today not all the
libraries are compatible with angular 13
and that's what
we are that's what the issue which we
are facing right now
um
okay this is this is sad
angular 13 from good project found
common 13.0.1
angular common 12
okay so even they are not compatible
with angular 13 because they are saying
okay this is for angular 12
okay
let's see if we have any other way
start by
let's start 5.0 okay so it is available
let's try to install bootstrap directly
and then we'll see and then install put
stuff
so uh if you are not aware bootstrap
five has actually dropped the support
for either so that's
that's one thing which they have done
so bootstrap is installed now let's see
so you can verify it from node modules
folder which we have available here and
let's go to a b
so distributable js and sorry css and
okay this is all bootstrap css files
which is available we want to use
bootstrap.main.css this is what we are
going to use and
there are multiple ways there are
multiple ways you can do it
let's see
let's try to configure it so
[Music]
okay i have to
i want you to copy the path actually so
here bootstrap main dot css
i'll copy
relative path
and
i'll show you both ways
first way is you can actually add this
uh css into your global global styling
how you can do that so you can use
import
sorry add that import
and then you can do
this
you don't have to actually give path
like this you can just say
build
this one
and of course change
pst css extra
wind.css and
let's try to see if this one works so
and then we will show you another way
which is uh not adding to your global
style css but in another way
we'll be able to see the changes because
of course styling of your page will
change because of
the font which is used by bootstrap
okay let's
there's some error
no such file directory open bootstrap
dst okay
what is
along here probably
let's remove this
and let's see our build
okay now it is compiled successfully so
let's
see okay so you can see uh
i think you might have seen this page
you can see this page and this page
so this one has bootstrap 5 which is
installed and now applicable to
your application this doesn't has any
css so this is how you can verify if
bootstrap is added to your application
or not
so
let me show you another way to add
bootstrap or any other css so it's it's
something which you can do with any css
any
css which you have installed using npm
so it's not only for bootstrap so
this this was the first way where you
can actually go ahead and add it into
style.css
or css whatever
type which you are using
so let's stop the server because in
another way we are going to add this
into our
angular.json
so i'll comment this out so we don't
have the css available here
and i can go to angular.json
angular.json has many properties there
is one property called styles
and i can go here and
i can apply uh just it's an array
remember and i can just go ahead and add
this part
and while adding this path here you have
to add with node modules remember this
okay good strap
paste
css
and strap main.css
and
if i'm not wrong bootstrap also gives
you
satisfy you can also use that let's see
tsd css
and i think you will have here it is so
in case you want to add or use sas files
this is sas files are available as well
so rather than actually taking the path
from list you will be taking it from
scss folder that's that's the difference
and now let's run it again
and then
and
you can see uh of course let's see the
difference right so you have this is
with bootstrap five and this is without
any style being added to our application
so right now of course as of today nzx
bootstrap ng bootstrap do both are not
supported with angular 13 but in future
they will so
uh the only difference would be you have
to run that ngat command and you don't
have to
set this conf this uh changes which we
did right now right so we added this to
styles array you don't have to do this
manually
that will be taken care by ngat command
which we used previously
so now we know how to use
this
as css so let's try to actually apply
some css here
class
table
so
let me close this now uh you can see
this table is uh actually having this
new class
and
we can
also see one more thing uh let's try to
minimize
so we have
you can see
as we added bootstrap now our
application is responsive so it is
changing the width of your table
based on your screen size
so you don't have to do that manually
anymore i mean you don't have to add
extra styles uh to make your application
responsive bootstrap will take care of
it for you
in this video we are going to talk about
lifecycle looks so
we'll talk about what lifecycle looks is
and then what are the different
lifecycle looks which exist
for uh
your components
so let's see what is component uh or
lifecycle locus
so
in angular what we are going to create
is we are going to of course go ahead
and create a lot of components
now all component needs to go through
some life cycle looks
or you can say some events which it
needs to go through
this will happen this entire
events or you can say hooks will happen
for each and every component
so in
other technologies also in other
frameworks also you have the concept of
hooks
and same applies to angular
in
dotnet in case you are coming from
dotnet uh
earlier in older days it has it had
something called page lifecycle events
which is
which is kind of similar thing which we
have here so if you talk about each uh
the component of a com sorry if you talk
about event or lifecycle hook for a
component
so somewhere it starts
creating a new instance for component
and at the end it will be destroyed so
from start for from creating an instance
to destroying an instance this is how
your entire life cycle looks looks like
and uh
there are
a few live stuff looks uh sorry these
are the life cycle looks which are
mentioned here so you have all changes
only need do check
after content in it checked we need
checked and then destroyed so let's uh
go through each of them one by one
and
yeah
and you might have already noticed that
ng on init lifecycle looks already exist
on your rooms component so if you see
this
there is ng on in it
so in angular for every lifecycle looks
there is an interface so for example
ngon in it has an interface called on
init so if i have destroy or ng on
destroy so there is an event called uh
or an interface called on destroy you
can just go to this event and uh same
fpl or control click and you will go
inside this to see which event is that
so ngo in it in earlier days it was
optional but uh
make sure that you implement the
interface
whenever
you are
trying to access some of the lifecycle
looks of your component so let's see
what you can achieve using uh ngo net
lifecycle load but before we go ahead
and do that before we actually move
so before sorry
before we go ahead and move do that
before we talk about ngon in it
here
you will notice that there is also a
constructor which is available so it
means before even your ngoninet event
gets called
your component needs to be initialized
so this is where this happens and when
in
when it happens actually on your page
whenever it gets
rendered on your view at that time
constructor will be called and
just after the constructor is finished
your ng on init lifecycle
ngon in it lifecycle look will be called
so people do uh get confused okay if
both are kind of same that okay once my
component is initialized i can just hook
into ng or unit lifecycle look
why what is the difference between
constructor i mean we are we are saying
that whenever a instance is created a
constructor is called
remember ngoninit is where your you
should write
your logic
constructor should be used only in case
you want to inject some services this
will become this will be coming later on
when we talk about services
but let's just keep that in mind in in
your mind
constructors should not have any
blocking code so in case you are writing
some blocking code in your constructor
it is wrong that code should be part of
ngoninet
so let's see uh what we can achieve
using ngon unit lifecycle look and um
to see this what we will do is we will
just move some
property declaration
from here to ngoninet
so here i am saying okay this
room list is equals to
empty and then in n g on it i will say
this dot
room list is equals to this records
right so we are just moving uh the
entire array here
inside ngo in it so in case you have any
let's say you want to load some data
from your api and you want to display uh
that data on your view
you should write that code as part of
ngo net lifecycle load
this should not go into constructor or
any other life cycle so ngo engineering
is something where we are saying that
okay now my component is initialized
and
just after my component is initialized
you want to do anything
just add that code into ng on in it life
cycle look so let's go ahead and verify
our view
and here we are i mean there is no
changes
and our code is compiled as well so this
is all about engineering we will be
using utilizing
we will be utilizing ng on it like cycle
looks in future whenever we
start
implementing our services and start
getting the data from the api so we'll
see some use cases where we'll be using
it
now let's go back and talk about other
life cycle looks
so you might be wondering i mean i said
ng on in it is the first life cycle
event then why i have mentioned it
second year
of course that's
that should be the question in your mind
right now so we have ng on changes which
is before ngon in it remember in this
lifecycle looks constructor is the first
one which will be called every for every
component once they are initialized so
we have engine changes before ngonin and
then we have ng do check
let's uh go ahead and talk about uh
so
there are two topics which will go
parallely here so lifecycle looks and
there will be something known as
component communication this these two
topics i generally take it partly
because they
they need each other i mean they uh they
needs to be understand uh while talking
about lifecycle looks and then you uh
needs to know about component lifecycle
sorry component interaction as well
so this ng on changes actually uh is
related to one of the
ways you can do component communication
let me just go back and
talk a little bit about component
communication because we will be using
uh component communication in our
code right now
so what we will be talking about here is
just theory i mean we are going to see
the examples so
let's introduce and then there are ways
for component communication we will be
doing this parallel right so ways for
component communication we will relate
to the component lifecycle look so in
case you write your real-time code you
know what needs to be done rather than
just doing something blindly
so
why we need component communication
in case you are going to create an
entire enterprise application there will
be scenarios that you need to
interact between two different
components right now we have seen that
we right now we have two components app
component and your rooms component
what in case they want to actually
interact with each other how we can do
that that's what communication uh
component communication is all about
we also said that
in future what will be
we also said in future what we will be
doing is we will be creating a lot of
html reusable html tags that's what
component is what in case
i want to create those
reusable tags and then i can use it
anywhere
who will be passing the data of course
someone has to interact with that
particular component right that's a
reusable component so it cannot contain
its own information it has to rely on
some information which is coming from
somewhere else that's your another
component
this is component communication
so multiple components interacting with
each other but there are multiple ways
now
so there are three ways which we
generally use so first is using input
and output second is using view children
or content children sorry we child or
contention and third one is using
service
now
as we talk about ng on changes we are
going to use the component communication
using input and output
so let's try to create a scenario first
so in this uh application right now if
you see
now we uh you are also going to learn
how you can actually split your big
components into smaller components
so if you see this html
uh which has like like 43 lines of code
right now 43 lines of html
if you see
if you think about this table
i think this table can be another
component
the reason being
i can just remove this logic and keep my
component smaller that's what we uh
often do right whenever we talk about
single responsibility
and this has nothing to do with rooms
right i can actually go ahead and
display a lot of information and then i
can just keep this logic separate
also
let's say we want to display this room's
list at multiple locations or multiple
pages
what you will be doing
is copy pasting a good idea the answer
is no
what we can do we can actually create a
reusable html tag put this somewhere
else and just pass the data that's it
that's what we are going to do now
so let's go ahead and create a component
and
as this component is related to rooms
i'll put this inside rooms i'll call it
call it as roomslist so here
in case you want to create this
component inside this particular folder
i can just go ahead and say open in
integrate terminal
and
to create a new component we already
learned the command so i can say ng
g c which is ng generate component
and then i can say rooms hyphen list
i'm not sure why i keep making the
mistake of
rooms
now so now we have this rooms list
folder and
all four files aspects earlier now let's
do uh one thing so we will
remove this
logic from here
and put it here
so my entire table uh logic i mean to
render the table or render the rooms
list is not part of it i mean it's not
part of rooms company it's part of my
room's list company makes sense right i
mean it it even tells you what it is
supposed to do it is supposed to list
the rooms
now let's talk about the data so we have
okay rooms list and
we don't have the data right now so we
want to pass the data so let's see how
we can do that
as we said we'll be using input and
output
so now let's try to understand both
here
we want to get
the data
which means i want to get the input so
what we will be doing is we will be
creating an input using accurate input
which is a decorator
sorry
which is a decorator and i can call it
as rooms
which is type of
rooms list array
is equals to i mean i have an empty
error by default
so we are saying
make this rooms property as an valid
html property on this html element this
is what we are doing here remember
whenever you add input tag it means this
property rooms becomes and
becomes an property on top of this html
tag so we can pass the data
now
few need a few things need to be changed
so rather than rooms list i will be
saying rooms
and that's it so now all the errors are
gone
now let's try to use this component in
my parent component
this is where we want to display that
component so we know the html tag yes we
do so i'll copy this
html tag here
and as i said the rooms is the valid
property which is added here so i'll say
rooms you can see uh due to angular
language service we are getting in
intelligence is equals to now we know
that the property which is available
here is called
rooms
room list
and we can close this html tag so
this is it now let's save this and see
if it is already compiled because our
application is
really small and see here so you can see
okay now you have your entire data
available but let's verify if it's true
right i mean if it's actually coming
from the rooms list
and you can see here so this is your
hotel inventory management and hyphen
rooms list this is the new html tag
which we created but where is the css
gone let's go ahead and try to see that
and we have rooms class table
ah okay sorry
if you remember we had added add odd or
even style so you can see odd and even
is actually added here so it is part of
room component how is this happening we
will talk about it there is there is
something called encapsulation which we
need to talk about
currently what we can do is you we can
actually add it inside rooms list or
we can add
in our global style sheet so let's do
that
and once it is added in global it is
available so
that's that's it that's this is how your
you can pass input to your
component now what we made it what we
made possible right now so if you think
about it what we did is we created a
reusable component
which doesn't need to know from where my
data is coming anyone can pass the data
by using this property to this
particular component so i'm not
restricted to use
list component only at certain places i
can use it anywhere i want because this
rooms component
only contains information about how to
render things not how to get the data or
how to drive the data
in
real world application we call this
relationship between
this two component
rooms component and rooms list component
as parent and child
you can also call this com relationship
as
smart component dumb component so this
is for smart component which knows
from where to get the data
and some
some action which needs to be performed
and this is your dumb component which
doesn't know anything it just needs to
know how what to render that's it
so parent child
smart component dump component these are
the things which you uh
if you come across these things this is
what you mean
in your real-time enterprise application
try to split your components to as
smallest level as possible
don't have a
component with like thousands of html or
thousands lines of ts try to split them
as much as possible generalize them
and uh
try to have like small component for
each logic so here we knew that okay
there is a rooms list which needs to be
created so what we did is we created
another room space component which will
take care of rendering those things
now
in real time application now let's uh
let's talk about the term right smart
component of component
in real time uh applications now your
child component may need to
do some action
for example so let's say uh we want to
actually
we have this rooms list now
i want to give an action button at the
end and i want to say
book this room or
uh
marks it mark it as sold right so this
is something so this hotel becomes not
available
we are saying this particular component
is child component or dumb component so
it cannot take action on its own
simple example real-time scenario of
course if you have a kid what you what
kids do right they come to you and say
okay i need this thing and then you do
it right and you don't give money to
your kid and say go ahead and buy it
until of course they they become um
they become smart right i mean they know
how to deal with things so same same
concept is applied here so now as my
child component or my dumb component
doesn't know or doesn't need to know how
to do stuffs what it can do
in case it needs to perform some action
it can ask
parent it can ask the smart component to
do stuffs
this is where we need to
pass the data back from child to parent
component how to achieve that
of course output right so we are saying
input can get the data output can
give out the data so let's create an
output and outputs are actually an event
so
let's right now let's create an event
called
room selected so i we will click on this
room
we'll say okay select this room and this
information will be passed to your
parent and your parent can do anything
whether
this room needs to be worked this room
needs to be marked as sold this room
needs to be deleted right i mean let's
say uh
now this room is used for some other
purpose so this room is not available
anymore so what we will do is we will
create an output
decorator we will use an output
decorator and then we are saying the
event name is rooms
room selected
or we can say selected
room
and
it it needs to be an event so there is a
new event emitter class which is
available in angular core
which needs to be imported so we can say
new event emitter and then we have to
tell what kind of data we want to send
back to parent so here the kind of data
we have is room list
if
it needs to be multiple of course you
can put an array but right now i want to
just select send the selected room
so done here so now what we will do is
we will add an action here and
i'll create an header and then say this
is
select room
and inside td
we will add a button
and it's auto
so we can say button class and vdn video
primary is a
is a bootstrap class
and
this is the function which will
implement select room so let's go ahead
and see and this is the room object
which we which it will get once you
click on this particular room
so let's go back to typescript and add
this function which is supposed to get
sorry
which is supposed to get a room list and
then once
this room list or the room is selected
we want to emit this data back to parent
so this this line of code selected room
dot embed will
give this data back to the parent who
has
remember who has actually
uh subscribed to this event it's not
something like i mean if i'm not
subscribing to this event this won't be
available so let's go ahead and see that
part of us see that part of the code so
here this is our
okay
button
[Music]
it was not closed so
now let's go back to the parent which is
this one
and let's implement the event so we know
the name selected room this is the event
name
and i'll
write a local function which selects the
rooms
so we can say select row
and this is something which is not
implemented right now let's go ahead and
implement
so here
what i will do is uh first let's
add a console.log
so it's a selected room which takes a
room and
we print console.log room
save this
here now as we are getting some data we
have to actually pass some information
here so here you have to pass something
called as dollar event
this always remains dollar event so this
is an event which will be received from
my child component
and here you can specify that okay uh
this event uh which will be sending me
the data of this type
so this room um
this this data will be type of room list
so far so good
let's see our build just completed
let's see our application now we have
the select button you can see when you
hover it becomes blue
right so
let's go to console and
let's
delete
and let's click on select
and you can see okay now you have this
rooms component.ts line number 68 this
is where this information is coming
right so you have your amenities
checking time checkout time and
whichever row you select you get that
row specific data sent to your parent
so this is how your output works
now uh we can actually do something more
with this i can say okay this is
selected
room which is type of room list
and we as we are using strict mode i
just add this so we don't get the error
and now
here
uh let's do it just before above the
table so i can say this
div
is
awesome
and we will use star ng if
so we'll just display it in case
selected rooms exist
and then we can say okay this selected
room
or let's uh
use json pipeline
to see what information we have
available
let's go back and
let's click on select
because there which is not saved looks
like
i think some
okay
looks like something is not getting
recompiled okay it is not
so somehow
now it is done
let's click on select
ah
my bad so
we have to assign this value right so
this dot selected room is equal to
and once we have assigned this value now
let's go ahead and click on selected
room you can see the information is
getting changed based on what data you
emit from your child component so this
is how you can
communicate between
two components child and parent or smart
component dum component using input and
output
now how it is related to
ng on changes event because that's why
we did this
we'll see that next
so far we have seen
the ng on init lifecycle look and we
also saw how we can
do component communication using input
and output
and we did that because we wanted to
talk about ng on changes lifecycle bug
which is next so uh let's go ahead and
do that and while
talking about ng on changes we will also
talk about
one
very important concept which is known as
change detection
in this is like really important topic
even in interviews as well a lot of
questions may be asked uh related to
related to change detection so let's go
ahead and
go in depth and talk about how change
detection works in angular and
how ng on changes helps us to actually
improve the performance so let's go
ahead and do that
so if you see our app right now what we
have is we have a child component which
is let me just close this
we have a parent component called rooms
component and then we have a child
component called rooms list
so this is and uh then we have a top
root level parent component which is
abnormal
whenever we do some action
the data needs to be updated right and
the data our view needs to be updated if
we talk about not the data
how that happens so angular
does it via change direction
so it is actually internally handled by
angular but there are multiple ways you
can actually um
[Music]
change uh change direction for your
component so let's go ahead and talk
about change section first i'll go to
the app so this is our app
and i'm going to enable
it's climbing on
okay
let's see
and we can go to
panels here
so we have style computer layout
and there is rendering on
let me just open it in another tab
and
show rendering
should be here compact points now
computer layout
[Music]
okay let's open this in chrome
and let's open
dev tools so you can press f12 or just
right click
and say inspect
okay so this is what i was looking at so
there is a tab called rendering which
you can see and let's click on
pen flashing this is the property which
we i was looking at and let's click here
so some green uh borders you can see
right now what is this green border so
this green borders are actually saying
these are the dom elements which are
getting changed
are we changing everything the answer is
no we are not changing everything but
still uh whenever you click on some or
you perform some action
angular detect there are some changes on
your view and your view needs to be
updated
this is by default which happens inside
angular
but there's components which doesn't
need to be changed for example this
table right
did we added or removed anything here
the answer is no we did not right so
uh this table should not change
why it is getting changed even if i
click on a toggle which is outside
of
like this is something which is
available on our parent company if i'm
not wrong yeah
uh this is a uh sorry this is on rooms
component if uh
yeah so this is on rooms component and
then it is also updating the rooms list
component how is that possible i mean
i'm not changing anything but it is
getting updated
consider like right now we just have two
components but in case you have a lot of
components on your view what will happen
so change direction will run for each
and every component
can we
avoid that the answer is yes we can so
let's see how we can actually optimize
this uh change uh detection strategy
which which is default uh to change
detect changes for each component
remember the way it runs is let me just
go back to uh dev tools
and i'll go to elements here
and there is angular dev tools also
which is available now you can actually
see it here
so let's say
down
on tree so this is your ts3 structure
right now let me just zoom in
so this is our tree structure right now
so we have root then we have rooms and
rooms list so in case someone performs
action here it
it will of course uh
send an event to the parent and parent
will start running change direction for
each and every component
so let's say i have rooms and then i
have
let's say employee or let's say
there is a there is another view which
is to add rooms time
so what will happen is the change
direction will run for both even though
i am changing only rooms
or i am changing something in rooms
by using change section strategy you can
actually optimize this behavior let's go
ahead and see that
so first i mean there are some rules
before you can actually go ahead and
apply change detection strategy to your
component
so here you can say
change direction this is the property
and
there are two modes by default it's on
its default let me just import change
instruction strategy first so we
will get this intelligence so you have
default which is default when you when
we don't change anything
so any event will cause the entire
change detection to run for your
application
and then there is on push before you go
ahead and use onpush there are some
requirements which you have to make
which you have to meet
on push change friction strategy can be
only applied in case
i am not modifying some data internally
in this component
how you can achieve it by using input
and output
in future you can also uh
apply the same strategy in case you use
some
state management technique for example
if you are using ngrx or if you are
using any other state management library
in that case also you can move it to one
push right now the state management part
is out of scope of this particular uh
course
so here we are going to apply it on
rooms list component because it uses
input and output so it doesn't rely or
it doesn't change the data internally it
relies the data which is coming from
outside so
it always knows that if in case the data
is getting changed
so here let's move on to on push and
to
now to actually uh show you the
difference
we have to do one more thing
let's see that
so what we will do is we will write
some small code to add a new record or
to add a new room number let's go ahead
and do that it's just a small button
so let's do it here
so this is div
and then we have button and i'll call it
as add room
[Music]
and
we will right now uh
pass the static data so
[Music]
let's say this is add room
let's go ahead and
again spelling mistake
and let's go back to ts and here
we will add a new room
so we'll create a room first so it's a
const
room
which is type of room list is equals to
and then we'll say um
let's see what is the properties room
number
four
and then there are room type there is
amenities
there is price
there is
photo so we'll just copy the one from
the existing property
and there's second time and then you
have checkup time and then you have
reading okay so this is our new room
data which is available let's copy the
photos property here
because all the properties are required
as of now so
[Music]
we have to pass each and every property
and
after this
i'll say this dot room list dot push so
let me just do this room list dot push
and
let's go back here and comment this out
so we are saying
right now my change detection strategy
is default so it means any action is
performed just go ahead and
run the change section for everyone
let's click on add room
see room list
chrome list push and then you have
chrome list available here so should
work let's see
let me just save this file again because
probably it is happening because it is
not able to identify
the change direction strategy
okay let's see if there is any error
let's
ohms component.ds
and what we have is this dot rooms list
so rooms list we have
okay we already have the record
available here one two three four is
added twice
so it should work
okay i just want getting added let's see
let's go ahead and check that
rooms list
okay so
we forgot to remove this pipe
slice remember so zero to three so we
can only display three records so even
though more records are available
and let's try to click on that room so
you can see it is working fine i mean
whenever you click on add room the
record is getting added now let's keep
this change this code as as it is and
let's go ahead and apply change
direction here because this is really
important i mean
you uh you might have understood now
that okay why to use onpushing strategy
because we are not modifying some data
here
and
the data is actually coming from outside
but there is one more important concept
which we need to understand so let's go
and see
now you can see actually i am clicking
on add room and nothing is happening but
let's see a magic so i'll go to
of course dev tools
and let's click
add a break point here
click on add room
okay
so you
you can see you your room list right now
here
okay somehow it is not able to show
click
add in the watch
and let's see what is available here so
you can see okay your
uh
data has
f
four records here so you have one two
three four and
let's move on but here you still have
three records why so because now my
component which actually is or change
traction strategy on push there is one
more requirement which we have to which
we have to meet
here let's see what is happening here
so this room list property which is
getting binded to my child component
what we are doing right now we are
actually pushing and record into this
particular array
so this is where you have to understand
the concept of immutability
whenever you are working with change
direction strategy on push the data
which you are trying to assign should
not be mutable
so it means when we apply a dot push
what happens
we actually change the room list
property
the concept of immutability says
we should always return a new instance
remember this because it is really
important because uh in future if you
try to use
some state management technique and try
to do the same stuff
you have to understand uh the concept of
immutability because entire state
management thing works with immutability
so here we are saying
rather than actually modifying room list
directly what we need to do is we have
to return a new object every time we
modify this instance it can be an object
it can be a array whatever but in case
you are trying to modify it
return a new instance
how we can do that so there are
i'll show you a syntax which is very
useful so you can say this dot
room list
now
is equal to
i can say uh dot dot dot three dots it
is called spread operator so i am saying
this dot
room list which means
keep the existing data and add the new
record
okay so this spread operator will say
okay this in this array spread the
previous data so in case i have three
records all uh present already so three
add three records plus the new record
if i click it click on it again what
will happen so it will have four records
and the next record will be added which
is fifth record
let's try to run this and
see how it works so let's click on add
row
and um of course i will remove
breakpoints
and you can see now a new record is
available click on add room again a new
record is available so now uh the
advantage of using onpush let's click on
toggle
so here what will happen is
now as my room's list component is
on change section strategy on push
the component also sorry the change
section three will check okay if this
component is marked as one push it means
i have to only
run the change direction in case
something changes inside this component
so here
this property will make sure that we are
not running
the change detection for this particular
component until and unless needed but
keep this requirement in your mind first
of course your component should not
change the data internally
second in case you are assigning or
passing some data
it should be
uh it should actually come from the
parent component right it should or it
should not uh it should the property
should be immutable so it means whenever
i am assigning a new property or new
value
it's
the whatever
your let's say if you are using state
management state management or like ngrx
or ngxs they always return a new object
whenever i try to modify something same
up same concept applies here so in input
property what i did earlier was i tried
to use dot push
what dot push did it modified the room
list property
so
right it actually mutated the existing
object but
it should not do that it should be
immutable it means whenever i am trying
to apply some uh or pass some data to my
child component and i have changed
action strategy on push it means i have
to apply a new instance or pass a new
instance every time so what i did what
we did we changed this
code from
this push method to this new uh
code where we are using spread operator
to make sure okay the existing data is
already available in array and the new
record gets added so this is related to
change detection strategy on push
now go ahead and
let's uh go ahead and talk about ng on
changes
so i'll close this
and
here
so on
ngon changes property or ng on changes
lifecycle look
can be applied on a component which has
input property remember this
you cannot apply ng on changes let's
look anywhere else
you can only apply on component or a
directive which has
the input property right now our
component
rooms list component has input property
so let's see how what it does and how it
behaves
so i am going to use in on changes
and let's implement interface
so uh you can see ngo changes
get some property which is changes of
type simple change
and let's see what simple change is
simple changes sorry simple change is
also an interface so uh here you can see
simple change
so what it has is it's a it has a
property name and
some metadata so let's see what this
metadata is simple change property so it
will give you
sorry
it will give you some information like
previous value next value so let's see
here so you have previous value current
value and whether it's a first change
and there is a is first change property
as well boolean property as well
what we can achieve using this let's go
ahead and do that
here
right now uh what we will do is we'll
just write console.log to just
figure out what's happening here so what
actually ngon changes does
let's inspect
let's go to console
so
let's go to console and
click on add room
and see here so you have some data which
says
rooms simple change
pre current value is like this one two
three four four records previous value
was one two three three records is it a
first change you can also find that
property so it says first change is
false it means no it is not a first
change it is because previously you can
see there was one
console log which is
here
at the top if it says the previous value
you was
like three records and
let me just
refresh this
[Music]
right so uh yeah so you have current
value 3 and then
we have previous value undefined here
this is what i was looking at because
whenever your component is initialized
you will have of course previous value
will be undefined and then you have
first change as true because this is the
first time the value is getting changed
and then you have current value as three
records and when i change it
every time you change this
uh you will get the records available
here now what
is the use case what where you can
actually use it so let's say in case i
want to modify some property after
getting the input values you can do it
using ngo changes so you can just assign
it inside ngo changes but remember ngon
changes will only work in case you have
input properties and your input
properties gets updated
or you get a new value remember this new
value not updated so it's like whenever
you get a new value you will
get uh the
uh data inside ngo changes and based on
that in case you want to write some
logic you want to log these values you
can go ahead and do that using ng on
changes
how you can access the properties so
let's talk about that as well right now
we have only one property called room
list
i'll add one more property
and we will say this is
title and
i'll say this is a type string
and
i'll say this is default values blank
let's go ahead and try uh to pass this
value as well i'll say this is rooms and
then we have
our title
is equals to
room
list and we want it to be in string so
i'll just use single quotes
so now with this string and let's find
this value
this title is equals to
rather than doing this we'll see
title
here
and we have rooms list available here
the room list available here right so
just add let's add as to
okay so we have room list uh which is
coming from outside so now let's go
ahead and try to change this value
uh and see what we get
so i'll just write
another
one click of
this toggle button right so we already
have the struggle button i'll say this
dot
title so we have
we have to define a top title property
here so i'll just say okay this is
again title
equals to
room
list
and let's use this title property
here now rather than string we'll just
pass this
title property here
and on toggle i'll just change this to
and say rather than room list let's call
it as rooms
list
and we just want to actually change the
property and see what we get inside
engine changes
and let's install it
and let's clear this console and let's
click on toggle
and we have rooms list available here so
let's see what we get here so you can
see right now only the value which is
which got changed is title
right so
whenever you will change your input
value
that will come as property so here
you can always do
so if
changes dot let's say title
which means the title is changed
okay index image
so i'm saying if
the title property has changed so uh you
can do something like for example i can
say this dot
title
and
changes.title.com value
let's apply to
[Music]
what we can do
let's try to do the substring
or two uppercase let's let's do
uppercase current value dot uppercase
you can see uh your property or value is
updated to uppercase because of this and
why it work because of course here we
are assigning a new value right so we
are saying this dot title equals to so
this is uh this is what you can do or
achieve using
ng on changes let's take a look
very useful in case you want to control
what value needs to be updated whenever
a new data is passed or you want to run
you want to run change direction
manually that is also possible using
this probably we will see once we talk
about
services because we need to understand
the services before we go ahead and use
anything
or any services available inside angular
so this is uh this is it from engine
genius so what are the concept which we
learned
because
we learned about input and output we saw
how you can pass data between two
components or how you can do component
communication
using input and output then we also
learned about change direction strategy
which is really important and then we
learned about ng on changes just because
of engine changes we had to actually
learn these two concepts very important
now as we have learned about ngon unit
and engine changes and now let's move on
to the next lifecycle look which is ng
do check
now this lifecycle look is something
which you will be
hardly using but you have to understand
or you have to know about what do check
does so let's go ahead and see it in
action
so here uh i will just go ahead and add
this on rooms component.these
so here i'll say ok this is
on
[Music]
search
to check yeah so this is the interface
which will be used for do check and then
we have to implement
the interface and just
sometimes there is something wrong
ng do check
and this is the method which we need to
implement
so
on changes i'll remove this
and
okay
and here let's do console.log right now
console.log and
i'll say on changes is called
okay
cannot find name blue chip okay
so let's add it in it should be imported
from angular core so let's add it here
and let's see the build and it's
completed now
let's go to the page
and let's inspect the element uh let's
go to the dev tools and here on
console you can see there is a
message says on changes is called
now i'll just do one thing and keep it
open here
right
i'll remove everything and let's
invoke some events for example add room
you can see on changes is called let's
click on toggle you can see on changes
is called
you uh let's click on this select and
you can see on changes is called so what
this on changes event is so this on
changes event is
something which will be executed every
time you raise any event
irrespective of where this component is
implemented or available
in case it is active it will listen to
any changes which has happened
inside your entire application remember
that
so this event uh or implementing this
lifecycle look is very costly in case
uh what what what can be the use cases
uh for uh
in last four years uh i have been
writing angular code and never see never
saw any example or any use cases where i
had to go ahead and implement ng on
changes
but it can be useful in case you want to
detect
some changes which is not controlled by
anywhere so let's say you have some
logout button where
some logout button plays on any some
corner of your screen and you want to
make sure whenever that log logout
button is clicked
you should go ahead and detect changes
but where you are not sure
what we can do what you can do is you
can have an implementation of ng on
changes or sorry are not engineer
changes do check event or do check
lifecycle loop
as there's an event which is raised blue
check will be called and you can handle
your special scenario where of course
that event is something which is not
captured by anyone will be captured by
your do check lifecycle so that's one
you that can be one use case but
try to avoid it as much as possible also
another thing which you should keep in
mind is
you should not implement ngo on changes
and do check together
on same component the reason being of
course both are going to do the same
thing
what on changes does it will detect any
changes to your input values what
changes on do check will do it will
detect any changes inside your
application so
it will be like capture twice so don't
do that and try to avoid on changes
sorry
do check as much as possible not on
changes to check as much as possible uh
some i like extreme use cases if you get
into it even before doing that just try
to
in case you have some special scenario
where you think that do check is some do
check is the answer uh you need to
implement budget
i would suggest go ahead and check on
stack overflow ask to ask the question
if uh what you are trying to do is
correct and then use it otherwise don't
so this is ng blue check
in this video we are going to discuss
about
ng
after view unit and
and
ng after wechat and we will also discuss
about something known as view
child
and we will learn about some
other stuffs like template ref
and how you can dynamically load a
component so let's go ahead and get
started
so far we have discussed about on
changes on it on init and do check
so to understand
how you can actually use ng after
viewing it we have to first learn about
view child
and how we can actually communicate or
load a component using view child and
what else we can use uh do using view
child so let's go ahead and do that so
we'll start with a simple
uh example the first example which is
which is really useful you will
get into a lot of scenarios where this
may be helpful for you so let's get into
that so
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
create a new component
and we will
communicate to that component using view
child so i'll call this component as
let's call it as header component so
let's say ngtc
and
header
now we have already seen an example
where
we have we are actually communicating
with a component which has input
property and then the child component
can
uh send some data back using output so
in using input and output but this is
another way let's say uh you have a
component but you don't want to actually
make it reusable i mean you don't have
to uh don't want to actually have uh
input and output properties because most
of the time they will be individual
component but sometimes let's say you
may need to
load them
uh in another component you may want to
access them in another component and
probably assign some property or
call some function of this particular
component or let's say you have any
third party component
this is really a
good use case for view child as well so
let's say you have a very uh third party
component which on which you don't have
much control right so
it's like they have some component and
then you can pass input and output
properties or let's say they have some
component where they don't let's say you
get an uh library ui library and where
they have some component which is
internal to them so they don't
want to actually make it reusable but
maybe you want access to that particular
component
you are working within a team like
multiple projects working together and
it's a library so they they don't want
to make it reusable like by using input
and output but you may want to actually
access them um so what what are the
approach what is the approach you will
take of course you can go ahead and talk
to the team and ask them to make it
reusable but let's say they don't want
to do that right i mean it doesn't fit
uh or it doesn't
actually help in their use case so what
you will see how we can actually do that
how we can actually access any component
into uh our other component which
doesn't have input and output property
so let's uh create so we have already
this header component now what we will
do is we will
create a property here and remember i am
not going to make it
input property
okay so we have title which is of type
string and i'll put this
title
here using interpolation syntax
so far so good i mean you created a new
component you assigned a new property
and then we just added that into our
interpolation syntax
so we just added that into our
interpreter using interpolation
pollution syntax
sorry we just added that using
interpolation syntax
now let's go to
appcomponent.html and let's say let's go
to room component.html
so we have this welcome to hotel name
uh what we want to do is
we want to have an title here
and we want to use this header component
so let's see how we how we do that
so i will just comment this out
and we will use
fbp
hotel header
is that the
component name oh sorry directive name
no
so this is the directive name hyp header
and this is it so we have places
component let's see how it looks like on
ui
okay so we don't have that particular h1
available here so let's inspect
and here
let's
open it here so you uh we have this
header here but i mean
we don't have any property right because
right how to pass the title now i mean
that component is uh
that component doesn't have input
property just have a property
but what in case i want to access it now
let's see how we can achieve that using
view child
so here uh we will create
we will use view child it's a decorator
so virtual decorator and then
it we need to pass some parameter and we
will talk about that parameter as well
so here i'll go ahead and pass this
component which is header component
right so this is the component we want
to access
and i'll call it as
uh so this is a variable i'm saying this
is header component of type header
component and let's import
this header component
okay we have already imported header
component somehow
it is taking some time
for some reason
anyways
so what we did here so using view child
what we have done is we have created a
new instance of header the setter
component and we can access this
instance inside this component inside
the rooms component right now so i can
access any property any method on this
particular component and i can achieve
whatever i want to
but there is a cache
let's do
console
dot
login
okay somehow my indecisions start
stopped working let me just check
so this dot
uh
header component has no initializer okay
we are using strip mode so i'll just put
this question mark to avoid this
particular level
and it is compiled
let's see the output let's see the
output now so we have uh
let's go to console
and here
rooms component uh ds line number
yeah here so you can see uh what we have
available here is let me just zoom in we
have undefined
this uh i i specifically said that using
view child what we are doing is we are
creating a new instance of this
particular component but why don't we
have anything if it's a component i mean
it should be give us some metadata
information right about that particular
instance but we don't have here
so let's see uh
why and how we can access it so first
thing which i'm going to do is i'm going
to create or
i'm going to implement after viewing it
so let's go ahead and do that
view
in it
and
we will implement the interface which is
ng
afterburner
and let's
use the same line which we have written
here online number 37
and let's paste it on line number 80.
it's saved so let's go ahead and see
and it is simply it is compiled
successfully and now let's wait and see
so online number
36 sorry now line number 37 as i uh
added one more line
we don't have anything we still have
undefined but at line number 80
we have the same instance but we have
now some metadata so what is that
metadata it is giving me information
about
it is giving me information about the
header component
so i just said that it is going to
create a new instance and it is it has
created but this instance is actually
available
inside after unit not inside
engine indeed why so so let's uh
discuss the difference here
using view child you create a new
instance but
there is one more property which you
have to
provide here
let's uh do that and we will discuss
about it so there is a property called
static true
by default this static property is false
and
what happens when we make it true so
let's go ahead and see both in the in
action
now
you can see now after making static to
true i started getting an instance at
line number 37
and of course i will get an instance at
line number 80 as well because it's
available so what we achieve using
static two
this is here you where you have to
understand the component life cycle book
properly
let's go to the slide
so if you see this life cycle look
ngo changes ngo in it ng to check and
then we have content in it content check
and then we have after unit and after we
checked and then
ng on destroy
this lifecycle
will execute for each and every
component
now
[Music]
i am right now inside rooms component
what i'm trying to load i'm trying to
load header component so what will
happen here so let's go through it
first
the ng on init of your rooms component
will be called and then after do check
after content in it after content check
after viewing it after we check an ng on
destroy
as i am trying to load header component
the same
life cycle of header component will be
called as
here we are saying static true
which has a very specific purpose that
in case i am saying this component
is
has this property called
with static true it means this component
is actually safe to be used
inside on init of its parent
why so i mean why we should make it true
and why why should we should make it
false
this is here where i will talk about
little bit i'll
talk a little bit about asynchronous
programming
if let's say uh my header component has
the same lifecycle look and inside ngon
in it lifecycle look it has some
asymptos code what will happen
in that case
of course
the execution will be blocked
and it is not
uh it is not
we
sorry
we won't be confident that this
particular instance will be available at
the ng on init of my parent because of
course i mean
this at this particular time header
component is still executing its
ngoninet on inaudible so it is still not
initialized
so whenever you have some component
which has let's say some asynchronous
code which may delay or something right
so which may delay creating or executing
the ng only lifecycle look
make it static false you do we need to
do that no the answer is no static is
false by default that's why we were not
getting that instance at line number 37
when we didn't add it static to property
in this case header component does not
contain any synchronous code so it is
safe to be used
but still
whenever you are using view child that's
why they removed it so earlier therefore
there was a lot of confusion people a
lot of developers used to miss this
property and they used to try accessing
it inside engineering lifecycle which
used to get which uh
used to cause an error and developers
used to blame the framework so angular
team decided around angular 9 that they
will remove make it by default false so
they will make static variable false so
developers don't get an instance inside
ngo in it in case they are sure that
okay i am sure that okay this will not
cause any issues they can make it start
true so
based on what you are trying to do
use this static property properly in
case you are not sure
just make it just keep it default so
where you don't have to pass anything
and you are safe to access this instance
after unit
now let's come and talk about after unit
what we did there right and why it is
available in after unit
so when we are saying static is false of
course we are saying okay this is
something which may cause delay and we
are not sure that we want to use it
inside ngo in it
after viewing it
is life cycle so
ngon in it is initialization of the
component like so component is getting
initialized
after we
viewing it is the
at this particular life cycle look the
component is saying
all the view
so remember so uh the component is
saying that whatever view i have that is
also initialized
so i'm if i'm trying to load any other
component inside my component it means
that they are also ready they are
initialized as well that's why we are
saying after view init so after view is
totally initialized i mean everything on
my template is also initialized it is
safe to use any other component in your
template uh in your
life in your code base right on in your
ts file so that's the ng after viewing
it lifecycle
now
the other lifecycle hook which is
related to ng after view unit is known
as after view checked so if you uh see
here it is known as after view chart so
to go to after reject let's do one more
thing
right now we have just accessed the
instance
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
remove this
i'm going to remove this static property
here from here
and comment this out
and here
let's assign the property title
and let's see this is
okay so we are saying okay this header
component title is rooms view
and you can see the properties available
here rooms view but
i want to show you one more thing so
here you can see uh there is an error
which says expression changed after
after it has been checked error
so this is one of the most um
what you can say the most searched error
related to angular and it has an
actually link as well so you can click
on this link and it will tell you more
about this error it will it has actually
a video as well
from the angular team
so let me tell you uh you should not
worry about this error in case you get
this error this is totally fine if you
get this error on your development
development environment right now we are
in dev environment how you can verify if
you are in dev environment you can just
click here six messages
and here right so in console you will
always see this message angular is
running in development mode
when you create production build you run
in production build if you get this
error in production build there is
definitely something wrong with your
error with your code but if you get this
in your development mode that's totally
fine and let me tell you why of course
you can go to the link and you can read
more about it but let me just tell you
as we are going through this uh
particular topic
in development mode angular runs change
detection twice
so that's why we get this error so it
says okay previous value was blank now
current value is rooms view so they run
it twice that's the that's the reason we
we have this error
and why they do it because it's of
course development environment so they
need to actually go ahead and recheck if
something has changed so don't worry
about it i mean it's it's totally fine
and ng after let's
view checked so we can actually go to
this
sorry
after
view checked right so you can see uh you
probably will never use this particular
lifecycle cycle look
so it says it says a callback method
that is invoked
immediately after the default change
director has completed one
change check cycle for a component but
as we said
we will uh the
by default i mean angular will run this
change direction twice in your
development mode you will get this error
even though we call this in after view
check so it's like
now let me just talk a little bit about
after what we have after we checked
let's take a look
so at this point
your
angular has already completed one life
cycle check already so in case you want
to um let's say assign some property
here you can actually go ahead and do
that here
after your life your change direction
has completed or you want to modify
something you want to modify some values
you want to call some function you can
actually go ahead and do that here but
remember in depth mode you will still
get this error so don't worry about it
this error
is okay in case you get in depth mode
but
if you are getting it in
production mode that's an issue
yeah so uh this is it
from
after unit and after view checked
is it no there is more so let's go ahead
and talk about those
what else we can achieve using view
child
life cycle looks i mean uh
[Music]
let's
do one more thing uh
how about dynamic components so let's
say
i just comment this out now i want to
render this room's component but
dynamically i don't want to do it in
template
so just copy some template here so we
have this tip then we have ng template
uh i'll talk about what ng template is
and then we uh have h1 tag welcome user
uh let's
remove this as well so we have just an
ng template with hashtag user and then
ng template so first let's try to
understand what ng template is so ng
template is kind of like
a tag
to understand it in uh like
easy words so ng template is a tag which
will be
uh which will never render anything so
ng template itself won't render anything
so it's like it is not visible i mean so
but
it can help us to render some other
template so what some other template can
be it can be another component
so let's try that out
here what we are going to do is we are
going to
dynamically load the
rooms component
using view child
so let's do that
so i'll say okay this is
few child and then
i need the access so let's view child
and close this
now after this i need the access to this
particular
ng template tag so this hashtag user has
some specifics i'll just talk about it
so we can use this
here
and then we can use one property called
read
and which we can pass view
container
ref
i'll call it as vcr the container ref
which is type of view container
it is going to give me some reference by
the name if you can guess so it's saying
okay i'll get it will give me some
reference
to what
now let's talk about this user
so here this hashtag user is something
known as template reference
once you define something with hash on
any html tag
you can access that
tag
so you can access that tag inside your
ts file using view child
it's not only with ng template i can
access any html tag i can even access
div i can access even input element
we'll talk about it i'll we'll see an
example right to just to be sure that
how it works so here we are saying give
me the reference to this user tag right
and this view container ref will
actually help us to
dynamically load a component
let's do that so here i am going to
first say
it implements oninit
and here i'll say this ng on init
and uh
okay so i'm getting some
uh hint because i'm using some service
from github so let's write i'll write
this force so you can const
component
as we want to let's uh assign some value
as well component ref is equal to
i can say this dot
vcr
dot so there is a method
okay
so you can use this dot view container f
dot create component and then you can
pass any component here directly so i'll
say okay actually i wanted to do
is
load
rooms component
and let's
import
okay so now
so it has rooms slash
rooms
dot component
so this is the file and then we need
rules component here
so at this point of time uh you will see
your component will be loaded so let's
save this
and see if our code is compiled yes it
is
let's go to
html and
cannot read properties of undefined
okay sorry
so we just uh sorry so we just learned
that whenever we use view child the
static property is false so what we need
to do is
here i need to use after unit
and here we can access this ng after
unit and now we will get the instance of
the
tag and it should work now so let's uh
see let's go to the browser and
here it is so you have your
view which is loaded which is loaded
dynamically you remember you uh you
didn't specified the room's
uh
component inside your template inside a
template you just have an ng template
and you just gave a reference a template
reference and then we loaded that
component dynamically from our
typescript file so this is what you can
achieve you can just let's see the
uh
html dom here you have hi env rooms
which is loaded inside this particular
div and this is it
this is how you can actually load a
component dynamically
just a single line of code and in case
you want to actually modify some
properties using component ref so i can
just do component ref
and i can do instance
dot
and you can access any property so let's
try to access any of the property which
we have available here
and i'll say number of rooms it is 10
right so let's try to change it
it is getting used somewhere yeah here
so i'll say this
number of rooms is equals to
and let's
let's run it and see the output here and
you have 50 here so
then you have actually loaded a
component dynamically you
changed a property as well
and
this is what we achieved using mutual
and we also learned about template ref
so let's try uh to actually access
a div element using template reference
let's see how we can do that
i'll just comment this out
and we'll keep the code
same here
let's comment and comment this and
here i'll create a div
and i'll say hash
any property name let's say name
so we have this div with hashtag name
this name is actually template reference
now i can access this
inside my component
using uh virtually also view
child give the name
and now as i'm sure that okay this
div is actually available inside my
template
and it doesn't contain any code which
will delay or cause any issue i'll say
okay this is static
true
right so i'll say this is name
and
you can of course you need to give some
type so you can give a type called
element ref
because it's an html element
and now
recommend
and use oninit
and let's see
ng on
sorry not that
enjoying it and then i can say this dot
name
dot
you know
let's try to access any property uh
okay so now intellisense is not working
in
but
it should give me negative element let's
see
let's do console.log
so first let's see what
this dot name gives us it should give us
an element
[Music]
so let's see if it is compiled once it
is compiled
and let's see here
[Music]
we have native element ref and yeah so
native element is the property which we
should be trying to access
so we have uh this or native.native
element and then you can access any
property for example i want to
set in a
text i can say equals to
uh
build then
hotels right and then i will just remove
this
console.log
now let's see
and we have
hello world
is there any issue
you can uh you can see it here so you
have built-in hotel available here let's
put an h1 tag so it's visible right now
it is not
or
it's it's it's okay right so we add and
even
uh it's available so yeah that's what we
wanted to verify so we have this little
nodule available here and what we did we
accessed an element remember so earlier
it was like uh what what what we have
done so far using which right so first
we
the
we actually accessed and
component instance using view child that
was our
um
header component right so we actually
access return component or created a new
instance using typescript using your
file uh we used view child for that then
loaded it then we
spoke about static property what it does
then we
saw in second example where we used view
container ref
we container ref to
dynamically load a component that was
the second example third example what we
did is we
accessed an html element we tried we got
the access of that html element using
using template reference and then we
assigned some value to that particular
html element
by using of course the
uh native property right so we use the
instance dot whatever property uh not
we used native uh what was that property
name
yeah so we use native element property
dot the property which exists on html
element so here we know okay div has
something called in a text and we use
that property to bind it
so these are three examples which we
have seen using viewsite and we also saw
that okay the instances will be
available
in case we you we are using static as
false
in after view init lifecycle look so
most of the time after unit lifecycle
hook is
good for anything which you want to do
after your view is initialized
and uh if you checked is it's optional i
mean you will probably
there there will be hardly some
instances where you will find it useful
but you can do everything which you want
to do after view is initialized inside
ng after viewing it lifecycle
now let's see one more example i'll do
one thing
so i
what i'm doing is i'm having multiple
instances of this header component
inside my rooms list
let's see how it behaves so we still
have single
uh
here
we still have only one instance which is
available and which has this room's view
property
rest doesn't
so here let's try to understand this
view child property will always access
the first instance which is available on
your template
in case you want to access all the
elements which is available
on your component of type header
component
you need to use view children so name
itself tells you what we are trying to
achieve right so view child in case i
have one instance view children in case
i have more than one instance right
child children
so let's try to do uh use view children
and the same uh the one difference which
we have here is view children
static property is by default false and
it's false you cannot change it because
it is saying okay you are going to have
access multiple instances and cannot be
available during engineering
so here i'll
pass header component
and here i'll say this is header char
children
component
and
we have to just do one more thing
now
query
list
let me just write this code and then
we'll talk about it
let me see if query list is imported
from the correct
path
okay it's still not
let's try to
so we have this uh
sorry so we have this uh view children
and we are saying this is the property
and this is hydrochildren component
children
and we are saying this is type of query
list of header component
what we are trying to do here so let's
see let's see
[Music]
okay looks like my laptop is consuming a
lot of resources
foreign
okay so
now here so what we did is we created we
used we children to create instance of
error component and then we named it as
header children component
and which is type of query list of
header component let's try to just to
console.log and see what what happens
here and we know that we cannot access
it inside ng on it as we said that is
like static is false by default we
cannot do anything here
so let's say this dot uh header children
component dot
now you can see it says forage
why it is saying for it because
uh let's do console.log and then we will
see what it contains and then we'll talk
about the properties it has
okay
so you can see uh what
it has it's a query list it has a
property called dirty
it means dirty means there is no uh
nothing has changed inside this
particular component then it has first
and it has last this is first instance
and last instance so in case you have
like multiple components of same type
and now you want to do something
different with first instance and last
instance you can do that for example
let's say uh
you have you you have multiple rows like
let's say you created a component and
you want to render them as rows
you want to
take first row and show them as header
take last row show them as footer
and whatever is in between you can
actually
treat it as your content that's possible
using first and last you have also
length property which tells you how many
results are there and then you have
underscore results property which gives
you all the result
so it means it is an array so query list
is something which has access to all
properties which is available here
you can
let's go ahead and
see
here right so i can just go ahead and
say header
child component
dot
last
okay so i can access last component and
then i can access the title property of
last so i'll say this is uh
last title just random string right
and let's see the output so it's a it
says okay this is your room's view which
is first instance which we have already
changed using view child and this is
your last title which we changed using
the last property in case you want to do
uh
something with each and every row you
can actually do it by using for each
loop
and what else
and
we will see no different changes later
but yeah i mean this is like an array so
you will get all the methods most of the
methods not all methods which is
available on your
on on your array so you can see it has
some
uh there is something called reset but
and it's
not what we need so we have fun find
filter
and you can also call destroy
to destroy any component
okay
and you can also get any uh component
using index in case you want to here you
have get method as well so this is uh
what you can do using header children
component this is really useful in case
you want to create your own
uh let's say reusable component or your
component where
you want to create your drop downs right
so
where you can your users can pass the
list of records and you can display them
as you want not the user want right so
these are some examples uh angular
material uses um
view children multiple players at
multiple places you can check out the
code base to understand it more so this
is
it from view child and view children we
also discuss about how
you can use view child you can how you
can use visual trend and the life cycle
looks as
in previous video we saw how we can use
view child and we also discuss about
some
uh scenarios where view child is useful
and ng after viewing it uh life cycles
look hook as well
ng after unit hook as well
now in this video we are going to talk
about
ng after content in it
but as i said we will be
going through the life cycle as well as
some some of the concepts
so here we are talking about after
content so it has to be
it has to do something with content but
what content we are talking about
here we are going to talk about the
really important topic called content
projection
so let's go ahead and talk about content
projection and then we'll come to ng
after content in it and what is and then
how we can use it
so let's go back to the code base
and for this what we will do is we will
create a new component
so uh
because we need to understand what
content projection is
so i'm going to create few components
and then uh let's see let's uh
we'll talk about the content projection
so first component which i will create
is
let's call it as
container
so this is a container component and
why uh content position is useful let's
let's talk about once we create this
component
so let's say you have your
application right
but what you need is you
uh once you finalize your design system
you said okay my sidebar can be on left
side
my footer can be on the lower side my
header will be on top of the
top of the page
but use i don't want to actually give
this functionality where user can decide
i mean not the end user but my
developers as
a lead engineer i want to actually take
care of where the components will be
rendered
and in what sequence
this is where actually uh these are few
scenarios where can this is actually one
scenario where content position is
useful what else
so let's say you have created one
component as you said components are of
course your reasonable html tags so what
we need is we want to give that reusable
html tag but what content should be
placed inside that
particular container or a particular
component
should be defined by user again if i
talk about user here i am talking about
the developers so your developers should
be able to define that okay i want to
put some let's say h1 tag or uh i want
to put a break here or i want to put a
horizontal line here that's something
which is up to the developer
so these are two scenarios where content
position can be really useful let's go
ahead and do that so first
how we can achieve that so to achieve
the
content projection what you have to do
is you have to place an html tag called
ng content
so let's do that i'll say
and this is what we have so we have ng
content open closed that's it nothing
[Music]
else let's take this component just
close this
so you might be wondering what is
different here i mean we have been doing
the same thing earlier as well right we
for example rooms component we have
placed the room component open and close
that's it
how this ng content is going to address
so let's
see the view it is act as it is
now
let's try to put some html contents here
so what i'm going to do is i'm i'll
place an h1 tag i'll say this is
from
energy
[Music]
content
let's go ahead and see
and you can see you have this is from
ngc content available here the content
which we placed inside an html tag and
if you see this i mean of course this is
how it looks like hiv container and then
this h1 which is replaced
by this ng content which we have placed
here
so it will not work with other tags for
example if i do try to do it here for
example h i n b rooms we don't have any
ng container here so it doesn't know
what to do with this so let's go ahead
and try this out
and see
and you don't have anything here right
so in rooms you are not getting that
particular
h1
content which we have placed but here we
are able to get it because we have
placed an energy content and you can
knows that okay this there will be some
content which will be passed by
the user i mean as a developer i mean
you can be
the same developer right you who is
writing container and who is using that
container
so this is uh what you can achieve using
ng content but of course this is not it
so let's go ahead and talk a little bit
more in detail
you can also do one more thing
as i said you can provide the order in
which you can
you want to actually load your
components so let's say i can give or i
can create a container component which
has like your dashboard header footer
sidebar
placed accordingly right
but you don't want to actually do it by
yourself i mean containers should not
have anything so container should define
okay where was what that's it
there isn't mean let's say what you can
do is that container component is your
reusable component and now you are going
to use that reusable component across
multiple applications so what you have
to do is you have to just create the
component
and you have to just place them that's
it that's what you have to do as an user
i mean as a developer
so let's uh create few components here
[Music]
let's see what we can create
we can create an employee component so
of course hotel will have any have
employees
and we already have rooms so we'll these
are two so let's say now what i want to
do is
i want to uh load
let's say employees data first
then i want to give an ng content where
people uh sorry where developers can
add whatever content they want to and at
the end i want to load rooms
so let's see how we can do achieve using
ng content so in ng content you can
pass a property called select
in select you have to pass the html tag
remember this so first what i want to do
is i want to actually load employee
okay so this is where i'm going to place
employee then there is an ng content and
at the end
what we want is we want to load rooms
so
let's go back to rooms
let's close this again
take rooms go to container
html and
let's replace this here
now we are done with our container now
let's go back
to this main component.html and now we
have this container available here so
what i can do is
i can place
so
remember i'm placing rooms
first
and let's put
in employee second
and let's save this
you can just format
and
let's go back to our page so this is uh
this is how it looks like so you can see
uh you have hello world then you have
rooms view
and let's see here
i need to comment this out otherwise
rom's data will be like displayed twice
and let's uh yeah so we uh it's compiled
now you can see so
let's open the container you have
employee first
then we have this is from ngcontent
because we placed an empty container we
are saying that okay whatever doesn't
match comes here
and then we have rooms
and we don't have the same sequence
here i mean we are sorry
we don't have same sequence here we are
loading rooms first employees second and
then at the end and it doesn't matter i
mean because you have defined this this
is the sequence in which i want to
actually load some content
and
[Music]
you have also defined this is these are
the uh matching tags so select we are
saying okay select this particular html
tag or select this particular component
right
which will be placed here
so this is how you can actually use a
continuous now what else what else we
can do
we are talking about ng
ng after content in it now what is the
content for a component
so for this particular component if you
talk about container component the
content is something which will be
loaded
or which will be provided by the parent
component
so
the content
also whatever is loaded inside this
container is the content now
[Music]
your components so my container
component can only access this
components in case they it want to
inside a lifecycle called ng after
content in it because at that moment the
company knows that my component my uh my
contents are initialized so who is
giving the comp content it right now it
is it is parent component like app
component which is giving the content
when container component will come to
know that all the components are all the
contents are initialized within my
component add the container oh sorry uh
ng after content
so let's put an implement
and let's see what we can do
using this so
i'll say implements
after
content in it
and let's implement
so here you can see in c after content
in it
but
how to select
the components so here i want to
actually select let's say
employee component for example let's add
some properties here
so i will say this is in b
[Music]
employee name
which is string and by default john and
let's display this employee name
here
so we want to actually so let's say
access the employee component here and
then probably want to change some data
or want to call some action or
want to actually do something with
employee component everything is
possible so how to access that
particular component first you have to
use something known as view chill view
checked
okay so you can say view child and then
you can pass the component so you can
say okay this is employee component and
then
you can give an a name sorry
not view child
content child
so we can give a property name so i can
say this is content
or we can just call it as employee
which is type of employee component
and let's import blue chip that's the
contentious idea
and now we have this particular property
of course this is uh strict mode so we
have to put this question mark as our
exclamation mark and now let's try to
access and uh before we move ahead you
might have this question so uh do we
have static true or false available here
the answer is no uh in content child you
can actually only access those uh
everything which you have defining here
inside the ng after contentment so there
is no option of all calling
static true the reason being of course
because this component doesn't know what
is supposed to be available here it will
be always passed by my parent component
and bad it will take some time right so
running through all the life cycle
initializing its own content then uh
[Music]
going to child component initializing
that and then coming to the content in
it life cycle look so it won't be
available here so we have to actually
just go ahead and
do whatever you want to do with this
particular component or access this
component here so let's do console.log
this.employee right now
and let's see our application so here um
just
so you can see here so you have access
to uh line number ts
you can see the line number here so it
says okay this is coming from container
component
and then you have the emp name access to
emp name as well
now what i can do with this so i can
just uh do something like i can change
this dot employee
and i can just
access the
let's say emp name equals to
from drawn to rick
and it will be changed here so you have
uh the updated value available so you
can actually dynamically oh sorry you
can actually uh
access any component at runtime so it's
not like something which is uh
you you can access any component
which is loaded by a content
or ng content then you can access access
that component using content chart and
then you can
do whatever you want to do so uh the
the preferred way is always of course
using input and output you can make as
much
or you can
so the preferred way is to use input and
output but in some cases this this is
really useful view child and view
children where you don't have much
control on your component you want to
access those component uh inside your
typescript file uh you want to create
the instance at that particular time and
then you want to assign some data or you
want to actually
bind some data or call some function
which is available on another component
so these are the some use cases where
these two are really useful of course
both having different purposes right we
saw what we tell us and now we are
talking about containers so energy
content remember this type so
in case you want to you are not sure
okay what will go here you just want to
provide
a container where
my i can i can replace any text in
future so you can actually add that
inside the container for example uh
one
com one example which we can give is
faqs right so for what in case you have
a lot of clients what you will be doing
is of course the design will remain same
properly probably the only thing will
change it will change is content so what
you can do is you can create a container
component uh
apply all the stylings you want to and
then just
ask your designers to actually write the
content for you that's it or who whoever
is uh
responsible for the content they can
provide the content that's it and that's
uh that's
that saves your time right
so let's uh
move on and now i've ng after content in
it then there is also there is a life
cycle of called ng after content checked
so in case you want to actually make
sure something is something needs to be
done once you are once
one time your change section is has
executed you can use that but probably
rarely used so you will not find
many scenarios where that will be used
which leaves us to our last lifecycle
look which is really important because
whenever something is created it needs
to be destroyed of course i mean
everything
it's it's part of the life right
so
our component starts when it is
initialized and
when it is destroyed
at that moment our last last life cycle
look which you can see at the bottom is
ng on destroy which on destroyed i mean
it itself says when i am getting
destroyed so this is the event which
will be called when your component gets
destroyed but
when does our component gets destroyed
very important question let's go ahead
and figure that out
so here
let's take an example of this so uh
remember we had this
hidden right so what i'm uh what i'm
going to do is now i'm going to use uh
ngif
on this
but uh what i will do is whenever i
click on hide rooms
we will
hide the entire room list remember what
ngf does it removes the component from
the dom
so
let's use it here
and
let's implement
on destroy
and i'll say this is console.log
on destroysquad
let's go back to our code
so i'll remove clear the console and
let's click on toggle so you have your
component back so it this is the first
time your component is actually loaded
let's click on toggle again
and
one second so you have bronze components
gf
night rooms
i just implemented this on destroyer at
the wrong place because the component
which is getting destroyed is not this
one it is the room's list component
save this and
we'll just remove the on destroy from
here because otherwise it will
give us an error that we have not
implemented the interfaces properly
yep let's see
so you uh we have this toggle button now
the component is loaded and let's clear
the console and click on toggle again
and you can see now it says on destroy
is called and root rooms list component
just to
clear that okay this is the correct line
where this code is available so what is
happening here why uh
uh why on destroy is getting called so
remember so whenever
the dom element gets removed sorry
whenever a component is get gets removed
from your dom at that moment the
components on destroy life cycle event
will be called
now what you can achieve using ngo
destroyer so it's it's getting destroyed
so it should be okay right i mean it's
okay it's getting destroyed
but it's really useful in case you have
some memory consuming code and you want
to free the memory this is the core this
is the lifecycle look where you can
actually do that now what is the
scenario for wrangler so in angular you
uh we will be using something called
subscription in upcoming sessions in
upcoming videos
and
using those subscription you can
actually uh subscribe to some some data
now once you subscribe to that data
that's that subscription become active
so somewhere you have to actually
unsubscribe to those that's where ngon
destroyer comes into the picture or you
want to actually
probably uh
let's say reset some data or
do some logic when you're you're
whenever your component is getting
destroyed you can go ahead and do that
inside ngo destroy for example let's say
uh you want to remove something from
local local storage or session storage
whenever a component is getting
destroyed yes that's that's the life
cycle book where you can book into and
call those code to clear your cash clear
your storage
those are the things which can be done
here
but
most of the time you will be using this
lifecycle look to unsubscribe to the
data in future
so this is it about lifecycle looks now
let's move on to next topic
in this video we are going to talk about
dependency injection
so we will talk about what is dependence
injection and we will see what uh what
is di providers so di stands for
dependency injection mixture
so let's go ahead and talk about
dependency injection so dependency uh
in case you are coming from some other
technologies you may have already used
it for example dotnet and java uses
dependency injection a lot but in case
you are not aware that's absolutely fine
so what what is the dependency here so
in angular a dependency can be a service
or sorry not
[Music]
you it can be a class actually it can be
class
so let's create it
so in angular a dependency can be a
class or an object which you can
access or you can inject inside a
component or inside a surface wherever
you want to
it's actually a design pattern which is
uh as i said widely used in other
technologies dotnet java they use it a
lot
and
in other technologies you have to
actually go ahead and do some
configuration to actually achieve
dependency injection but
angular has the dependency injection
built in
and this is one of the
uh this is one of the uh i would say
one
fun
so
dependency injection is one of the
feature which actually
makes angular what it is it makes
angular really better because this is
one functionality or you can say one
feature which is not available with
other frameworks
and it is really powerful so we will of
course go ahead and see what we can
achieve using our dependency injection
as we said there are uh there are
multiple types of providers so you have
class bis providers then you have value
providers and we have factories we will
talk about those uh what what are those
and
but and we can also uh
before we actually go ahead and talk
about other di providers we'll start
with class based providers so we'll
start with class base provider then
we'll see value provider and we will see
factory as well so here let's go ahead
and see how you can create and consumer
service we will also talk about what
service does because that's important
right before you can you go ahead and
use something you have to be aware what
why it is used
so here rooms component.ts let's go back
to this component so if we see if the uh
number of lines of code in my rooms
component is already raised around 126 i
mean including the spaces
but yeah i mean more than 100 lines of
code
and some of the code may be reusable
right so uh but not right now but of
course in longer longer term
some of the code base some of the code
which we have written inside room
component can be reusable
so what we can do of course the
what we can do is we can create
something reusable and we can move this
code somewhere
what is that somewhere so that's
somewhere in service so what we can do
is we can create a service we can move
all reusable code in that particular
service generally what you try to do is
keep the code minimum inside your
component and try to split that code
into
multiple services i mean services is
something where you will be writing your
business logic so your business logic
should go into your
your services so don't try to write
everything inside component always split
them into services services are
something which will which is which
knows okay what it's supposed to do for
example it's possible that you may do
multiple things inside a component for
example uh
you can have a dashboard where you are
accessing the data from let's say
employees you are accessing the data
rooms data you are accessing the booking
data
so what you will do write all the code
inside your component the answer is no
of course what you can do is you can
create multiple services based on what
uh each service is supposed to do for
example each service one service for
rooms one service for booking one
service for employee and then i can just
use all those services inside the
component and the uh the advantage is i
can actually go ahead and use that
service anywhere i want to and i don't
have to duplicate the code
so let's see how we can actually do uh
or
start creating a service and split the
logic in this example so what we'll do
is we'll create a service for rooms
now
[Music]
for creating the services it's up to you
what folder structure you follow
generally
what i do
i keep a folder called
service or services
and i create my all services here for
example any service related to rooms
goes into this folder
similarly i mean if i have to create a
new service for employee i'll create a
services folder in employee and then
move all the code base or
add all the logic there
[Music]
so let's let's go ahead and create our
services so we won't be doing it
manually we will be using
angular clm so you can type ng g
generate as service and the name of your
service so here i want to create a
service for room so i'll say okay rooms
so my
new file will be created inside this
services folder
and
here it is so you have rooms dot room
service
class created so you can see okay it has
a it has a class and then provided in
root what is this provided in root we
will discuss about it let's ignore it as
of right now
and what we will do here is we will move
some logic from my
rooms component to here and then we will
use this service rather than actually
writing that code into room service
let's see first
this data right so we have actually this
data which is coming for example in
future what we will do is we will get
this data from our backend or from some
api
so
generally the driver of
any data should go into service
so here i can
create
a method
i can say this is get rules
so this is rooms list
and then i'll just return
in this dot room list
so nothing
extraordinary right right now because we
don't have the apis we just want to
understand how services works
so we got the rooms data which is now
part of my service
and rather than actually uh doing
or
getting all the data i mean inside the
component what we have done is we have
moved that logic into service now let's
see how to use that particular service
as we said in angular we are going to
use dependency injection so what is a
dependency injection it's a design
button of course we reset it's a design
pattern so but what it it does
so
using dependency injection approach
the dependency injection approach says
you should not create an instance
directly
so
in general if i have to create an
instance of class this is this is
something which we will do we will say
okay this is room
service
which is type of
[Music]
is equal to new
room
okay so
this is how you will create a new
instance of a class
but when we say
we need to use dependency injection this
is something which you should not so
rather than creating the instance
manually we need to rely on the
dependency injection uh which is already
provided built in by angular we don't
have to do anything else
so let's see how we can do that so here
i can inject a service i can inject
anything i can inject a class i mean i
when you can inject a component which
you should not do until unless you think
that's the last approach possible which
i think which i don't think so i have
seen some developers doing that but
that's an antibiotic i would say
should not inject a component so here we
have created a service
and now we want to use this particular
service inside our component so this is
this is how you will be doing it so you
will say
uh rooms
i mean the variable name
service which is type of
rooms service
now
once you do this
we have to also provide the access
modifiers
now uh this is where a lot of developers
get confused whether we should get it uh
get uh take it public or private i would
say always make it private
the thing is if i make this particular
service public
it can be accessed on the template which
is again an empty pattern a lot of
developers does that does that does it
should not access services directly from
your template try to avoid it
so what i can do is i can mark this as
private it means okay i'm limiting this
particular service to my template or
sorry to my typescript file itself not
anything else so it will the instance
will not leak on to my html or my
template
now to get the data i can what we can do
is we can say this task
rooms list
is equals to now we have to get it from
service so we'll say this dot
room service start get rooms
and
let's square in
let's go ahead and see the output
so
so let's go ahead and see the output so
here of course we have to click on
toggle and you have your data back
the only thing only difference is now
this data is coming from your service
not from
component itself so component doesn't
know
how to get the data generally your
component should not know um how to get
the data or how to add the data or how
to even do any business logic that
should not be the responsibility of your
component that should go into a service
so what uh what is a service a reusable
class where you can actually put some
business logic
and then you can just access those
inside your component
and
this this is how you will create a
service
so let's go ahead and move on
you can also achieve component
interaction using service so in case you
want to pass the data between two
components you can do that using service
better example which we'll see is
when we learn about alexis so right now
just just be aware there are multiple
techniques so we have used input and
output view child view children content
sorry view view child content child and
you also have some services as the
another approach
so now we have to actually talk about
let's let's go into little bit more
detail into the services
here so provided in
we have root and you have uh two more uh
you have root ini and uh there is one
called platform which is which is not
used uh which is in get which gets
internally used by the router service
uh as of now there is no
like concrete example which is available
for using provide uh provided in
uh platform in case there is something
comes up we will add a new video
but right now we have to provided in
root and any uh we are going to discuss
about root right now and any we will
discuss once we go into routing because
uh that's there is a solid use case
which we can use
before actually we talk about this
provided in root we have to talk uh
something about how this particular
services
gets resolved
right so we said dependency injection so
once once we inject this particular
service
angular has to actually resolve these
dependencies how we do that how angular
does that
so to understand it
let's uh talk a little bit about
this diagram
which is
known as dependency resolution
here
whenever you inject a service
angular needs to figure out where this
particular service is provided
so right now
if you see
this provided in is something which is
known as root
so what what does it denotes
in
older days i mean
before angular 6 before angular 6 what
we used to do is whenever we had we
create we used to create a service we
used to register that service here
so you can see this providers area is
empty
we actually used to do it here
then with angular 6
angular team came up with a approach
where they said
when we create a service we will say
provided in root by default so when we
say provided in root the service is
actually registered here inside this app
module you don't have to do it manually
now now why it was done which is of
course again very really uh
again which is really important to
understand
so a lot of time what the developers
used to do is they used to inject they
used to register a service
and over the time of over
the time
probably after some sprint developers
used to actually stop using that
particular service for example let's say
i was doing some poc the code made into
master and now i am not using it after
the next release because the poc is not
needed anymore
but as this is already available in
providers it is getting
bundled as part of your code final code
so agnes that once we once you create a
service and say provided in root we will
take care of registering your services
here in app module
also in case this particular service is
never getting used we will also remove
this from the bundle once you create a
production build
win-win situation for both of us right
and as framework and as well as the
developers
now
what else what else provided in rulers
once you add a service using provided in
root you get a single instance of this
particular service available across
remember this
so
what do you mean by singleton
let's uh try to figure that out
so what i'm going to do right now is
here let's uh
we know constructor right so we we
talked about constructor multiple times
so what it is i mean this is uh
something which will get called whenever
a new instance of your class is getting
created so here what i will do is we'll
say console.log and i'll say room
service initialized
why i'm doing it let's let's go ahead
and figure out
so let's say i use this particular
service somewhere else for example in
employee component
and say this is private
uh
not employee rooms
service
and
room service so we injected this
particular service here as well
now let's go to
let's go to our view and see
what is happening here so you can see
room service is only a room service
initialized is getting called only once
not at other places and it is from room
service
this one i mean if you even
see i mean if i click on toggle
you will not see okay this service is
not initialized again
why so
because there is only one single
instance of this particular class or
this
employee as a room service which is
available right now so there is only one
instance
whenever you use provided in root so it
means i am registering this particular
service into my root module
if it gets used of course it will be
part of your bundle if it doesn't get
used it will be removed
but you are also getting a single
instance of your
service
now let's go back
and try to see what in case i need a
separate instance
valid use case right i mean i don't want
to use the same instance for
multiple components i want
what i want is
so employees should have its own
uh uh sorry in employee should have its
own instance
so i can we can actually pass something
known as providers and then you can pass
a service here so i'm passing room
service
again here
so now let's see what uh what happens
and you can see rooms service is
actually initialized twice one
of course the global instance second
is for employee so who is using global
instance right now rooms
and who is using the local instance
employee so employee has a different
instance and your
rooms has a different instance so this
is how you can actually uh
create
instance
of your service in case you need to most
of time i mean single in singleton
instance is more than enough but
there might be some there may be some
use cases as per your application for
example a real-time example which i can
give is
in
one of the project i was part of we
wanted to actually
take some json data and we wanted to
put some controls on the on the ui
and
remember so every screen has that json
data coming from the backend
so what we needed is every screen should
have its own instance so
unfortunately uh in during testing we've
actually figured it out it didn't made
into the production but uh what we did
is we removed this provider's property
while migrating our port because our
code base was on angular 5 and we wanted
to migrate to angular 7 i think
where this provided in concept came in
so we ended up removing everything and
then just adding provided in so what
happened is now
whenever i used to
switch the uh urls
i used to get more and more components
being added onto my view the reason
being it was a single instance or single
instance which was available so whenever
i used to
switch back to another page i mean all
the json it used to get uh used to get
added into the same ad
because it was a single instance so
make sure that you are sure that you
whether you want to create a single
instance or not
so in case you don't want to create a
single instance go ahead and register
your service inside that component and
you're safe
so now we know about single singleton
instance and how you can make non single
in a singleton instance
now one more thing which is again very
important to understand during
dependency injection
so uh how your services are getting
resolved right
so here uh
let's talk a little bit about it so
whenever a component uh
or a service right it checks that okay
there is something which is injected
here
the service
resolution starts from this particular
component so it's okay it identified
okay now this room service is actually
injected here
first
the component will check with itself
do i have an provider's array available
here if it is available the entire
dependency resolution tree stops
if it doesn't identify that okay this
particular service is not available here
in case i have a new
module
remember i can have a number of modules
we have not just done it
as of now we will be doing that while we
move into routing
so let's say if for example rooms has
its own module it will go to the parent
so it will be module in that case
it will check with that model do you
have this particular service it says
okay i don't have it
and then it goes to
the parent of
the that particular module so let's say
right now we have component
appcomponent.html which is our root
component it checks with this particular
component do you have this particular
instance it says no and at the end it
reaches to app module and as all the
services which you create are marked as
provided in root
it comes here and it says okay i have
found this particular service but in
case this particular service is not
registered i mean we misprovided in root
or
uh you you never had this particular
property so there is possibility that
you may not
have this provided in property available
in case someone migrated the code base
so
what in this case
now you'll get an error so this error is
again uh you will find of course you
will find a solution on stack overflow
if probably on the first page so
whenever you get a error like something
like this which says no provider for
room service so here it is saying that i
am not able to figure out where this
particular service is registered
remember you may get this of course
while working daily on your code base
it's possible
so here it is of course saying that okay
this particular service was not
available at app module so what i did is
i went one step above so
let's see
let's go back to the this diagram
so it it
it actually went to this
app module our rf module it didn't found
this particular service here
then
where else it can look at lookup so
remember above app module we also have
something called main.ts
and we use something called platform
browser here so it goes to this platform
browser and says do you have this
particular service by any chance it says
no i don't have it
after this there is one more level which
is called null injector which is
actually specifically to use
or
check if this particular service is
available or not
and once it reaches there
you get this particular
null injector
makes sense right null injector and null
injector error so you
get this particular error says okay this
particular service is not available i'm
not sure what you're trying to do but it
is not available it is not registered
and let's go ahead and put it back
so i can go to room service
and
just
put it back and our application
will combine
will compile again and it works so this
is uh what this particular
hierarchy means so
this is how your services gets resolved
so
this
now
uh so this is it from the dependency
injection uh we will we need to discuss
one more thing before we end up with
dependency injection and then we will
move on to our http
so far we have learned about dependency
injection and how it is resolved but
there are few
more important things which you should
understand and which is known as
resolution modifiers so we are going to
talk about four resolution modifiers
which is which exist
and which are really useful
uh
based on your scenario so we will also
discuss about the scenarios where it can
be utilized
so let's start with the first resolution
modifier which is available called self
let's see a use case for
this self decorator
so we are back to this code and
here
we will go to this employee component uh
because i think this is the best place
where the self decorator scenario
is best suited for
so remember we discussed about how you
can actually go ahead and add this
provider's property on employee service
because we want to have and separate
instance for this particular service and
then we also discuss about the
resolution uh how how your dependency
gets resolved right i mean it goes to
your parent and
uh it keeps going
till it finds uh the root and if it it
is not available at the root it will go
to the
null injector and then it we will get an
error called null inject error right so
this providers does not exist which is
like as i said
widely
uh
[Music]
a widely searched error which is
available on internet but
now let's go ahead and see how you can
utilize the self decorator here
so in this scenario in employee
component we are actually injecting the
service
at the component level right so we are
we are sure that this particular service
should be available here that's the
use case and that's the expectation as
well
so what we can do is we can by using
either itself decorator
which should be imported from angular
core remember this
by using this we can
by using this self decorator now we are
saying that this particular service
should be available at this level
if this particular service is not
available here it means
we should throw an exception now when it
can be uh useful
so
in my uh one of my real-time project
where i was working so we wanted to
actually
create
the
forms by collecting some json data which
was coming from backend
so what happened is by mistake while
migrating our application from the lower
version to the upper version so the
lower version was actually angular 5
and
we were migrating to angular 7 and the
provider's property came around angular
so what we did is by mistake we removed
that property and what happened
but as we remove this property whenever
we used to actually revisit different
forms all the controls
used to get added into the same service
because it's it was single digit service
and at one point we realized that our
form one of the page or one of the form
is really slow and then we realized that
okay behind the scene it has like 300
controls
so that was the use case but in case we
added this we had you we might have
added this self decorator
it actually serves the purpose because
it it should tell us that okay now this
particular
service is should be available here
should be registered here if i
use this self-decorator let's run this
application first
iphone or
so the application is here and
let's click
and
let's keep it side by side because we
want to see the error
so let's say if i add the self decorator
and i remove this provides property
so now what will happen is we will start
getting the same error which we have
received earlier which says
let's come back here and
okay looks like this employee component
is not available that's why
i'll just add this employee component
somewhere let's
add it here
and now we have the snow provider for
room service right so we started getting
this error
now actually here
as we added self decorator now
during uh
our file resolving this particular
instance
angular will not go up it will just try
to see if it is available here if it is
not available here it directly goes to
the nail injector error and it traces an
error that this particular service is
not available so pretty useful pretty
useful in case you are aware that okay
your service will only be registered at
this particular level go ahead and use
it
now let's move on to the next decorator
which we have
which was itself
for that we will take an example of this
rooms component service because
if you see
we are not registering the
service here
right we are not saying okay this should
be available at the
component level
we are expecting this web service to be
available
somewhere i mean maybe his parent
uh parent of room component
may be app component or app module
so we are aware that okay this this
service will never exist at this level
so what we can do is we can ask the
angular to skip the check
for this particular component by using
skip self that's the name right so name
itself suggests skip self skip myself
from the entire dependency resolution
tree which you are going to execute skip
myself
again
to give you an idea do we should we use
this the answer is
maybe because angular internally
because angular internally uses
something known as bloom filter to
figure out where the service or the
instance is available and it is pretty
fast already you don't have to do uh go
ahead and use itself but it is a useful
uh with another attribute or another
resolution modifier called optional
[Music]
so let's uh go ahead and see
now the next
attribute which is available we will see
optional first and then we will go to
the host
to understand
the
optional one what i have done is i have
created a service called logger
so this is logger service and it
contains a method called log and you can
see uh what i have is i'll just add this
provided in property here because i have
removed it right now
so i have added this uh created this new
service and
what i'm going to do is i'm going to use
this logger service but what we need is
we want to use this logger service
only during dev environment
during production actually we don't want
to use this long service but as we have
seen if we try to remove this provided
in property
we will get an exception because we are
saying uh if this particular service is
not registered anywhere go ahead and
raise an error even though we use skip
self or we use self
we are going to get this error so this
is what
we can achieve using optional decorator
so let's go to appcompany.ts we will
actually inject this particular service
here so let's
say private
log the
service
which is type of login service and
let's
uncomment this so i'm going to call this
log method
and let's see
and we have uh this app component.nc on
it right those so this is this is
something which is
blocked at this line angular you can see
logger service dot ts
but
during production let's say we don't
want to inject this service i mean there
are multiple ways we will not talk about
it right now
but in case uh just to recreate the
scenario where this particular service
is not registered
what we can do is let me just add option
later on but we can actually go ahead
and
recreate this scenario where this
service is not registered by removing
this provided in root property right now
we will start getting an exception
saying this uh
service is not available right
and no provider for log service this
this was expected
so what we can do is we can mark this
service as
optional so let's go ahead and use
optional decorator
not option optional decorator and now
list currency
and the error is gone so we don't have
that no provider for logger service
anymore because this is optional so in
case angular figures out there is an
instance which is available it's okay if
it doesn't just go ahead and execute it
i'm using this ternary operator here
because in case this particular service
is not available uh we will get an error
so let's see
so if i try to execute the log method
there
you can see cannot read properties of
that so to avoid this i am using this
ternary operator which will only execute
in case logger service exist otherwise
it will just skip that
so this is optional
now what we will do is we will go ahead
and see the last decorator which is
available called rose
and for that what we are going to do is
we are going to get uh take this
container example
right so
what we have here is we have injected
this room service
here
in my container
now how host is
useful let's talk about that
so here
how many instances of uh room service
which we have let's go ahead and see
that
so we have one and
two instances right now
[Music]
what in case i want to have and
separate instance for all the component
which are part of container like this
this container component
in that that case what i can do is i can
just register this particular service
here
first
and then i can add the host decorator
here
now all the component which is actually
uh loaded inside this particular
uh this particular container will start
using the instance which is available
here
so to just recreate the scenario we have
uh employee and rooms right so what i
can do is
here remove this
and from here remove this because it was
creating this second instance if you
understand if you remember right
and let's go ahead and see
now
okay one more thing which
we missed is this
container right
so we have
we have to uncomment
because we we are not right now using
container so
i'll just do this i'll comment this
employee and then i will just use the
container
and let's go ahead and see
so now you have two instances so one
instance is actually which is of course
global one and another one is actually
which is created by the container
component now the content everything
within container will start using the
second instance which is created by
container also we are saying this is
host component
so
and no actually none of the component
which is loaded inside container will go
above this particular level to look for
this particular service instance so if i
remove this
and try to run you will start getting
this no provider for room service found
in node injector it will not go up it
will never go up and check with its band
so this is what you can achieve using
the host decorator remember most of the
decorators you are not going to use
delhi probably few use cases where it
may be useful
skip self i have as i said it's not
mandatory but you can use it it's uh as
a flute builder is already pretty fast
and
you don't have to use it self is really
useful do use it in case you are using
providers on the component itself
not to actually avoid that because blue
filters is already uh pretty powerful
but just to avoid the scenario which i
mentioned right so sometime by mistake
refactor while refactoring the code we
remove it if you have add itself it
means okay i actually really wanted to
have this component this service
registered at this component level and
in case someone new comes in and joins
your team and
he figures out okay this providers is
probably not useful and removes it he'll
start getting an error and probably he
can read about self decorator and what
it is
of course documentation is a better way
but just in case nothing is documented
right so this is all about
uh the
resolution modifiers
and let's move on
in this video we are going to talk about
another type of service so as you can
see there are actually three types of
services which exist so we have used the
first type which is class based
providers so till now whenever we used
to do ngg service we used to get a class
with of course add direct injectable
decorator
and we used to inject it and then use it
let's go and see where value providers
can be useful
value providers are like you can pass an
object as a service and you might be
wondering
where that can be useful why should i
use object as a service so let's go
ahead and figure that out first first
let's see the use case and then we will
create our service
so so far uh let's go back to our room
service this is the code we have
we have an constructor and
let me just remove this line
and we have a get rooms method
because this service does not do
anything i mean this is an kind of
sorry so this is us like a static
service right i mean uh with mock data
and does nothing right so we have just
some dummy data which is which is
available and then we are getting the
state but once you create a real-time
application your data is going to come
from of course an api
and for any api you need an endpoint
that's that's how apis work right so
what in that case
let's see an example in case i have to
access an api endpoint
which
will be used across my application i
mean in multiple services
what can i do
the first way let me show you the
simpler way which can be done so i can
go to environment i have added already
added this uh uh this endpoints here so
what i have done is in environment.ts i
have added a property called api
endpoint which is of course and right
now targets to local state 080 and some
api slash v1 so even version one of our
api
this api does not exist
and i have to add the same configuration
in productions so my build will not fail
otherwise it will fail so remember in
case
you have multiple environment files
whenever you change into your
environment or ts make sure you make the
same change into every environment or ts
file which is available for example i
can have one for staging i can have one
for uh uat and of course two are
required which is environmental ts and
product we will discuss about
we will discuss this later on uh while
deploying on deploying our production
production uh application how we can
change this settings
but right now just remember so whenever
you add something just make sure that it
is added to all the environment files
and in case i want to access this api
endpoint inside my service how i can do
that
let's go to in room service.ts
and i can import
from
dot dot slash dot dot slash dot dot
slash and till i reach to environment
and then i can say environment. uh the
environment file and then i can just
access the property
right so environment and then
i can use this environment anywhere so i
can just
say here console.log environment dot
api endpoint and let's save this and see
and you have this url available right so
here you can see room service line
number 18 sorry 44
and we have this api endpoint which is
available in our config file but what we
are talking about here is we are saying
this url will be used at multiple plus
multiple services what in that case just
think about your import
right i mean it will be like everywhere
i have to give entire path
how i can avoid this so this is where
the
value providers come really comes really
handy and we are going to see two
examples so first let's see how we can
actually deal with this objects right
some uh
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
create a folder i'll call this as app
config so it will uh contain some
services related to application
configuration
so the first thing which i'm going to do
is i'm going to create a service so
let's see how we can we create a value
provider right we i'm going to call it
as a service because it is we are going
to actually inject it so i will call it
as app
config
dot service
dot ts
if you are wondering why i am typing it
because of course there is no command
for it you have to do it manually so the
first thing which we are going to do is
we are going to create a
export constant and i will call it as
app service
uh it depends i mean if you see i'm
using
capital letters but it's okay even
though you don't use capital letters
that's absolutely fine because uh
generally
we have an habit of
mentioning const as capitals but it's
not mandatory so choose whatever you are
comfortable with and then what i have to
do is i have to create a new injection
token so i will say new
injection token and you can see uh i'm
using something known as github
copilot that's why i'm getting this
autocomplete so i'm going to use it
and let's import injection token from
angular core and then this is app config
right this is actually an interface we
are going to create so let's go ahead
and create that
i will create an interface
let's call it as abp
config dot interface dot this
and let's do
let's create an interface
and you can mention uh all the
properties which
belongs to your app configuration and
so uh right now what we are going to do
is i'm going to use api endpoint this is
the only property we have but in case
you have more just go ahead and add all
the properties here
now
here i can just use the same interface
which we have created
and let's import it
so this becomes my service this is this
is the service we are going to use but
we also need the data
so by value providers means i am going
to provide some value that's let's go
ahead and create our value so i am going
to create another constant
and i'm going to call it as app config
and let's provide the value so i here i
can say api endpoint because this is the
property we have here and then we have
to provide the value now
what we can do is we can import our
environment dot ts file here
and
slash dot dot slash
environment slash
one
and take the property which we need so
we are going to need
environment dot
api point and now i have to do it at
only one place i don't have to repeat
this inside edge and every service so we
don't have to do that
so now this is done so we have our
service ready we have sorry we have our
service ready we are we have our value
ready now let's see how to register this
particular service because we have not
done this right i mean we don't have
anything called
here called provided in
uh so let's see let's see how to do it
so
we can go to app module
and you know that you can see this
providers here this is where you can
register yourself so you can say provide
sorry
it will be an object so i can say
provide
and here i am going to say provide this
particular service
and i am going to use a property called
use value
and inside value
i am going to say
this is the value
and let's import both so i'll just
done so we have what we have done so far
is we have created a value provider we
have registered that value provider now
the next step is
to use this provider let's
do that
i am going to go back to roomservice.ts
remove this
and now we need to access the url from
that particular service which we have
created so we know we know how to inject
a service so let's write that
constructor this year
and
our service name is
app service config
so
if i do this
and you can see i cannot
right even
my intelligence says it it is not
something which can be recognized what
is this
so the way to use the value providers is
you have to use
something known as inject
decorator and then you will pass your
service
here
app service config so let's import
now you can see it's it is giving me the
path somehow let's change this it should
not be src
so we have our uh app service we have to
use the add inject decorator
and now i can say private
so i'll call it as config and
here we don't have to use type any
because we also know the type so let's
go back to the surface this is the type
appconfig so we can use
this particular type here
so we get proper
intelligence right i mean even the
typings
and again
this is
now let's try to access uh the same api
endpoint by using this particular
service so let's save this
go back to the code base and
sorry go back to the url
and let's see if it is compiled
it is compiled so let's see
and we have room service initialized
here and this is your end point so you
can see line number 46 now we are
actually getting this value from a value
provider rather than actually directly
accessing environment dot a value from
environment.ts what we are doing is we
are we have created an
uh
injection token or we have created a
value provider and then we are using it
so this is the way you should be doing
that
now let's talk about the second use case
so if you have uh
by learning javascript you might have
seen some
apis right i mean you may have seen
windows we have
local storage station storage what in
case i want to use those inside angular
of course you can because of course
that's javascript and angular at the end
gives you javascript as an output right
and it's a friend it's a front-end and
every javascript code is a valid type
script code so you can use that
but there are some ways so there is
there is a way to use it
so to do that i will take an example
where we will use
the local storage service
okay
so we'll see an example where we are
going to use local storage service
as an value provider
inside angular app
so to do that
we will create a new file
and we will call it as local storage
dot token
remember any javascript api which you
have seen can be used in this way
and i just copied some code
so here what we are doing is we of
course we are creating an injection
token we are using provided in root here
because i want to make sure that this
particular service is reshapable and if
no one is using it it the code can be
removed it and
i'm calling a factory function to return
a new instance of local storage that's
what we are doing here we don't have to
register this service directly anywhere
so
let's see how we can use it so i'll go
to webcomponent.ts and here
let's see uh we will inject something
will import
from
dot slash okay
dot slash local storage token
and
now we can use this
into our constructor so
we will we need to use inject
right and then we will call our
local storage token which is type of
local storage and you can also give type
storage so this is any this is actually
the type for your
let's see
yeah this type for your
storage api which is which exists in
browser
so actually typescript also ready has
type definition file for most of the web
apis or javascript based uh apis which
we use generally
it's called a file called lib.dom.ts
because it's all related to dom right so
here uh we can use it in case you get
any error while compiling just move it
to any that's subject
and once this is done let's go ahead and
add something to local storage so to do
that
i just add one value
so let's add
on ngon init let's add this value into
our uh local storage so
i'm adding a variable called name and
the value is related
let's see
it this this value will be added once
our app is loaded right because it's on
engine in it on our root component
let's go ahead and see so this is uh
where you can verify local storage so
here you can go to your
application
and
just see local storage localhost four
double zero right so because our
application is right now running on
localhost four to double zero you can
see this value name data notable yep so
this is this is where your value will be
available don't try to add anything
which is secure to your local storage
this is just an example how you can use
local storage in similar way you can
also use session storage so in case i
in case you want to use look stress and
storage inside your angular application
rather than directly using it try to
create an injection token like this
which like the one which we have created
for local storage
the only difference would be
session storage
right
and uh
even you can use other apis for example
window dot for example in case you want
to use uh location right so rather than
actually injecting location directly
which is
or accessing location directly which is
possible yes of course it is possible
try to use the token so you can use
location menu bar there are navigator
there are a lot of apis which access
right i mean
you can all you you can use all those
apis as a token here rather than
actually directly using inside your code
base in case you come across any
existing code base which is not
following this try to refactor i mean
you will learn something new so this is
it from value providers
in this video we are going to talk about
angular http and observables
this is really important to understand
because
in your enterprise applications what you
are going to do is most of the time you
will be interacting with the apis so
this is what we are going to learn here
how to interact with your apis how to
handle uh the http uh calls
and how to do
different http calls
so let's go ahead and see uh the agenda
for this particular video so we will of
course go through the introduction then
we will set up the http client we will
use the http client service which is
which will be used to make those api
calls
we will talk about
rxjs we'll talk about observables and
streams we will see different http
methods which exist
we will see some examples of rxjs
operators
and then we will see http interceptors
and at the end we will see
at the end we will see app initializer
so let's go ahead and see uh why this
angular http is important so in
enterprise application as i said you
will be interacting with apis
in
javascript you might have used hdx or
fetch if you have never used it that's
absolutely fine that's those are the
low level apis which is available inside
your browser
http client is the service which we are
going to use to interact with our apis
and destitpic client
internally uses rxjs so what is rxjs of
course we will see that but let's go
ahead and start with setting up our
skipping line
to use the functionality provided by ctp
client to interact with your apis we
need to do some configuration
so let's go through that those steps the
first step is we have to use something
called http client module as soon as you
see module it means this is something
which needs to be registered
at your module level
a strip client module generally should
be registered at your root level because
uh
you are going to use http calls across
your application right so you just need
to register it once and that's
absolutely fine
until unless you are using services
and even in that case this will be taken
care of okay sorry i just added it to
declarations really sorry for that
i
okay so here it is so we have
http client module registered and we
have imported it from angular common
http remember this
angular common http because http client
module should be imported from here in
case you get an old code base
it's possible that uh there was another
uh
[Music]
there was another library called angular
slash http so
if you are getting something from
angular http you are probably on the
older version and you should move to
angular common http which was of course
uh introduced
in 2017 so you don't have to go ahead
and still use that particular api
remember angular slash common slash
yesterday this is from where you should
be using it
so this is first step now we are done we
are done with setting up the http client
now let's go ahead and see how we can
use http client service but before we
move into
uh
start using our http client service we
need an api and we don't have any api
available as of now so what we are going
to do is we are going to
use a mock api which i have created you
don't have to worry about this i'll
share the we will share the code and you
can just download it
this api is actually written in nest js
and it is written using typescript
so i'll just do npm start here to start
this particular api
and it will expose some api endpoints
which which we have already written so
you can
go to rooms controller and you will be
able to see aps slash rooms uh this is
post this is get this is get by id
and this is patch and delete these are
different apis which is
available and we will be interacting
with this api so you can see these are
the end points which we get api slash
rooms post abs slash rooms get
and
now let's go back to our code base uh
sorry here uh let's go back to our
uh application like and the first thing
which we need in case you are setting up
your
http uh or http api or your api server
locally you need to create one file
which is known as proxy.conf.json
is something uh
this is something which is available
inside documentation so i'll just guide
you to the document documentation and
uh in next time
whenever you want to set it you can just
refer the documentation so you can go to
angular.io which is of course the
official documentation
search for proxy
let's see
um
okay let me see
you get this set up okay
oh so yeah you can go to the
documentation and go to uh this
ng surf command
and in ngsurf you will find
one property called
proxy
yeah proxyconfig and you can just click
here to it will take you to the page
where all the information is available
so we can create a proxy.con.json this
is first step which i have already done
for us and then you can just copy and
paste this uh our api also exists with
slash api right so slash api slash uh
[Music]
so slash ap slash room so we'll start
with slash api and this is where the api
exists
local 3000 so you can verify from here
uh this application
main.ds and app.listen so right now it
is running on localhost
and after this there are few steps more
which i have already done for us but you
can refer it from here we have to
actually add one more configuration
so we have to add one more configuration
inside our angular.json uh the surf
command
this is the configuration for serve and
we have added this inside development we
have also added proxy config and path to
our proxy.con.json file once you do this
that's it you're done right so this is
to set up the proxy and now let's go
ahead and utilize the service
http client service to make our first
api call
so
room service this is uh where we want to
go and
we are going to use http client service
which is available inside angular so
we'll say private
http and we'll say type of http client
let me just remove this and
we will import http client from angular
common slash http so this is
this is imported now we have our strip
client service available let's go ahead
and make our first api call so here
right now we are getting the data from
uh of course service itself we have hard
coded this data let's remove this let us
get rid of it
i'll do one a small change as my id at
the back end is a string i'll change
this room number
to b string
and
probably i have to change at one more
place which is this
now to get the data in
from an api we generally make a get
called so get calls can be
accessed from the browser itself so
let's try to see
if that works so i can say localhost
3000 slash aps slash
rooms this is where our
resources are available and you can see
uh we have three records available
already and this is our data
so
here rather than actually getting the
data from this dot room list what we are
going to do is we are going to call the
http get method so there are multiple
methods which exist so we have get post
put delete patch
and there are a few more but we won't be
using them uh pro
a lot so let's use generally we call
like
whenever you start working with a new
uh
sorry whenever you start working with a
new framework the first thing which you
learned is cloud operation right create
rate update delete that's what we are
going to do
this get method is read
so here i'll say this dot
http
dot get and you can see i'm getting
intelligence but i'm not going to use it
right now so i'll say so we get and we
need an api endpoint right now as we
have a proxy server available we don't
have to give entire paths so we don't
have to mention localhost 3 3000 slash
api slash rooms what we can do is i can
we can mention slash api slash rooms
this is it
because of the config proxy config which
we have so proxy will redirect or this
call slash api rooms to localhost
which is available here
right and now let's say let's save this
and
once we go back to our component we will
start getting an error here
so
this code is commented right now but
let's uncomment and if we will start
seeing an error it says this dot rooms
have some swiggy lines let's see what it
says
it says type observable of object is
missing following properties
so it is saying okay whatever data you
are trying to actually assign this
assign it to room list is
is of something
of type called observable
what is this observable
so let's uh see this first what i will
do is we'll just con
do a console.log to try to understand
what this observables and everything is
and let's go to console
and we can see this right so we have
observable which says operator and there
are something called source
but there is no data
so let's try to understand what
observable means
angular uses a library called rxjs
internally to work with data
and it is also
used inside your http service as well
even there are few other places like uh
we we will be using it in forms we will
be using it in
routing so multiple places so alex just
let's see what is this
so this is the official uh web page here
it's just dev so you can go ahead and
see what rxjs is it's a there is a small
introduction which is
written here so it's a library it's of
course a library to work
with
even it's a event best program uh sorry
to work with event best programs using
observable sequence so what what do you
mean by observable sequence i mean
probably you might have
never heard about observables
it's a because it's a of course a
different library and generally we don't
use that those libraries but rxjs is one
of the powerful library which which
which is available here and can be used
with any
framework so it does not that it it's
only technically coupled with angular
it's uh it's used in react it can be
used in woo it can be used in swelt
anywhere you want
so rxjs
has a concept that whatever data you get
is a stream of data
right so what do you mean by stream for
example uh you might have already used
lot of streaming services
so let's go to youtube let's uh
let's go to netflix let's go to amazon
what are those they are your streaming
services like amazon of course amazon
not the
shopping app
right amazon prime
so uh what you get is you get
a stream of data right i mean that they
are streaming some data to your
your devices
once we say stream so it's like once you
what happens uh when you
when you want to access some streaming
services the first step is you subscribe
to it right i mean of course you you
need to create an account you subscribe
and then you can start getting those
streams the similar concept works inside
rxjs so
once you want to get some data the first
thing which you have to do is you have
to of course someone needs to publish
the data that's that's of course true
because of course if no one is
publishing the data or no one is
publishing the streams you will not get
anything
but as a user
as a developer what you should be doing
is you should be subscribing to the
stream to get the data
it's a continuous stream generally uh
let me just try to explain you as a
common
term which is used a lot called push
versus pull architecture
let's go back to our code piece i'm not
going to write entire code but yeah just
just an example
so here let's say
if we are not using stream
what you will do is you will call let's
say get data to get the data
in case let's say we perform some
operation
we add the data
so we add a new data what you need to do
is in case i want to get the latest data
generally we do
sorry generally we do is call the get
data again
right this is this is something which
you we have been doing from long time
right in javascript
we have been doing from long time so
whenever you
modify the data what you do is you get
the data again what you do is you pull
the data
this is called pull pull based
architecture so every time you update
something just go ahead and pull the
data
rxjs works on a push architecture
it says
once you get the data
it is continuous stream
continuous stream of data
so
in case
you add some data you add the data
directly into the stream
and once this stream is updated
anyone who has actually subscribed to
the stream will get the data you don't
have to call the get data function again
to get the data that's full based
architecture here we are saying whenever
you update the stream you will get the
updated data that's push based
architecture you are not doing it doing
yourself
actually stream is pushing the latest
data to you
so hope you understand understood this
because this is really important to
understand rxjs and streams
i'll just leave it here in case you want
to refer this again so
what we are going to do is we are going
to get our of course rooms data first
thing in case i want to access this data
what i have to do is i have to go ahead
and subscribe to it and how we can
subscribe using uh
rhs
it has a subscribe method so you can to
get rooms
dot
let's see
subscribe and here
we can say this dot rooms list is equals
to rooms but we are getting an herb
again i mean why
let's try to read the error
this is one of the
most important skill you should learn
in all the modern or the latest
frameworks which we have available
nowadays the developer experiences
really the developer experience is
really great what you mean by developer
experience
so it's all these things right errors or
messages while developing so it guides
you what the actual issue is so it says
that
this room list is of type this room list
array but
you are trying to assign it to an object
and of course there is a mismatch in
data type
what we can do here is we can go ahead
and change uh in get rooms we can
actually ask our http service to
actually give me the data in this
particular type so i can use these
generic syntax and i can say room
list
so
i'll start room yeah
room list array
so we are saying whatever data i am
going to get just transform the data
into this particular object and then
give it back to me and you have your
data available and let's see what else
we are missing we are just missing one
bracket
and let's save this and let's go back to
our front end and let's click on toggle
and you have the data you just made your
first http get call from an api using
angular
you can go to network and you can just
go to uh
[Music]
fetch xsr
and you will be able to see your request
so here we have our get request
uh which returned us status code 200.
you can go to preview to see the data
which is written
and these are requested us and request
response address so
this is your plain link
json response and this is your formatted
response
and it also tells you uh when it started
and how much time it took so it was
completed around in 11 11
0.89 milliseconds so it took this is how
much it took to actually
download the content it was waiting for
11.32 milliseconds to complete the call
but total if you see
uh here
31.88 milliseconds so this is absolutely
fine i mean you should not your api
should respond within one second and
31.1 uh thirty point eight thirty one
point eight eight millisecond is perfect
i mean of course it's a local database
and we sorry it's a local api and we
just have three records to fetch but
yeah congratulation you just did
your you just made your first api call
and
you have rendered the data on your ui
so now we understand how to get the data
from http but i'll focus again on rxjs
because this is really important to
understand so we saw that okay rxjs is
something which gives you stream of data
and it is used for writing reactive
programming and we also discuss about
pull versus push what is the difference
and it gives you like it gives you
observables like stream of your data
which we can subscribe to what we are
going to see now is
we are going to create this
observable
by using rxjs itself
not using http
and see how it works so
let's go back
to our code base and let's create an
observable by r1 so
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
create
and
stream i'll call it as a stream is
equals to new
observable
see
survivable is something which should
come from rxgs okay it is not imported
and we'll remove this
right now
okay
and now here in observe
we get an observer which we will call a
method called next
so there are multiple methods which
exist on your observable so you have you
can see you have unsubscribe
you have complete you have error you
have remove and add
here what we are going to do is we are
going to call next what you mean by next
so whenever you call a next on your
observer it will be emitting a new data
so whoever is of subscribing to this
stream will get this data so let's say
i'm
saying the next data is
uh user
one
and i can of course call it multiple
times so i can say okay this is
observer
dot next user two
and
next user three
and i can also call observable
observer dot complete so whenever this
of course every stream will finish
somewhere
so i'm saying whenever this uh
after this just go ahead and complete
the stream so you can see i'm going to
call complete method and this is where
my stream completes
we can also handle so you can see it
says observer dot
uh we have one more method error right
so we can also handle the error in case
what uh if error there is any error
right so we can just say okay in case of
error just raise an exception and that's
it so we'll say this
uh i mean we are not going to use it we
will see it later on whenever
a stream
raises an error how to handle those so
we'll see that as well
so now this is our our stream which we
can subscribe to which has an observer
and which can
which can
raise or which can give you new stream
every time you have you are calling this
let's go to stream ngo init and here
i'll say this dot
stream
and we will subscribe to this
right so we'll subscribe and we'll say
this is
our data
and we'll call
console.log and we'll see what the data
is
let's go back to our hotel inventory app
let's go back to the console and
you can see you have user one user to
user three after this your stream gets
completed right so
we are going calling complete
let's try to
call this again so we are calling it
multiple time it is anyways happening
multiple times right now so you can see
user one user to user three and again
user one user to user three is getting
uh
getting uh rendered so we are
subscribing to this stream multiple
times and we get the same data every
time and after this your
your stream completes
inside this subscribe also you can get
three values so let's go ahead and see
uh the definition of course so you have
next value you have error
and you have complete
three values so
you can actually write some this as
this is our next value so
so once we subscribe to this we get
three times of three types of data so
you can see we get next
which is of course next value so we'll
we can also do something like this on
complete i am going to say
just go ahead and
complete uh sorry
we'll just print that this is this
stream is completed
and in case you get error you can also
just say okay uh there is some error
right so whatever stream whatever the
error is you can just print it
let me just format
so we have next complete an error
let's go to our ui again and you can see
it says user1 user 2 and this is where
com your stream completes
then again user 1 user 2 user 3 and your
stream completes right
okay this is uh at another place where
it is getting
called so user room component
this is the one
okay because our rooms component is
getting rendered twice it is getting
called wise that's that's that's the
thing
uh i think it has to do with this
right so we have portal rooms here and
let's come
comment this one so we will just use
this
and it will be rendered only one so you
have user one user two three and then it
is completed and then you have user one
user to user three and then your uh api
uh sorry your stream completes so
this is what
will happen this is what we will be uh
we won't be using this syntax uh um
we will be using this syntax a lot of
times even not this syntax we will see
what is the standard way this is just to
make sure that you understand streams so
what uh we have as part of uh streams is
there are two parts
one is of course your observable which
will be subscribed right which your
users can subscribe to and
internally observable will have an
observer which will observe the data
if there is a new value which is
available now where this is useful so in
case let's say you are working with some
real time database
right so whenever a new value is like
pushed because it's a push based
architecture
your observer will actually observe okay
there is a new value so what i have to
do is i have to call next internally
this is what it will be doing internally
it will call next method so whoever has
subscribed to it gets the new value
even in case it uh it also has complete
and error so in case you get some error
or your stream completes that's it if
your stream completes it will not going
to give you anything in case
error is sent it will capture that error
and it will send it to you you don't
have to go ahead and create this
by your own you will be using some
operators of course we will go ahead and
see that
this is just to let you know how
observables internally work
and what's what you get once you
subscribe to it you get next complete an
error these three methods are given to
you
generally what we do is we work with
data but you should also work with try
to handle the errors gracefully as well
i mean your user should not see the
error right red lines in your once your
application is available
so
we will see how we can also handle error
in case we get it from the api so this
is this is all about observable streams
observable observer
and how you can create it manually by
using observable class which is
available here right so if you go to
this rxjs observable you will see this
is a class and it also
has time so right now if you see uh let
me just show you uh
here so it says observable of unknown
because we have not given any type uh we
can actually make it string because
right now i'm working with string so it
will know okay this particular stream
will have string of data you can make it
number in case you are working with
number but yeah this is higher level api
you don't have to do it you don't have
to use it directly inside your code
because most of the time you will be
using http and
you will getting you'll be getting the
data from there or
you will directly work with streams by
using other methods so we will see those
right now this is what we have
in rxjs right so
and observables now let's go ahead and
move into other methods
move on and see other operations right
now we have done get operation and we've
discussed something about rxjs
now we will next we will try to do post
operation right so we uh we are done
with red
let's do it let's see create
and
let's go back to our code this is our
service and we will call at rooms
add room okay we will pass one room not
rooms
and
here we are going to do return this dot
http dot post
api slash rooms and the room data which
we have available right
so our service is done this is this is
uh this this is the
a service is done so this is it
but you have to
be aware whenever you are working with
apis you should be aware of request
format as well as response format
so let's uh
let me just check what is the request
and response format for my this
particular api so we have this
post this is the create and create room
which is
which requires room number room type
amenities everything apart from
the room number
which will be created for us
and let's go ahead and see
the service
just to see what will be the response
so in create this is just
of course i'm not accessing any database
so
okay i'm returning the room's entire
list of data which is which is added now
so let's see uh so we have this our
post
generally you get the latest record
which is added but it's up to you i mean
it's it's a really bad practice to
return all the data which is added but
this is just an example right so i'm
just going to return all the data which
is available
after adding this record as well
and now let's go back and
this is our ad room function remember we
just wrote this
here
we will call
will recommend this and we will say this
dot
room service dot ad room and we will
pass this room as
uh the data i will comment out room
number uh which is which won't be passed
here
let's see if it gets any uh it gives us
any issue otherwise this should be fine
and this dot room list
we will assign
whatever data we are getting from this
response to room list
right so we uh
let's go ahead and
try to
let me just close other browsers
and
we have our get data right so this is
available get call succeeded and we got
our data from the api we want to just
add functionality so let's
click on add room let's go to network
first because this is where we will be
able to see our request click on add
room
and we got
201 so if you see
we have 201 created it means my api was
successful we also got the latest record
which is added here you can see the id
is alphanumeric because it is generated
using uuid which will be unique id
and its alphanumeric string so
let's see the payload so this is the
payload which is which we have sent to
our api and
of course this is uh this is the
response which we have received and this
is json response in case you want to see
it and you can also see other
information right so your timing and
everything
so
this is it this is how you make a post
call i mean in case you get a single
record of course you have to try it uh
you have to go ahead and see i mean how
to handle that data but right now i'm
returning all the
record including the current record so i
get everything which is available
and i can add more so you can see
right
so you have
those different records with different
id the same record we added with
different id
right now i'm
uh sorry right now we have our hard
footed the data because we don't have
any
form
in future we will replace this with the
form that's what we are going to do
so
let's move on and make our next api call
which is now update
so let's let me just check quickly what
is the update
api looks like
okay so this is my update and it takes
the data and
updates the
data and gives me back okay let's try to
make an update call and here
what we are going to do is of cour again
i am going to hard code some data
just to see how to make this call right
and
this also returns the entire records
remember this this also returns entire
record in reality you are not going to
get this you are not going to return
entire data probably you will get
the id right so this is updated or not
that's it
so let's go ahead and
add a button
and
i'll call this as edit
room
and let's implement this function
okay so edit room function and as we
said we are going to
just use the dummy data here as well so
i'll take it from this
and i'll
say uh room number three
so this data will be updated for room
number three
and we will call it as
edit
room again in future we will have a form
from where we can edit this record so
let's see uh what we have at room number
three which is private suit
and 15 000 so i think we have a
different yeah so we have different
record here so this will be updated with
room number three
let's write the uh method so i'll say
this is a date
room
which will get a room data and will
return
so i'll say this.http.put and
again i'm returning the entire list so
i'm saying okay this is the type of
response and then
i did we'll have the same api and this
is our data
let's go ahead and save this
thank you
so let's see
let's try to make an edit call so we
have
so we have our edit call here so let's
click on edit
edit room and
we don't have any ah okay one second
did we
call this particular api i don't think
so
no we didn't write so we have to save
this dot
s t e d b
room service
dot edit room and then we will subscribe
to the to the data and then we will just
mind it
i'll say this dot room list is equal to
data because we are getting everything
back
let's save this
and
go back to the ui
see the data so we have this one
available click on edit
and okay it gave some error let's see
let's go to the network and uh we have
api rooms
put
404 not found okay okay
let's see for what we have to what we
have for ot here
okay we don't have put okay
but we have
rooms post get patch and delete okay
this is
let's see if we can change get patch
which takes an id and
let's see if we can make it put
and we need to pass an id then let's
run this again
so i'm restarting the server so it
uses put uh
it actually captures the put api as well
but we have
yeah now we have put so it says it is
available on api slash room slash id so
we have to pass the id in the request
itself so let's go ahead and see how we
do that
so we'll go to edit rooms and
this is where we have to pass room slash
id so we'll say okay i am going to use
this this tick operator and
i'll say slash
dollar
and here i'll say room
or dot
room number which is the id for us and
let's go ahead and see let's uh
go to the browser and see the data or
see the request which is being passed
let's click on
let's go to the network we are already
on the network tab let's click on edit
room and we have 200 okay yes we made
our uh put call as well so we have this
payload
and you can see uh the data is updated
as well right so we uh earlier it was
something else now we have same data
which we had sent here available in our
table so
you can see your payload you can see
your request it says localhost
4000 api slash room slash 3.
so this is how you can make a put call
so
ah this is this is uh let's see the
delete next
so i'll say delete and
if you see delete also requires the id
to be passed so i am going to
do is
i'll say just id just type of string
you don't need to send the entire data
to delete so and
delete also does not return anything so
you can see okay
here
right now it returns the id
that's it right so it returns the uh
it returns the data apart from this id
we as we said this is a dummy api so i'm
returning all the data but in reality
you will find that delete will never
return anything that's that's uh that's
true
and let's call
let's see
this is delete room
and here
we will save this dot
delete room dot sorry this dot
your service room service
delete room and i am getting the data
back again as i said i am
giving the entire record and let's try
to
delete this one with room number three
home surface
delete okay
and let's try to assign this data here
so we have let's see api slash room
slash id this is how our request looks
like right now api slash room slash id
we don't have to pass any payload to
delete
go back and uh we need of course and
delete from delete button available to
call the delete so i'll say okay this is
a delete room
and
we will be calling this delete room
function from here
and let's go ahead and see the data
first and let's click on delete room and
done so now we have learned about the
delete function as well right now you
can see it returns something but in
probably in real time your real-time
application it will just give you
information about okay whether it this
data is related or not or in case you
have received some
uh other error right that might that you
might get but delete gen generally just
performs a single operation okay just go
ahead and remove this data and that's it
and
in in case you are also taking care of
your apis make sure you don't delete the
data from database always prefer soft
delete over heart delete so soft delete
it means you
have some flag which we just turn on so
probably you can just have a column
called deleted and just mark it as yes
deleted yes and that's it
so that's it from the crowd operation
you now understand crud operation we
will see
some of the rxjs operators next and
then we will
wrap up the http method by after
completing few more videos like fbp app
initialize
now next what we are going to do is we
are going to explain explore one more
api which is really powerful it gives
you more information about your http
call and it is known as request so
one thing uh before we go ahead and
implement this request api i need an api
which has lot more data
so
what we are going to do is we are going
to use a dummy api which gives us around
more than more than 4000 records
and
json placeholder
is one of the dummy api which is which
exists it's a fake rest api
and it has a method called
photos
which gives us 5000 records which will
be sufficient
which actually suits the purpose for
this particular example
so let's go ahead and do that before
we move into this i'll just make one
more change let me just close all the
files
and in rooms component
i'll just talk change the value of
toggle because right now by default the
rows are written which we don't want to
so let's change height rooms to
[Music]
true and i think it should work
let's uh write this api call as part of
room service itself
and i will we will call it as get photos
this api is known as request so the
first thing which we have to do is we
have to go ahead and create a request
http request so let's go ahead and see
how we do that so i'll create a constant
request
and is equal to we'll say this dot
sorry
monitors dot will say new http request
which
you can see actually comes from
here http request which is coming from
here let me just remove this yeah which
comes from angular slash common slash
scp
and we are going to so let's go ahead
and see the uh payload so we can
actually pass
several methods we have get head boost
sorry get head json b options uh but
remember this doesn't work for post
because post is not here right
and uh we will be calling get method and
this is the api which are which we are
going to call
sorry
let me just check
this in placeholder
and let me just copy the url again
in case you are trying for yourself you
can also refer this json placeholder api
for your your project
so this is the api and now it needs some
we need to pass some configuration here
so let's go ahead and see what are those
configuration so we are going to use
report progress
for this particular example that's
and
now
we are going to pass this http request
to our request method so let's do return
this is not http request and we are
passing this particular request
and we need to create the interface as
well because we need to provide the
typing we will do that but i mean that's
that's for you you can try this out you
can just refer
the metadata or you can refer the
properties from
this particular url just a placeholder
type called typecode.com photos
and it gives you response so you know
what type of response you have and then
you can create your interface based on
it
so you have album id title so all these
parameters
now once this is done let's go ahead and
call this method
inside room component.ds i'm going to
i'm going to call this method on
ngoninit this is just an example right
so in case you need to use this
you can so let's see what are as i said
this is going to give you more
information about your http request so
let's see what those information i'm
talking about
so i'll say this dot
room service
dot get photos
and here i'm going to do subscribe and
let's see
the first uh thing which you should
always do is just check what the data is
or how your data looks like
so let's see uh so
i'm saying console.log data and
go to console
and
this room number component.ts line
number 66
and let's see the response so
remember earlier whenever we
subscribed to our data what we got we
got the data that's it
but here your rooms component is
actually giving you more than this
it is giving you entire http response
which has lot of information which has
body status code status text
but
one more thing
if you notice
your http
call
which you made using http request
and then you subscribe to it it is
actually
printed multiple times so let me just
start from the top right so here we
don't have anything but
we have to see for line number 66
so here so first is here so you can see
it has some information it says http
header response
so it says okay
uh
your
request to the server is sent this is
what we get
this is what information we get here
okay and now this is also 66
and
here it starts loading the data
okay so here you can see at this line
again this is line number 66 so this is
where it actually start loading the data
so it also gives
so it also gives you information
how much data is loaded so you can see
here line number 66 again line number 66
here
same if you see object type 3 and how
many bytes are loaded here again and
then finally
when you get the
data it gives you http response why this
is printed twice because
we are loading it twice right so you can
see here it's the same component a room
component getting called twice so you
can you get same information again and
again let's hide one so i can we can go
to app component dot
html
and
inside this
and we will so we will see get some
sorry we'll get
a small log to work with and yeah so now
at the end we have this http response
what you can achieve using this so let's
say if you have an api which takes some
time to load data and you have a lot of
records to display for example the same
example right we have 5000 records so we
don't want to actually
make made sorry we don't want to you
make user think that this is hand the
application is hanged right now
rather you can display the user that
okay this many devices are downloaded
and you can probably show some loader
right and
based on that
uh your user i mean your
even your application will be
interactive rather actually just being
there and user thinks that okay there is
nothing which is happening
so let's see how we can read this
information
let's go to room component.ts
so this data is actually not the data
it's its event so if you see there are
multiple events which is being called so
i'll call this as
event
and then
here
what we can do is we can subscribe to
multiple
events so i'll say okay
let's use switch
okay looks like some
okay
switch based on the event type
i'll say case uh i'll uh first let's see
http event type which we have to
import
http event type is what is going to give
you those information so whether your
request is sent
i mean in case it's an upload event
if upload is in progress if it is
download
what is the response editor whether our
request is actually sent to the server
or not in case uh there is some problem
communicating with server you will get
an error here
and let's go ahead and do that so first
and we are going to see we are going to
say okay
[Music]
so in case
the request is sent i will say okay
console
dot log request has been made
and of course don't
miss the break
and then case and say this is
http response setter
and say console
and
here we are going to say
request
success
and then
case
this is uh
important so we are saying okay case
http event download progress and here
what you can read is uh let's create a
variable i will say this is so
sorry
total
bytes so this event is actually going to
give us
how many bytes are downloaded so what we
can achieve here is we can say this dot
total bytes
plus is equals to
event
and
if you try to access right now you will
get two properties total and type so
total can be uh
sorry total can be null while you are
downloading the data so what we need is
loaded so we need to show how much data
is loaded and
that's
about this and finally we will handle
the response
and now if i do console.log
and
let's consider console.log
again so if we try to access event dot
you will see you will get uh many
properties and these are the properties
which you generally get from an api
let me show you
here so if you go to network and click
on rooms
click on headers and you have requested
us right so sorry not requested us but
yeah
this one so you see uh you get status
code you
get the data of course which is part of
your your response so you are going to
get more information about what your
response was including the status board
including your body including your
headers status everything
so i'll say let's try to access body
and let's see
and this is your photos but this is not
what we are interested into we are
interested in console.log right now so
let's go ahead and see
so we have of course this is uh
[Music]
this is our data so this is 5000
requires which is available
and
here
we want to
display the total byte so what i'm going
to do is
here i'll say there is
let's play send h1 here sorry
so it is visible
and then and say this is total bytes
loaded
let's see
and you can see uh of course it is my
internet speed is real fast so you can
see two
this many bytes loaded but we can go to
network and
we can move to slow 3g
and let's reload
right so you can see okay it was it was
it started from zero and then it is
loading the data
so
i'll just go to no throttling again and
so it is too fast of course so to
download this many 72 bytes so it didn't
took a lot of time
but yeah this is what you can achieve
using request api it is really powerful
it gives you a lot of information more
information than what your you generally
get from your http kit
uh so try to utilize this as much as
possible we already saw the use case
where you can do that the only thing is
we have to utilize the json placeholder
api because we don't have an existing
api which gives us
those many records
so yeah that's it from the
next we are going to discuss
and see some rxjs operators
as we said in past rxjs is really
powerful and you should learn about rxjs
in more detail
though this is an introduction uh though
this is and not and fully fledged rxjs
course but yes we are trying to cover as
much as possible so you understand the
basics
and we will be covering
rhs
as much as possible which can be used in
your production application
so once you start writing or once you
start working on angular application you
will be able to
use enough
rxjs operators as well as well as enough
rxjs in your application
there are many operators which exist
there are i think around
there are more than 100 operators which
exist
it's not possible to know all of them
and you even don't need all of them to
uh to be frank
you can always refer the rxjs operators
on rxjs.dev which is official website
and in case you are not sure which
operator to use they have one really
nice operator decision tree where you
can
give some information about what you are
trying to achieve and they will
give you an operator which we can use
you can see the documentation for
operators here
as i said there are more than 100 it's
not possible to understand all of them
and probably you won't be using or you
never need more all those hundred
operators you are going to
almost use most of the time around 10
operators which from which we will be
using most of the pitch from which we
will be covering most of them here
the first operator which we are going to
use is share replay
now why we need rxjs operators
remember rxjs gives you a stream of data
and
that stream of data cannot be modified
it can be modified only within
a stream or
before it is subscribed
so how to modify those data so that's
where operators come really handy
so here i'll give you an example
of how we can use share reply operator
and then we will also see some examples
of operator where you can modify the
data while the stream
within the stream and then give it back
so
to see this example what i'm going to do
is i have i'm going to make two changes
here i'm going to uncomment this again
so we get the request twice
i have made one more change in
container component remember we had
this host
uh decorator here on
the service and this providers have
commented this and i have removed this
as well just to make sure that you are
following the same because if i don't
remove it i mean we are going to end up
with multiple instances of a service and
of course it will make two different
calls
so let's go ahead and talk about this
share replace service
so here you can see rooms is being
called twice photos is again being
called twice
it's the same data right so why we need
to make two calls
what we can do what we can do better
here probably we can catch whenever
first make call is made and then we
don't have to make another call right
that's that's looks like a perfect
solution yes that's what share replay
does share replay can help you to cash
the request so you don't have to make
your call again
it's very useful in case you have some
master data which uh you don't need to
download again and again right whenever
you are visit your user visits the page
and in case you are making the same call
at multiple places which is possible
it's not something which uh you which
you should avoid it is something which
you should avoid but it's it's possible
that it may happen that you are calling
the same api again and again to get some
data
so let's see how we can use our sorry
rxjs share replay operator to cache this
request and
make our application little bit faster
so i'm going to make some changes into
room service i am going to use a
different approach generally i prefer
this in case i don't have any uh i don't
need a function so
i'm going to use get rooms but
i'm going to use a dollar i'll talk
about what this room installer does
and then
i'll call this get rooms api
and
remember as i said we cannot go ahead
and modify the stream
after we subscribe to it a stream can be
modified inside a function that function
is known as pipe
so
this pipe is where you can do anything
with your data and right now we are
going to call a share replay operator
with share replay 1
so we are going to repeat or replay the
last one record which we have received
and this is done this is uh the method
now let me talk about this get room
installer what we are doing this is a
property so we are saying this is a
property and this dollar is to denote
that this is a stream
so generally whenever you work with
streams try to use this approach try to
uh
use this syntax and so you don't need
ngo in it or you don't have to call
anything inside engineering we'll see an
example where we can actually avoid
subscription as well so once you get
comfortable with this it will be easy to
understand that code as well
so here we have a property get rooms and
then we are saying okay this is
a stream which we get here
and so far nothing has changed we still
getting to record to request right so
rims rooms
now let's go to rooms component.ds here
and rather than getting to get rooms we
are going to access get rooms
property and let's go ahead and see
that we are now getting rooms request
only once but of course we have the data
available multiple times because we are
caching the first request so we don't
have to go ahead and make another call
this is something which is really
important to understand because of
course you may have an application where
multiple calls are being made
unnecessarily
with even though the data never changes
you share play and then you are done
in this video we are going to discuss
about one pipe which we had left while
talking about built-in pipes remember we
said we are going to use a sink pipe
while working with http and that's what
we are going to explore here that's why
we are back on this particular topic
we are going to see how we can utilize a
sink pipe and what's the purpose of
using a sink pipe so this is going to be
little bit
longer theories plus
examples
so let's go back to our port
so here right now the code which we have
written
you you can see everywhere we are doing
dot subscribe
dot subscribe right so we are
subscribing uh our
uh
stream everywhere
now there is a downside to this
there is a downside yes
to subscribe the streams
try to relate this streams uh streams to
your streaming services
when you subscribe to let's say netflix
or amazon prime
once you subscribe let's say you
subscribe to netflix and you wanted to
actually cancel that subscription next
month and you forget you actually forgot
to cancel your subscription what happens
you pay the price
same thing is applicable here
but here what is the price we are paying
the price is actually performs
so whenever you subscribe to a stream
the streams are active
the standard way is whenever you
subscribe to stream you should
unsubscribe to it
how we can unsubscribe to it
remember we discussed about ngo and
destroy
and we said engine destroy is an event
where we can go ahead and
uh re uh i mean release the resources we
can actually
unsubs uh we can release anything which
we have
in memory so this is where we can
unsubscribe to it
but
most of the places we don't need to
subscribe manually it's not impossible i
mean it's not even
totally impossible to remove all the
subscribe methods it's not
but yes
there are places there are things uh
there are like operators by using which
you can you can do that
and especially in case you want to just
read the data
you can go ahead and avoid the streams
uh sorry you can go ahead and avoid the
subscription manual subscription
for example of course this one
or
we had the photos one as well right so i
mean of course we are
here we are trying diving deep that okay
we want to handle this even this even
this event but yeah uh even
in this case right so we can just avoid
the subscription because we just wanted
to access the data
so async pipe
makes a spot makes it possible to
manage the subscription for us
what in case i have to do it myself
so this is how the code will look like
and you will see this code in a lot of
places in your application or maybe if
you get hired to work on any application
probably the chances are that you will
see this code
generally we get
and
subscription object
which is type of subscription
which comes from rxjs so you can see
okay i'll just do this one
right so subscription which is come
which comes from rxjs you can see this
and
we will ask
this we will use this variable to hold
the subscription for us
and
then
i'll use ng on destroy
and
you will find that some code which looks
like this so if
this dot subscription it means there are
some there are any active subscription
go ahead and unsubscribe to it so this
is the code which you can find at many
places and this is the way you can
actually
uh unsubscribe to an active subscription
as well why ng on destroy we are saying
whenever this component gets destroyed
just go ahead and destroy the
subscription also because we don't need
it we don't need to it to be available
in the memory
and
in case i want to avoid this
which i said totally i mean uh there is
a service i'll share the code there is
an actually
[Music]
there is a service which you can use at
all the places
to actually achieve this uh or write
this write your code in a simpler way
but yeah i mean i'll share that in
future because that that service you can
utilize in your real-time application
here but right now let's say i don't
want to actually
subscribe it manually here
how we can do that
so i will remove this and
let's use this stream so i'm going to
comment this line because
i'll keep it here but i'll just comment
this
now remember the earlier code which we
wrote for sherry play i am going to use
the same approach here so i'm going to
say this is uh what this is rooms
i'm going to say this is the room stream
and this is equals to this method so i'm
going to say okay this is room stream
and actually this data is coming from
your no subscribe method
let's see
once this is done
of course let's go back to
the ui and we will see okay there is no
data which is available inside my table
let's go to component and let's try to
read what is available here how we can
do that
so we can
use
i'll just remove some
headers here
and
whenever we have a stream we have to use
the async pipe and then i'm using json
to display that data so think like what
it will do is it will unwrap that object
and it will give you the data so
remember earlier
previously what we used to do is we used
to subscribe
to get that data out and then read the
data here
what is happening is we are passing the
entire stream to a sync pipe which will
unwrap which will unwrap means it will
unsubscribe to that particular data and
give the data back to us
once your ng on destroy is called
passing pipe will also take care
of unsubscribing to that object so you
don't have to write go ahead and write
this code where you say okay this is
equals to this subscription is equal to
this and then unsubscribe in ngon and
destroy so you don't have to write this
code by yourself
now let's go ahead and see how we can
use it so i'll just copy this i'll
comment now we know how my data looks
like
and here
we are passing this uh rooms data
let's see
where is my where where is the table
and i had her
here
now i can say uh this room stream
pipe
a sink here
is it room or rooms
[Music]
and we will also say ngif
rooms type busing so in case some rooms
is available go ahead and display this
and it says a room list of okay so rooms
can also uh
sorry
this is a sync pipe uh can also return
null so that's what it is us telling us
right now that okay if it is null i mean
i'm not able to assign this to an array
or null
the the thing which we can do is we can
say okay this is type of
not here
this is type of this or none
and this error will be gone
so now we have uh we are checking if
rooms data exist then only use
but there is a downside to it so i'll
show you i'll talk about that as well
but right now we have our data which is
absolutely fine right we are getting the
data but here right now uh we are
checking this in rooms async
and here also we are doing the same
the downside of doing such or writing
this code is we have to i mean your sync
pipe has to subscribe it multiple times
can we do it at once yes that's possible
you can do something like this so you
can say rooms are sync as
room and then you can just pass uh
let's do it
make it rooms
and we can pass it here
well even so we have to subscribe only
once let's go ahead and verify our ui
and it works no error and everything is
as
i mean looks the same as it was earlier
so
try to avoid multiple async pipe on the
same
stream rather do this so you can rather
than actually
doing multiple passing pipes you can
just say okay as this and then you can
just use that data unwrapped data down
below
so this is how a sync pipe works
why we discuss about it because uh the
next operator which we are going to use
depends upon sync pipe so let's go ahead
and see that
now back to our rxjs operators and right
now we are going to talk about the
another object called catch error
and that's why we learned about trussing
pipe so let's see how we can actually
handle the errors
in our code base
so so far we have written the code all
the happy flow no exception that's fine
right i mean most of the time you will
get the ap flow but we have to handle
the exceptions as well
so here let's try to introduce an error
how we can do that
i can just change the api right so i can
say api slash room and
let's see and we have
okay somehow application still works but
get room okay sorry
here
we are not using the get rooms now so we
will get 404
we generated an error now how to handle
these exceptions
right now we are saying okay we have a
stream and whenever like that stream
gives you the data just go ahead and
display them let's see an example where
we can also handle the exception
so
you can handle the exception inside
service as well as in your
component
the best
thing would be to use something like
ngrx which is like advanced topic which
is not part of this but yeah let me show
you how we can handle exception here
so this stream as i said we cannot
modify the stream after we subscribe to
it but we can modify it by using pipe so
we will apply the pipe and here i am
going to say catch error this is the
ngrs function which we have
and
we will handle the exception here but it
says okay there is some problem so it
says error it declared but right now we
are not using its value
let's try to use the value and to do
that
what we will do is we will say right now
let's
do console.log
and we'll say error
and it says array of void
ah okay so it accepts room list
parameter right so we can say okay do
this
capture the earth and
written
off
this i'll explain what we are doing here
let's
format
and we have an extra error
okay so we are handling uh we are we are
saying okay this is uh log the error and
then just return the empty array
so
let's go ahead and see
okay so nothing here let's see the
console
and we have the uh error
which is http line number let's see line
number 68 yeah so line number 68 we have
error http error response and it says
okay this is the message
right so this is the actual message
which we have now what we need is we
let's say we want to display this
particular message you want to show okay
this this is the actual error which we
have received
how we can do that
i'm going to use another
type which is available in alexis which
is both observable and observer so i am
going to create an error stream
and i am going to say this is a
type of subject
and it is
sorry
just type of subject and which is type
of string
uh sorry
and as this is not initialized i'm going
to say okay this is
uh
application operator which will avoid
that particular error
now let's see what is this particular
subject is as you can see it is coming
from
rxjs of course and it is subject is
actually base class for all the uh
different uh
uh streams which you get so it's a uh
like
uh what you can say it's a base class
right for all the type of streams which
you get this is the best base class so
you can actually create a subject and
then uh there are different types of
subjective which also exists internally
angular also uses subject at a lot of
places
so here uh what we have done is we have
created uh this subject and now
here what i'm going to do is i'm going
to say okay this dot
error
dot i'm going to call a method called
next remember we said whenever we we saw
an example of observer we said there are
three methods which exist next complete
and error so we are going to say next
error
and
whenever we get the
new error value
we are going to subscribe to this
so we are going to say
here
this dot
we don't have to
let's see
let's
do this dot
error
stream dot as observable
so this
is my subject
this get error or
let's make it i'll keep it get error as
of now i'm saying
i'm going to subscribe to this so this
is this active stream whenever there is
an if there is an error which is erased
i'm going to push this error you
generally should not write this code
inside your
component because there is a drawback
whenever next
gets called you uh your change detection
is going to run again so that's a
drawback but
of course you should learn about this
how to do exception handling as well you
can move this to your service you can
move it to another common place wherever
you want to
but yeah
now we have this error which is
available and now let's go ahead and see
so i'm going to save this
and
going to subscribe to this error
just above this and
uh here i'll say h1
and get error pipe
sync
and what i'm going to do is i'm just
going to take message out of it right so
we don't need to display the entire
error
so
let's see how the ui looks like
and okay there is some error cannot read
properties of undefined okay probably
i'm missing something let's see
okay
new subject
this is how it should be actually we
have to create a new subject of type
string and this should fix the
issue now we have
of course everything is working fine
looks like everything is working fine
but you can see you have error code
available here so it says your error
message has to be failure response for
this blah blah blah which is available
now
so what we are doing is whenever there
is an exception
now we are handling that error we are
handling that error and then we are
subscribing to that error as well we are
saying okay in case we get the data
that's absolutely fine but in case i get
the error just go ahead and display the
error as well you can customize this
error based on
your
requirement now let's go ahead and fix
the url
and our
data will be back now we don't have any
error so nothing no error will be
subscribed to right so this is how you
can use catch error
and yes just make sure that okay you are
not doing not writing this code in your
component this is just an example you
can do it inside service we will see an
example of
where we do the
component interaction using service
where we are going to see different
types of subjects which exist
and probably we will move this code
outside so this is it from
[Music]
so far we have seen two operators share
replay and catcher and we also saw an
example how you can use a sink pipe
which is really great you should focus
more on using a sync pipe as as much as
possible
let's now see an example of map operator
we are going to see some uh
other map operator as well because there
are there are few different like uh you
will find there is switch map merge map
and uh
there are a few operators like that so
but here we are going to just talk about
map operator so let's go and see how we
can actually use map operator to work
with our stream
and
modify it
and by the way this is the first
operator which we are going to use which
can modify which will modify the data
right
this is the first operator which we are
going to use which will modify the data
so far we have seen cache error which
was able to cache the error and we saw
we saw share replay which was able to
cache the data right so let's see uh how
we can modify the stream by using
shareplay now sorry by using
uh how we can modify the stream by using
map operator
and to do that what i'm going to do is
i'm going to
subscribe to the same streams
okay and i
call this as
account
and i'm saying this is a stream and here
i am going to
subscribe so i'll say this dot
room
sorry
room service
dot
get rooms so this is our stream
and then we can use pipe
and now in map using map operator so we
just use map
and okay this is coming from rickshaws
we'll say rooms and we will take the
number of rooms which is available
inside this
and now if you see this type the
important thing is see the types
here it is array of rooms and here it is
count
which means number of rooms which are
available inside this particular area so
we are actually modifying the stream and
we are just returning the number of
records or you can see rooms.length
which is number of records number of
rooms which is available in this
particular stream
but
we are not subscribing it manually we
are still
in the stream we modified the stream and
said okay it was like room of numbers
which was coming inside the pipe and
then we took only the count as and we
gave that count as a stream
so here now i can just go ahead and use
this
in our template
and let's put it here
and let's uh okay there's one thing
let's put it in it in h1
and we'll see number of rooms
is
sync
and let's save this as well because
otherwise uh this variable won't be
identified because the file is not saved
let's see if it is
compiled
yes it is compiled
let's go to the browser and you can see
it says number of rooms three so this is
how you can utilize map operator and
uh
without subscribing to the stream you
can just get the data whatever you need
from the existing stream
so this is
uh the map operator and now we will move
on to the next topic
in this video we are going to talk about
several things first we will see
how we can add the extra headers to our
http request
and then we will see how we can actually
intercept those requests that's where
the concept of http interceptor will
come and then at the end
we will see app initializer
so first let's go ahead and talk about
modifying the header information
so
we are back to our code base
in
your enterprise application there might
be scenarios where you may need to pass
some extra information in the header
whichever we are talking about http
request header
so we will first learn how to do that
so
let's uh go to our
service
and let's try to add some extra headers
to
our
this calls right so we have get call we
have post call how we can pass that so
if you see the signature
of every http request which we have i
mean get both put everything you will
find that there is something called http
headers which we can pass
which takes a key value pair
similarly you will find it for post as
well
and post delete everything
so let's see uh how we can create an
http editor and then we will try to pass
it so first let's create the header i'll
call it as
header and it will be new
http
headers
right so uh as we know it takes key and
valid
so a few combinators which we see
content type
you have let's say forms data no that's
not a header
or you can pass token right so token is
a common use case here we are going to
pass let's say
um
token for example
and
it will take
this is the value so alpha numeric let's
say our token is some alphanumeric
random value and then here i can just
say pass
this headers
to okay
so we now let's
verify inside our browser that if if
that particular
header which we have sent is received or
not
let's go back to our network tab
and let's reload this
uh it's compiled and this is the request
which we are planning to see which we uh
in which we have added that particular
header information which is named as
token
let's see so this is responsive this is
not what we are looking at we are
looking at request header
and let's see if we have
okay there is one thing
uh there's a one mistake which i made
if you i mean we are not calling this
method anymore so if i have to do this i
have to actually
pass this letter information here right
in inside this call
so
i'll do one thing i'll create
and cut this
and
paste it here and then we'll pass this
header information
into this
with the start headers and
let's remove it
and let's remove this as well
okay so this is the http method which we
are calling let's go ahead and verify
our build which is comp which is
compiled application is compiled now
let's go back to our code base and let's
try to see request header now
so we have this token which is available
now this token can be received from at
your api so in case let's say you are
working together with some back-end
developer he says listen uh for this
particular api call i am going to
need some token this is the token which
you have to pass with every request so
this is this is how you are going to do
it so you will
let's go back to the code and then let's
talk about it so this is how you will
create a new header and then you will
pass that header into your request so
this dot headers which you have passed
here
and you can of course pass multiple
and let's see
[Music]
so you can call append method and then
you can add multiple so that's how you
can do it you can also see
there is a method to get the headers you
have has has to actually see if this
particular
header exists or not so
you can just copy the same header let's
say let's try to add a room and see if
it works
and we have this information passed or
not so we can pass headers and we will
pass this rotators in add info in add
api as well
let's go back to the code and let's add
a room
and this is our rooms api and we will be
able to see
token here as well
right so this is how you will be adding
header information now once we know this
how to add header information let's talk
about another use case so let's say you
get a token and
now the requirement is you have to
actually go ahead and add this token f
to every request
do you think the what i'm doing is
correct or is the most in efficient way
of course the answer is no right i mean
what i'm doing is i'm duplicating the
code which is of course i shouldn't be
doing that so what we can do so this is
where the concept of http interceptors
come in
http interceptors is not only made for
this but there are bigger use case for
http interceptors
http interceptors i mean you may have
actually heard about interceptors let's
come back and talk about interceptors
first before we talk about http
interceptors what do you mean by
interceptor
you might have seen some movies right
where
some someone says okay your call is
being intercepted what you mean by that
so actually there is
sender and receiver so client is my
receiver and server is my center right
uh
if you see i mean your server is
responding to uh each and every request
and your
your client is also making a request to
so it goes from
your client to server and server to
client
now there is someone in between who is
listening to what is happening what what
data is going what data is coming
that is interceptor so
similar way http interceptor is an a
service which will sit between your http
call which is being made from your
client which is your browser to the
server and
in case also your server responds it can
also listen to your request that's http
interceptor here
what can be the use case i mean there
are a lot of things which you can see do
using http interceptor one is of course
you can add this combinators inside
interceptor so you don't have to add it
everywhere
what what else what other use cases can
be in case you want to let's say add
date timestamp to each and every request
yeah that's you can do that uh you can
do using http interceptor what else
let's say you want to uh handle the
scenario where your token is expired yes
and should be interceptor is the way to
go
and you can add multiple http
interceptor it's not like you can only
add one http interceptor the only thing
is it will be called in the sequence
they are registered so let's go ahead
and create our first http interceptor
to see how it works
and to do that i'm going to use a
command so
of course n g g
interceptor
and i'm going to call it as let's say
request
request interceptor so
and we have this
this two classes created and you have
this
request interceptor which is which
implements http interceptor that's why
it is called http interceptor
remember
http interceptor can modify your request
as well as it can modify your responses
as well in case you want to
now
http interceptor has
has actually an function which we need
to implement which is called intercept
and this is really important next dot
handle
this line actually sends the request to
your server if you don't re if you don't
call this method
nothing will happen so
let's try to first
do one thing
i'll just do console.log
and we will just log our request
right so
request interceptor and then we'll pass
the request with us
once you are done with this i mean uh
right now this interceptor will not do
anything because it is not registered
let's go ahead and register the
interceptor so
we will do it here
and
this is the this is how you are going to
register it so you will say provide
so we are going to say provide on
this
those
value which will be http interceptors
so uh let me talk about this uh in in a
little bit uh
[Music]
we'll talk about this what we are doing
here so we are saying provide use value
this and then we will say multi true
and let's go ahead and verify first so
our build is successful
let's go back to our application
and console because we want to change
see the request and
request success
request has been made and
let's see there is anything from
interceptor okay somehow it is not
provide request interceptor which is our
class
please value this multi true
okay let's see our amp is getting
updated
the build was successful and nothing
changed okay
somehow it says nothing changed
okay
let's see
[Music]
room service has been initialized
okay let's
not use
customs value i think
just
done the opposite of it so
you have we have to provide http
interceptor as a service and then we
have to say use
class which is our request interceptor
so
i just use the values somehow
and let's talk about this and let's
verify again in case
it is working fine or not and we will be
we should be able to see now
first
here it is so you can see request
interceptor line number 16 and it has
everything so right now aps rooms is
called
and
we have
context body header and there should be
one for uh
photos
and there should be one for
where is
the rooms api
ah this is the rooms one right so you
have rooms one and as well as the photos
so both the requests are captured here
in case we want to add room you will see
uh when
the request is handled here so you can
see body context headers and in headers
you will be able to see the token
because right now we have one uh header
which is added here
so this is this these are the
information i mean this uh this gives
you complete http information i mean
which is being sent from your client
machine to your server server machine
now let's come back to this and talk
about this provide and use class
so here
this http interceptor is nothing but a
token so remember we created an
injection domain and this http
interceptor also is also the same so
here what we are saying is we are saying
i have created a new http interceptor by
implementing the interface http
interceptor
go ahead and add this http interceptor
into list of interceptors which already
exist and you might be wondering which
interceptor exists
yes so angular internally adds a lot of
interceptors the reason being if you see
this information right now are we
preparing this information no we are not
this is something which angular is doing
by itself
so
of course it has some list of
interceptors which is internally
implemented and then we are adding our
own so it will be executed in sequence
so once every interceptor is executed
then this will be executed
if we add one more after this
in that case first this request
interceptor will be executed and after
that the next interceptor will be
executed it will always be sequential
remember that in case you uh
end up adding multiple interceptors so
remember the sequence
now here we have the information uh
which is uh needed and now we understand
what http interceptor does for us now
let's go ahead and
utilize that right so here what we are
going to do is let's uh first
add the header information right so
right now we have added the header
information inside the service we cannot
do it for
each and every uh api call
so let's remove it from here so i'll
just
comment this out
remove this
from here
similarly i'll remove from add
and let's come here
so first thing you cannot directly
modify the request you cannot modify the
original request so let me just refresh
it because it may cause confusion so you
cannot
modify the original request
you can clone it and then modify so i'll
say okay this is new request fonts
new
request
is equals to
i'll say request.clone
and here
i can pass headers which will be
i'll say new
http
headers and now let's copy the key and
value from here so i'll say this is
token
and this is the value
and
the one thing which we have to do is now
we have to pass this request not the
original request remember that
uh so it happens a lot of times that i
end up just passing the same request and
then i see okay why the modified values
are not there so it's absolutely fine um
everyone makes that mistake so
[Music]
and let's format
using prettier and now let's verify the
application again
so we have uh
network tab let's go to photos and it
photos should also have this token so
you can see the token is available here
did we add it to photos no we did not
who is adding it the interceptor is
adding it similarly in
the rooms
you will find the token available here
you will
just let's add a room
and we will find that okay it is also
added here you have inside room
uh we call delete room and inside delete
room also you will notice that token is
available so now with each and every
request the token will be appended
or added to the request
you can do
of course more thing for example let's
say if you want to handles or you want
to create some use cases when you forget
request not for course request you can
do that because
this request information
you can see uh it has a lot of
information so you can say request dot
method
and let's uh do it for post one d right
we will add this information header
information only for post
so i'm going to do this i'm going to say
okay if requestism dot method is post go
ahead and add this
token and make a request otherwise
make the original request
let's format and
right so let's verify
now our get request should not have this
in this token let's go to photos and
no we don't have it
for
rooms
we don't have it let's
execute a post request by adding rooms
and now
we have it
so this is this is uh these are the
things which you can achieve using
http interceptor right now we are only
handling the request remember this you
can see i'm not handling the response
i'll show you one use case uh
in while working with probably routing
and forms how you can also handle the
response so
yeah that's it uh from the http
interceptor now next thing which we are
going to talk about is we will see app
initializer so
let's do that next
next we are
next we are going to do last topic from
stdp intercept uh sorry from http
and we are going to discuss about test
initializers now
what and where you are going to use it
so this is little bit advanced topic as
i am trying to cover everything which
you can
sorry i'm trying to
cap
sorry i'm trying to cover everything
which you can utilize in your production
application so you should not get any uh
certain things okay uh this is something
which i'm not aware of so this app
initializer is something which is really
useful it's kind of again a service
which will help you to
load the data before your app gets
initialized and now you might be
wondering what is the use case when i
need the data before application is list
for example let's say you have some
configuration
you need to load that configuration
before your app is initialized and then
you need to save that data into your
service and then use it how you are
going to do it
i'm talking about before your
application is sliced i mean before you
get your first page
this is where app initializer can help
you app initializer can
plug in your service and it will call
that particular service before your app
is initialized and you can do anything
where uh whatever you want into that
service you can make an http call get
the data from your any api or you can
just load a config file from your local
uh disk right i mean for example if you
have
saved some file in your assets and you
want to
based on your configuration you want to
load that asset file or config file
that's possible so let's take an example
where we will be using a config file
and we will load that config file and we
will
make that data available before our app
is initialized
to do
that first what i'm going to do is i'm
going to create a service
so i'm going to say nggs and i'm going
to call it as a init service initializer
and i'll add some code here
and we'll talk about it
so i'm going to make an http call
and
we'll create a property which is type of
readme
and let's add
this tab update
so what we are going to do is we are
going to load this config.json file
which we don't have right now
let's create in assets
config.json and
let's add some properties so let's see a
version
[Music]
and
some some normal properties right so
let's say it has to these two properties
as well
now this service needs to be called
before my application is like so i can
make the http call get the data and do
whatever i want to i mean i can just go
ahead and use this service anywhere and
the data will be available
now let's see how to use it so that's a
little bit change in this index so we
are going to create a function
we will call it as init
factory
and we'll pass our service here so we'll
say okay this is
init
service
which is type of innate service which we
have
and then we are going to say return a
function
this is really important part so we are
going to return a function which says we
need service dot init method which is
the method which we have here so this
method will get make an api call or
should we call float the json file and
add save this into this particular
property
now once this is done we have to
register it to register we are going to
say
provide app initializer because that's
the service where we want to actually
plug in this particular method then we
can say use
factory as we have factory available and
then we have to provide dependency
dependency will be
the number of the services which you
provide here it's possible that you can
call multiple that's possible yes
and
you have to say multi-truth because app
initializer is again an object where we
are going to add a service
now this is done let's go ahead and
verify if
this works or not and how we can verify
i'm just going to the network tab and
config.json is loaded yes that's loaded
let's try to read the property
now to leave to see if this property is
available or not we can inject the
service in here
so let's say this is private
and restart i just
will just do console.login
server start
config
and let's verify it
and we have
this data available app component or tsl
number 24 and this is available and this
is loaded even before your app is
initialized so yep this is how you can
do it uh common use cases maybe let's
say you have a config.json file where
you have
environment apis based on your
environment and you want to load that
and then make api calls
yes that's that's how you can do it
so this is the last topic from http and
now we will continue with router
so far we have learned about
the basics of angular
and
one thing you may notice is we don't
have so much of ui right now available
we said we are going to use we are going
to create a project based on hotel
inventory but we just have like a table
and we saw some functionality where we
can add details
and
that's it right we can edit but we don't
have forms and even we don't have urls
where we can click and move to different
views
so this is what we are going to start
right now we are going to start with
angular router
so in this video we will talk about the
introduction of course and then we will
see we'll see how to set up router we
will also see some services which is
provided by router itself so we have
activated route router service we'll
talk about future module and we'll
we'll see how we can do feature module
routing as well we'll talk about nested
route child routes lazy loading route
cards we'll also see uh if you remember
in last
session uh we in last video uh we didn't
covered how you can communicate between
mult between multiple components using
services so that's
uh what will be covered in this uh
this part as well we'll see how we can
do that and we'll also see angular
material so
let's go ahead and get started
so let's see what angular router is so
it's provide it provides the
functionality to add routes i mean what
is the routes right so first we have to
actually go ahead and understand what
the route is so let me show you a page
and i'll go to angular.time so
the
documentation right so here you can
click on features you can click on
routes these are different sorry you can
click on features you can click on docs
you can click on resources so these are
different routes which are available on
this page so
using angular router we will be able to
configure all this on the front end
itself so we don't have to do this on
backend it provides this spf
functionality single page application so
if you see
we are still on the same page
right if you click on blog it redirects
to another page so this is different but
this is single page application so where
you can click on any let's say we can
click on docs click on any of the urls
overview you can see your url is getting
changed but there is no
uh request to the server
so everything is happening on your front
end which is which means it's a single
page application where everything is
known to your application in advance so
it doesn't need to
take any data from the backend
apart from the http calls which we'll be
making
we can also configure nested routes so
what is the nested route so you can see
if i click here you can see guide is the
main route and then in
guides we have different i mean this is
not uh this is not the uh
uh child yeah so you can see kite is the
parent route and then you have different
child routes available inside this
so
if i go to get started you will find
okay what is uh angular
the developer guides but yeah i mean
everything is getting loaded inside the
same route so we'll see how we can also
configure something like this where
we can replace some part of you so
that's will that will be covered as well
so let's go ahead and see how we can set
up router so
let's go back
to the code
so this is our code and we don't have
any uh router routing functionality as
of now and let's go ahead and add that
so we'll be adding it inside app module
let's see what needs to be done
let's go
back to the slides
so what we have to do is we have to
first go ahead and import router module
so router module is uh the module which
will provide us all the functionality
required for
or required to use the routing
functionality which angular has
so let's add
so i will not do it here so
we already have something called app
routing module remember when we created
this application there was a question
using ngnu so there was a question do
you want to configure routing module and
we said yes
so that's the purpose so we can keep our
code
in different modules
so here this app routing module is
to configure any routes which we want to
configure so we already have this so you
can see we already have router module
imported and then we have exported it so
my app component sorry app module knows
about this so you can see app routing
module is already added here so the step
is automated now
then we have for root module so let's
see forward function
so here it is for root
so you will be configuring for root 21
remember this you should not
configure for route multiple times
singleton service so in case you do it
will probably override the previous
routes which you have added so this is
taken care for which is all also
available and then we will talk about
default route dynamic route and wildcard
route so let's go ahead and see first
how we can configure the routes so
what we are going to do is we are going
to create multiple urls as we saw on
angular.io where you can click on guide
we can click on talks we can click on
features and it moves to different uis
so let's see how many
components which we have right now
so we have this uh employee rooms and
containers let's say we have three these
three so let's see how we can configure
a route so to configure a route
you have to pass two things so first is
you have to provide a path
so we will say okay this is path
and uh
you can give any friendly url name you
want to for example if i want employees
component to be
rendered
when i click on a url called slash
employee localized 3000 sorry localized
four two double zero slash employee
i can do something like this so i can
say employee
and when i click this just go ahead and
give me employee component
so first is configured
we will similarly do it for others so
let's say path
and we'll see rooms
and
when i do this i want this rooms
component
to be rendered
and the last one sorry
is i want
this
to be
let's call it as
container as of now
and when i do this i want component
but once again
okay container component will not render
anything by default so i'll just remove
it i'll keep this
so we have two routes available right
now so employee and rooms
and
let's try to see if our application
works
and let's say
rooms
i entered the incorrect early
and it doesn't right it be it goes back
to whatever we we had so let's see
so there should be an error let's see uh
so
okay right now okay that error is
because okay this route is
okay
so when we are clicking on slash room so
you can see okay there uh in ui you can
see the url but nothing happens right i
mean
so it should only display the content
related to rooms or when i say
slash employee only it should only
display the content related to employee
because we are
missing one important thing
when we configure routing we have to
place so i'll just remove this i mean
i'll just comment all this out here
and container let's remove this
let's remove this and let's remove this
as well
so here we have to place something known
as a router outlet i'll come back and
we'll talk about this what this router
outlet is
and let's see so we have in uh so slash
employee and it says employee works and
then there is john because this is what
it is available on
employee component that's it let's try
with rooms
and you should be able to see all the
details related to rooms it works i mean
sorry
so it works i mean so we have
rooms related data when we click on
rooms we have employee related view or
we can say employ related data when we
click on employee so we have configured
a route
but do you think this is usable the
answer is no of course right i mean
generally we don't do that we don't ask
users to go ahead and click on this url
so you will go to good rooms or click on
this url so you will go to employees we
don't do that we generally have a nice
navigation available
or
whenever you do localhost four to double
zero let's see this
so four to double zero and nothing
happens there is nothing available on my
route
so generally what we do is for this
we
set up a default url so what we will do
is let's set up a default url then we
will see how we can work on the
anchorings or the urls and then we will
add an angular material
so let's go back to the code and let's
do first thing first
we will add the default url so what i
want is
or as a user as a developer what i want
is i mean whenever a user comes on to my
page let's say he and uh mentors ww2 dot
abc.com or right now local is for zero
the user should be redirected to rooms
so how we can do that so we can say path
and redirect to
slash rooms and path match full so it
will match the entire path that's that's
what this path match full means uh you
can also provide rejects expression in
case you need to most of the application
don't need that so don't over complicate
things so here we are saying okay
whenever i come whenever a user comes on
my web page
and there is nothing after that slash
four double zero
so the path is empty
redirect to the rooms which is already
configured
and
make sure that you are matching full
path
so let's see and now we are redirected
to rooms let's go ahead and verify it
again
photo zero and we are redirected to
rooms so this is how the default url
works
now let's see how we can actually
add some navigation so first what we
will do is we will add some anchor links
and then we will see how we can
ease this process by using angular
material or any other ul library of your
choice
so i'll add enter
now you may have used href
don't use href here so let me show you
what happens in case we use href
uh so of course we can do h reference
equals to rooms
and
i can see rooms
and similarly
i can say employee
so there's two anglings which are
available
and let's see let's click on employee
hey it works
let's click on rooms then why i'm saying
not to use hf
do you saw any uh odd behavior as we
discussed about
click on employee and you can see the
entire page is getting reloaded this is
not an sp this is multi-page application
which this is something which happens in
mpa multiple multiplayer applications
so to avoid this what you should be
doing is rather than using href angular
provides a property so you can say
router link
is equals to
and let's see
click on employee and it works click on
rooms it works but did you saw there is
no page reload so it means page is not
getting reloaded it's a single page
application on the same page the views
are being changed now coming back to our
this
router outlet
we need to discuss it otherwise how you
will understand that how this works
so whenever you click on any url what in
what happens in case i just keep this
router link and remove this outlet
let's see
and nothing is getting loaded
so there is no
error you can see cannot read out this
is something which is related to earlier
view but there is nothing which is
getting rendered click on rooms click on
employee url changes but there is
nothing to render so let's add back this
router outlet and we'll talk about it
so whenever uh there
is
any
uh url or you have some provided some
route which is configured
the thing is angular looks for
let's go back to this
so angular looks for this router outlet
on your view
if this router outlet is available
whatever component which you have
configured here so let's go back to the
configuration again so here you have
added some configuration right so load
this component load this component so
angular will
add this component just after this
router outlet remember this so you have
rooms added just after this router
outlet in case this router outlet does
not exist angle
i mean won't be able to add this because
there is no router outlet so same in
case i click employee it will just
remove the existing component and add
this employee component this is how
this works this router router
functionality works so make sure i mean
when you start
you it will happen that you will miss
router outlet a lot even it happened
with me and i still do that i mean
whenever i'm doing a live coding i miss
it generally i mean
not generally but occasionally not it
doesn't happen a lot but yes it it
happens so in case your router is not
working route functionality is not
working just check if you have router
outlet available or not and that's it it
will be taken care of
now
now what we have done we have added the
routing functionality we have
added the routes we have added anglings
to shuffle between it we have added the
default route we have uh even
yeah that's it so now what we will do is
now
of course this url this navigation
doesn't look nice right i mean
uh of course i'm not going to use this
application if i have to i mean how this
ui looks like so what we can do is let's
go ahead and add material next
now in this video we will be adding
angular material to our application and
we will also add a navigation nice
navigation using angular material itself
so the page is material.angular.type
this is the webpage
where you can read uh everything about
angular material so it's a
ui component ui component library
similar to remember we try to add
angular booster so this is some similar
but it uses the material css so material
or you you can say it uses material
design so material design is of course
something which is uh created and
maintained by google itself so they have
created a component library on top of it
you can see it has a lot of components
you can go to components it provides cdk
as well in case you want to build your
own components
uh which angular already has and it has
a guide
so
let's go ahead and add this
the first thing which i'm going to do is
i'm going to stop the server because it
will add some configurations to
angular.json
and have to anyways restart it
so
let's go ahead and
get started
so it says uh there are some
guide for angular and then there are
some steps which we have to do so the
easiest thing to ins or easiest way to
install angular material is just to run
this command
so let's do that
ng add angular material
so it says the angular material 13.1.1
will be installed i would say yes
because that's what i'm looking at i'm
using angular 13.
and it will ask you to choose themes so
the themes are same which is available
here so you can see
it has purple and green pink and blue
deeper palette amber
and
you can choose whatever you like so
let's go with indico and pink
which is the default one okay
you want to use angular typography we
are not going to use it but let's add it
do we need animation yes we need
animation
because a lot of angular material
component uses
animation
you can disable them if you want to i
mean in case you are using some older
browser we have seen
uh the animation doesn't work properly
on i11
in case you are supporting it if you are
not supporting it you are lucky
now uh angular has itself dropped the
support for i11 and most of the uh
most of the applications out there
doesn't support i11 anymore
and now it is added
let's go ahead and see the changes
so it
adds this
css you can see the css is added here
and it will add some styles
it added some meta tags
here
and link
which is which is to you uh load
material icons
and it will also
add browser animation because we said we
want to use browser any uh sorry we want
to support animation so this browser
animation module is added
and that's it
let's
go ahead and run our application and see
how it looks like
remember we have not added the uh
navigation as of now we'll do that next
once we see the changes on our
application
okay so
probably uh the changes are not that
visible but you can see
the
font is changed
because of course the angular material
has a different font right
now
click on employee rooms everything works
let's inspect
and there is no console error apart from
one which we have already discussed
about this error
now let's go ahead and add the
navigation as we discussed about
so we'll go back to the uh guide section
here
let's see
and in guide there is
something known as schematics
i am showing you because
you should keep this in mind that
whenever you want to refer it next time
just refer the docs so
you can see uh this step is available
here and in case you want to install cdk
which we don't need as of now
we what we want to do is we want to
create a navigation so for creating a
navigation there is a navigation
schematic which is available
it means it's a command which will
generate the entire navigation page for
us and we can just use it
so let's go ahead and do that
so it here
so i'll see this is navigation so i'll
call it as this is a app nav app
navigation
and this is done
so we have
this apple nav
or we could have just said navigation
that's that's all also fine but yeah
so we have this uh component available
here let me just close this
and it has some already code which is
available
so we can see okay this is available
here as well
and
some breakpoint observer i mean this is
something which you may have do
by your own in case you don't use the
schematic so let's see how it looks like
so what i'm going to do is you can see
uh you can you can see uh it has some
matte list some with some href we will
be replacing the search reps with router
or router link
and this is where the content goes
you can see it says add content here
so
let's replace
and make this component available here
let's comment this out let's
comment this
and let's see our view
let us see our application so you can
see it has some menu link one link to
which of course doesn't work right now
because there is nothing which is
configured
but you can see also this is
responsive
so you don't have to actually go ahead
and
make this responsive you don't have to
write any extra css this is all taken
care of so a responsive navigation bar
created for us without even writing a
single line of code yes this is what
angular material does
or this is how you can actually utilize
the schematics which is available by
angular material
so let's uh
add some let's make this
navigation work
so here
let's go back and we said here we'll add
router link
and as we already know the routes we
don't have to actually go ahead and
move it in box so i can say okay this is
uh rooms
and this is a router link
is equals to
i'll say this is employee
and
we'll say this is employee
remove this and now we
want to add a component here router
outlet
and let's
see our application it works right so
you can now navigate to room so you can
navigate to employees and everything
works fine
so this is how you can uh add angular
material to our application
or any application and you can also
configure the routes and
you can also add navigation without
making much of an effort so you can see
it is responsive it will work for mobile
so you can just click on mobile here and
it will work so you can move to whatever
url or whatever routes you have
configured
so this is it from this particular video
so far what we have done is we have
configured the route we also saw how we
can set default route for our
application but let's see there is one
problem with what whatever we have done
so far and we will see how we can fix it
so here let's say if i try to enter a
route which does not exist
and this is where the problem is you can
see blank page
and now if i go to the uh
console.log let's see
something interesting there
so in console you will see an error
which says cannot match any routes with
this particular url so let me just zoom
in and of course this url does not exist
but we should not give a blank page
right what we generally do in real time
applications you might have visited lot
of applications you might have used it a
lot of web web apps what you generally
do
yes the answer is four or four pages
right in case uh you guessed that you're
absolutely right
so
the solution is to add a 404 route how
we can do that using angular
so this is where
we are going to do
so this is where we are going to do
a wild card route example or we are
going to see an wildcard route example
so let's go back to
let's go back to our code
and let's open the configuration file if
you remember it was app routing module
and we had added this default route now
let's go ahead and add a wildcard route
which will take care of and we'll talk
about it let's first add it so how to
add wireless card route you have to say
path
and
you will say double star which is
the
let's
write this and talk about it here so the
path double star says any
route which does not match
to any of this
will be captured by this and what we are
doing is we are redirecting to rooms
do we need to the answer is no we don't
so let's uh create a 404 page and let's
redirect the users to 404 page so let's
add a component
and we'll say ngc
and we'll say this is not formed
you can show whatever you want to
probably i've seen a lot of inventive uh
ways to actually show not one page there
are a different application which uses
some
svg svgs like some
skull logo
depends right so whatever whatever your
use cases
so here we are adding not phone page and
let's go back to component
and i'll say this
or we can say the resource
you are
looking for
does
not exist
right so we can show this
and
what we can do is we can just wrap it
inside a div
and
let's
do
[Music]
just add some css here h1
and we'll say this is
font
size and
font color
so color
would do
and we'll say this is red
let's see
let's go back
to our application and let's try to
enter a url
uh but again sorry right now it will be
redirected to rooms because we said it
should be redirected to rooms here
but what we want to do is we want to
redirect to
of course
not found page so we can say component
and we will say
not
bom component
let's save
and let's try to enter url which does
not exist and here we are the resource
you are looking for does not exist i
think there is some problem with css
which is uh not
taking the color probably it should be
font
color if i'm not wrong there is nothing
called font color
that's my mum
okay there is something wrong but yeah
anyways this is not
what we want to do so
so now what we have is we have a 404 uh
page which is available for us by using
the wildcard route match so this is how
we can
handle those scenarios
and
let's
see what's next
so now we will talk about
how we can create dynamic urls that is
interesting right so what in case i want
to uh
redirect a user to let's say room slash
id
right so it uh you might have seen some
uh ecommerce applications and let's take
an example of e-commerce application
let's open one so let's go to amazon
and let's click on let's see any product
so i say yeah
one plus
nine pro
and when you click on this you can see
uh there are some parameters which is
added after this right
if you see this one it has like s k one
plus whatever your product name is and
after that uh you will see here
uh you have keyword one plus nine pro
equals to this lot of parameters which
is added in the url
but in case we want to create some url
where we can pass some let's say in our
case a room id and it opens the new page
right i mean it redirects to a new page
let's see how we can do that how we can
configure a url like that
so this is where we will be discussing
about
the concept of dynamic routes we'll see
how we can create dynamic routes
the first thing which we'll do is we'll
go to rooms uh let's see the ui first
sorry
so let's uh go to the ui first and we'll
go to rooms
and remember we added the select button
so what we will do is on click of the
select button we will redirect the user
to
another view where we can see the
information about this particular page
in
as we move forward we will
we will actually
change this button to book
now and so users can not use this but
let's say it's a hotel inventory
management so the hotel uh receptionist
or anyone can book the hotel from this
particular button
so
they know which particular room number
is this and then they can just enter the
information related to the user and
that's the type in the
guest and that's it so let's go back and
what we will do is
i'll
create a new component here
so let's go to open in integrate
terminal
remember one thing i mean i'm i'm
[Music]
creating the components which are
related inside the same folder for
example right now i'm going to create a
room booking folder which is of course
related to room so i'm keeping this
inside this world folder so i'll say
this is ng
c and i'll say this is rooms
game
now we have this component available
and
so now we have this component available
now what we have to do is we have to
redirect whenever we click on that
particular select button on this
component so
but that particular id will be of course
it will be dynamic we don't know the id
by default i mean in advance so let's
see how we can do this so it's a path
rooms of course rooms will remain same
because that's the
main url let me enter point slash and
you can put colon id
and let's see what the purpose of that
particular component are sorry colon id
is smooth
here and then it's a component and we'll
say this is
rooms
booking
let's add this to
module and this is
so a room slash id and then rooms
looking component let's test this right
now
and is there any missing thing yes
there's a
comma missing here let's
close this and now let's try to
test this first how we can test it i can
just enter whatever i want to after room
slash and you can say it says rooms
booking works
and from where it is coming it is coming
here so it means my route is working
fine i mean i can enter whatever i want
to after this and it will just redirect
me to room smoking works
now what we have to do is we have to
make a link from
this rooms list
right so whenever we click on this
particular button select room we should
be redirected to that particular
component how we can do that let's see
so there are multiple ways uh i can just
use router link
remember we uh right now on select room
we used to actually send the data back
to the component so what we will do is
we will just
comment this out
and we will use button now
and with router link
right now the router link value will be
dynamic so
input
box is equals to
and then here i can say rooms so i can
say slash
rooms
and
the next value is the id which we want
to pass so we already have that
particular id which is room dot id if
you remember so
here room
and why we don't have id
anyways we
will see room dot id
and
let's close button and we'll say
book pro
okay somehow it says rooms does not have
id as possible room number okay sorry
so we have a room number
and
i'll also add a class so let's add the
class
btnb primary let's use the same one
so let's go back to our employer sorry
rooms
now we have this book room button
available here let's click on one of
them and you can see room slash one so
you have the values available here so
let's go back again
and click on rooms
book and we have the id has two
available here so now we have configured
a dynamic route now we can actually
navigate between that but let me show
you one more thing
i am removing the slash here and it has
a purpose so let me show you
because this is something which you may
face in your real-time application so
you can see now what what is happening
here
now i am not redirected to rooms booking
page remember i am redirected to 404 the
resource you are looking for does not
exist why
let's see the url found the issue
yes room says
twice
why so
why it was working before so whenever
you say slash it means the route should
start from here
by default the uh
routing functionality works in a way
that it will always append the previous
url which is already or sorry previous
uh you can say uh the parameters without
parameters which is already available
that's the reason it was like so doing
room slash rooms because
uh we said we we don't have slash right
so it will say okay the earlier
parameter is rooms here
right so it is it is it has the rooms if
i click on this
it is saying just go ahead and add these
two parameters to the url when we put
slash it is saying just start from here
so whatever the url is i want to
redirect to rooms slash id
so this is the difference remember uh we
really uh keep this in your mind or you
can just revisit the video again in case
you get this error uh in future
so now uh we have configured dynamic url
we are now
able to redirect to uh the component as
well what next what next what do you
think what should be the next step for
us
yes you guessed it right you we need to
get the id right so whatever id we are
passing in case you want to boot this
particular room we need this id we need
to read the one or two whatever value
which is available into the parameter
so let's see how we can do that for that
we will go back to rooms component
and let's say what we will do here is we
will put the id
uh i'll just do id right now and let's
see how we'll read this id
i'll go back to the slides
and
we will talk about a service called
activated route service because this is
what we are going to use
remember so what activated route
activated route services so it allows
you to read the router data whatever
router data which is available inside
your application
you can also access the snapshot data so
we'll talk about what snapshot and the
other data is and then you can also
access data from route config we will
see all these examples but let's
do first what you want to do is we want
we have
right now the value which is which we
are talking about is it is available
inside our route right so we want to
read this one
so i'll say private this is a service
and it is available by default by and
provided by angular router so you don't
have to do anything else you we have
already we have already imported the
router module so we don't need to
register anything extra
so let's say this uh
router
which is
activated route
right so we have injected the service
and they should come from angular slash
router remember this
and now uh here we will say this dot
router dot
so there are multiple parameters which
we have and the ones we the one which we
need is we need terms
and then in params see this
so it's also an observable yes so router
data is an observable so we can say
subscribe and let's see uh
let's say
let's say params
and
see if there is an extra closing yes
and console.log balance right now we'll
just do this
let's see what we get here so
console and
we have this right so we if let's zoom
in so we have id and one so it gives you
key value but from where this particular
id is coming from
right we are not seeing this uh just
required and read id
let's go back to our code base and let's
go to the configuration
this is the id so
angular remember it knows that okay this
particular key whatever i'm passing here
is actually defined as id
you can name it whatever you want it
doesn't need to be id i mean you can
just say room id
let's try that right so we can say room
id
and let's see here so you will get it as
room id not id
so
keep it whatever you want to
should be i mean uh
it should describe itself right i mean
here we are talking about room so room
id doesn't make sense i mean even room
slash id does make sense but just not to
get confused you can just keep it
whatever you like
now we uh now we know the key
now let's try to redrive the values how
to get it
so here
you can say params.get
there are multiple ways so we can
do this one let's try it with
terms
dot
no this is not the one
so parents of room id and
let's see
we need to of course do a console.log so
let's try let's do one thing so i'll say
remember we already said uh we'll be
using a variable called id and this is
number so i'll say this dot
id
is equals to
param
of room id so let's see
and we will save this as well
the template one
okay it has no initializer so
and say this is default to zero
and you have one available here so you
can see uh the value which is available
inside our route
is
now we are able to capture it so let's
go back click on rooms
click on room 2 and the value 2 is
available here so this is how you can
actually go ahead and access whatever
dynamic parameter you define inside your
url but let me show you one more thing
here
so here uh you
remember we always we said while talking
about rxjs you should not subscribe
remember while talking about uh
observables we said we should not
subscribe it will lead to memory leakage
so how we can actually make sure that uh
[Music]
i mean how we can avoid this particular
subscription so there are ways of course
the way is using
the rhs rxjs operators so here what we
can do is we can actually do something
like this so i can say um
this dot id is equals to i'll say this
dot
uh
router dot let me show you snapshot as
well sorry we've actually wanted to
discuss about this as well so params
snapshot
dot patterns
of
room id
and let's see
snapshots and then we'll come back to
the subscription so let's go to rooms
and click on one let's go back to rooms
and click on two so you might be
wondering okay if i am able to get the
data using snapchat why should i go
ahead and use subscription
so remember snapshots will never update
the data in case you are changing the
value being in the same view
so whenever a new value is submitted by
anyone that value will never be captured
right now we are actually migrate we are
navigating to another view so it is it
knows okay we are coming from another
view and i need to update
our take this status from snapshot so
this will never receive a new value in
case it is already in the view remember
this because in case uh in future we
will talk about child components and if
you try to access using snapshot you may
get into issues right where the value
will never be updated so this is
snapshot but this is not what we are
looking at so i'll say this dot id i'll
create one
here let's create
id
uh stream is equals to
right
which is type of sorry
type of observable
of number because we know what this is
going to be number
and
we put this here
and let's see so we'll say this dot id
which is stream is equals to this dot
router
dot params
dot now we will use pipe because we
don't want to
subscribe and here we will use something
known as there are multiple operators we
can use we can just use map right so
let's try let's go with map i mean this
is the this is the easiest one right so
we can say map and you can see the id it
says it will be type of number because
it knows the type and let's move and
use this
id
type
async
right so what we have done here so we
said now we are not going to subscribe
manually we can just do this let's let's
try to
avoid this and let's do this
id is equals to this
and recommend this one
it's format
and
[Music]
let's see the application so you have
the value when available here click on
rooms and values to
click on here and values three so we are
still able to get the value the param
value by using
passing by we are not we we are not
subscribing anymore
and we also saw how we can get the data
from params
using
the
activated route service
and
what else what else
here uh let's talk about
so here let's talk about one more thing
so right now we are using this params
property right
but there is one problem with params
property what in case we have multiple
values available as part of your query
your parameters right
but in that case what you will do of
course you can say params of another
value
but uh there is another uh api which is
also available which is more preferred
than this params so let's try to use
that particular parameter uh or
particular property so i just comment
uncomment this
and rather than params
we will use something known as paramap
same it also emits the observable but
let's see what is the difference but
sorry what is the difference here so it
is the params and to get the value
here you can use params
dot and now let's see this so it has
some methods like get all has keys so
you can before even accessing the values
so before even accessing the values you
can see if this particular particular
key exists or not right it is really
useful in case you want to redrive
multiple information and other
information is probably let's say
optional right
so you can just check if this particular
key exists by using ash sorry it has and
then you can access the value so here
you can see get
and then you you have to provide the key
again the key will be room id
so
this is how you will be writing it but
as we already have this code what we
will do is we will replace this using
this one so we can say paramap and uh
here
i'll say params dot get room id
and let's uh comment this out we don't
need it anymore we just wanted it for
reference
and let's go back to our ui
and we still have this working code
available so you can see
the values whatever value we change we
are getting that value available here so
this is a preferred paramap because it
is like more clean ui rather than
actually uh
uh just getting the value like this
which may throw an exception in case the
key does not exist here you can actually
go ahead and check if this key exists
and get the value
so this is
from the dynamic routes and let's move
ahead
so before we go ahead and utilize more
services related to routing or more
functionality related to routing we are
going to
have some more views and for that what
we are going to do is we are going to
jump
right now or into forms so what we will
do is we will create some views uh using
forms and we will combine both together
i mean forms plus routing so we get a
complete picture
how our application looks like
so
we are going to start with template
driven forms
so let me tell let me tell you this
first angular has two types of forms
template driven forms and it also has
reactive forms
for me personally i prefer reactive
forms but it's not like
they
one is one is bad one is good it's not
like that they both are powerful it's
just on based on your use case what you
prefer or based on what
flavor you prefer right so we will go
through both we will create forms using
template driven forms as well as
reactive forms and
you can choose while working on your
application which suits your team which
suits your
application so let's start with template
driven forms first
so what the agenda is we will set up
template driven forms we will see how we
can add validation we'll see how we can
submit and reset forms
we will uh
see some examples if you remember we uh
we saw pipes and we saw directives so
here we will see uh how we can use
custom uh for how we can write a custom
pipe how we can write a custom validator
uh and how we can also write a custom
directive so validator part it's related
to forms how we can validate forms
so let's see uh and let's go ahead and
see how we can actually set up a
template driven form and how we can
create our first template driven form
but what we will create
so remember we performed some crude
operation card operation right and we
took an example of adding a room so
let's do that let's create a template
driven form for adding a room
so
first thing
we already
have some functionality available so
let's close all this
rooms
we have rooms list and if you remember
we had this
add button somewhere add room
so what we need to do is we need to take
this add room functionality out and put
it in a different component so what i'm
going to do is i'm going to call it as
a new component so let's
say open integrate terminal
and here we will say ngc
and
let's call it as rooms
add
okay so it's
it will be used to add and grow that's
what we are planning we are trying to
do
and let's see
so we got our component and let's go to
the slides right
let's go to the slides and let's see
what are the steps which needs to be
performed so first we have to add forms
module
to module
and then we have uh we have uh template
driven forms so
that's next step so how we create the
form so we'll come back to this first
let's
do the first step so first import forms
model to module right now we have one
module so let's go ahead and add this to
this module and into imports area as
it's a module remember
and let's
format
with prettier
and add
forms
module
and it is auto imported for me so from
angular forms and this is what we wanted
to do now let's go ahead and create a
form so to create a forms we uh
we will be using html forms so we will
be writing html form
you don't have to do something extra
here i mean if you know html you know
how to create a form in html that's what
is needed to create a form in
template-driven forms
so let's first see what are the values
which is required to add a book room
and for that we already have this
add room functionality so we need room
type we know we need amenities we need
price we need photos
and check-in time checkout time rating
right so these are the things which we
need so let's go ahead and add a form
for this
so i'm going to add form right so this
is uh sorry not from
form right so this is how we create a
html form nothing fancy here and let's
add some divs
let's see how many fills we had one two
three four five six seven so i'll add
seven tips
three four five six seven and i will add
one more for submit button so it that's
it
and now
here uh we i'm going to use some
bootstrap classes so uh bootstrap has
something called
form group
so let's use um
group
so for all the tips we can use form
what it will do it will just add some
space so that's what it is going to do
except the last one because uh that will
be our submit button so that we
already
gap so
from group and now we need controls we
need
our controls to be added so let's go
ahead and
do that so we have room type
so i'll say input and we have to say
type
uh so input
type will be text
and
name let's give a name
which will be
room type
and here
we are going to use a class
of type form control
and let's format the document
so uh what we will do is we will create
a route
for adding a room
and let's go ahead and do that here
so here and just add
path
we'll say its rooms
slash add and component
is
rooms
add component
and once done here we need to add this
into our routes uh sorry our navigation
bar
so let's go to navbar go to html and
here
we will add
outlink store rooms slash ad and we'll
say
add
room
let's verify this functionality first
let's say add room and we have this
input text available here
so
first step is done we
added a forms module we
just created an input field we added a
uh route that's it and now let's
complete our form so let's go to rooms
slash add
and let's add the other inputs
okay
now before we actually move ahead and
talk more about forms why we create
forms remember in case you have an
enterprise application there will be
some use cases where you have to collect
user input so that's the that's the
reason you will be using forms mostly
for example let's say you have some
filters which you need to show you need
to collect some user input in forms of
feedbacks you need to uh
collect user profile information that
these are some cases where you may need
forms it's not mandatory right you can
still have an entire application without
forms
what are the use cases like
the applications where you just need to
display the data for example you have
internal revenue system
and uh so what you will end up with so
some charts and all those things but
still you may need some filters as well
so that those are scenarios where you
will be using forms and
let's uh move now and let's add other
controls so i'll say this is
and we can add uh one more thing we can
add placeholder so we know what we are
we are supposed to enter correct so
let's say this is room type
and let's see
so you have a nice uh placeholder
available here so it depends so
a lot of applications uses label
but a lot of mobile first applications
does not use label they use placeholder
so it's up to
uh your design system how you want to
proceed with it so
and what we will do is let's see if i
can add
okay let's uh let's take css later
and let's see what else we have here
amenities prices photos or amenities
so it will be let's say this will be
text as well
and this
will be m and these
and placeholder will
be installed
and then it is
let's add to
let me just
it's here so i can just refer quickly
so i'll see this is input type this is
price so guys to save type is number
price i'll say this is
placeholder
room
price
for that night
so because most of the prices are
perfect
then we have photoboos
and this should be text and placeholder
photos
and we can say provide link right so
this is done
and we need check in and check out time
so this is our date time right so we can
actually use date time
and let's say check-in time and
place folder
because all the hotels actually have a
check-in checkout policy right so you
have to check in by three i mean it can
be part of policy but let's try to keep
it minimum so i'll say this this chicken
time
and check out time
and this will be date time as well
and then say this is placeholder
and this stage report time
and this is rating so it will be again
number
rating and placeholder ulcerity
you can in future actually replace this
with some rating component in case
you come across some
some component library which has rating
system or rating component you can use
it
and here i will say
button
okay so we will have a submit button
available here so you have button button
button primary submit let's go ahead and
verify our forms okay this looks nice i
think this is some things which is
missing
from
input class form control
from group
okay so i think the spaces are missing
let me verify
okay
class form group okay this is correct so
now
control
this is
okay so now we have this form available
but let's see
uh we are still not able to do one thing
what's that
so we need to collect this information
and send it to our backend that is
something which is missing how we will
do that so
to do to achieve that we need some
two-way data binding which is uh which
needs to be available how we do two-way
data binding so angular forms provided
by default so in case you want to do it
do two-way data binding we will discuss
about what data binding is
uh but let's see it in picture and then
we will do that
so first thing uh we need a model uh
what we uh the model which we are
talking about is we need a interface
which tells us how my room
information is going to look like
so to do that
i will create a room
which is type of
let's see room
list i think
is equals to
yeah this is the uh so remember id room
number we have made anyway is optional
so let's
add some uh other things so let's say
room type this this will be the default
values which we are adding right now
amenities
and
check in
time check out time
and then we have photos
we have price
and then we have rating
so these are the default values whenever
we are supposed to enter some values
into the form this will be the default
values which will be available
now we need to connect this
model
this represents our forms fields right
so now we need to connect this model to
our form so we can pass the information
from template to my ts5 and vice versa
even i if i change something in my
typescript file it should reflect back
into my form so these are the that's
what we are supposed to do here so let's
see how we can do that
we have already added forms module into
our
and module so it
it unblocks or it gives you some
functionality what is those
functionality it gives you info
functionality true achieved we're
determining how
we have to use something known as
ng model so remember this so you have to
say ng model
is equals to
uh room
which is my property
dot
your
uh
sorry room which is uh my model dot
property name so here we are supposed to
get room type
right so this is
done here
let's add for others so i'll say room
type this will be amenities
this will be price
this will be photos
this will be
chicken time
check out time
so
and this will be rating
now we added this now what what next how
we can verify that two area binding is
working fine let's see that so what we
can do is as room is my property which
is supposed to
update whenever i enter some value value
here i can just do something like this
room by jason let's see
and you can see uh it has room type
amenities check in time checkout time
photos price rating everything is
available let's add something in room
type you can see the value is getting
changed it means now i have the power of
two-way data binding available with me
so whenever i make some changes here it
will be reflected back into my ts file
so let's add a valid room type and then
we will add we will provide a submit
button
or we will add the functionality to
actually send this data to our backend
which we have already done so
here we have a submit button right but
how to submit this form let's go ahead
and do that
we can see uh ng submit is equals to a
function which will actually add this
data or send this data to our backend so
i can say this is add room function
which we will implement which we don't
have right now and let's
go ahead and do this so let's add room
do we need to pass some information to
this form
of course no because we already have all
the information available as part of
this model because whatever value we
enter is updated into this property so
we can just do something like this so
i can go to room number ts we need to
get the reference to our service
which is
let's where is the constructor yep this
one so i will say room service i don't
want to
i can just avoid skip self and all those
things because
we already discussed about it and then
in add room i can we can do this dot
room service
dot
add room
uh where we can pass this dot room
and we'll subscribe we'll say this is
data
and
you'll say if
[Music]
let's
do something like if
okay so right now we are in
we are
actually giving all the data back so we
can just do something like this i'll
just do console.log
well let's do one thing but even better
so what we can do is
i say success
message just type of string
is equals to this
and
you can add
a deviate
and we can add a class
strap
you can see which class we can use
right we can use alert here so you can
say alert
alert
success
right and then we will set this message
and say this dot
message success masters is equal to
let's see what
room added successfully this is what we
needed and let me just format
so
everything is visible here so now we
have uh add room functionality uh we
injected the service we added a success
message which will display in case our
room is added or not
let's go ahead and
verify
so
here i'll say room type is
economy
i mean it is is we have wi-fi
uh ac
and price is let's say 5000 photos
provide link which let's say
leave it right now and
and this is
23 let's make it 10
[Music]
and 30 23
let's provide rating
for
let's do submit and it says rooms added
successfully but why should we trust it
right so let's go ahead and
verify in the console and
let's go to the network tab
and let's add another one right economy
and this is deluxe room
and we will say 6000 and let's click on
submit and rooms is added you can see
you have two extra values available room
type amenities and everything
and this is it so what we have done is
we just created our first template
driven form
we
attached or we added the functionality
to send the data to the back end the
only thing is
the spaces are not working properly but
we will fix those not an issue and you
can say that rooms added successfully
was already there which doesn't look
good so we will see how we can actually
avoid that as well we should get it once
the submit button is enabled or sorry
once the form is submitted and also if
you notice there is no validation
so we can just empty we can just enter
an empty form so i mean i can just avoid
all the values click on submit and still
we are able to add
the room you can see price is null
rating is null
and there are no amenities so
let's go ahead and add validation next
time then we will see some more
functionality related to our template
driven forms
let's go ahead and add some validations
to this form because we haven't done
that right and we can just
we can just submit a blank form as of
now
to add validation
in template driven forms we have to use
the html5 validations so in case you are
not aware of what html5 validations are
let me just uh
go back to
so uh we as you said we will be using
html5 forms and uh sorry html5
validators so there are multiple
validators which exist so let's go ahead
and uh see them
first so the first and i think
first and i think most of the time you
will be using this validator which is
known as required so let's go ahead and
see how we can add that so to add a
required validator you have to just say
required
that's it that's uh that's
you are done so you have added a
required validator and now this field
becomes required but
it's going to be verified
does it look like it is
required
of course no because we have to add some
extra checks we will talk about it
let's go back to the code let's add the
fields right now so we'll say okay
right now required this is required this
is also required
this is required
that so all the form fields are required
right now
but we can still go ahead and submit the
button now let's see how we can actually
uh i mean we can still go ahead and see
the submit button so let's see how we
can actually disable this control
until unless we have received all the
values and valid values
let's go back so uh to actually
get the status
of my form whether this form is valid or
not we need to get an instance of this
form how we can do that
right i mean we have talked about
classes to create a instance of a class
we do
object equals to new and then whatever
class name is and it will give you
instance but what about this i mean this
is the form how you will get the
instance so remember we discuss about
something known as a template variable
right so we said hash and some name and
then equals to
a hash some name and then it gives you
the instance of that particular uh
particular html control right we we
discussed it for
div
so here also we can actually use this
way so i can say this is a
rooms
form
is equals to you have to say ng form
remember this in g form
and now you will you get an instance of
this form
to yourself now how we can verify so
let's avoid let's remove this and use
rooms form here
and let's see what we
get let's see what we have here so
[Music]
console and we have some errors
because uh this json has a lot of
properties so right now what the
property which we need is rooms form uh
we need
errors
double rs yeah we need rs property let's
go ahead and see
so
it says null vice versa so
[Music]
so we have tombstone
okay so uh the property which we need is
valid so it has two properties uh all
the forms all html forms has this all
these properties so it's not like it is
available only for angular no it's not
it is available in normal html as well
you can actually access this properties
via javascript in case you want to if
you're writing a normal javascript or
typescript code so let's talk about all
these properties which we are going to
see so
valid will tell us whether this form is
valid or not let's verify
so it is false so the current form is
not valid so this is how we are going to
figure out whether to submit or not
whether we need to enable the submit
button or not enable the submit button
so let's uh talk about few other
properties which we are going to use so
here i'll just copy paste right now and
then we'll replace so
we are going to talk about something
known as pristine
then we'll talk about something known as
valid
invalid
and we also have something known as
value
well if not values let's see let's see
what we get here
so we have true false false true and
then this is your forms value right
whatever you enter here will be
available here you don't have to
necessarily uh take the value from form
dot value you can also get it from your
uh
of course the model which you have
created
so here uh let's go ahead and see what
these values are false true false true
right let's see
so this is pristine this is 30 this is
valid and this is invalid so what are
these values so pristine and dirty are
real uh
good use cases i'll talk about it let's
talk about valid and invalid right so
they are like opposite of each other
so
if your any of your
control has some validation error it
means your form is not valid
so valid will be false as soon as all
the form control
becomes error free it means they don't
don't break any validation rule which we
have provided it means they are valid
which will be true and invalid will
become false so here if you see
currently
if you see currently it says uh
valid is false and invalid is true which
is true right so let's see how we can
actually disable this first
let's you uh handle this use case where
how we can disable this particular
submit button
before i go ahead and do that let me
tell you one thing very clear in case
you have some validations don't just add
those validations at your front end your
back end should also have those same
validation because what you are going to
do is end of the day there will be an
api call and if your someone figures out
how to make your api calls and without
passing the data if you
he'll be able to break your system so
make sure that you add validation at
both the places not only at frontend so
here you can we can use a property
called invalid
sorry
we will be using disabled and i will say
rooms form dot
so we want it to be disabled in case
uh
perform is invalid so let's
say so it should be disabled in case our
form is invalid so let's enter all the
values
and let's see
and now our form becomes valid right you
can see this so if i remove
this value it means my form becomes
invalid again so submit button the
submit button becomes disabled so this
is how the required validator works and
these are the values uh the these are
the properties which you can access by
using this particular form so pristine
dirty invalid value
and value as well so
now here also let's to
check so i'll say this
start ng if
is equals to we can say
success message
is not equals to blank
so
and let's see now
so this
the success bar should be only available
after the submit button is clicked and
in case we have some message otherwise
it won't be
enabled or it won't be displayed on the
page so now what we have done is we have
taken care of two cases which we
discussed about now let's go ahead and
add more
validators
the next validator which we are going to
talk about is uh we will see min and
min length and max length so
what
is the use cases for mean length and
maximum so in case let's say you want
amenities right for example let's say
amenities so you want that amenities
should be like minimum five characters
and maximum 200 characters
so in this case what you can do is you
can use min and max let's let's let's go
ahead and do that
so here i'll we already have required so
i'll say min length
is equals to 50 or 35
and we'll say max length
is
let's make it 20 as of now
let's send the room let's enter
amenities but let's not enter five
characters and let's enter
photos
what you can see uh the form is still
invalid right so but the problem is here
it it actually introduces to uh us to
another issue
we are not able to display the errors
based on what the actual error is
we should right now we should display
the message saying
okay this particular for
value or the amenities which you are
trying to enter is it should be minimum
five characters but it is not
the users will of course will be
confused what's going on here
we should display uh the messages so
let's go ahead and see how we can do
that so this message is actually right
now or this error is actually available
right now with the control so here what
we need is the access to control how we
can do that yes let's go ahead and see
so to get the access to this control we
can say hash and whatever property name
you want to set it so let's say this is
amenities right so i'll say this
amenities
it's a room i mean it is because it will
conflict with another variable
room amenities is equals to you have to
say ng model remember this
and now let's go ahead and see
i'll place another
div
here and we'll say
amenities
dot errors as json let's go ahead and
see
so it says right now uh the error is
required too
but let's enter something right so now
you can see it says mill length required
length is 5 actually in this one if i
try to enter
more than 20 character i won't be able
to do it because it is supported by the
browsers so it says okay maximum length
has reached
50 characters or 20 characters and we
cannot enter more than 20 so it it has
stopped i mean i'm right now i'm still
typing but i'm not able to actually
enter the values and if i go below 5 it
will again give me the same error let's
see how we can display this as a message
right so here
we can use so here i'll just say
first
star in g if
if it has errors right you can also uh
do errors dot which type of error we are
talking about so here let's say if we
talk about mean length right so i'll say
okay if
the errors
okay so it says it should be
accessed as this main length
and
strength it is possibly done
yeah
so i'm trying to access uh the let's say
it's i'm saying if it is
mill length error
so what we can do is we can say
and we'll just add a class right so
class alert
alert
link let's
what was this uh success right so it
should be alert
from a wrong danger and let's see
uh
emanate peace
be
minimum
or should be minimum
minimum five gas so this is the
information we want to show
let's go ahead and see
let's enter one character and you have
the message available here it says i
mean it should be five characters and as
soon as we
go beyond five characters the error is
gone but yeah so this is
how you can display the errors on
control level
so we have this and of course you can
also say errors of required and then you
can also say okay this amenities is
required
this room type is required
all on your control level that is also
possible
so we saw min length and max length
what's next what's next so we have uh
the min and max
as well
i'm not sure if it still works but let's
see
so it's a mean uh which is
one
and max which is
five let's see
this is okay i'll not do it here i'll
let's do it for
rating right i mean i um i don't want
anyone to rate me less than one
a lot of services a lot of business do
that right
so
one two three four five now i won't be
able to actually go beyond five i'm just
still still pressing the up key but i'm
not able to go so let's go ahead and say
lc0 and let's enter all the other
details
and photos but we are still not able to
submit as soon as we move to one because
this is the minimum required we are able
to proceed so i we cannot go up
beyond five i don't want anyone to rate
me um more than five because that's the
max so this is how you can do with min
and max so we learned about required
min length max length
uh then we talked we talked about min
and max what else what other uh
validators which we have in html5
so we also have a validator for
email
so email of course you can mark any
property as email and it will be
considered as an email so let's try
right now we don't have anything for
email but
just
for an example right so we just make it
email
i think email is enough let's see
and let's display all the errors
otherwise we won't be able to figure out
right
which kind of error is this
so you can see uh it says okay min
length max length
and then now it says it's uh there is
this particular text whatever you have
entered it's not an email
so if i go ahead and say the rate
now we have actually
a valid email that's as per the html5
validate validator this is an actual
valid html uh sorry valid email
so this is email and
what other so there is also something
known as format so format takes regex so
you can actually
use
ah okay sorry it's not uh so the next
validator which we are
we're going to talk about it's known as
patent so pattern is something where you
can provide a regular expression for
example i don't know what this rejects
is thanks to our
github co-pilot uh which gave me this
rejects for some some reason so let's
see what this pattern is so here i can
just provide this pattern a regular
expression
and my text whatever i enter will be
actually
validated against this pattern so this
is regular expression
let's see
so it says okay required pattern is this
i'm not sure what required pattern is it
starts from a to z and then there are
number so one two three
ah then there is plus
at the rate
okay i still don't understand what this
pattern is probably we can search for
this regular expression and see but yeah
you can provide any regular expression
as a pattern and this will be validated
so we learned about required
mid length max length min map min max we
talked about email we talked about
pattern so these are different
validators which we can use
while working with template driven
sorry while working with template driven
forms and all these are built-in
validators you don't have to do anything
extra to use them
so
this
it this is it from the required
validator part what we covered is we
also saw how we can
validate your entire form how we can
validate your
specific control
and how we can actually show errors
based on specific uh controls as well
so that's it
in this video we are going to talk about
few things
uh we talked about valid invalid but we
didn't test pristine and dirty so let's
talk about these
two states because they are really
important to understand and
to show you an example let me
just open the
um
let me just open the view and you can
see here right now
this required true error is already
there right so once again let's go back
to our code base
and
this errors
so if i do something like this
div
and star in g if
errors
dot
required
[Music]
and here let's say
please
provide
the amenities
let's see the output
so you can see this error message is
available here of course and we have not
provided the class but yeah this error
message is available here but
as a user i haven't actually touched the
controller i haven't entered anything
so using pristine you can actually avoid
something like this so you can do
here
remember this this property is available
on form as well as control so i am going
to use it on the control so i can say
if
dot
pristine
so let's say dirty
and this two so i'm combining these two
properties let's say uh let's see what
we are going to achieve using this rate
so you can see i don't have the error
when the view was available at the first
time so i'm providing
the ability to
enter some text
before i go ahead and show the error so
in case i remove it
i delete the entire thing i will get
this error which is really valid right i
mean as i have entered something and
then i removed it i should show this
particular error message so how does
pristine and dirty helps so let me talk
about these two properties
so pristine
always means fresh state to your form
control it means no one has actually
touched your form so let me just refresh
this page
and you can see the pristine value is
true why i'm saying this is a pristine
because of course we have actually
logged pristine first
so pristine is frustrated as soon as i
interact with any control inside this
form let's do that it becomes false
and it will be false remember valid
invalid can change the state i mean a
form which was valid can become invalid
in case i remove some
values or delete some values from some
control
but a form which becomes pristine
to dirty
will never come back
until until unless you reset it
the thing is we are about to go ahead
and see how we can reset our form that's
why we are talking about dirty and
pristine
so remember pristine means frustrate i
have as a user no one has actually
touched anything no one has entered
anything inside the controls provided
once you do interact with it it becomes
dirty so this states are actually really
important in case you want to understand
or you want to see if user has
interacted with your form or not you may
actually have let's say form where you
want to collect some feedback
but you really want feedback so sometime
you may
get an requirement that okay users
should not be able to
move out from this form until unless
they provide some feedback
so how you can do that so based on this
state so if it's pristine or dirty so
let's say user entered something and
then he decided to move out you can just
restrict him okay uh you have someone
save changes or let's say it is a really
important form right you have stepper
control for example in case you are from
india you might have filed your taxes so
at each and every steps it asks you to
save the data
but in case you don't save the data so
it will give you some effort right so
something like that can be implemented
using this form control values so pc in
order t
now as you understand pristine and ready
now let's move back uh sorry
so let's go ahead and talk about
how to reset the form right
if you see this right now uh we have
let's say go on
wi-fi
ac
and let's say this is 5000 this is
anything and you might be wondering why
this is not daytime because uh the
datetime control is actually broken on i
think this is chromium browser so i i'll
replace this with
material datepicker we will do that
we'll do that together so just wait
right now it's it's the default date
right and then
we can do
i have to remove one thing remember we
added email
sorry we added pattern
yeah
let's remove the pattern so we can
actually go ahead and save the data so
we say okay this is economy i think i
have
wi-fi and then ac
and let's say this is 5k
this is random data and let's say this
is three star
let's see so room added successfully now
this room got added but what about the
data
the data is still there don't you think
this is wrong yes it is wrong i mean we
should reset the form so i can as a user
i can enter new data right it
may be possible if we still show this
data the user may actually just
duplicate the data by by wondering okay
why this data is still available here so
let's see how we can reset the state
reset the state of this one so
to do that
we can
say here
let's go back
so i want to reset the state after the
operation is completed right so i can do
something like this here so i can
let's
this remove
and then
we can get the access to this form
control how we can do that so we can
actually pass
this rooms form
as a variable here
and now here we will get this rooms form
which is which will be type of ng form
and
let's see if i am uh
accessing the current yeah control
container
so
after this i can say rooms form dot
reset so let's see how it behaves and
let's save both
so i'll say this is deluxe
amenities
and five
tv
pc and then
this is six games random data four star
and save now you can see your room is
added successfully and now
your entire data is actually resetted
right so now we have a fresh rate you
can see also the most important thing to
understand here is once you reset your
form
you
set your form back to form straight back
to the pristine that's why it became
true otherwise it will never become true
so this is
this is how you can actually reset the
state of form as well and there are few
more methods so you can also do
preset form and here you can actually
pass the default data so i can just do
here i can just copy this and i can say
okay once you reset the form just go
ahead and
treat this as default data so let's see
i'll say this is deluxe
now or you can say this is
double room
mnt
55 ac
two
beds and let's say this is 500
and let's say this is
four star right submit and now you have
a reset state as well of course because
you can see pristine became true and you
have this default data which you
provided so these are two methods which
we can use to reset your forms using
template event form so let's remember
how we do this so we are passing this ng
form
as a reference to our type script file
and then we are saying okay this form is
actually type of ng form because
remember this this ng form is like uh
extended or you can say it's a top level
form group which will be available so
under which all the control will be
available
and then after you have added
successfully you can just go ahead and
call the reset button reset form and
your state is receipted now
so this is from uh this is how you can
actually
handle the states and how you can reset
your form
so next thing which we are going to talk
about is custom directive with forms you
might be wondering where the pipe part
went so pipe part will be actually
covered in
reactive form uh because it's it's
almost same so i don't want to actually
repeat it again so that's why we moved
it there and right now let's see how we
can actually add a custom directive
uh with forms and what we are trying to
do is we will be uh
uh we will be creating a directive which
can modify the behavior of an element
so what are the use cases so uh let's
see
let's let's see that right so we will
talk about them
so for this what we are going to do is
as we are going to need a login form in
future we will create another form i
will not touch this form as of now we'll
keep it as it is and let's create
another component we will call it as
login component so i'll say nggc
login
and we will be using template driven
forms and so let's go ahead and do that
so form
div
let's say class
form
group so i think form group is not
working because of some conflicts with
angular material
so let's see
and we will add some controls so this is
input
uh type is
text from control name ng model and i'll
say this is email
let's
say type is also email because we are
going to treat
uh username as email i mean
provide
your
user
so we are not going to implement any api
for this we will actually just mock
and that's it so we'll just mock this
entire service with some dummy data and
we'll move
so here it is password
email and i'll say this is password
provided enter your password
enter your password
right so we are done uh now we just need
to create the model let's go ahead and
do that
so i'm going to create uh this is
username
which is type of string
which is equals to blank
and this will be password
which is again type of string uh let's
call this as email so
because we have already uh yeah we have
uh used it as email so let's do that and
then we need a button uh so button and
we will
create a login button
so let's go ahead and write some logic
here
login
and we'll say if
this dot
email
is equals to
admin
gmail.com
and
this
dot
password
is equals to
the best password in the world admin
admin right so
username and password is admin
and let's see
and after this we have to go ahead and
let's uh right now use an alert and we
have to actually go ahead and implement
this uh with some other functionality of
routing we will come back to that later
right now let's just do this
and here
we will add route
we will redirect
we'll say this is path
since the path is
login
and component
is
login component
and now here we will redirect the users
to login
so we added a new component and let's
add a comma here so
yeah so perfect so we added a component
login component we created a form for
login and we now change the route so by
default it will go to login
let's see so i'll
remove this
and here we are right so provide
username and password
and this login button so right now of
course the admin and password does not
match so it will not show you another
but let's try that out
of course we wrote some logic so let's
verify
and find gmail.com and
password is admin and yep login
successfully
ray we created our login page right i
mean of course you can design it in a
better way i'm not that great into a
great using css but yeah i mean you can
uh
you you can design as per
your knowledge
so here
what we are going to do is we are going
to create an
directive which can modify this element
so we will try to modify this input
element and we will see how we can
actually work with directives because we
have not seen how to create a custom
directive right so we saw build
directives so far
so let's go ahead and create a new
component i'll just try and say ngg to
create a new directive you can say ngg
directive d and we'll call this
component directive as hovered so
uh what we want to achieve is whenever
we hover above this particular elements
it may change the background color right
so uh
a minimum example is to give you a
real-time uh field of how you can
actually write a directive which can
modify your element
of course in real-time application you
will get more advanced use cases but
i mean this is this is one of the
examples which
can help you when you will plan to
actually write some of the directives
like this
so
not
done now we can go to
[Music]
word directive here so let's go ahead
and create a folder so or it will be we
will do that later
so
when we talked about directive we said
directives are
sorry when we talked about directive we
said directors are similar to component
but they will never have one thing which
is template
so here uh let's see how we can actually
get an access to the element which is of
course
uh this
hover directive right so this over
directive will be
kind of an helper method to your element
where it you can apply it so let's see
how we can do that so
here
we will say
uh
we are supposed to use host listener but
we will do that later on but let's try
to do first thing first
we will say
let's apply some color
so i'm saying the
by default your
when whenever we try to
let's say when we apply this particular
directory we are not talking about right
now how to use host listener i mean host
listener is something which we'll talk
about so let's not get confused so right
now we are just trying to see once we
apply this particular directive it
should change the background color to
red
right so
here what we can do is we can implement
implement
on init let's take a look
the reason we can actually use life's uh
ng on it on all the lifecycle looks is
as you said directives is similar to
what your components are apart from this
template but it can still go ahead and
use all the lifecycle looks as well so
here now what we need is we need this
color to be applied to the element which
is available outside right
it's uh
i mean how we can do that
so let's see
so here we will see we will provide
we will inject
element which is type of element ref
and
let's
do a console.log here
and see what this element is
on init
why okay so let me just add this so what
we have done so far we have just
injected element ref and we have just
done console.log now let's go ahead and
apply this particular directive how to
apply it so we can go to the component
this input element is where i want to
apply it just add it like this h i and v
and let's apply it here as well so we
are we we can use directives it's uh
reusable thing so let's inspect
let's go to console and here is the
interesting thing which we want to
discuss about so you can see
a native element it gives gives you
access to the native element so what to
simplify this i mean of course we can
see that okay it is referring to the
login component you can see the context
so it says okay it is coming from
something called login component so to
simplify it
let's go ahead and say this element dot
native
element and let's see what we get
so here you can see you are actually
getting this input element how you can
actually just go ahead and see i mean
you can just click on it
and see okay this is the email and this
is the password so we are actually
getting the reference to the element on
which you are applying the directive so
this element riff will give the access
to the element now you can actually go
ahead and do whatever you want to with
this particular element let's do this so
i can say this dot element dot native
element and i can just write in store to
dot style dot color is equal to this dot
color let's see
but okay nothing happened because of
course color is not a property so i can
say back ground
color
let's see
okay so it was small g so now you can
see i i just change the background color
of this particular
input control by using the style
property directly but you can of course
do better you can actually go ahead and
do it using
the
document object right so you can go
ahead and do using that so let me show
you an example so i can say
this dot document
[Music]
or let me
use the
class actually uh there is a class which
is available so uh let's
grab that class again we just go to
angular dot io uh it's document
i'm not wrong yet
okay so anyways that's that's the api
which i wanted so you can actually just
inject this private
document which will be type of document
let's see
it's an
injection okay
it's an injection token so i can do
something like this at the rate
inject
now using this document so uh
let's talk about this document object
which we are talking about so remember
in web so let's say if i inspect this i
mean this is normal html if i try to
access this document
right so it gives me access to the
entire page i mean whatever control
which is available here so you can see i
get access to html and body everything
and by using document dot get element by
id these are some apis which are which
is available here so i can just go ahead
and say i can get access to any element
which is available here for example
let's say this aio shell right so this
is one of the element if i do this okay
this is not id
okay sorry this is an uh
tag this is not an id
let's search for something which is an
id
and class this okay there is nothing
there is no id so
let's try to do this mac toolbar
by using
document dot get element by tag
name
and i can just put the tag name here and
you can see i can get the access to this
html element so this is a web api so
this document is actually a wrapper
around the same and by using this we can
actually just simplify this so you can
say this dot document dot
uh
you can say get element by id so not
getting metal you can get element by id
but i can just to let's see what we can
use here
create element
very selective let's see if i can pass
uh element here
let's see what it takes so it says html
of type or html element as well so let's
see
probably this is not the one also we are
looking for
okay there are few more properties i'm
looking for when let's see
stylesheet replace
very selective different plugins okay on
something related to class detailing the
class name
and child contains focus create element
okay let's see document
so uh let's go ahead and see this i mean
using multiple ways so there are
something which we can do set
uh we can actually do it using the dom
or we can actually i mean this way style
dot color or background color which we
have seen
so back
background color
and
let's see the application again now
yeah
but there is another way as well another
way possible let's
see that so there is another api which
is available and we can also use that
api to simplify this
uh which is known as renderer 2 so i can
just do renderer
or just name it renderer and you'll see
renderer 2.
why render 2 because there is already a
api called renderer so
renderer 2 is something which you can
use and we can actually simplify this by
using rendered api so you can say render
it dot and now you get access to all the
methods there are set style set property
so this is something which is
property if i'm not wrong here
oh sorry this is the style
so we can say set style and the first
parameter which we have to pass is the
element so we can pass the element and
then the
second parameter would be the property
which you want to change and the third
parameter will be the actual value so i
can say with this
dot color
and let's see
we will achieve the same thing so we
have now same
available
uh the background color available as red
so this is this is the sim uh simple api
simple example right how you can
actually be change the behavior of your
dom element by using
the
element ref and the renderer
but in case we want to actually do
something based on the event which will
happen on your parent control
a simple example can be let's say
whenever you hover above your rows right
so you have a table and whenever you
hover above your rows you should
probably change or highlight that
particular row so common example right
so how you can do that so i'll just take
an example of
here
host listener so host listeners are
actually used to listen to any event
which is happening on your parent
component
the component where this particular
directive is applied so let's see what
we can do here so here i just copy the
same
and i'll say okay whenever you hover
change the background color to green
so on mouse enter my background color
will be changed to green let's go ahead
and verify and you can see one of over
let's refresh it again
and
you must refresh it again and on here
the background color is changed to green
similarly
we can
listen to mouse leaf event so we can say
okay on mouse leaf just go ahead and
make this to white
so as soon as i leave it becomes white
so you can see i can actually go ahead
and do that as well by using the host
listener so host listener will listen to
any event which is happening on the
component where this particular
directive is applied
what else so you can also pass the
properties
input properties
to your directives as well as output
properties because as i said
it's same right i mean
the only difference is it doesn't have a
template to deal with
so here let's try to convert this
color
so now the user or developer can decide
which color to pass so i'll say okay
this is now input
which is of type color and by default
it's red in case some one does not pass
it
if i pass it so let's say this is input
oh sorry this is color
we can actually just avoid this
box property i can say color equals to
and because uh this is going to be a
string only so i can say okay
for this just use color is equals to
green
and for this use steel blue another
my
one of my favorite colors
so let's see
and here it is so you can see uh let's
refresh it again so now we are we are
able to pass the default color to your
directive
by using
they may uh
by making the input as input property
what else we can achieve
i'll show you one more thing which can
be done
so is it possible that i can just
combine my input properties with my
selective as well
how let's do that
so there are multiple ways i'll
you can actually just do by using this
so you can keep your input name and same
as your selector and let's change this
and
concept is done here we will go to this
and now
i'll say h
green
and
same here so i'll say okay this is
equals to
steel blue let's see
if it works
you can see uh still works right so we
are now uh what we have done is
now we are not using any extra variable
so we are we are using the same variable
name
to actually capture the color as well by
using the same input property as of my
selector property this is something
which can be achieved
so or
there i mean there is another hack but i
will not tell you because that's uh what
you can say that's a linting error
in most of the application
that's a lending error you should not do
it but yeah so this is this is another
example how you can actually deal with
directives so what we did here is we
created a directive we applied the
directive to our components
and we discussed about element reference
renderer to or the apis which you can
use to change the behavior of your dom
then we discuss about host listener how
you can actually listen to any event
which is happening on your components
where your directive is applied so
directives are some what what directive
is it's a helper function for your
components or for
any dom element
so
in this video we will see how we can
utilize
the custom directives to create a custom
validator for your components
this uh
technique can be applied on any template
driven forms
so let's go ahead and do that so first
we will create a directive
so i'll create
folder
and let's create an email validator so
uh as we said our username is email so
if we detect a text called test in the
email we will say okay this user is not
valid user so
let's see i'll call it as email
validator
and then we have to create
sorry
and the g b and i'll call this as email
value
so how to add this so remember so in
case you are trying to implement a
custom validator for your template
driven forms you have to implement
something known as a validator
finally
one second it should be
it's a class so it should be extend if
i'm
there are two things so
let me just tell you so there is an
interface validator which will be used
for our use case there is a class called
validators which we will use with
reactive forms so let's implement
validator and see what we need to do so
we have to add something like this i'll
just copy this and then we'll talk about
it
so here
you can see i'm adding a providers and
we are saying provide ng validators
use existing where you will provide this
class and then you will say multitude
what is the purpose let's we will talk
about it and this validator class
actually gives you a validate method
which has signature like this so it
gives you control validation errors so
this is uh the interface right so this
is the function which is provided by
interface
let's talk
from top to bottom what we have done
angular already has like all the
built-in validators right which we have
seen email required and patterns
everything
in case we want to actually add our own
validator we have to actually let
angular know that we are adding our own
validator by using an
injection token remember we did it for
http interceptor we added our http
interceptor as part of the angular's
interceptor queue so here similarly here
what we are doing is we are adding
our validator into all the existing
validator which exists
and for that we are saying whenever i
try to use this particular selector you
have to go ahead and add this particular
class as part of the validators which
exist that's why we are saying multitude
because it's not object it's an array
it's an array of
all the validators which exist
now here you can see it returns whether
null or validation errors validation
errors is type of key and value
so here we can do something like this
this abstract control actually gives you
the value of the control this is base
class for most of the classes related to
forms
remember this one thing there is no
difference between template driven and
reactive forms right because the apis
are same so the core apis are same it's
the only way the flavor changes right i
mean what we have seen till now is
template driven form where we did
everything on html we will see reactive
form and you will know the difference
but right
here we'll do something like this we'll
say control
and as as uh this is a
input control so i'll say okay if this
uh control dot value
now you can see i'm not able to get
anything after this
why so
so if you see the value is type of
any
if i need uh
or if you want the typings i will
suggest doing this so you can actually
do
create
control dot value as we know that we are
going to get string just type cast a
test string and now
we can do something like this
value dot now you can see uh i'll say
okay if it includes
the word
test
i will return so this is how you will
return an email validator so you'll say
email validator and then it's key value
so i can say
email
valid
[Music]
true
right and so let's say invalid email
and if there is no error it means we can
return null so you can see the uh typing
error is gone here and let's apply this
validator now to email
and see if we get the uh error we are
looking at
so
now let's go back to login component
apply this to
this one
and i we will take hashtag email
equals to
ng
model right so we have seen how to get
the access to this particular control
and now here we can do div
email dot errors and pipe json
let's go ahead and verify the code now
we have this
uh
top type test at the rate g
mail.com
let's see
ah there are some errors cannot assign
value
variable email template variables are
read only where i'm trying to assign a
value
email dot errors in email
that's probably
the name
after let's stop the server and start
again
probably i changed some variable and it
crashed
let's verify it again so i'm saying
email control because probably i said
email that's why it crashed but it's
verified
yeah so now we have null so it means
it's valid so i'll say test.gmail.com
and you can see invalid email true so we
have the validation error available here
and what we just did is we added our
custom validation to this particular
control by using a
custom directive
and now you can just go ahead and add
this validator it is reusable right so
you can actually go ahead and use this
custom directive anywhere you want
within your application
and this is it from the custom
writing your
own
validator using custom directive
now we are back to the routing part
remember i said we will create some
views using template treatment forms and
then we will be back to the routing and
the place where we left is router
service
so let's uh go ahead and see an example
how we can actually use router service
and a small example
so far we have done some navigation
right so we have used router link to
navigate to whatever view we want to
but in case we want to do it
programmatically it means let's say we
have some logic and
after that logic is satisfied we want to
navigate to some other view
that's why we created login component so
remember we just added this alert login
successful
but in case
uh i want to
redirect to rooms after we are logged in
how we will do that
so angular has a service called router
so let's put in c
we'll use
route
which is type of router
and it comes from angular slash router
so you can see this and now let's see
how we can navigate there are many
methods uh which this particular api
exposes so i'll say route dot and we
will be using navigate so in navigate
you can just pass the url where you want
to redirect so i can say i want to
redirect to rooms
and the thing is you can pass the
commands as well so for example if i
want to say room slash ad i can do
something like this let's try this out
we already have a url called room slash
ad
so
let's
provide admin ad
gmail.com
and this will be admin right so
and let's click on login and you can see
we are redirect to room redirected to
rooms slash ad so this is how you can do
it programmatically there is something
called there is another api called
navigate by url as well so you can see
uh in this case you can just give the
url so you can say it will be
slash
rooms
slash add
and let's see
let's uh remove this and
go back to the login page
and
now we are back to the room
so only thing is the difference is
uh between navigate by url navigators
navigate by url will
take the list of commands so whatever
you are passing inside so let's go back
to navigate
so here we are passing the list of
actions or you can say commands and
navigate method will create the entire
url for us if we navigate by url we are
saying okay this is the url just go
ahead and redirect so that's the
difference so this is about cloud
service we will see more about router
service soon but not right now
in this video we are going to talk about
feature module and routing
so
remember
so far
remember so far what we have done is we
have we have single module right so we
just have an app module which is
available inside our code
and that's it
but
over the period of time the app module
becomes like a huge
code base that it really becomes
difficult to manage it
so that's where the concept of feature
module comes in so feature module
the concept of feature module is you
should actually wrap all the features
together in a single module for example
if they are related sorry i just missed
that part so if they are related so for
example rooms so what i can do is i can
create another module
move everything related to rooms inside
that particular component sorry
inside that particular module the
advantage is in case i want to use that
particular module or some logic from
that particular module it becomes really
easy to share those things
also
in future in case we want to lazy load
that particular module which
is the uh which we will talk about lazy
load so don't worry about what lazy load
is right now but in case you want to do
that do that it really becomes easy
to achieve lazy loading if you already
have feature module i always suggest
whenever you are working on some
application try to create your
components and wrap it together
using feature modules or you can save
modules
there is also concept called scam which
is a single component and module which
prefers that you should have for every
component you should have a module
that's also a very uh good thing to do i
mean in case you have a large
application with like thousands of
component uh where it really becomes
difficult to difficult to actually see
where this particular component will be
used and then we ended up we end up with
like huge code base uh with a single
module with
thousands of components inside it and
all the components being loaded by
default increasing your entire
application size
so always start with like think about
okay if i'm creating this component
where this component should fit in does
it need a module separate module just go
ahead and do that in case it is already
related to some feature just go ahead
and add that particular component to
that feature module so let's start by
actually breaking our rooms
uh component because remember in most of
the application let's say uh if you get
assigned to any project
this may be a problem that
some feature is already created but
everything is registered inside a module
so the first way i'm going to show you
is how you will fix
the scenario where you have some such
concept right where
uh you have uh everything available into
app module
for this example are rooms right now
everything related to rooms is actually
registered into app module we can
actually remove that feature and create
another module for rooms right so let's
go ahead and start with that
so here we already have rooms folder
what i need to do is i need to create a
module how you will create a module is
nggm4 module and then just give rooms
and i will pass a flat equals to
true otherwise it will create a folder
which we don't want to i we want that
room's model should be available here so
we got our rooms model
uh we want also wanted one more thing we
wanted uh that rooms should have a
routing module as well similar to what
we have outside here app routing module
so we want that rooms also should have a
routing module and we will say flat true
and
let's see
[Music]
so there is a flag to actually overwrite
i'm just looking for that particular
flag force
so i'll say i have an f1 force so it
will overwrite the existing file so we
will have
uh
rooms module
routing flat true
unknown option
okay sorry this is like an effect flat
equals to true and then we have iphone
force
merge conflicted rooms module
let's see
okay let's delete this file right now
[Music]
okay so what we got there's rooms module
and room sorting model similar to app
module and apps app routing marketing
but remember this
uh
we will talk about this part for child
let's uh hold on
first let's talk about this room's
module now what we have to do is we have
to move everything related to rooms out
of app module to here so let's go ahead
and do that
so we have rooms rooms list component
let's do that
and
what else we have
my employee rooms booking room set
so
[Music]
and let's remove this code so you can
see just uh by creating another
component i have removed like almost 10
lines of code from here
from your app module so
now this is step one so now let's go
ahead and
add this all this here
so all these components are added here
and our application will break right now
so let's go ahead and see what is
happening here
and let's try to click on add room
rooms you can see nothing is getting
loaded and
you may get some exceptions so
a native element but
it's okay
but you can see i mean there's nothing
which is getting loaded because of
course uh
there is a lot of errors a lot of
compilation errors so let's go ahead and
try to fix those i mean don't the one
thing about refactoring i'm also trying
to show you how to refactor the code
base you are uh
probably i mean it's it's a good thing
you should always re uh revisit your
code base so i'm just trying to figure
trying to tell you how you generally i
generally uh go ahead and refactor the
code base so now we have a lot of errors
don't be scared whenever you see such
errors don't be scared i mean it's
absolutely fine
uh that's the first step if you are
scared i mean of course you will end up
like you will roll back the code base
and you will be in the same mess as you
were earlier
so now let's uh
kind of
close this and
let's try to see uh what what needs to
be done more right
so we have moved all the components here
now
right so we
we have all the components here and now
as we have created just a feature module
what we can do is we can actually go
ahead and register
this rooms module into
this
app model so what we have done is we
have removed some code from your app
module and then we created another
module and as we want that module to be
available everywhere we have just
registered that module here rims module
so let's go ahead and compile this code
again
so what you can do is you can actually
put some of your reusable code inside a
module and then you can just
use that module wherever you want to in
case let's say you have a component to
show a table right
and what you what you can do is that's
what that table is getting used like
at many places so what you can do is you
can just create that particular
component with table and a module and
then you can just use that module
everywhere where you want to now let's
go ahead and see the errors so there are
multiple errors so it says roomsat
component no directive on for ng form
now once you create a module there are
few things which we have to
which there are few things which you
have to keep in your mind
now this
components
which are available here they are using
some specific
modules
for example uh this error
sorry this error which says okay this is
no directive found with export as ng
form it means we are using form
functionality here but that form
functionality is not available how you
can do that we have already learned
about it so what we have to do is we
have to go ahead and add into imports we
have to say forms
module
so you will see
each error gone one by one so now
the first error will be gone so it will
be recompiled failed to recompile and
now there is another error it says this
header component is not part of this
module
now we are using this header component
in rooms component.html this is uh
this is really really good use case for
a reusable module
as rooms component sorry this header
component can be used at multiple places
we cannot just register in inside the
inside the main module app module
otherwise it won't be available for
other modules which which is created for
example rooms so what we can do is in
such cases the same example which i was
giving a table a reusable table which
can be used so here
what i can do is i can just go to header
i can say open an integrated terminal
and create a module here so i'll say
this is a header
hyphen fn
flat but i don't need a routing module
here because this is a just a usable
component it does not contain any
component which can be accessed by route
the reason i created inside room is
there are components which can be
accessed by route by urls so we will
also move the logic related to the urls
inside its own module to avoid writing
so much code inside your
inside your app module
now let's register this header component
here
now once you do this
you will start getting an error so the
thing is
one component can be registered as part
of only one module remember this keep in
your mind
so
here uh this header component is
actually uh if i if i do this
if i do
[Music]
here i register the center module
and let's add
the setter module
here
so
the thing is your imports
or your modules can be
added into multiple places right and
that's the whole
that's the whole uh
uh you can say the that's the whole core
about creating the module so you can
actually reuse things around your entire
application into multiple modules
but i cannot register or i can i cannot
actually uh import sorry i cannot
register a component multiple times so
if i have added declarations uh header
component into declarations are here i
cannot add it into here so
if i do this that's an error so here
let's remove this over
header component from
here right so header component is
removed
and now it's only available at one place
but let's see
if it fixes our issues so
let me just compile compile it again
it will not so the answer is it will not
so we'll see how how we can fix that so
now
let's let let it give us the error first
now it says okay this header is still
not found the reason being
in case
if you are using a component outside of
its model
so this header component is actually
used inside rooms module
so you have to also add it to exports
it means
i am exporting this particular component
so anyone outside this module can also
access to this particular element
remember this whenever you are creating
reusable components this is the thing
which you should do
you should always add it to exports
array so it can be accessed outside
otherwise it won't be available now
let's go ahead and see our output
and it is compiled successfully
so
let's see
how if our application works
rooms
ad rooms worked employee worked
login
worked
let's try uh the functionality
okay just looks like
something is broken but
it says uh includes test this is ah
right so it is it is giving us error
uh what was the
admin it was admin right
and now it works as well so
so entire functionality is working again
what what we have done here is we have
created
we created actually two feature module
one to show
the scenario where we will not have any
routing module we will have a component
which is reusable and can be accessed
outside of its own module so it's not
going to be used inside its own module
here right header module and then we saw
another example where we created a rooms
module we moved all the components which
is related to rooms module inside its
own module
and that's it and then we also added the
modules which is uh which is required
here for example it was using the forms
functionality it was using the header
component so we added both the modules
to make it successful always read the
errors remember whenever you are
refactoring the code always read the
errors what is that all the errors are
readable so you know what is going wrong
now let's go ahead and let's move ahead
and also try to move this
rooms related routes to its own module
so we already have this module available
we'll remove it from here so you can see
how easily we are able to remove lot of
code from our app module and app routing
module
and we will add it here
so
[Music]
rooms component room sat component and
booking component
once done
you will see a difference that in app
routing module we always use for root
and whenever you have a feature module
with routing it will always use for
feature sorry for change the reason
being uh your for root is like it's a
singleton service so you are adding all
the routes inside a singleton service so
we are saying for root it means this
this is these are the routes which are
available globally and all
other routes is part of your feature
modules they can be accessed from within
your feature or once they are registered
so
here we have three routes which are
available and the way it works is
routing module is actually registered
here you can see
imports in uh we have added a rooms
routing module so now
this routes are also registered but
there is a catch there is a catch let's
see
we have added rooms module here let's go
ahead and see if our application works
it will break so just to give you an
idea so you can see if i try to access
employee it works if i try to access
rooms it says resource you are looking
for does not exist same for ad room
what's happening here the routes exist
yes but why we are getting 404 let's go
back revisit the basics remember when we
were talking about this routines right
we talked about this
wildcard we said it will go
sequentially from top to bottom
let's go to app module and figure try to
figure out why it is happening so all
the import statements are also executed
sequentially so you you can see it goes
to app routing module first
and go to approaching module it says
okay employee login
this default route and then start it
says okay the any other route is not
available here right now
so how to fix that so in case you have
feature modules with its own routing you
should always register this
uh
you should always register your feature
modules before app routing mode just
remember this
because of course when you start
learning angular you will get this error
you will get okay why my routes are not
working that this is this might be one
of the reason that you are getting four
or four pages
let's go back and that's it everything
back to normal
and your functionality works so this is
how you can create a feature module and
uh
and also how you can create a feature
model with its own routing module so
remember right now what we did is
right now what we did we just did is we
refactored a code base to make it more
uh
what you can say flexible more uh
extends extensible so in case anyone
wants to actually make changes to
related rooms they know that they have
to just make changes inside this
particular folder that's the whole idea
about creating this small small feature
modules right people know where to make
the changes they don't have to touch the
entire application they don't have to
make changes into app model every time
that's a really bad structure in case
you get into some code base where
everything is added into a module of
course you should the first thing which
you should suggest is to refactor that
code base by splitting them into
different feature modules
the advantage is of course the code is
more maintainable and we can also do
lazy loading which we will see later on
now in this video we will see how we can
do nested routes and we can
load child routes so let's see let's try
to understand what
we mean by nested routes right so we can
load another route inside an existing
route that's nested routes and it can
have some child routes as well so let's
go ahead and try to figure out a
scenario
so here
so you have this book room right right
uh so right now if i click on this book
room it is going to another
view altogether right so all the
existing view is lost so what in case
you get an requirement that
but in case you get a requirement that
when you click on this book room
the
another view should open below this
particular table
so you can just fill out all the details
and complete the booking you don't have
the form of course we will add the form
later on but let's try to fix uh let's
try to build this scenario using the
nested routes concept
let's go back to our code let's see
where the routing exists so our routes
are here so what we want is this room
slash ad should be loaded on
below sorry not on but below this
particular table
so we can do that
so here you can use something known as
children property
and you can move
this route inside this children property
so this is step one
once we did we have done this let's see
right still i mean it is getting loaded
on another view
because we are referring uh to the wrong
view all together so this is the path
which we needed room slash id
now let's go ahead and see here you can
see uh when you click on this it goes to
this room slash one but it says the
resource you are looking for does not
exist
this is
strange because we said room slash id
is already configured
and
it should go to
rooms booking component but this is not
happening
so now we have to do one more thing we
have to go ahead and tell where to
actually load this room's booking
component by placing another router
outlet
so let's see how it behaves now so let's
go to rooms
let's click on blue chrome
let's see what's
different here okay so now as we are
already inside rooms so we have to
remove this
okay let's see rooms
so because it's child right so it's uh
it's child route so we have to
okay let's remove this slash as well
now let's click on rooms and click on
book room you can see this component is
actually getting loaded here let's uh
put some
more content here so i'll say
booking
this is
edge
room
so it is visible right so you can see so
booking room 2 click on any room you
want to book and it will be displayed
just below the table wherever you have
placed the router outlet so remember to
do two steps which is needed in case you
want to do nested routing so why it is
nested routing because you can see this
is already available inside a router
outlet and then we are loading another
router outlet here so let's try to
understand this uh template right
so here
we can see
this is our first uh
app
and then you have the sidebar
and we have first outer outlet here and
then
there is another router outlet which is
available here so it is nested right so
what you brought so understand the
nesting needs one thing same thing again
available inside same thing so router
outlet again available inside router
outlet that's nesting and
as it is getting loaded as part of this
existing component it's
part as it is treated as a children
routes so you can see this is children
and then we are saying when we click on
room slash id so we don't have to
specify room slash id again here we can
just say colon room id
and
that particular component will be loaded
wherever we place
this particular outer outlet so if i
place it
above
here
so you can see uh
booking room this one
right so whatever room you select it
will be loaded here so this is how you
can achieve nested routes and
children routes you can play more i mean
you can actually uh
experiment
by creating more
child component and see how we can load
them you can you can load multiple so
it's not like only this will be loaded
you can actually add multiple here i can
just do uh
i can
just test routine
i can also move this one
inside this array
and i can remove this and i can say
slash so now it is also
child component so the only thing is
actually add room is available here so
if you try to click so let's go to room
and let's click on add room you can see
let's
let's do it on this one
let me just do this and here
on rooms component.html on add room this
one right so on add room let's do
router link
so we'll say this is router link
and i'll say this is
room
slash ad let's verify if it is correct
rooms okay it's rooms
slash ad
and let's try to add a room let's click
on add room and it says room slash room
slash ad
the reason being because we are already
here okay
let's see
as we are already inside child probably
that is the issue and here it is all
right so we click on add room and
booking uh
and what is there inside room ad
room set
okay this is the form
room slash at where is this form gone
[Music]
okay this is good that we came across
this issue uh
here
so uh the thing is
right now uh if i say room slash room id
or i say room slash ad
this
slash
ad can also
match to this
the reason being it uh
it's like it just uses that okay i i can
say room slash any place holder and this
will be called so to avoid this just
make sure that uh you place at this uh
this before and then you have dynamic
crowds after this
that's a really good thing that we
actually uh came across this issue
because this is also one of the uh
reason where a lot of developers get
stuck so what we have done is we are
saying that ad is first so it will match
to add but if we place this one i mean
it's a wild card right i mean it's a
it's a placeholder so if i keep this
first it will also match to room slash
ad
and it will always go to the booking
number and that was uh the thing now if
i click on book room you can see i'm
getting going to this if i click on add
room i can see the add room
functionality available on this view
itself so this is how you can play
around with multiple children components
you can add a number of children
components in case you want to display
them on the same view you don't want to
redirect to somewhere else so this is
how you can do it and uh let's move
so far we have seen how
angular routing uh can help us to create
several routes
and in last video we also learned about
how you can create modules
so
as discussed modules are something which
where we can actually wrap all the
functionality related to a feature into
its own module right in its own angular
model
but
once your application grows there will
be many modules
and so the application size will grow as
well
and
one point of time you will probably end
up with huge
main bundle size so
this is where we will talk a little bit
about uh the
build which we create for deploying on
protection
so so far we have been using a command
called ng serp which is used to run this
application locally and debug it
now we will use another command to
create a production build which can be
used to deploy your application on
production
so to do that i am going to run a
command called ng build
and
you can say c equals to production
now what this command will do is it will
build your application
with production mode so
this this uh whatever
files which will be generated
it will be
minified
and it can be deployed on your
protection server so
let's see it will take some time to
generate the bundles
you will get several files and we will
talk about one main
file which is called main.js
so here you can see uh you have main.js
which is around
476.91 kb
right now our application is really
small i mean
it
contains an app modules a few components
and one module
consider it like a huge enterprise
application
consider uh now in future you will end
up with a huge enterprise application
here you will probably have hundreds of
modules you will have thousands of
components
even not that big let's say
in range of hundred right so this bundle
size will increase and this main.js is
the file size which will be
served to your customers
now 476 kb is it's okay right i mean it
can be it will be pretty fast on your 4g
network
but what in case you have this bundle
size in mbs and that's where the problem
comes in now you will have a big bundle
which needs to be loaded whenever your
your user comes to your portal
so they have to wait they have to wait
based on uh how much speed they have
right how much the bandwidth
they have
what you can do is using angular mod
angular router you can also split the
code
if let's go back to our application
so if you see here
the functionality related rooms
do we think i mean this room's
functionality should be available by
default to the users the answer is no
right i mean of course
we we have to actually go ahead and add
few forms more functionality to our
to our login screen and
that will be the first page which will
be served to our customer so without
login they cannot even use this room's
functionality even employee
functionality so it doesn't make sense
to actually give all this
views with your main.js bundles i mean
all this code is something which is
useless at that time probably your user
just comes to login page and goes away
and
this this code will never be used
so this is where actually angular router
can use angular router can help us to
split our code based on several routes
it has some advantages of course
this code will never be downloaded in
case your user never comes to this
particular route and once the user
visits this
it will be once it will be downloaded
only once so it's not like i mean if i
just uh go to another route this all
code will be um
removed and then we will be added back
once we come back to this route that
that's that's a no so
but there are few requirements which you
have to fulfill to
achieve this
what are those requirements
remember whenever you are trying to
create a module as lazy loaded model or
you are trying to separate that code
from all entire application the first
thing which you should think about is
what are the things which needs to be
reusable if it's reusable probably you
have you have to rethink about your
architecture let's say there is one
component which is reusable from rooms
in that case i will remove that
from the rooms component i will put it
somewhere else which is with where we
will put reusables so i can use it
inside rooms and other places as well
never do something like this where you
have rooms module lazy loaded and then
you are there is one component which is
being used somewhere else
in that case you have to go and
import rooms module in that particular
module which will fail the purpose of
having a lazy loaded model so a lazy
loaded model should be isolated i mean
it should not talk to any anyone else it
should know everything about itself and
once loaded it should be able to perform
all the functionality
and your application should not know
about this module until unless it is
requested so here we are talking about
this code will be downloaded based on
user interaction so once i interact with
this rooms module
or rooms url
the code will be downloaded so let's go
ahead and see what are the prerequisite
so first thing is
now as we have
chosen the rooms module to be lazy
loaded the first thing is no one should
know about
rooms modding
remember last time what we did is we
created a feature module for
this
room's module and then we added here so
first step remove this
now no one knows about rooms module and
it should not work right i mean if i
recompile the application you can see
there are a lot of errors because of
course the list uh this room's module is
gone i mean no one knows about rooms
module anymore
now what's next
now
here in app routing module we will add
one part
remember we have already fulfilled one
particular step
we have already isolated everything
related to rooms module in its own
module so we are not sharing anything
outside rooms module
right so just keep that in mind keep
that in your mind whenever you are
designing uh
this lazy loaded module for your
application just keep this in mind
here i'll
say path rooms you might be wondering
why we are doing here and we'll talk
about it so
rooms and then you have to use a
property called load children
and here we'll say
we will be using an import statement so
i'll just let me just talk about this
and
okay something is missing
what
oh
okay
so what we have done here is we have
added a path rooms and we are saying
load children
and then some import statement we'll
come back to this let's go back and make
some changes to your room's routing
module here we will remove this path we
need to book it put it blank
and let's go back let's go back and talk
about this
so now we rather actually directly
importing
the rooms module into app module so
what we are doing is we are trying to
lazy load it so
uh the lazy loading means
now
we are providing the path inside the
routes array because of course this is
your you remember app routing module
right the main routing module
so now my app routing module knows that
there is a path called rooms and
whenever
someone tries to access rooms what i
have to do is i have to go ahead and
download this particular rooms module
remember this is the module which we
created earlier
so i have to go ahead and download this
rooms module which has a angular module
called rooms model right so this is
this import statement is something which
is native into a to the browser so at
runtime at runtime remember i'm not
talking about the compile time compile
time is when we are actually building
our port right
at runtime
it will whenever we click on rooms it
will go ahead and download all the code
which is related which is available here
inside this rooms folder
and make sure that you are not using
anything outside rooms module right
so here
we have we got we
did this we can do some similar thing
for employee that's something which you
can try what you can do is you can
create another module for employee and
then try to lazy load that module you
have to just
create a routing module and then you
have to
create a angular module that's and those
are two things which we have to do and
then you can in similar fashion you can
download the employee module
in case you are not able to do it
just
raise an issue and we will help you
now this is also done we have removed
this because
why we left this path blank because we
have already defined this path here so
when this particular module gets
downloaded and it goes to its default
url i mean the first url so it will
check okay this is the component which i
have to download so rooms is my default
route i don't have to do anything and
then we have the children which we
already configured last time
now let's go ahead and verify the
application so
two things we will verify but there are
two things which will verify uh first
let's verify the build
let's see if there is any difference in
the files which got generated earlier
right so earlier we got four files
now let's see after making these changes
how many files we get
and how it impacts uh impacts the bundle
size as well
so you can see it says there are some
initial chunk files and there is
something which is lazy chunk files so
you can see uh now we have another
module which is of
11 kb
and it will be downloaded separately
once i interact with that particular
router let's go ahead and run the
application now
and meanwhile let's see if we are
missing something here
and okay
so let's verify how if our lazy loaded
model or lazy loaded functionality which
we did is working fine or not how we can
verify
of course
in build we can see there was a
different uh bundle altogether but we
can actually verify it from here so you
can go to the sources you can go to
webpack. and go to src app
and here
you can see okay so here we can you can
see we are actually using room service
somewhere so
one file is already downloaded
because we are using it outside probably
uh in
app module or somewhere else
but
let's see the main functionality
let's click on rooms
now you can see all the files apart from
services are downloaded as i clicked on
this rooms and now i can just go ahead
and visit any other url that won't
impact this files so this is how you can
verify what are the files which are
downloaded
uh lazily right i mean apart from
services everything is being resoluted
right now and it will be available as
well inside your network tab so let me
just remove it and let's refresh let's
go to employees and let's refresh this
page
and let's clear
and let's click on rooms so you can see
src app rooms rooms module so this is
something which which is telling you
that okay this all the file
this code is actually being loaded
separately
and
when is happening when i click on rooms
so this is how lazy loading works and
you should
as i said there are there are many
things which goes behind whether this
module needs to be lazy loaded or not
few things we already discussed one more
thing which we need to uh
make sure is you should i mean it's not
like in us if this is a functionality
which is available we should go and down
sorry we should go ahead and implement
lazy loading for all the models it's not
lazy loading lazy loading is useful for
the modules which are really big and
which you think won't be
used frequently by your
end users remember not developers
developers can just go ahead and add
anything right uh because it's uh it's
based on the business requirement i
would say so whenever you are
implementing this you should go ahead
and
ask business that okay
what will be the frequency how many uh
users we are expecting this views to be
used by
it's okay in case you don't get don't
implement lazy loading at first that's
absolutely fine i mean it's okay because
you don't know your user behavior right
as you know your user behavior you can
actually go and implement lazy loading
but
at least have feature modules in place
uh and there will be of course there
will be many modules which you will
realize even while developing that okay
these modules are not probably going to
be used
more frequently for example let's say
you have
uh
a profile section how many times you do
you think uh your users are actually
going to use the profile section
probably
once in a month that's rare right i mean
in case they have to update some mobile
number or email id which is really rare
so those are the modules or let's say
you have some kind of reports
which will be uh let's say which are
month and report so you know okay this
this reports will be actually
will be downloaded only in a month only
once in a month so you know that okay
this frequency will be really less so
you can go ahead and configure is a
loaded model so it's like
whenever you are thinking about lazy
loaded modules it's your
developer mind as well as the business
needs or the business uh idea which you
get how frequently it is going to be
used so keep all those things in mind
before you go ahead and implement lazy
loading mode lazy loaded module for your
code base
so this is it from lazy loaded model try
it for employee if you don't if you're
not able to do it just let us know
now we are supposed to actually uh now
we are going to actually discuss about
round cuts but we will hold this topic
for
a few few more things which uh we will
cover and then we'll come back to the
route cuts
so i'm going to show you a few more
things related to the lazy loading uh
right now what we have done is we
already had an angular model right we
what we did is the approach we took is
we created the all components we created
everything inside rooms and then we
added a module then we did a refactor
and
finally we ended up module which
was lazy loaded
what in case
i want to start from the day one i have
the requirement
right so i spoke to my business team
they're saying okay this small this is
something probably won't be used a lot
but we need this functionality or
probably this functionality is really
huge and in case if we include it in
your main module it is going to bump
our bundle size so you decide that okay
we will lazy load it to so uh the bundle
size is less and it will be loaded
faster for the users
and you want to start with lazy loaded
module from the daven
let's try to do that
so what we will do is we will uh
create a module so let's create a
booking model
which will show all the bookings which
can be done which will be done using the
rooms module right so this is
rooms booking but i mean it's a great
module so
this will be
used to see all the previous bookings
which are made
and we need to download to make sure
that it is lazy loaded so what you can
do is there is a command to do that so i
can say ngg
module
i can say a model name so i can say
booking which is my module name i can
say hyphen f and route is equals to
booking
and hyphen iphone routing
uh to make sure that there is a routing
module which is created so let's go
ahead and
enter
and see what happens
uh module option required
module option required when
iphone module
is equals to booking
let's see or i i think let's see
so specified module booking does not
exist it's okay
sorry
okay so uh
there was a problem with the command now
uh let me just talk about this
particular module so
what this module is so it is asking me
where should i go ahead and register
this particular lazy loaded module right
now we have two models rooms module as
well as app module
so
we have to provide the module where we
need to go ahead and create a lazy
loaded route like this
so right now what i need is i want to
create it with app with app module so
uh it will now go ahead and create you
can see
uh it created a path here so you can see
booking load children import booking
module and booking module so if i go to
booking module now you will find several
things you will find a module you will
find a component and all the related
files as well as booking routing module
as well
all this
by using a single command
so you don't have to go ahead and do
whatever we did earlier right so go
ahead and create component then add a
module and then do this no you can just
do it with a single command also i'll
show one more command which we can use
so let's say
is there any other
screen we want to create
okay so let's say uh i want to create a
filter
uh functionality right so where we can
search for like search functionality so
we we want to search for rooms
and we what we want to do is we want to
create a module first and then we want
to add components and we don't want to
lazy load this
remember
this one we wanted to resolute this one
and we don't want to let's load so what
we can do is we can create first the
module so i can say ngm
and i can say search
so it will create a module first
right so now we have the module now i
want to create a component so what i can
do is i can just go ahead and say
nggc
search
now this will create a search component
inside the search folder so you can see
uh it created the files inside search
folder as well as one more thing
search module will register this search
component
so this is all all done automatically
you don't have to do it manually
the only reason i went through or
i went through the uh
the path where i did everything manually
is probably you won't be writing
uh the code from the scratch in your
application you should know how to
refactor the application or how to
revisit the code right i mean what's
wrong what's right in your code base
otherwise you will be lost
so that was the whole purpose of
actually doing that exercise
in case you are creating new code this
is the way you should be doing it so
first create the module and then create
the component in case it needs to be
lazy loaded from the day one just go
ahead and reuse this command and that's
it and you can define which on which
module i want to actually register it i
could have given it as rooms as well
remember this so
in case i am going to actually access
this from the rooms module i can do that
so i can actually lazy load any other
module inside rooms that's also possible
probably we'll try one exercise with
that as well
now we have our booking module and this
is loaded as well so now i can just go
ahead and
add
navigation
and
we can say this is
bookings
and
what was the route booking
and let's
revisit
the application
and you uh
let's go to sources
pack
dot slash src app and you can see we
don't have anything related to booking
let's click on bookings and now you have
everything related to bookie
so this is another command another way
to do it and we will of course go ahead
and add a form
where we can see all the bookings in um
in upcoming uh videos right so we will
be using angular material table we will
show you an example of how you can
utilize angular material table to do
that
so yep that's uh that's another way to
implement lazy loading
well
so when discussing
dependency injection if you remember we
left one thing i mean we said we will be
discussing about it once we go through
the lazy loading so let's go back and uh
do that so
we discussed about provider types we saw
a route right we said okay in case it is
root you can actually go ahead and add
use this particular
sorry you can use that particular
service as a singleton service across
your application
now
we will talk about the other type of
provider type which is aiming now you
might be wondering where this any is
useful so let's go ahead and talk a
little bit about it there are there are
multiple use cases
and i wrote a blog post on the same so
i'll be trying to cover the same example
here but let's figure out what
is the use case for using any
so here let's say we have a service like
we uh what we will do is we'll create a
service we will call it as a config
service
we already have app config so let's
create another service and
for that
i will be creating a services folder so
this is like a reusable kind of services
and let's
open the integrated terminal
snggs
and i'll say this is uh what should we
name it
config let's call it as config service i
don't i don't think so we have anything
called config service as of now
and
here so we have this config service
let's go ahead and change this to any
and
one thing which we will be doing is we
will be uh let's do
uh console.log
and let's see how many instances get
gets created so we know that whenever a
service
is configured with provided in root we
get a singleton instance and we in case
you want to create multiple instances
you can just go ahead and use providers
property as we saw earlier
now using provided in any let's see uh
what happens so i am going to use this
service inside the rooms component
we will just inject it
as of now
and so this is concrete config
service which is type of config service
and let's go back to the application
let's see if
uh it is compiled here
now let's go to console and this is
where we will we want to see an
interesting thing
so here uh
let's use config service services at one
place other or is it okay
okay let's do ctrl f5
let's click on rooms
and here i
see
let's see we have this
room service initialized conflict
service right
so
[Music]
config surface initialized
and we will be using the same config
service inside app component the same
way i mean we are not going to use it
we'll just inject it and see how it
behaves
constructor
this is this
and let's see if we have any other
module
that's okay okay these two modules are
enough more than enough
let's go back to the ui
and now you can see uh here it says
config service initialized so we have
config service dot ts line number nine
it means one instance of config service
is created right now
and we cannot see any other instances
which are available
ah okay
go to one more thing i'll just clear
this
and let's see the messages
so we have this config service
initialized so
now
[Music]
why actually uh moved away from rooms
because on click of rooms i mean it is
supposed to create another instance so
let me tell you why
we have not done providers property we
have not added to provide this property
why should it create a new instance so
let's go back go ahead and talk about
how any place an important role here so
we have config service initialized here
let's go ahead and click on rooms
and you will find that
here config service is initialized again
one instance
two instance
by so
so when we say con
this providers
so when we use this providers at
provider in providing as any
it will create
one instance for the entire
code base where there is nothing lazy
loaded right
and it will create separate instances
for each
lazy loaded module in case it is getting
used for example it is getting used in
rooms so it will create another instance
for rooms module
if we go ahead and inject it
inside let's say
we have another model called header
if we inject another instance in header
it will not create an another instance
because
it is not lazy loaded but let's go ahead
and inject let's try to inject it and
see right so how many instances we end
up with
so here uh we have
copy this
header
so as as per expectation header
should use the global instance which is
available which will be created
and we'll create one for booking because
booking is lazy loaded so
let's see
now rooms
has so one is global instance config
service initialize then rooms has
another instance config services
initialize two and now let's click on
bookings and once we click on bookings
booking has another config service
initialize so we have how many instances
right now three instances
two
used two separate instances used by two
different lazy loaded modules as we said
provided is any and one which is global
instance which is available everywhere
what can be the good use case so let me
just uh give you an interesting use case
which actually wrote a blog post on and
it is great it is actually used in uh
one of my friends uh book which was
launched let me just stop uh so uh which
was launched last year
yeah it was launched last year uh it is
a book based on angular iv so it's it's
a little bit advanced right now you are
on basic so i'll say i suggest once you
have the basic idea or little bit idea
about angular how it works then just go
ahead and purchase that book so it's on
angular iv which i actually profit so
let's go ahead and talk about the use
case which i was talking about
so here what we will do is i'll create
another
so we already have service and i will
create one
injection token
and say this is uh
config
or
let's call it as route config
so this interface uh this will be the
interface and we'll say this is export
interface
without config
and we'll say this is a
[Music]
title
this type of stream so we have just
single property
and let's
create an injection token so let's say
this is
cloud
config
dot service
dot is
and here we'll say export
const
without config
which is equals to new injection token
which will be type of
this particular interface
and i'll say this is a
route config
and
what is this route configure first of
that is being used as a type
name section token which is type of
route config
okay let's see what i'm missing here
ah
this route config
which is
looks like uh this is something which
already exists in angular
core
and
let's import this import
the interface
dot slash without config
and
we'll say this is the interface which
you are looking at and
it should be fine
config
token
great so we created our token and now we
have an interface let's see how actually
it helps in case we are using provided
it provided in as any
i'll use this route config token
in app module we know how to do that
right so we already have an example here
so i'll just add provide
and we will use value
which will be
let's go back to our module
and we'll say which will be
having
so we know the type so we have this
title
which is home
[Music]
and we will be using this route config
token we let's go ahead and use it
inside the config service
so now we know how to do that so we'll
say inject
and
config
cloud config token
real quick
config
token
and out something right so we'll just
import this as well
and let's print the value
i think this is our extra
console.log
this is not conflict token let's verify
this functionality as of now so we have
this
uh service which is
now injected in so what we did is we
created a config service and we created
a token we uh provided a value to this
particular token we said title is home
and then
we use this particular thing in service
and we have
tried we just
we are just actually
logging the top token value
let's see what we have done so far and
there is something unexpected
which is app model.ts line number 68.
let's see probably x just
mr common
then
let's go ahead and see so what we have
here so
config service right now has few uh
few instances right so we have this
config service initialize and then we
have title home
you must be wondering what we have done
i mean this is something which we have
already done again why i am covering
this this thing again i mean and we know
how to use injection tokens but there is
a difference when you use
provided in any
here
let's try to
pass
this value
to rooms module
and what we will do is
providers
and i'll set our title is room
so remember right now we are saying
there's another
we are just changing the title let's go
ahead and see so we have title available
as home available here right let's go to
room
and
let's see what is the title available
right now
so we have title as room
it changed
let's switch back to any and let me show
you what will be the value in case we
use any sorry we use root
so let's go back to the rooms sorry
config surface
and change this
to root
and
here it is so you will still get
for rooms even for rooms we are getting
the value as home
let me show you i mean probably let's
move into uh another module so we can
see the value so we have this home of
course which makes sense click on rooms
we will still end up with
home
why so
because when we say
root it's a singleton instance which
will be available when we are saying any
it will create a new instance for that
particular service
so we ended up with the new value which
we registered into the module otherwise
we will just get the previous value as
which was
added into app module remember this this
is a really interesting uh
interesting thing which landed in
angular 9 and uh it's really useful so a
lot of developers don't know this
functionality which is available but can
be can be really useful in case you want
to actually go ahead and
pass some other configuration
which is which or you want to overwrite
some configuration inside any of your
lazy loaded module very interesting use
case so
as i said my friend has also covered it
in very much detailed way in his book
and you can also go through that use
case as well
so this is it about any and i'll just
change back to any because this that was
the purpose of having this particular
service
and we are done so now we will end up
with whenever we click on rooms we will
end up with configuration as title room
you can pass any configuration for
separate or you can just override the
configuration for your lazy loaded
module using in so uh we saw both the
example using just a service how it
behaves and then inject we added
injection token to show you how it
behaves in case we pass an injection
token
let's go ahead and talk about route
cards
so
as per name suggest writes its cards
what what you understand by cards so you
have many type of cards and you might
have seen your in your real time or real
life as well right so let's say
atms they have guards banks they have
guards what they're trying to do
they are trying to secure something of
course in that case it's money
so what route guards do so it means they
these guards are actually trying to
secure route
but how so there are multiple guards
which are available and they do
different stuff
so we will go through one by one and we
will talk about resolve guard at the end
and before we talk about resolve guard
we will
create our booking form finally and we
will fix the date picker issue which we
have uh in our
earlier form right we if you remember we
created our
rooms uh add rooms form and we said okay
this date time doesn't work then we will
be using the angular material date
picker so we will fix that as well
so let's see uh how
route guard behaves but before we go
ahead and talk about how route card
works we need to understand one thing we
need to understand the
routing event
how does your route works
right so we have not seen this we have
seen okay how to configure your route
how to
do your default route how to do your
wildcard route but
in which sequence they are called i mean
what happens when so you click on route
so let's go ahead and talk about that
and to do uh that
we will be
subscribing or we will be using the
router service which we have already
used but
we'll be using some different properties
let's go and see that
so here i'll say private
i'll say this is route
and this is router
now let's call it as a router right that
makes sense
and now on ng on init live cycle look
i'll say this dot
router dot
events
and it's an uh observable so i'll be
subscribing to it and then we'll say
this is event
and here
we'll just do console.log
event
and let's go to our ui
let's see if it's compiled yes it's
compiled and i think that is something
bigger which is available
so let's move on
i can just let me just disable
and let's go to console
and here
we want to
hm
so here you can see
line number 34 so let's go ahead and see
how it starts right so when in this case
the navigation happened if you remember
let me just do this one thing i'll just
remove this and let's go back to
employee right so we have the only route
cards
or route events are blocked
so there are multiple events which gets
fired when you click or
in case a navigation happens
so here you can see it starts from
navigation start and if you see there
are few parameter which your navigation
start has so it has a url it has a
unique id generated for each and every
navigation event which happens
these ids are really helpful in case you
are getting some issue
during navigation a common use case or a
common issue which we generally get
during navigation is
by the time the first navigation gets
completed you are trying to navigate
again so you can only figure that out
based on the id
so
navigation started then
it tries to recognize the
uh route so it says okay now this route
is recognized so i have to uh there are
some states which is uh available so
remember
a snapshot that's part of this you can
see router snaps uh router state
snapshot
so you have url url after redirects
then we get a get guard check start and
this is where the route cards come into
picture so it says okay now i'll be in
go ahead i'll go ahead and check
whatever guards you have implemented so
this is where it will start
then it will say okay now let me go
ahead and activate the child
where we have seen the child's so if you
go to rooms
click on add room so this is child right
so it will go ahead and check if this
child
uh it will go and start activating this
child routes
then activation starts it will say okay
now everything is figured out now i can
go ahead and activate this particular
routing or route
now here all the cards have checked all
guards check have ended so it says okay
now it's fine everything is okay all
guards
said
uh so all all the cards which we have
implemented they are saying it is okay
to allow this particular user to enter
into this particular
route guards check in right so nowadays
when you try to enter into bank or atm
what they do they check your temperature
they try to see if you have any symptoms
right so and then they allow you so
that's where guards check end
then it says okay now let me just
resolve uh this particular route
right so it will it will try to resolve
this particular route where we are
redirecting to room slash at and then it
says okay now this is also fine this all
ended
then it will call activation ended and
then it will say okay now child
activation also ended and
navigation finally it says okay now
everything is fine let me just send the
navigation and uh the last event which
we have is scroll event scroll event is
something which you can use in case
let's say you click on a url and now you
want to scroll your
uh scroll your this horizontal bar right
somewhere or top bottom wherever you
want to you can just go ahead and
subscribe to the scroll even task so
this is
related to this is related to your
router events how they are called in
sequence
and now we will go ahead and talk about
the route cards
while working with router events it is
also possible to listen to a specific
event as we saw there were multiple
events which were getting fired right
but in case i want to let's say
show loader when navigation start and
show up and i mean remove the loader
when navigation ends
how you will be able to do that so we
can actually achieve that by using
something like this so i'll just rewrite
this code or let me just keep it here so
you can refer this
while revisiting the code
and let's try to listen to the specific
event navigation start navigation and
that's it
so we'll say this dot
router dot events
dot
now as we said we need to listen to
specific events so i don't want to go
ahead and
listen to all the events and then filter
out
we will be using rxjs remember little
bit difficult but with some practice you
will figure out how to use rgs
so here i'll be using pipe
and inside pipe i'll be using filter
operator so you
let's see if it is here it is from
alexis and in filter i will say this
event
which is instance of
i'll say navigation start
right so i'm just listening to the
navigation start event and then i can
subscribe
and here
uh let's say console sorry
i'll say this is
navigation start
and we can remove this i think
let's see
and we can say console.log
and now
you can actually write a code here to
show a loader navigation
started
right and then i can just use another
given where i say navigation end
and i'll say navigation completed
let's go ahead and see if it works
right so
let's
inspect
go to console
and
let's go to
[Music]
default route first right so we can just
remove all the comments which we have
and let's click on employee and you can
see navigation started navigation
completed so we are listening to only
this two events so this is how you can
filter out uh the other events in case
you don't want to listen to them so
uh just to give you an idea how you can
actually achieve this as well
now we understand how the routing event
works and how we can listen to specific
events in case you want to so now let's
move on to the route cards so we we
discuss what guards are what route
guards are and let's
see what this different guards do right
so as you know in banks also they are
there are different guards in case there
is a guard who is like standing in front
of your bank there
if there uh there are some lockers or
some
uh yeah some lockers in bank they have
different guard available right to
secure that area so similarly router has
different cards for different
uh areas to secure so let's start with
can activate
and for connectivity we actually have a
very nice
use case already
let me show you
so remember we already have this login
page but is this login page usually
useful the answer is no this is useless
i mean this is like
some uh guard who is standing in front
of bank but he is not checking anyone he
is just letting the everyone go
so
it's pretty useless right so here uh
what we can do is the can activate guard
let's relate to can activate card so can
activate cards
uh guard actually tries to
c
if i'm
sorry if i am as a user
of course at the end as the as a end
user
is
a valid entity
to access
this particular route or not can i
activate can i activate this particular
route that's what can activate is all
about it means
that guard is actually checking
if
no one has fewer right i mean that's
what they're supposed to do in in days
of corona so they're supposed to check
your temperature and everything
so if
you have a few fever they are supposed
to let you go
and the same thing will
uh is
same thing can activate will do for us
here so in case we are logged in we
should be able to access the different
routes which we have in case we are not
logged in we are not supposed to do that
so based on some conditions you can
secure your own
let's go ahead and create cards
how we can do that so i'll just
what we will do is as we are supposed to
write few other cards as well i'll
create a new folder i'll just call it as
guards
and
let's go to terminal and you can see ngg
card
so ngg
and i'll say this is login card as we
are supposed to check if the user is
logged in or not i mean it can be
anything right it can be your scenario
so
we have can activate we will be using
can activate child but we will be using
it for rooms so we will not add this
and can activate we will use it for
another form which we are supposed to
create
and can load we will use this one so we
can select you can select which of these
if router guards you want to implement
one why resolve guard is not there we'll
talk about it don't think about it right
now so we are supposed to we chose two
words which we need to implement can
load we will talk about it later but as
is it is supposed to be part of this
particular file i just added it here
so now
let's see so what we have it's a
interface it's an interface which has a
function called can activate it gives
you some data we will see what we can do
with this particular data
and it returns some
parameters let's talk about this later
on
so here uh by default this route guard
returns true
it means
this is the useless card which we have
so he is just letting everyone go
without checking the fuel
so but let's see how to apply this guard
right at least let's understand how to
actually put that guard in front of the
bank
so
here
in your routing configuration you can
just go to route configuration and you
can choose
what are the different areas which we
want to secure so we want to secure
employee we want to secure booking we
want to secure rooms
right and we don't want to secure login
now if we secure the login
game over right i mean no one will be
able to access login
so here you can use can activate
property
and it's an array it's an array remember
this it means i can just add any number
of cards
so let's say i have a login card i have
a role guard for example there are
different types of roles which are
assigned to access your lockers
right uh as and let's say someone from
admin i i'm not supposed to access the
lockers but someone from the accounting
i am supposed to access the login let's
see access the locker so those are those
are the uh criteria which you can put
you can create another card and just add
it afterwards so here we just have one
so i'll say login card
that's it i'll just apply this to all
the places which we have
which we want you to secure so let's say
this you get a guard you also get a
guard
but as we said
right now everyone will have access to
everything right
now let's go back and change that true
to false
and
here it is
we don't have access to anything
and let's go to login
we should be able to access login
because we said okay this is something
which is not secured as of now i mean
there is no guard in front of login
so
it works
but what in case
i mean
here so it doesn't work for anything
else and even
if i
try to do this will be redirected to
login but you saw right i mean we were
on
employee route i think and then we got
kicked out and there was an empty page
we will see how we can actually dis uh
uh
handle that scenario as well but let's
do first thing first
so what we need to do here is we want to
actually write the code so we want to
write the code so
once we are logged in
and we
or the end user is logged in and it's a
valid user
that particular user should be able to
access the routes so we can redirect to
wherever we want to for example let's
say we will redirect to
brooms right
let's see
let's put that logic first
so in login
what we will do is we will create
another service
i will call this service as login
service
and here i am going to put a
flag
which says is logged in
and which is type of boolean and false
and then i am going to put a method
login
where we will just copy the logic which
we have already available so i'll say
this is
email and password so i'll say
email
which is a string
and
password which is also string but rather
than doing navigate here
right so we'll just keep the navigation
part here and say this dot is logged in
is equal to true so i'm just setting up
flat that okay
this particular user is logged in now
and as this is a singleton instance
everyone using this particular service
will get the latest value for is logged
in you can do it in multiple way do you
want to use uh some behavior subject go
ahead and do that but let's try to keep
it boolean uh as of now
and if this is
uh
not logged in
or we can just do something like this
right so
set this and return this dot is logged
in so if it is not true of course it
will return the default value which is
false
and now let's go back to our login code
and
here
say private
login
which is like login service
and
we will just check
if this dot
login server start
login
and we will pass this dot email and this
is not password
let's see if there are extra
so if this is true we should be able to
navigate to
rooms slash ad let's try to
go back go to rooms right we don't want
to go to room slash yet so
but still it will not work right so
let's try that out
the reason being uh we have not made
changes to our guard our guard still
returns false
so i'll say this is admin at gmail.com
and this is
admin
right so nothing works you can see
here navigation started but
uh there was a guard which said okay you
are not supposed to come here just go
back go back
and that's
where we will just write the code to our
card now i can use login service here so
uh remember this is a service right so
it also has a constructor
and then you can say private
login
service
which is type of login service so now we
have access to login service server here
let me just close this and rather than
returning false what i can do is return
this dot
login service
dot
is logged in
so remember you uh it can be observable
as well because it can return observable
or it can return
url tree it can also return a promise
which we are not using anymore and also
it can return a boolean which we are
using right now it's a boolean value
so
now let's go ahead and verify
the
functionality so i'll say okay this is
admin and password is
admin and let's click and
here it is we are
on rooms page let's click on employee
let's click on add room and everything
works fine
right so because now your guard is
saying okay i checked you you don't have
here let's just go
go into the bank and similarly here
our login service is saying yes you are
logged in just
go ahead and enter and access the urls
you want to
so this is uh one way
but let's try to do one thing let's
refresh this page
remember now it's a blank page we are
not even on login page
the reason being once
we refresh of course you
lose the state of your application
in that case you be your locked in state
becomes false
but
your guard does not know where to
redirect to you so it says okay i'm not
sure where you uh we want to redirect to
you because you have already passed you
have already uh
you are already past the login uh sorry
the routes right so you uh you have
already checked the routes and you
failed the
what guards you failed the card state or
you failed you failed the guard check
now where to redirect to you so this is
where you can do something like this so
you can say written if logged in then i
can say okay return true
or
you can use
throughout the service so let's see
inject
private
router
so you can say this dot
router dot
navigate and i can say just go ahead and
navigate this user to login
let's see now
and here it is so we are on login page
but you might be saying okay this that
was by default why us why you're lying
i'm not let me show you
so let's go ahead and say login
and
same thing we will refresh
and we are on login so we fix that
particular issue as well so this is from
can activate card
let's go back ourselves now
now let's go ahead and discuss about can
activate child so it has something to do
with child as it says
and lucky luckily for us we have already
seen some example how you can use the
children property in your route right so
we did it for rooms
let's go back to the code so here
we have
rooms and then let's go to the routing
and we have these two parts
so
now what we want to apply is we want to
say in case this logged in user is admin
i should be able to access children
otherwise i should not be able to access
children
possible right as i said i mean even in
banks you can have a guard
who can who is responsible for checking
what kind of role someone has who is
trying to access this particular logger
locker if you are a teller of course you
should you you can get the access if you
have uh if you're a user you should get
the access to the locker but if you are
someone who is not authorized to access
the locker you can get into the bank
so you
pass the can activate
guard but you should not be able to
enter into the locker room
that's what we are supposed to do here
so here we will be creating another
folder we'll call it as cards and this
is related to rooms so i'll just close
others here
and
let's close this as well because there
are too many files which will open
and let's go to integrated terminal and
g
g and i'll say this is room card
related to room so in case in future we
want to add more we can
and the only guard which we want here is
we want can activate
child and that's it
right now it's true but let's go ahead
and apply this card
so here you can say can activate child
again this is an array so you can have a
number of cards applied here
and you can say room
card
right so
everything great so far
and we should be able to access once we
are logged in so i'll say this is admin
admin
and we should be able to access
rooms
and add rooms you should be able to
access book
room
and works fine
now let's break it
so to break it we have to say return
false
let's provide
admin
and
click on employee click on rooms
bad room now we don't have access
click on book room we don't have access
and it says navigation started but it
never ended because
because of course the guards kicked us
out
let's now fix it
so we can go to login
and now we are supposed to have two
types of login so one is user logged in
a user login and one is admin so i'll
just add i'll say this is admin and
which is
boolean and which is false by default
and if
someone uses this so i'll say this is
admin which is true
and
i'll say else
or
not else
if
else
you can just use it right
yeah
i'll say this says
user
i can say okay this is logged in is true
now but is admin is false
so now
my login service knows who is admin who
is not
let's go ahead and use this into our
cart
so we can use constructor
facebook
login
service
just type of login
service and then here
i can say if return this dot
login service dot is admin
so if this is true written truth that's
it
in case you want to add some extra check
go ahead and do that
let's figure out admin first add room
yes works
select room select
book room works
let's refresh this page so we'll go back
to login now and
now you will use user and
gmail.com and we will use
user
right and let's click on add room we
don't have access to it
select books
and we don't have access to it either
so this is how you can prevent the
access to child drums
next card we are going to talk about is
not candy activate but we will talk
about can load and then we will come
back to candy activate and resolve card
so why i mean in candy activate we need
a form so we will go to the uh
another topic which is reactive form
which is pending right now and we'll
create a form and then we'll come back
to candy activate because the scenario
is related and i don't want to skip that
let's see can load
we already have an issue which is
related to
where we can apply can load so let's go
ahead and refresh this page so we will
be redirected to login
and let's go to sources
and let's see what are what is the code
which is loaded right now so you can see
you can go to apps and
rooms
what's this possible
let me just refresh again
so yeah rooms is gone right so we don't
have rooms available here
which is okay right i mean we said we
already tested this then you might be
wondering why i'm talking about it
talking about
this rooms again which is lazy loaded we
know that it is not supposed to be
loaded
let's go ahead and click on rooms
so this room says loaded are we
redirected to rooms the answer is no
but still have access to this particular
route the reason being
we are not redirected because of can
activate card so we are not able to
activate this particular
route
but it is loading the code because it
doesn't know what to do in case i am not
authorized to access this particular
route
this is where can load this is this is
where can load route guard comes into
the picture
so this is where the can load card comes
into the picture so it is itself say it
is saying that can i load this
particular route
it is only applicable for lazy loaded
router remember this so i can apply the
scan load card
so i can just go to cards
and i can apply this the same apply the
same
so i can just say if logged in
right
and
let's apply the card here
so this is rooms
i can say can load
and then i can pass the card
and you might have a question again i'll
come back to that point
but let's go ahead and verify this one
so i will go to web pack
src app
rooms not available let's click on rooms
and still not load it because now it
knows that okay in case
if i am not logged in i am not supposed
to do anything i am not supposed to
allow access to this particular sorry i
am not supposed to load this particular
uh lazy loaded module so that's what we
are restricting here now let's come back
to this point
you might be wondering that for can
activate and can load both
i am applying login card
i mean i can just go ahead and have uh
can activate child here as well and
i can have sorry we don't have child but
in case we had right so we can also
apply um resolve guard here the reason
the thing is whenever uh
it tries to actually
apply or
run particular card it checks for which
property so here though even though we
are passing a login card for both
in this case it knows that i have to go
ahead and activate this scan load
function
in this case it knows that i have to go
ahead and implement ah so we call can
activate method that's all so that's
absolutely fine so don't get confused
here um that i have to go ahead and uh
create multiple guards for multiple use
cases even the even though the code is
same no you don't have to
before we go ahead and explore the other
round cards which we had
we'll go ahead and create a form so we
already have something called booking
which uh
we want to
uh create so we want to create a booking
form where
users
can book
a room right so as in someone who is
working in that hotel you will you
should be able to book a room
and that will be the form which will be
created
so we will be using another approach
called reactive forms we already saw a
template driven form and
here in reactive form as well we will go
through a step we'll
do step by step we'll set up reactive
form then we'll talk about
so
we'll uh we'll see how to create a form
then we'll also see how to create uh add
controls dynamically then we'll talk
about the built-in validators we'll talk
about submit and reset form
we'll talk about how you can listen to
the changes on a form which will be of
course using template driven form
we will also talk about patch value set
value which is really important uh
important question in case you are
giving an interview
we will talk about few rxjs operators
and then we will also add a custom
validation so let's go ahead and start
with setting up your reactive form the
first thing which we need to do is we
need to create or import a reactive
forms module
we will be doing it for booking and for
booking we already have a module
separate module so
what we'll do is we will add a reactive
forms model here
and remember
in template driven form what we saw is
we created the
we created entire form using html right
in template driven form you will see
another approach we will see that all
the forms will be created using st using
typescript and we will just be rendering
the those forms which is already created
so now first step is done reactive forms
module added now let's go ahead and see
what else
so we'll create reactive form using
typescript and this is a good approach
in case you want to have like more
control on the typescript site of our of
your form
and uh
in case uh sorry the apis are same as i
said but you will be using something
like form group form control form
directives
uh
so let's go ahead and do that
so here
let's first see how our form looks like
it means we have to have a model so here
i have created a model which will
which will show you how my uh how the
form looks like so
let's paste it here
so we'll be having
a booking id which will be order
generated so we can remove this
we will have a room id of course because
we will book a specific room
then we will have email we will have
check-in date checkout date we will have
booking status which will be generated
uh or we can send it so booking amount
booking date we will have a mobile
number
guest name guest writer is city state
country and zip code
and we also have
uh
guest count
which will be type of number
and
in case it is
number of guests are
more than one right so we have to have
that cash list
so we can say guest
list
and some
random
thing right some random object so let's
go ahead and add let me
just add this into my back end because i
have not done that
and
it's a guess list which will be the
array
okay so i'm not creating an interface
here but it's absolutely fine but yeah i
know this is these are the fields which
we are supposed to have
so let's go ahead and see uh how we can
create this form using reactive forms
so the first thing which we need is we
need uh
the first thing which we'll do is we
will do one thing
i'll remove this connectivity card from
here i don't want to actually log in
every time
and
let's do it
here as well and we'll put it back
thing is uh here i need
let it be
we can keep this and let's do it for
booking
so booking component the first thing
which we need is we need a form so how
we'll create a form
so there is a class called form
group
where you can actually go ahead and add
multiple controls
we will see some other variation as well
what in case i don't want to actually
have entire form we need a single
control we'll see an example of search
so here i'll call this as booking
form
which is type of form
group
so this is the first class which we are
using form group and we are saying okay
this um booking form
let's
use this
so we don't have the error available
here and then we now we need
we have we got our form so it's an empty
form what else
you will do after you got your form you
will add controls how you will add
control so let's go ahead and see that
so there is a class called form builder
the name itself suggests that okay this
is something which will be used to build
the form
let's go back to our slides here
so
we will go through form control later on
for another example but here so we can
use form group to group multiple forms
multiple controls
and we will be using form builder to
build complex forms so uh it can be used
to
add multiple controls to that particular
form
so now let's go ahead and do the step
two so we want to use form builder so
i'll use
this is a service remember so form
builder is a service so we are injecting
it
we will say okay this form is form
builder
and then we can say this dot
your booking form is equal to
fb dot
group we are grouping the form there are
multiple ways we will talk about how we
can create a control because
this form builder allows us to add
multiple things so you can see it says
there is a group which is my widely used
you can say there is a star in front of
it means it is widely used and then we
have array and control we will see all
the examples don't worry about it so
right now we are saying okay there is a
group
and now in this form group we can add
multiple controls so let's go ahead and
add
so it's a room id
so let's replace this semicolons with
comma
okay
and i'll copy this and then we'll talk
about it
okay
and we will add this guest list later
so we have this one form group closed
here we'll just remove this two commas
uh with
single comma
okay
let's format this
and
somehow this is not close
uh okay
let's remove this now
so
format document
so we got the form and now we have added
some controls
first up let's go ahead and verify this
we are talking about we are saying that
this is a form but is it really a form
let's go ahead and talk see that how we
can verify if it is a form the simplest
way is to go ahead and check the
properties which are available generally
on forms so remember pressing the d
values so let's try this one
so booking form dot value
pipe json
and then we'll also talk about pristine
and dirty
and now let's go back to the ui
and of course this uh these routes is
not supposed to work but bookings will
and you can see uh in
values we are getting all the values or
all the properties which we have defined
and all the values are by default empty
empty string
right
so let's talk about this first so this
is a shortcut to uh this one so you can
actually
use new form control and provide a
default value
so either use this syntax or this syntax
i generally use this syntax because it
it is
it i mean i love to
tell them okay this is a form control
and because of typing right so
otherwise you can just go ahead and use
this particular syntax as well
so now we have all the controls
defined so what we did so far is we
created
we uh sorry we added the reactive forms
module we created the form using
reactive way
by using form group form builder
now next thing
sorry the next thing which we have to do
is now we have to go ahead and render
this form remember as i said the form is
already created and this is the proof
right so
form dot value it means the form is
created
pristine dirty it gives gives us the
values as well so it means the form is
ready now the next thing which we have
to do is just go ahead and render it
now let's go ahead and bind this form to
our
html right
so how to create a form of course we
have to use form tag
there is no other option
the next thing is uh you have to define
that okay now this form is already
created so we have to somehow tell the
html that okay you don't have to create
a new form if you don't i mean it will
create a new form right so the way to do
is you have to use a directive called
form group
and now this form group directive is the
booking form which we have already
created
so this line of code
will tell
the angle compiler okay look uh sorry
look we have already created this form
just go ahead and bind this form to this
booking form which is already created
and which has this controls
so step one done
we said that
um now let's go ahead and apply a div
but here we will be doing something
so here we will be doing a different
thing we will be using materials control
so we can go to
uh sorry components and we can go to
form
right so there are multiple ways to add
your form input text
so let's go ahead and see how what needs
to be done so
here the following element doesn't work
inside the mat form field so we have
uh
sorry input we have text area
and
let's see the code here so we have
mat form field
uh mac label uh select button
we have text area
and then there is should be an input
input as well so we use mat input here
so
for input we will be referring this
but this matte input can be wrapped
inside the form field so we have to
actually combine both the apis
and we can see it here uh
html
right so we have this mat form filled
class
and we will copy the css as well from
here so let's do that i will just copy
one and then we will repeat it for this
so here uh
now we are getting some error we'll just
remove this let's get a get rid of this
div now because here mat form field is
what we are looking at
so i'll just say for my document and
just ignore about the error
we'll fix those
we'll copy the css from here
and
so the they have some my uh error states
okay i'll we'll remove this will not
make this much complicated i'll remove
this one
from control is what we need mat label
is what we need
mat error okay matte and
okay i'll remove mat hint
matte error okay
and now let's talk about this
so here uh
what are the apis which we are going to
use is mat input and mat form so let's
go to the form control
field control and let's see what we need
to do so we need to import this mat
frame mat form field module
let's go ahead and add it
so now matte form filled
error should be gone then we have label
and input so let's take input second
and now all the errors related to input
should be gone
and then we had label so let's go to
[Music]
okay looks like label is part of this
particular api so we don't have to do
anything
and that's it now here
in form field we will say this first
property let's see what is the first
control which is room id
so i'll say okay this is uh
text
and
i'll say this form control is room id
room id is something which is available
here
so
apart from this
so room id is
i'm not getting this is string so i have
to save this
okay
so yes we will be using form control
name and
let's see
from control name room id it should work
and now let's go ahead and comment this
mat error for time being
okay so what we have done is we are
saying this is room
id
and let's see how it looks like so it
says okay we have this uh
room id a placeholder and so this is
home id
and let's enter something here so you
can see room id is actually which is
getting mapped here but there is some
problem with css let's see what is this
did applied the css
example
uh
full width
where is that example full width and
okay we have not applied the form
so let's do that as well so
i think it should be
input
it should be applied here so so this is
class
example form
so we applied the css as well now let's
see so let's go to bookings and
still not
the
thing which you wanted
so it says width is hundred percent but
someone is
actually stopping it from
okay so this is hundred percent the
stave is hundred percent this is hundred
percent
okay this is not an impression so
mat form filled in fix
let's see
uh
width
okay
no this is
okay this is also says its
width is hundred percent someone is
actually stopping it
uh
let's try to do this let's add it in
global css
okay so
not
what we wanted it to be so
let's remove this
and
let's remove this classes as well
and let's remove this appearance as a
little bit
uh okay
so we have this form filled uh
okay so now it is not even applying the
material
css so let's go ahead and see
so we have the styles available here and
let's go to angular.json
indica pink i'll just remove this
bootstrap one for time being
and let's restart the server probably
they as we are using both it is actually
causing a conflict
so let's save this
event
okay let's hope it works now
ah okay so i was right so it was it was
just due to the conflict because we are
using both
uh angular material as well as uh
bootstrap css so now you can see it has
room id and this is this is how you are
actually material can component
material control should look like
uh i am sure other forms is broken now
because we were using bootstrap but we
can we can actually replace everything
with material control we will do that we
will do
i mean you can try it as a practice for
other controls but here we will be using
just the
um just the material form
so let's uh go ahead and add other
controls so i'll just remove i'll just
keep this but
i'll just come
okay let's do it for mac
uh form field and then we need the input
control
right so we'll just add this and then
we'll replay uh just with multiple so we
have a lot of controls so
let's do a copy paste as of now and then
we will
see which
control to use right we'll just need to
figure that
out
so we this was the first one uh
let's open the model so we have
this many controls
and let's put it here
somehow i think not everything was
copied let's see okay room after room id
so we need guest email so the next one
is type is email
guest email and we'll say provide
and
email
did we have name okay sorry so name
should be
the first one right
so we'll use text and
let's save it
and we'll move this
before email
now we can have other things uh which is
mobile number
so this is mobile
and then we have checked in date
so we'll say okay this is from
controlling it but uh interesting uh so
check in date and second uh checkout
date right we need uh control i mean uh
date picker control so we will use date
bigger
booking status we will uh sit later
booping amount
looking amount and
type is number because
it's an amount looking amount
booking date it will be again date
picker mobile number we already create
and then we have guest address
city
let's do it later because i can see uh
i think
this can be another form as well
so we will see that i mean we can how we
can actually
uh put this entire thing as a different
property as an address
so let's see that later on uh let's wrap
it by commenting the other controls
as we are going to need it so we'll just
keep it here and let's see our form okay
unexpected tag looks like i compended
the form as well
okay it's here but
something something which is not closed
properly yes here it is
okay so now we have room id guest name
email mobile number booking amount so
these are few properties which we have
let's enter so we can see okay guest
name is something which is getting
updated here email
is getting updated here mobile number is
getting updated
uh here and then we have booking amount
which is also getting updated just to
verify the form i mean if everything is
fine or not
so done so all these properties are
actually mapped to its respective
controls right by using something called
form control name which maps
this
input control to the control which is
already defined
next step
we need date pickers let's take it from
here so we have something called date
picker available here
and which gives us some nice state
picker so let's go ahead and see the api
so it says okay you have to add this
you have to add date picker module so
let's do that
and do we need to do anything else the
answer is okay
no
let's see the uh here um okay no so we
don't have to anything we
we can just use
mat
there are okay there are two things uh
we also have range
do we need range
the answer is yes we could we can
actually uh
provide start date ended by using the
range control but let's
let's see we will use the date picker
so we have two different properties so
here mandate picker so let's see how to
use it
we already have
this mat form filled i'll just comment
the first one mat form filled
from here to here okay
okay
let's copy this
and move this commented
thing to here okay
so we have mad date picker which is
speaker what we need to do is we need to
map
the uh
map the control so we will be using here
form
control name is equals to we have
check-in date
and let's format this
and let's verify
okay so it says uh matt date because
center is internal property of input
so we added mat date picker
module here
and it is not saved so you can see there
was a white dot line it was it means it
was not saved and let's see
the form now
and there is again some error okay
so it says mat date picker no provider
found for date adapter interesting
because yes we need to set something and
it is already provided in the
documentation there is nothing uh this
error is not wrong because we have uh
this
you can see here internationalization
properly no no provider for data
so you can see it is already uh given
into the documentation so so it says no
not provided for all injectable data
it's choosing a date implementation so
you can
use multiple uh date implementation
which is available
and what we will do is
we will use native one so i can just use
mat native date
this one
module
okay i think this is not part of this so
let's see from where it is
it's part of before let's see if it
fixes our issue
and
bookings yep so you can see uh it
doesn't it has nine nice date picker and
which you can choose
and it
shows you
uh uh do or
allows you to access
a calendar right so
our date picker so you have available
just shows a date you can we can
actually change this
and say
this is
chicken
[Music]
date
right so here now label will be changed
to check-in date and you can see when
you click on this the label goes above
it's it's a mobile uh first approach
right so whenever you are using material
it's a mobile first approach
so now we have chicken date and all
other controls which are available so we
also added and
we also added a date picker so we can
just go ahead and create all other
controls what we will do is we will add
all the all other controls and then we
will see how our form behaves and then
we will add more controls
so
i have created the forms
affiliated with form uh we i have added
few more fields for example we have not
checked second date checkout date
booking date
booking amount mobile number and email
and guest name and room id which is
right now our text box but we will uh
change it we will do something like
where we click on rooms and then book
rooms and the id is actually retrieved
from the url which we already know how
to do that so here let's
do something right so we already have
few more fields where we have address
city state country zip code
and we'll talk about guest account later
on so what we will do is we will try to
cover as much scenario as possible here
so for the second step
we will add this address information in
our second form
you if you are wondering what is second
form so we will be will do nesting form
nesting which is that one feature which
is available inside the
angular forms which you can do
so
uh this form right now as we know that
this is a form can have a nested form
controls
so
we will create another group form group
inside this existing form
but
before that let's go ahead and talk
about few more things
let's go ahead and see how to submit
your form
okay so we will see how we can submit
the form and then we'll be back with
some uh few more things for example how
to add uh
these this message control nested form
control then we'll talk about how you to
add controls dynamically and then we'll
talk about built-in validators
so uh
let's go back to bookingcomponent.html
and to submit the form we have to use
the same uh event which we had used
earlier if you remember in template
driven form we used
ng submit so we'll say this assembly
submit equals to and i'll say this is
add
again
[Music]
right so here
let's see
let's just uh
and then we'll do console.log to see
what is the value which we're getting so
if you might be wondering how to get
this values right now so you can do
something called
this.booking.bookingform.value
and let's verify it right
so one thing which i want to show you
here is let's say if i enter a wrong
format here right so as this is already
date picker i mean you can see the
validation error is already there and
this is how actually angular material
shows validation errors
it it becomes red so just to let you
know in case
so uh let's go ahead and see
props
so before we can submit
we need a button as well so let's add a
button which we missed
and we will be using angular material
button now
and to do that let's
go to material dots right so in on
material.angular.io we have lot of
components there is a button component
as well
and we will use this primary button so i
can we can just go to example
and see the code and let's copy this
primary button and put it here
which i will put inside another tab
and
as we are using material button we need
to add also the api
so we will say import map button module
which right now is used inside
this one
looking module in case i'm using it uh
in other forms
you can also add it to app module
let's go ahead and see uh
this compilation is done
let's see the form
and we have this button available here
so
everything works even the css works and
we'll say uh
book
room
let's go ahead and see in console let's
clear everything let's click on book
room and you can see you have all the
properties right now it's empty because
we have not submitted anything let's
click uh let's provide the room number
guest name
provide an email
mobile number
booking amount
and then we will have
check in date
checkout date
and booking date book room and you can
see you have all the information which
you have submitted so you have booking
amount you have booking date book
check-in date check-in check-out date
this will be the guest name email uh
mobile number and room id so everything
is available
but there is a catch
what in case uh so let me show you what
what the what is the catch here so here
you can also do something like this so
you can actually say
uh that okay your default value is 2
and that and you want this
see the api so form select okay so
so you can submit
a form state which looks like this
and
we don't have any typings here so that's
what the problem is and
you can say value and uh a disabled
state let's see let's see what happens
in this case
so your form control will be disabled
so you can see the value 2 is available
here but the state of this control is
disabled
so
or you can
i mean you cannot
type anything here so it won't allow you
let's now submit that form and see the
catch
okay so can you see something is missing
here
let's zoom in
[Music]
any property which you think is missing
yes
the answer is room id you cannot see
room id available anywhere even in the
object
even it's in form we are not able to get
this particular value which was
available earlier
this is a this is one thing which
is not available when we try to access
the value dot value property
so
try to use
another property of form which is known
as get raw value so get raw value will
also give you
the values of the control which are in
disabled state
so let's clear it
let's enter
the
email
mobile
kingmont so checking date
check out that and booking it
and click on book room
and now you can see room id is available
as well so remember when you submit this
submit form and you want to get the data
out of that particular form try to rely
on get raw value to get the correct
values rather than just dot values
so
this is one thing which we wanted to
show you
now let's move on and let's add the next
part as we said
we will be nesting the form what we mean
by that
so here you can see i have lot of
controls right so
what we want to do is we want to do
something like this so we want to have
another form control which says address
and then
this address contains
the values or you can say the form
controls
and
so this is how we want it our form to
look like so there will be an address
object which will hold uh i can say this
is
let's remove this
guest right so we can say okay this is
state
country
zip code
and
here we can actually break this into two
address line run
because most of the i think uh booking
form has like address line one address
line to address line three
so
we want this form to look like this and
let's verify this form is created in
such a way you can see address and yes
it is right so you have address and then
address contains all this object it says
at this line at this line okay i have to
mention one address line one address
line two city state country and zip code
let's
see how to render this particular form
on our ui right now
so the first thing which we need is i'm
going to wrap it inside div
and let's add a accordion control so
here we have something known as
let's see
expansion panel so angular material
contains something known as expansion
panel which we can use so we will be
using this api
and let's go ahead and add this
all right so we added my expansion panel
and now we want
something like this right so where we
have we can click and it will just open
all the addresses which we have
so let's see the code
and
this
is two buttons and
these are the form controls right so we
will
okay let's see
okay there is okay this is the expanded
collapsible button we just don't need
that anyways
so we need from here
mat expansion panel accordion
and let's see
i'll just put it as it is and
we'll close the accordion
and we are also using mat icon so let's
add that as well so mad
icon module
and this is it let's see let's see how
our form looks like right now so you
have this personal data so we'll let's
let's replace all this object right now
right away so we will say this is
address
and here we want to
add matte panel description we will
remove this
or
let's remove this mac panel description
so we just have a title
right so
cool sounds looks good and then we will
add the other properties inside this so
let's start doing that
and we will take
let's see
where is the diff con because that's
really important here
okay so i'll move this
matte accordion inside the diff i'll
just tell you why i did this let's first
create the form
okay so we have this address information
available here and let's copy
this mat form field
i think the closing of
is missing and let's try to use this
address line one as
form control name here and placeholder
is address line one
so let's format it again
okay so what we have done is right now
this mat form field anyways does not mix
right now it's not used but this is the
one which we added right now so we are
saying at this address line one is the
form control we are looking at but here
let's see something
which is available here cannot find
control with name address line one and
you might be wondering i mean this
control is available here but can you
see if i type anything here it is not
getting reflected into this particular
control
and there is also an error which says i
cannot find this control with address
line one but you might be wondering okay
i mean this particular control does
exist here
but how it is not available so this is
where
we have to understand one thing this is
another form within a form
so to access this particular controls
the first thing which you have to do is
that's the reason i place this thing you
have to use form
group
name
remember we have already used form group
here
and there can be only one form group on
a single
oh oh sorry there can be only one form
group on a page
so this form group is available now
anything which you want to add inside a
form can be nested form and another form
right so
it's okay i can create another form
using this fb dot group and that can be
another form altogether
but if i'm adding it inside a form same
form it can be form group name now so
we'll say okay this form group name is
equals to
address
and we are saying any control which will
be available inside this particular tab
will be related to the address
and you can see the error is gone
you will not see any error its address
enter the address and you can see it is
getting
applied to this address line one
property
similarly we can add address line to
city state country and zip code all
those controls
so now your form looks little bit better
right i mean it's it looks much better i
would say we can actually uh also move
this section the entire section into
another accordion or expansion panel and
it will look really nice so we we will
have list information displayed while
submitting the form
so uh
what we will do is we will add all these
controls uh let's go ahead and do that
so we have address line 2
this is across line 2
and what was next city state country
so let's say this is city
okay and the final is zip code so let's
see
uh yeah see code or we can we could have
just said zip it's absolutely fine
let's see the form so we have
uh there's no error it means we added
all the controls successfully and now
let's submit this all together so i'll
say okay this is this
booking announced
chicken date
so called date
city
state
right and let's click on book room and
now you have all this data available
let's see the address one right so you
can see
the address line one two city pin code
everything is available inside and
properly
formatted address property right so you
don't have to do anything so yep this is
how you can add nested control and this
is how you can do submit let's move on
to the next where you will see
how to add controls dynamically to your
form
now let's go ahead and see one amazing
feature which is provided by the angular
forms we will be adding and removing
controls dynamically and we you will see
how many uh
number of lines of code we have to write
to achieve this
because it's
not that much as we end up generally
doing in
regular forms in case you have created a
dynamic form in past using jquery you
will understand the pain
or you will understand how easy it is to
actually do that i mean sorry for using
the term easy because i've been doing it
from a long time maybe it's easy for me
but yeah you will understand at least
the basic
difference in the api both angular and
other uh
sorry other
framework has to offer so let's go ahead
and do that what will be the scenario
what we are going to do here
so
we will add a functionality where
now while booking
of course it's possible right you can
have a number of guests you can have
more i mean three for whatever number of
guests you want to
so we will provide a functionality where
you can just click on a button which
says add guest and it will add more
controls as you go
right so here
rather than guest count
i'll say this will be guests
which will be this dot fb dot array
so we are saying now the control which
we are supposed to provide will be area
of controls not the
uh
group so it won't be a nested form but
it will be a nested form
array of a form
so here we can do something like this so
you can pass like
one two three
something like this right so you can
pass a number of values here or we can
also pass
this sort
fb dot group
but not control
and
here i can say okay this is the guest
name so it's
let's add the controls so we have guest
name what what we generally uh what are
the information we generally take so we
take name
age
right so let's say this is new
form control
remember you can just use whatever way
you like you can also mix both but
follow one i generally use this form
control to get the intellisense part
running so uh yeah so we get the guest
name we get age
uh what
else
i think this two is enough let's see
as of now so
let's verify this one form
so there is no error but you can see
guest has this array right so if you
have guest name and h it means
this area of
a control has actually two controls
available within it and we can have ad
we can add n number of it let's do one
thing let's add a button first
so remember one thing uh the this div is
there for reason so i'm not going to add
this new controls inside this as uh as
they don't belong there they belong to
uh this form right so this booking form
so i have to add it inside this form
right so
i'll just do it after this particular
div
and here i'll pop this button
and i'll say this is
add
guest
and
this will be type
of button because remember if i don't
give a type it will also submit the form
which we don't want to we can have only
one submit button within a form
and on click of this button i want to
add guest
so let's uh go ahead and see do this
we'll write this functionality first
so let's add
guest and here you can do something like
this
what we can do is we can create a get a
property here
so i'll say this is guests
is equals to
this.bookingform.get
you can see this
you can actually access any controls by
using this api which is available inside
angular reactive forms so we can say
bookingform.get
guests which is referring to this and we
will type cast it as form array we will
tell that okay this is an array this is
not a single control or this is not a
nested form
so once this is done we can do something
like this so we can say this dot guests
dot
add
[Music]
okay let's see the set controls set
validator status test
okay so we can say controls
dot
push
okay so we will be using this controls
dot push to push a new control so we can
actually do something like this
so
as this is and
what we can push we can either push a
control or we can push a group
so right now it's not of course it's not
the control which we are looking at we
are looking at a group so let's save
this and let's verify the functionality
first
okay there is some error let's see what
is this cannot read property of
undefined of get let's see why
the start
because
this
what i'm doing
and we have to say pretend
okay sorry i've had written some wrong
syntax for getter which
changed why did that so we have getter
um guess so now let's go ahead and see
get from http no we don't want this kit
from http we want to use getter
let's go to booking and we have this add
guest available here right so right now
of course we have not added this uh or
we have not rendered this particular
form group or sorry for mary on to our
view so we can click here
uh on add guest
okay
something happened
and guessed why it is not doing anything
one click now we have add guest
let's see if it is doing something
strange no
guest dot controls dot push
by that actually we need to add it
to this area so guest dot push because
we don't want to go inside the controls
let's see if it works
let's click on add guest and you can see
we are able to add the guests
so
still they are not rendered but yes we
are able to actually add those uh
controls dynamically
right so this is something which we uh
we are doing uh we are actually adding
this controls with a single line of code
remember this
so if you count this as a line another
line so two lines of code right so we
are doing it in two lines of code now
let's go ahead and do the next part
let's go ahead and add it
uh
on your form right so we need to render
this on your on the form at the end so
again
we'll start it with a div
and here we will do something like form
array name because we have already uh
sorry we don't have this as a form group
we have it's an array so we will say
okay this is the guests
area which we are looking at
and now here we have to
go ahead and
add multiple so uh i'll just let me just
write this code and then we'll talk
about this so here uh
not the guest form but
[Music]
we'll say looking form uh let's
write this and then we'll talk about it
or
it's not
we already have this
guests
dot controls okay
and let's remove let's
do this
form
control name
i will say this is
this is stiff and let's remove this
it's
and here we wanted another div
where we will use form
group name
is equals to i uh so let me just
complete this code and then we'll talk
about
what i have done
and
ctrl x remove this extra controls
and let's see if we have matching divs
so this dave closes here this dave
closes here this div does not close
anywhere so we need to
close this div and okay now it's look
fine it looks fine
and here we will put uh from uh so what
is the first property which we have
inside guest so it's a guest name
from control name is the guest name
and we will
use
this
and similarly we will place another form
field
which is
of type age and which is h and which is
of type number
and let's go again
so let's go ahead and see it so you've
got guess the email is sent or something
and uh looks looks like there is an
error so it says okay uh cannot find
controls with path guests i and guest
name
let's go ahead and see
what it is referring to so
we have a form area name guess
and we are saying within each
control go ahead and loop over this
then we have form group name and this is
where the problem is we have to put it
in box we'll talk about that as well
let's enter and
done right so we have our
uh
form
working right now let's click on add
guest and you can see you have another
form control
which is again you can see the value
available here click on again another
guest
right and you can just see it is it is
in working state so we created the form
of course we created uh this controls
dynamically but we need to
discuss about this what we have done
here i mean this is really important to
understand this we know that okay we are
referring to
that okay this
guest is in one of the for for mary
which is available inside the form
that's why we did this what is this
logic what is this magic
so let's go ahead and talk about it
let's go to the booking component
so here what we have is uh
yeah
so what we are doing here here first so
let's try to understand this so we are
saying
now this array this is an array how we
deal with array in angular we have seen
that okay in case i want to access an
area of controls or sorry array of
values generally we end up doing or end
up writing ng for so this is the same
thing which we are doing here so we are
using ng4 we are saying
go ahead and loop over
each and every control which is
available inside this array you guys
said it
then this part is clear and then we are
using the index value
for next line of code which is available
here so form group name
so remember
let's try to understand the structure
so we have a form group the main form
group then we have format and then
inside that form area we also have a
form group
so
technically i have to go ahead and use a
form group name again here but do we
have a form group name the answer is no
right we don't have a form group name we
are actually just adding a form group
here
it doesn't contain a name so i had to
create
a form control name dynamically so i am
saying okay this i will help me to
control that form group name dynamically
because form group name should be unique
so it starts from 0 1 2 so that's how it
this line will help
now once we know that okay this is form
group name each row will have its own
unique name
the next thing
which is pending is your controls then
we are just placing this controls inside
this particular mat form field
and that's it
we are done so this is what this code is
so similarly in case you want to add it
in your case of course you have to do
the same line
nothing will change
so
once this is done sorry
let's go ahead and see
we have this control let's put it inside
same accordion right so
let's try to do that
and i'll remove this commented code now
we don't need it
so this is our
matte accordion
mat expansion panel
let's put it
on top of formatting name
and that's right
and then we had
some closing
mat
expansion panel and accordion
so we'll put it here
so
this added this ends here this ends here
okay
and
rather than address we'll say this
let's see
done so we have guests and you can add
number of guests
so within this
accordion also right so you can create
multiple panels if you want to
that
uh it should be guest one guess two
guess three something like that we can
do that as well
so try it by your own otherwise we will
add an example so here we will say guest
whenever you click on guest it will say
guest one guess two three something like
that
so we are done uh adding the dynamic
controls as well
we will talk about one more api uh which
is
very useful
in case uh you want to add some extra
fields
so let's take an example let's say uh
there is an optional field
to add a passport
okay so let's add a form and let's add a
button here on top
and we'll say this is that
passport
and let's implement this function
so we only want to add passport in case
uh we click on this button right it's
optional so what we can do is we can
just add this dot
let's see the
api first so we have something known as
add control and remove control in case
you want to remove that particular
control
so here
we can say this dot your form name so
this is booking form dot add
control and
as it says control so we'll be using
adding one control so we can say okay
this control name is passport and we can
choose to have a default value
right so let's go ahead and see
so of course it's not available here
right now
let's
click
on
the button
and for that we have to save this
form
and let's see so we click on add
password and you can see a new form
control called passport is available
here
so this is just in case we need some
extra information right so you can
actually do that by using the add
control api which exists
you can remove the same using
remove control but let's let's see how
to bind it because
but in case this control does not exist
right
so here let's see we how we can add it
so i'll just add one mat form filled
and we'll say this is
passport
and we'll say this is the control name
is passport
and place folder name is passport number
but if i try to add this right now let's
see
so if you try to add this right now we
will get an exception because right
currently this form control does not
exist
right so it does not exist and it will
throw an exception if you click on the
password
and now enter
as there was already an error it will
not work
how to handle this scenario
so we can use
ng
right so we can say
in gf we can say okay this dot sorry not
this
booking form
dot
control
okay let's see which
api we have contains that value get
value
dot as control i think
so here we can just check
get
and
put the control in
so we can use this get method to uh
get access to any control so in case
this particular control exists
then show go ahead and show this
otherwise don't
so let's see if it works
and now we don't have any error click on
add passport provide the password
information it works so this is how you
can handle uh such scenarios where you
want to add a control dynamically and
you want to render it adding is okay
right we saw that okay we can just add
it but how to render it so you have to
go ahead and check
first whether the control exists if it
exists go and then add the control
otherwise tone
so using this code uh you can also
remove
i can say delete
passport
and here
we can call the other api
remove control so first i have to check
whether the control exists so i can say
if
this dot
booking on dot get
the control name
uh passport then go ahead and remove the
control
so let's see
and
we have to save the form as well okay it
is safe so we have add password delete
password and the functionality works as
expected right so you can see it's it
it's not like it's only getting deleted
from uh ui right it's getting actually
deleted from the form
so
platform
add password delete password and we are
done
one more thing uh as we are already
talking about the reactive form or sorry
dynamic forms here also right we have
multiple guests
and we can add as many as one we want
but what in case you want to delete y
card so we added one extra what can you
do right now nothing you can do you
probably have to reset the form
so let's see uh let's cover cover this
scenario as well
so to remove our control from the list
of controls we need the specific
index from where you want to delete the
control remember this keep this in your
mind
so what we will do is
we need access to this form group so we
need access to this eye actually
so
i have to add this button inside this
div
so here we'll add one more div which
will say
button and i'll say remove guest so this
is remove guest button which we have
added
and let's implement and we are passing
the site we are passing the index from
where we want to remove the control
so here right we can go to
[Music]
remove cast
and
yeah so
we can just do this dot guess dot uh
remove at so we can pass the uh
pass the index which we are receiving in
this function so we are saying i which
is of type
number
and we will pass this index here
and
the control will be removed from the
array
so every uh row so here we will see
every row will have a remove guess
button so as we add one more
add one more and it remembers from which
index it is removing the control right
so if i remove let's add some
text here
and if i remove this one it remembers
that i had removed one the first one so
it will not change the values remember
this
and you can add one as many as you want
and then remove as many as you want you
can remove all and then add more
so this is how you can actually
do dynamic stuffs with this particular
api so what we learned we learned about
the form array we learned about how you
can add multiple uh sorry controls
dynamically using form array then we
also learned about how you can add done
controls dynamically using add control
and then you can remove them using
remove control and then similarly we saw
how you can remove controls from an
array
one more thing uh you might be wondering
that okay this code
and this code looks same yes they do
look same so what we can do is we can
actually go ahead and
export this so we can just go ahead and
say right factor and we can say
let's
create a method let's create a function
so i'll call this function as
add
rest
okay
and
let's see
okay somehow it got added inside this
for some reason
okay
something wrong here i think
i had guest function already exist and i
just named it the same
so we'll say refracted
[Music]
accept
to inner function in method no i want to
actually extract it in the function
let's write it
add the guest
control
and here we'll just use this code
and we'll see
written
return
written and here we can add this dot add
guest one rule
and similarly we can let's format
we can use the same line
resort and guest control here
let's verify so we have we don't have
any errors
uh the guess
is available here let's add and see if
the value is available here and it is
and let's click on multiple guests and
that's it so we don't have code
duplication as well now in this
particular code base
now what we will do next is we will add
some validation right now there is no
validation we completed our form we
wanted uh
we want we added all the controls which
we needed to create a booking form and
uh let's go ahead and add validation now
because you can see i can just go ahead
and submit without anything and
you can see it said it's all empty
values all over there
now we will add the validation to our
form but right now we don't have any
validation so let's see how we can add
validation to
reactive forms we have already learned
it for temporary driven forms remember
we can just use html5 validation so in
case of
temp sorry
in case of reactive forms let's see how
to do it
so
it is actually a second parameter which
is available here you can see uh you can
see the typings so it says uh the second
parameter is validator or options you
can actually pass it something like this
you can say validators
and then there is a class called
validators remember validator was an
interface which we used in previous
video while talking about adding
a custom validation to a template driven
from
here we are talking about validators
class which comes from angular slash
forms
and it has all the validations uh
built-in validations which we have seen
in
html5 validation
so you have main
max required everything so let's see how
to use them
so here we are saying okay validators
validators dot required and similarly
you can also add it here in similar
fashion you can say okay validators dot
required and
i am using two validations here uh which
is validators dot required and then we
are also using email
else what else we can apply uh
you can also play with min max so let's
uh
check we can have guest name
as
validators dot required and then we can
also have
a mill length of
5.
and let's go ahead and see our form
so here you can see a
star
so at some places uh or some
properties you will be able to see a
class available here sorry a star
available here it's actually you don't
have to do anything with angular
material uh whenever you add validation
you will also will get this star when
it's default behavior
and
it tells you that okay this form is not
valid right now and it's easy to figure
out the validation error as well right
we added it for guest name and email
and
for room id
right so which is already
true
and you can add more validators as you
want so the validators
are a different type of validity
validators which we have has been
matched required required
so i mean i'm sure you know uh the
others because they are same as we
discussed about
by working with template driven forms
let's see required true so for required
rule it's like
let's say if you have a check box right
so let's actually add a checkbox
and we will
go to material and we'll see how
checkbox
can be used
so here uh
c
so we have a different api for match
match checkbox
let's add this
remember why the reason i always refer
i'm referring to the documentation is to
make you a habit of referring to the
documentation whenever you are working
with any ui control
because
there are chances that in some
like in next release
they can add something extra and
if you get into some issues you will be
able to easily figure out that issue by
by using the documentation
so now we have this checkbox available
let's go ahead and add
our checkbox so we will say match
checkbox and
rather than uh
using this
let's add a property first
and
we'll see this is
pnc right so terms and conditions
which is
new form control
and we'll pass false and then we'll pass
required to so before you can proceed
with the form you have to submit or
select this tnc so we will place it
after this
match box we will not use ng model
so we will not use ng model but we will
use form control name as we saw
and
we will say this is t and c
t and c terms and conditions let's see
so you can see
you have this checkbox available here
now so we have to check this check
this box uh to proceed with i mean
to proceed with submitting the form but
we have not added that check as of now
let's go ahead and do that so we now add
some validations but our form is still
we will be able to submit our form so
let's use the same approach we used
earlier so we'll say disabled and then
you can say this is booking
okay somehow
typing is not working for this
dot
keep it disabled in case the form is
invalid the same things the same
controls are same properties are
available here so now you can see the
book room is invalid let's provide all
the values
mobile number i mean these are not
required values so we'll just move on to
tnc and
okay guest name should be five character
and you can see the button becomes valid
and you can click it now so we have some
validations in place
and we have added a required true
validator as well
and
now you can play around with other
validations uh
in uh so you have been max email we
already added
we have pattern in case you want to uh
have a control where you have some
rejects
you can also apply the pattern property
as well
so this these are few built-in
validators and now let's move on to
creating our own validator
before we learned how to submit the
forms right we also added the validation
now for pert reset
right so we have not seen that scenario
so as of now
we know how to uh do reset we already
learned about if that if you remember we
did it for template driven forms
so let's go back to the code and see how
we can do it so we will go to our ad
booking method and here you can do
something like this so this dot booking
form dot
you can call reset so you can see you
can pass all the values so it's a value
is optional so by default it will just
make everything to null which we don't
want to so
you can
provide the values for each and every
control which we have available here
so let's do that
here
so remember we are providing the values
not the control value right so we
can just have the default values for
each and every
control
and
this
is guest name
here we will just remove this
and put a curly bracket
here we can just pass an empty array we
don't want anything to be available
and in dnc we can just say false
so let's go ahead and verify so we are
using reset
method
let's provide the values so we can say
okay this is
tom
oh we need five characters so let me
just enter my name
okay i just
spread my name down okay
uh
we'll just use the uh
values which are required rights and
let's do that let's save it and you can
see now the values are actually
it's back to the original state so we
know we have like default values
available here right now right so
whatever we pass so you can see uh tnc
let's say tnc tnc is false
guess as we said it's an mtr
address again we pass some default
values
and this is how you can reset the form
one thing which we have not seen so far
is
what what is missing what do you think
so we have not seen how to uh validate
the controls
uh sorry how to show the errors on
control level remember this is some one
thing which we did it uh with
template driven form here for example uh
the guest name is required but it also
has a limit right so it has a max
mill length property which says it
should be at least five character so
let's go ahead and see how we can
actually add those validation messages
here
so uh now let's see how we can add
control level validation we already have
some code available here so we'll uh
uncomment and we will talk about it so
let's see uh
angular material also has something
known as mat error so if i go to
material
dot angular dot io and components
and let's see is it's part of form
filled and you can see it's and there
should be an example this one
form filled with error messages
and it has something called mat error so
which we are going to use
to show the error so you can see it says
not a valid email
so here let's do it let's copy this and
move it to
guest name right so we have uh
check that it should be minimum
5 characters and how the way you can do
it is
let's copy this
so it has a
api so this booking form
has an api where you can check has error
method so here let me just remove this
because we just needed one validation we
don't need both
and has error which is min
length
experiment
and we can
let our users know that okay in case it
has a main length error
we can say please
guest name
should be
[Music]
five
characters
should be minimum
five characters
right so let's go ahead and test this
and then we'll add few more validation
and guest name so let's see
okay somehow it's not available
let's
is that not saved
let's see here probably it has to do
with booking form dot
uh errors
ah okay
so uh you can see here uh we are
actually looking at the booking form
which is not true uh because this mill
length is available with this particular
control and let's see we can how we can
do that so you we can do something like
this so working form dot get
and you have to say uh the control name
so which is
guest name
and then we can use
has error so we will use as it can be
null
let's see all right so we can actually
do something like
let's print this
dot errors let's put question mark so in
case it's
not null
and
that's it let's see
so it says object object right now and
the reason being it's actually an object
so uh let's see uh we'll just do json
because it's right right now require
true and you can see now it has mean
length error so
uh m
small
and we should not
have this error message
you can see guest name should be minimum
five characters so we are able to
display the error
based on your current control remember
this so
uh
we'll remove this one command this one
so you can what you can do you can just
so use a booking form to get the control
and then use has error method to and
check if
it has this specific error
and that's it that's what you need to do
so now
uh if i try to move and
if i enter less than five characters i
know the exact error that okay guess
name should be minimum five character so
i have to enter one more character
now
you might be wondering okay this is okay
i mean this is my top level control what
in case i want to validate this address
line one address line two how to
mention
uh the errors based on the control
so let's go ahead and do that as well
and we will do it for errors
so here let's first add the validation
so we will add
validators required and let's add it to
few more controls
so we have cp
and let's add it to state
so three a few more controls which are
required now
and you can see okay the validation is
already applied so
that's not an issue
now let's go back
and see how we can show that error so
we'll be using mat error
and let's go to the address so address
status line one here
uh we will add mat error here and we
will say
now you have to actually combine this so
you have to say address
get
address dot
address line one
and has error uh let's say required
and we can say our address
design
fun
is it quiet let's see
oops this is fine
so you can uh see uh it says
so you can see it says address line one
is required right so we just added this
this validation so remember
for top level it's
booking or whatever form name you have
dot get and the control name
for
nested form you have booking form dot
get
your
form group name dot your control name
and then whatever error you are looking
at
now how about the inner sorry array
right so for array
now we uh we do have your form group
name but we also have form area name
so let's see
we will add for guest name
let's go ahead and
add this
guest name and we'll say this is
validators
let's copy this
so we have this
guest name as required and let's see if
it is required
and yes that is required now let's go
ahead and add the validation so here we
can
let's copy this matte error thing again
matte error
come back inside form and this is mat
form fit where we want to add this edit
so here now it will be little bit
different
so now because this is an array so the
thing is you have to pass it something
to pass it like this so first is
your form area name
comma
and well
so but
already
it's first is your
guess
so this will be string
then
form group name which is i
and the third one will be your control
so which is guest name which is again
string
let's format this
so we have guest i and guest name and
then has required
let's see
to guests and
you can see uh right now of course we
just copied the same so we can say
request
name
is required
and let's try to enter
delete it
and move on and you can see the guest
name is required so this is how you can
actually display the control level
validation based on
what field you are trying to validate so
we
started with the top level controls then
we went to the to the nested form and
then finally we went to the array so ah
this is from the uh this is it from the
validation part because the sorry
built-in validation part so we learned
about uh how you can reset your form and
how you can
uh go ahead and add the control level
validation
we are going to talk about two important
apis which is available with angular
reactive forms which is known as patch
value and set value so first let's
understand where it is
useful so right now we have this form
let's say what in case we have this
form values coming from some api
how to bind that value here
so let's try to do that first
so let's say we have
um
get
um looking
data this is a method
so we can achieve it in by using two
values two apis the first is uh patch
and second is set
so i mean first is set and the second is
patch so we'll talk about both so let's
see how set behaves set value and then
we'll see
what patch values can do first so here
we can use this dot
booking
form dot
set value so this is the api
and it
takes
so if you see this
the api
so it says values and it says key
and value right so remember this key so
key is the form control name which we
have and then this is values and then
you can pass some
other values which we'll see
which we don't want to see right now but
yeah so here you can
pass the default values
let's say it's coming from back and
right so
second date
right now it will fail but let's see
and
let's call this after our form is
created so this is where we will call
this this red uh get booking data
inside ngoninet remember so i am just
calling it after our okay sorry wrong
place
so we need to call it after our form is
created inside ng on in it so here our
form is created and then we are calling
get booking data now let's cut and see
so we have all these default values
right available here because we provided
all the
remember we provide all the values but
here you see
yeah that's fine we don't have uh yeah
we have an error here so must apply a
value for form control at index 0 this
is what i wanted to show you uh but let
me just do one thing let me just remove
any of the property
see this error must supply a value for
control with
name checkout date
and
why so
the thing is whenever we use set
value property or set a value api it
expects us to pass
all the values for all the control which
it has
keep this in mind set value we need to
pass the value for each and every
control
patch value it makes it little bit loose
so
in patch value you can you are allowed
to skip
some of the controls
so now you can see we don't have the
error anymore and everything works right
so if i just provide guest name it will
work and we already have this value
which is provided or set using the patch
value method so this is the difference
otherwise
there is no difference between set value
and patch value set value makes little
bit strict that you you have to go ahead
and pass every uh value for each and
every control patch value makes it
little bit flexible so i don't have to
pass everything
form api also allows us to listen to the
form value changes in real time
so
how it is possible
so you can use a value changes property
which is a stream remember we have
already discussed board stream so which
is a stream and which looks for any
changes which is happening in real time
on your form
so let's go ahead and see how we can
actually utilize this api so here
after my form is
done
we can actually uh use
booking form dot value changes as this
is a stream we are subscribing to it and
it will give us the data in real time
let's see
so console.log data
and let's remove this and enter the
value so you can see as soon as i enter
a value it is actually giving me the
data mobile number
and
now we have this mobile number available
so it will be called for each key press
remember
so if i enter
5 now let's enter 0 0 0 right so for
each and every value which is getting
changed you can capture
that value in real time using value
changes
but
it
isn't it an overhead
i mean why should i need i need to know
the value changes which is happening in
real time
but remember it means
in case i have any validation
or custom validation it will be
triggered for each key press
sometime it becomes a
little bit
it can give you performance issues
sometime
in case you we have a small form doesn't
matter but in case you have a lot of
controls and every control has some
validation which is getting triggered
it may make your forms little bit slower
let me tell you angular is really fast
so probably you will never get to see
this issue but just just in case so how
we can avoid it so let me introduce you
to another property which exists on your
form controls
which lets you
control the behavior how
your form values will be changed
so right now values get changed on each
key press
that's a default behavior
to change the current behavior you can
do something like this so here we have
this validators.required validator.email
right
so here we can change this to
validators so we will say okay this is a
value and there is a property called
up
dated
on
once again
form control let me say
see where we have used form control so
we can
add control
yeah so uh
we have validators and update on sorry
not updated on so update on
move this
and let's update on
blur
and we need to change this to an object
so i prefer using new form control
rather than this but yeah it's okay we
will
do update
on
this is okay this is okay and this is
done and we haven't this as an extra
let's see uh
then we can pass you can remove this
and yeah let me just format
so
here with this we are passing an object
which has two values update on and then
we have validators so now for email
and let's add it for some other control
as well let's add it for mobile number
so i can just do something like this i
can
alright so i'm saying this is this will
be updated on
blurry
so blur is an event which will be called
once you move out of the control so
let's see
let's remove this
let's enter mobile number so you can see
no values is being captured in real time
so as soon as i press the keys it's not
happening
press the tab or move out of this
control you will see the values being
changed for others it will be same i
mean we have not changed the behavior
for entire form can we do that yes we
can you can also pass this value here
as the last option after your form is
created and you can pass the same
properties so you can say update
[Music]
update on blur and then in case you have
some validations which we will use
you can do that so let's
test it now
let's enter booking amount and you can
see it is not getting called as soon as
i move out of this particular control it
is getting called so this is the for
template driven form this is how you can
be
uh change the behavior uh based on uh
based on how your user interact so there
are three values which it has so you
have blur change and submit change is by
default
submit is really useful in case you
don't have any errors or any validations
or you want to show the validations once
your form is submitted so you can move
to submit so in that case
let's try to understand how it impacts
right so for change let's say you have
one of 10 controls
where i average users enter five keys so
10 into 50 times your change even it
will be called
in case we move on to blur it is number
of controls right so if you have five
controls
and
uh sorry ten controls and
let it be any any your users
enters any a number of times or any
number of values
only 10 times your changes will be
called on the control value changes
submit one events
you might be wondering i mean is it
possible to control uh the same for
template treatment forms yes it is i
just wanted to wait till this time to
let you know that okay this is possible
for template driven forms as well
and to do that we will go to
rooms add
here
so
we can use
ng model options here where you can pass
the properties so you can say update
and you can say okay
this will be plus
so this is how you can control it for
your
uh template driven forms
so uh remember ng model options and you
can see here so it has three properties
it has name standalone and update on so
update on uh is referring to these three
values which is change blur and submit
so you can set it for
um or set it to anything you like
yeah so this is how you can control uh
so this is how you can listen to the
control value changes and this is how
you can also control how you want to
listen to those changes
so this
uh this is it from value changes now we
can talk about
a few arrangements operators which we
can combine
with
value changes
and
we will discuss about few
map operators which exist in rxjs
and we'll try to understand each one of
them because that's really useful in
case you are working with rxjs in some
big project so let's go ahead and do
that to
the thing is now we need to connect to a
real-time api
and
what we will do is we will use the uh
jsonplaceholder api which we used in
past
because we want to post this data and
in jsonplaceholder actually you can post
anything you like
so let's
not json video json
placeholder
and
we will use post api
and let's see
so we can call slash post and that's it
so
here let's go ahead and create a booking
service first
i'm going to send you gs and
booking
service
and we'll use our http
and we also need to register should be
module so let's do that that should be
declined module and let's save this
and here we will use the http service
studio p
client
and we will say uh
book
room
which is
which has booking data so right now i
don't we will not create the interface
so let's do it as any which we should
not but yeah i mean this is anyways
uh dummy apis right so we can say this
dot
svp.post
and we will replace this with
placeholder jsonplaceholder
slash
posts
and we'll pass this booking data here
and let's remove the subscribe
and let's return
whatever we get
and
next
we will
inject this particular method
where is this component
so it's a private
room
booking
service or just call it as booking
service
and we will do it here so we'll set this
dot
booking
service dot
book room
and we'll subscribe to the changes so
let's say this is data
and
we will
listen
and we'll remove this reset as of now
because we want to
see different scenarios
so
this is one place
and
this is on submit right so i'll just go
console.log
data
which will be using
in some time but
let's go ahead and control some update
this right now and
so to see the example of how this
uh map operator works different map
operator works we will be calling
our submit method here let's see
so i'll say this dot
config our booking service
dot
book room
and we'll pass the data here
so
you can see actually what we are doing
is we are subscribing
or
um
okay so what we are doing here is we are
subscribing uh
the book room method within subscription
which is not a good practice but
we want to actually see the different be
different behavior which we have
while using the map operator so
this is not the way we are going to use
it so how we are supposed to do that
so here uh let's rewrite this and
we will be using it uh doing it via the
map operators so we can do
this dot booking form
dot
value
changes dot
pipe
and we will be using the different map
operators so let's start with merge map
and in merge map we will say okay this
is data and then we will be
uh
calling
this dot book room
let's comment this out
and let's see the behavior right now
and let's comment let's remove this and
let's go to the network tab because it
will give us clear idea how the
merge map operator works
so remember we have
right now um the form will be sub uh
like value changes will be called when
we move out of the control because we
have sent said uh
this updated on blur so let's remove
that this as well
and say uh rather than blur i will go
back
to
update on
[Music]
okay so
now as uh we have moved on with the
default behavior which is change let's
see how it behaves so network
amount
and
okay
see what's wrong here
okay we
have not subscribed so let's do that
and let's subscribe to this
data
and we'll just do console
dot log
it
let's see now
because as we discussed i mean of course
we need to subscribe it otherwise
nothing will be called
so let's remove this network tab and
let's enter the guest name and you can
see post requests being made
in parallel so you can see it doesn't
care so
now trying to understand different merge
merge operators so first is merge map
so in this case merge map does not care
about the sequence
so it will try to
post the data or
you can say subscribe to the stream as
soon as the data is provided
sequence does not matter much more
let's move on to the other operator so
we have mergement which says okay i
don't care about
the sequence as soon as i get the data
or a stream is
as a stream is emitted i will just go
ahead and
pass this stream to whoever has
subscribed
now next
which we will use switch map let's see
how switch my behaves
clear
network tab
yes can you see something uh which is
different
so let me just explain this behavior now
so you can see there are a lot of
requests which are being cancelled
what what is happening here so in case
of this switch map switch map will wait
sorry a switch map will cancel any
existing request if it receives a new
data
so let's say if you care about that
whoever has subscribed to your stream
should get the latest data only and
should previous data or previous stream
which is raised should be cancelled you
switch map operator is the way to go
now let's talk about the last one
which is exhaust map
let's enter
you can see i entered multiple
characters
exhaust map cares about the sequence so
it says until unless the previous
request is not completed i will not
subscribe to any latest changes so it
takes its time to complete the previous
one so you can see it has
uh so here you will see uh the data
let's talk about
request header
response
and
right so you have your data available
here so it says okay until unless the
previous request is not completed i'm
not going to call anything else so this
this api is i think it was never called
but you can see here so this
api started here it says 204 okay so
these are two apis which are called you
can see the first api request
and you will be able to see the values
requested a response editor payload
where you have all the data so we
entered the guest name and then it
waited until unless this request was
completed to
make the second request so you can see
the
rest of the values actually went into
second request so in case you care that
okay the previous
request which you made should be
completed before i can make a new
request
this exhaust map is your
operator which you are looking at
so we discussed about three map
operators which are really useful as i
said you don't have to use all the
operators like more than hundred
operators which exist you have to
remember uh
um list10 operators which we have
already used in this particular uh
uh in this particular course and if you
use uh all these operators if you master
all these operators
it's more than enough
and
once you move uh or once you get more
scenarios
you can actually explore more operators
but you don't have to start like
learning hundred operators on day one
now we will talk about how to write
custom validation for reactive forms
so
we will learn how we can add validation
for control and we will also see how we
can add
validation for form level which is a
little bit interesting because
you may get this issue and i'll talk
about few scenarios where actually this
is useful
but before we do
that let me just start
before we do that uh remember last time
we got some issue and we had to disable
bootstrap so what i have done is we have
just added this we have actually
enabled this input which seems to fix
the issue where
both
angular material and the bootstrap seems
to work so if you see uh this is the
form and this is the table right so it
both works
we'll also do one more thing we will do
a little bit clean up because we if you
see i mean on
all the pages we have lot of junk data
for example this which we
use just to
just to uh show you right how the data
looks like
so let's go ahead and clear those first
and then we'll move ahead
so i'll just i'll just keep it here it's
not like i'm going to remove it so you
can always refer
uh these values
and
gone
and let's
do one more thing
let's clear this as well uh we'll just
keep the table that's it
so
this is our rooms component
so let's
get rid of this
let's remove this
let's remove
those
and
let's click keep this and we will use
btn
between
success
let's remove
sorry
we'll keep roams list
the reason being okay
and
will disable those buttons too
let's see
room is missing following property rooms
list
okay
and looks a little bit better right i
mean now we don't have a lot of junk uh
data which is available here right now
and let's
comment this one too
i'm just doing it because you should
know that what are the changes which we
have done and that's it so now we can
click on book room and this is the book
room
component which is available here
so what we will do is let's go ahead and
add few custom
decorators are sorry not because sorry
uh let's go ahead and add some custom
validations to this reactive form and
let's see what are the different ways in
which we can do that
so let's start with a simple validator
where what we will do is we will
validate a control let's say example
guess name same same scenario which
we'll take remember in uh we wrote a
custom validator where we said okay in
case
there's a test in name uh go ahead and
reject this particular
value so it should show the validation
that okay the name is invalid same we'll
do it for guest so we'll add a
validation but using the custom
sorry reactive
well i mean
so we'll add a validation where we'll
say okay in case this name contains
value as test
we will
just give a validation error
how to do that so i generally try to
follow the same approach which is uh
followed by validators class
so let's go back to the booking
and
looking component
and remember we have already used some
validation right so we have added the
built-in validation right now which is
which uses this
validators.requirevalidators.email
if you see the implementation of
validators class it's a class with some
static methods so we'll try to follow
the same approach and
to
do that let's go ahead and add a folder
we'll call it as
uh valley
directors
and let's create a class so
[Music]
let's see ng generate um if it has a
class
uh i'm using uh this is okay let me just
show uh talk about this as well i have
added a extension for called nx console
which lets you do that so um
i'll just say this class name is custom
valley
dater
and project name is fine this is the
folder where i want to do it
and that's it run
and we have this class created
and here we will add some static methods
so let's
add some validators we will be adding
all the validators in this particular
file so i'll say this is a validate
value date name
and
so
let's talk about this now so we have a
validate validate name function and
it takes a parameter called abstract
control so what is this abstract control
is so abstract control is base class for
everything from group form control form
array so it's a base class so it knows
it has all the information which your
all
form control form group can have
and
you can get the value by using so
control dot value so this this will give
you uh the value uh which which which is
entered into the control right
so let's try to validate name so first
thing first thing which we'll do is i'll
say const
value
is equals to control dot value as a
string because uh if you see the value
is actually type of enemy
and i need some uh
as we know that we know that okay this
name is going to be string so we are
type casting it as a string
and we'll say if
value dot
includes
test
and it's the same so if remember
we can return an object in case there is
an error so i can i can say validate uh
not this one i can say return
in valid
name
truth
and if
this is not the scenario return null so
once you return null it means there are
no validation error
and let's see how to apply this
validator now so we can go to our
component
and we want to apply this to name so
let's see where the name is this as well
and you can add your validator in this
list of array so you can say okay this
is
custom
validator dot
validate name
and
let's go ahead and see
save this and here
let's go to the name
the guest name right so we will enable
this to see the list of errors which we
have
and let's go ahead and say login
let's select the room and here we are
and
let's enter a name which has like test
so you can see invalid name troop
so uh now
this is this is the simple validator
which we also wrote for uh
template-driven forms so where we are
just checking if this particular text
exists in this particular control just
go ahead and give this in validation
message
so
now the next validator which we will
write is something where we we can pass
some value so it's like
let's see
here right so you have mean length and
we wanted to pass how much the length
should be
so we will try to write a similar
validator and
what we will do is let's say in case
we want to restrict the special
characters in guest name
i mean of course it's not possible guest
name should not have contained special
characters but in case someone enters it
right or let's say mobile number so in
case someone enters
anything apart from plus
what's that
oh
i and
let's let's not take that scenario but
because it's it should be number i mean
you can go ahead and directly use the
pattern uh so it doesn't make sense but
yeah let's see
uh
guest name let's take guest link and
what we want to do is we want to pass
uh some characters which should not be
allowed
so it's it happens right so perfect
scenario for your passwords let's say
you have a password control and you want
to uh you don't want to allow some
specific uh special characters
and you want to re write the custom
validator for that so what we can do is
let's
write one
and say this is static
validate
special cat
right so we are saying okay uh let's see
so we are saying okay uh this
value
but
you might be wondering right now it
seems similar to this so what we are
missing so let me just show you what we
are missing so rather than passing the
substrate control here this will change
we will return control like this
and here
we will
and we we'll pass a character here so
it's okay this is character which is
type of string and we will check for
this character if this character is
available
okay so let's see what we are doing so
rather actually passing uh the
object directly we are returning the
function
so it's a function inside a function
right so this is the main function which
will take the parameter and then it will
return a function which will return
either invalid special character or
return null
and to use this there is only small
syntax change if you see so rather than
passing this control here we are just we
just moved it inside here
so let's try to use this and
we'll apply it on the same guest name
you can say custom validator dot
validate special care let's uh say
uh we are not supposed to use stuff
okay
so we pass start and if it
so if this uh if someone enters a star
into this particular guest name
it will be invalid name so let's enter
to do that
so we are
entering the right
name i mean
a valid name but we entered a star so it
says okay this is the invalid special
character so you should not use star so
this is how you can do that you can of
course implement your own whatever you
want to pass i mean
so
whatever character you want to pass
now third scenario which we will talk
about is
perform
so
where this type of validation is
sorry where this valid type of
validation will source so let's say you
have two controls right which you want
to validate for example password confirm
password here also we have an example
we have the second date and checkout
date right now i can just go ahead and
say
that my check-in date
is 20th
and checkout date is 10th
which is not possible right
so what in case we want to write a
validator which validates this which
validates okay this
check-in date cannot be greater than
checkout date
right so let's try to write a validator
for this how we can do it
let's go back to our validator class
so let's say this is static uh we'll say
validate
date
but rather than actually passing
abstract control right now i know that
this is this is a form group
and here we will
get the values for both so we'll say
okay give me the control call checking
date
and why this is keeping an issue
ah okay
so uh we i'm saying give me the value of
checking date and check out it let's
verify the
names i mean because this this object
should object name should match
so we have
check in date check out date days
capital in both the cases yeah looks
fine
but
let's put the logic to actually
calculate the date
so i'll say this is
new
i'm just typecasting it to date
and this is
new date
and we'll take difference between two
dates
okay first we need the timing
uh
check-in date check out it
let me just type cast it to any right
now so we
can see the stiffness
is less than equals to
zero
i'll say this is invalid date
and otherwise
let's return
let's verify this logic right so what we
will do is we will just do a console.log
for all the values to see
if
this is what we are expecting div days
and div
time
and
let's use it so what we have done is we
wrote a validate date function which
takes form group and we are checking uh
getting the two values checking date and
checkout date from this and then we are
calculating the difference let's go
ahead and apply this on booking
component.ts
and what i want to do is i want to call
this particular method once
my update on value is
blur
and
i want to call
validators
and which is
custom
validator
dot
validate date
okay
let's inspect
and we'll add a breakpoint so we can see
what
is the value which we are getting right
now so i can say here also to search a
file you can
let me show you some shortcut as well so
you can press ctrl p ctrl p on your
keyboard and then you can just start
entering the file name
so i need customvalidator.ts
and let's add some validation sorry
breakpoints here let's choose chicken
date which is already there
let's choose checkout date
and let's see
so we have checking date as this monday
feb 20 2020
and then we have checkout date
which is
right now
jan 18th
let's say the difference 708 days and
if div days is less than equal to zero
then invalid otherwise valid so right
now the form is valid let's
provide a date so this is 18th right so
let's select our
check-in date after
january so
let's see now so we have
check-in date checkout date and then dip
days should be my minus right now so
okay somehow it is 21.
how come
checking date minus checkout date
okay
let's try to select
10th
so jan 10th jan 18th
because we are doing absolute that's the
that's why
it is
okay probably something wrong let's see
okay so we were right i think this uh it
is happening because of this math dot
absolute
let's go ahead and remove this math dot
absolute because it is it is returning
as positive value
and in case we need
the diff in minus we should
let's try this out
and
it's disabled and run it
and let's enable uh now let's
provide our date so we'll just select
jan
18th
so uh right now okay this is not a
number that's that's okay
and let's select a previous
date and dave days
is
18th and 10th
okay so it should be checkout date minus
checking date if i'm not wrong let's
let's try this out so if i put
this date on 26th i think we should now
get a minus value
yeah so yeah so we just need to now
change
the position so i can say check out date
minus
second date
and we are true so now we have added a
validator which validates to date
right and this is something which you
can also take and apply to password and
confirm password
so let's supply jan
10th
and if i try to check out early
and let's apply uh give all the values
valid values
mobile number
let's
let's see
just want to give the valid values so
our required values
right so even though we have provided
all the valid values for required fields
there is still a
problem with the form validation because
the date condition is not satisfied we
cannot check in sorry check out early so
let's go ahead and
see this first
so here
i can apply
let me just close others so you can
right click here and say close others
booking form
dot
invalid
and
we will do one thing so right now it's
it's really hard to figure out right
where the problem is because
uh we are saying okay this
date does not match but we are not
displaying any errors so it will be
really confusing for our users to figure
out the actual error so what we can do
of course we can add a control level
validation
so let's do that let's
try to see how we can apply this to a
control level uh i mean how we can
actually apply this error to control
level uh
property
right now
uh this error is actually available on
form
it's not available on the control so
what we will do is we will add
here so we can do something like this so
we already have access to the control so
if you see this is uh control checking
date and checkout date so here we can
add something like this
get
dot
set error and we can save
[Music]
in validate true and of course it can be
null so just put it here and now this
error will be added to your control
let's go ahead and try to figure out if
it's true
so we will go to
checkout date checking date checkout
dave this is our checkout date
and we will use the same
approach
to print
the years
booking date checkout date here it is so
we'll take check out date
dot errors
check out date
and let's see let's see if this
particular control is applied to the uh
checkout date or not
so
[Music]
let's select a date 2020
jan and i'll say 18th and checkout date
is 10th so you can see it has a invalid
date error which is applied to the
control right now so this is how you can
actually also show meaningful messages
to your end user so they know okay what
we are doing wrong now let's go ahead
and print
fill in all the valid properties
and
let's try to submit this form
and dnc and looks like there is one more
validation error which is not satisfied
which one
okay
which which property is that
guest name
and here it is so now this book room is
valid
we submitted it let's see and this is
your guest email data which is available
here ids101 mobile
and
so remember right now we are actually
sending this data to our dummy api right
so which we which we wrote uh and which
we
uh took it from jsonplaceholder so we
are just sending this data back that's
it
and this is it
so uh this is how you can add custom
validator to your reactive form we
covered all the scenarios all the
scenarios which we can think of and
which
is useful in case you are writing the
validators for your application
so
ah this is it from the custom validator
part
let's go ahead and uh talk about one
route guards which we had left
we actually have two left uh we will
come to resolve but
let's see
let's talk about candy activate guard
sorry
so candy activate guard is something
where
we are saying that okay now you have
entered the route
but can you exit the route so we are
trying to
see if user our user is actually
uh
authorized to exit the uh route right so
here
example can be let's say you entered
into theater but can you exit the
theater i mean probably you need some
authentication to exit
so you are locked until unless let's say
move finishes or you have
interval
so to
generate or to have a real-time scenario
here what we will do is we will create
we already have a booking form
so what we'll do is in case there is
some information or let's say our form
is in dirty state it means
as a user i came and i made some changes
into my form
and if i try to exit we should display
some message let's say saying
you are not authorized to actually or
you have some pending changes you can
display a pop-up saying you have some
pending changes do you really want to
accept
some kind of message right
so
we will be
trying to generate the same scenario so
let's see
with candy activate the fun thing is you
can do it for a routed component
so if you see our booking is actually
one of the routed component which is
available here
so i'll just change the path a little
bit
okay
i'll make it as
uh booking
slash
room id
so we are booking for a specific room
okay
and
here on
rooms
we had a route so if you see uh
we said okay this should redirect to
booking component
and
it's it's another booking component
right so actually we never
did anything here so what we'll do is
we'll remove this
okay so we removed this particular route
we have booking slash
or room id
let's go back to the rooms list
component here
and here we will say redirect to
booking
slash room number
let's verify this change and then we'll
proceed
and to do that we have to log in let's
see
and let's click on book room
so we are here booking slash one right
so we are getting the book uh room id
for which we want to book so this is
first we
are here
next step we will try to get this id
here with this room id
let's go back to our
booking
ts
and how we can get that data so by using
activated route we have seen that
we'll say this is private
and
this is route
activated route
and we can uh do something like this
here so we can say
once
room
id and we can say okay from param just
get me the room id
and now i can pass this room id here
as we are inside the ngo unit we don't
need to do this dot room id
let's verify this in this behavior
click on
this
and we have this two and this two but
you might be wondering okay that was the
default one let's try to use it for
three okay it's still two let's see what
is wrong here
room id
this is a reset i think uh get booking
data yeah
remember we hardcoded this
get booking data where is this function
here i'll remove this because we don't
want this default value for room id
so it's empty room id
and let's go back to rooms
let's login again
let's click on
room
okay so now this value is not available
let's see why so
we can debug
let's go to src
app
okay
and booking component
and this is the line number
so let's
see what's wrong here
click
and f10 to my d is
okay
param id it says it's room id available
but
params.get room okay high capital okay
cool
so the code was correct only problem is
the uppercase and lowercase so let's fix
that
and
we will say okay this is room type
remember the key should match
let's refresh this page now
and let's see
and now we have the id okay
great let's move
okay i'll
probably close this and
[Music]
open it again
and let's click on
this
and works right so we have room id3 and
now we are looking for a specific room
so this is the second step so first we
fix the route second we are sick we are
saying okay we are we wanted to book it
for specific room we are here and now we
want to add the card to make sure that
in case there are some unsaved changes
on this form
we should send a message we should show
a message to the user that okay
there are some unsafe changes so let's
see if we can use some material control
to do that so i think material has
something for us
material
angular material
so we can use this
let's see
yeah we can use this matte dialog to
show and dialogue saying you have
someone say unsave changes
but let's do it later first let's add a
card
here we will create
and i'll say this is ng g
g
and this is booking guard
and what we need is we just need can
deactivate and that's it
so you can see in can deactivate we are
getting one extra parameter so we have
something known as component so this is
the routed component so we will pass
this booking component as one of the
parameter
here which is unknown
and same here so let's go ahead and see
what we can achieve using this
so now we can
put and
check
so i can say
in case this
component
dot the property which is booking form
dot
if it is dirty
so
if it is ready so go ahead
and so
yeah so it's if it is dirty we should
not allow the user to exit if it is
pristine we should allow user to exit so
i'll just go ahead and save pristine
and let's verify uh by applying this
card so we will
apply
this can
deactivate
to the smoking guard
this and pass the booking out again it's
an array so you can pass multiple
let's verify this functionality so far
and then we'll add the dialog
so we have this let's try to click
somewhere else we are not able to
redirect
right so you can see i cannot um
let's try again with login you might be
wondering okay probably because the
state has reset we are not able to but
let's
log in and see
right so we have three let's enter
something let's try to move and we are
not able to do it
let's reset this form so i'll refresh so
it's in pristine state let's try to move
so
let's see we are able to redirect
this is it
so we it means our
guard is working perfectly fine
let's put the dialog now
[Music]
so here let's see some example open
dialog okay
cancel let's
see the code
and open dialog
we can pass some example dialog here
or let's uh
not do this i think there is another
control which
where we can just directly pass the
message uh there is that
divider date picker chips
let me just go to
the default page i think there are there
should be
slider buttons
okay uh
no we are not looking for chips we are
looking
for
you know progress bar
elephants
okay
stripper tabs toolbar duty
okay let's see
okay this is not
let's see there should be a way to
hmm
let's
and pass
some
data okay so we will we'll be using this
one we'll be using dialog to uh show
that okay uh we'll show the message that
okay you have someone save changes this
is what we are going to do here
now let's go back to the booking card
and here uh let's
use import the
api
image dialog module
and
let's go to the example
so it says okay you have to pass an
component so let's create a component
[Music]
okay we can use snapper okay this this
will be uh the easiest one so snack bar
is something where you can
display a message like this so let's say
here right so we can display a message
it's a simple api and then dialog
because we don't need to create a
component but we will add this
try to use dialog
module if you can if you want to try
this out
and here
uh in
the thing is you can just inject a snake
mat snake bar
into your service so let's do that
we'll do a constructor and then inject
the snag bar
and here we can do before we return this
message right so we will say if
component
is pristine
return this
else what we are going to do is we are
going to return false anyways
but
we will open this dot snack bar dot
from template open
we can open and then we can say okay you
have unsaved changes and that's it
let's verify this one
click
so admin
admin and click on booking room
and let's
do this and try to move
okay let's see what's wrong
huh
so circular dependency for booking guard
okay so how the how
is that
a circular dependency
book module
it says booking guard is
no provider for matt's name bar okay
let's see let's see the api so in case
we want to
we have to provide something
so um
so we had to actually just add matte
snack snack bar module into app module
as well somehow to uh make sure that it
works so now let's go ahead and verify
this functionality so you can see let me
just refresh this page so we uh go to
login
admin and then be
logged in
click on book room
go to employee works
go back book employee now let's make
this form dirty
let's try to move and you can see you
have some unsafe changes so we are not
able to redirect but we are also
displaying this message that you have
someone save changes and you can just
discard complete the form and then once
your form is
in pristine state you can just go ahead
and redirect or move from this
particular
url so this is how you can uh
use can deactivate card this was a real
time example which i can give you
sorry this was a real-time example which
i can give you you can find more uh
more real-time use cases in your
application as you go
but you don't have to probably you will
not get the scenario i mean once you
start the application so yeah this is
it so
now next what we are going to do is we
are going to discuss about how you can
use
form control
you might might be wondering okay we
already saw form group and we also saw
form control now why we are talking
about form control again so we will see
that example
and we will apply
that with a pipe
so we will write our own custom pipe
let's talk about the scenario where we
are going to use it
so on this page right so if you see this
on on this page what we will do is we
will add a text box here
which will be like kind of filter where
we can enter the room price and it will
filter the values based on that roon
price
okay so let's see how we can
do that
so this is our rooms page
let's go to the rooms component
here
so if you remember this values is
actually coming from
this particular service so we are
calling room service and from here we
are getting this all these values so
what we will do is we will apply a
filter
something like this so let's let's let's
try that out let's do uh let's write the
code first
so we are going to use reactive form
here so we will add
react deforms module first
and
let's create a form sorry form control
because we just need a single control
and to do that what we will do is we
will create
we'll call it as a search
or
price
filter
sorry
which is is type of or which is
equals to new form control
remember this we are seeing new form
control and we are passing default value
as 0
let's render this
here
we will say this is div
and we will provide our input
input
type
which will be number
class which will say
is form control place
holder we will say this is
twice
and here
as we don't have form group we will be
using something known as
form
form control
is equals to the
price filter
and let's
do this so we will just
put price filter here to see if whatever
value we enter is getting applied or not
so let's go ahead and
test that first and then we'll apply the
filter so we'll save this is
admin
and
so uh
you can see this value right this value
is getting changed so as i have right
now it's a control right so control will
have all the properties pricing dirty
all this all those properties
what we are interested about is value so
values getting changed that's it the
first step which we have done is okay we
are able to apply or sorry we are able
to get the values from this particular
control
step undone now the next step which you
want to do is we want to apply this
value filter to this rooms list how we
should do that
so here
what we will do is we will
create another property called price
filter
so let's see
how we can do that rooms list
html
and we will apply uh we'll pass that
value here somewhere
with a new pipe which will create so
let's go ahead and create that pipe and
so we can say ntg type and we'll see
this is filter
so
i'm creating kind of a filter but
remember never do that no never do that
on a real-time application always go
ahead and uh do filter sorting at your
back end i mean at your api level just
don't do it at your front end i mean
this is just an example
and now uh we can
say okay this
pipe will have multiple parameters so
first parameter is something which will
have
the list of rooms so i'll say this is
rooms
and which will be of type
let's see the type here
room
list
right so we will say okay this is
the array and the second parameter would
be
price
which is type of number
let's
and here we will return we'll say okay
this rooms
drop filter
where price is less than this price or
sorry
where rooms dot price is
so if you enter 5000 so yeah it looks
correct
and then we can apply this filter pipe
so let's see this
rooms
list
we'll do one thing i'll just avoid this
change direction strategy on push
and then we can apply this pipe
filter and we have to pass a value so
let's pass 1000 right now
no more phones
let's see
unknown was not assigning
let's fix this issue so it says uh
unknown okay so here if you remember we
are actually passing unknown here so we
will say okay this will return an array
we can remove this an empty array in
case
uh
this that is this is not satisfied so
let's go ahead and test this because it
should work i mean we have we are
passing hard coding this values right
so let's go ahead and see our ui
and we will say admin admin
and you can see it only displays the
values which is less than thousand less
than equal to thousand
right now we are not passing this value
so
let's go ahead and now fix that
so this value will be our filter
so we will
take another input
and we'll say this is price
which is equal to 0
and we will use this price
here
and let's verify again
so
and
okay so there is nothing which is less
than zero so
i think our filter logic is wrong we
should do this
right so
i want to filter everything which is
above this particular value so yeah this
looks correct
and now
let's pass
this filter
which is now a new person
not filter but price which is the new
property which we have added
is equals to
price filter
dot
value
let's see
and let's enter um
500 so you can see now i can see only
values which is greater than 500 let's
enter 5000 now we can see only values
which is greater than 5000 so which is
15 there is only one record which is
available
so this is how you can combine form
control
with a filter so this is a real-time
example which i can which i can give you
and you can utilize that in case of you
want to just create some filters on your
page you don't want to have a form
basically so in that case just utilize
the form control that's it you don't
need to create a form group
so
this is the flexibility which reactive
forms gives you and then we apply it we
added it with a pipe custom pipe where
we wrote a logic that whatever price we
provide
it will
filter out all the room first price
which is greater than this price which
is provided
so this is it from reactive forms and
let's move on
now let's go ahead and talk about the
last card which we had left and we said
okay this card is
little bit different from the existing
cards we saw that okay can activate can
deactivate connect with child and can
load cards are related to the routes
but
what about resolve guard and why it was
not available when we tried to create a
guard and it was not available in the in
the list of options which we had
so
this one card is actually related to
data featuring
okay let me okay just uh i said data
fetching but it's not data featuring its
state of prefetching
so might be wondering what is data
prefetching
generally what we do is whenever we want
to display some
records or display some data what we do
we go to the component and then
we make a service call to get the data
that's what we generally do
but what in case let's say
we have a requirement that okay this
user should not
go to this particular view until unless
the data is available in case something
goes wrong there is no point actually
redirecting the user to that particular
view
so this is this is a scenario where
resolve guard can help you so resolve
card can help you preface the data let
me show you an example
we need some records for this and we
will be using uh we'll let's do one
thing we'll create another component
and we need some data so we don't have
some dummy data available right now we
need like more than 1000 records
or let's see how many records this json
placeholder got
so it has
comments
which has like 500 records
okay let's uh see let's uh use this
comments api
and to do that uh what we will be doing
is we will be creating another component
and let's do
so it's a nggm
and this is post
comment
i'll use iphone fill route
is equals to
comment
and hyphen iphone routing and i want to
use um app module i want to register
this in app module
so this will be lazy loaded of course
and we got this component and now what
we will do is we will create a service
for this
and let's verify the routing so we have
our route available here
and okay everything is good now let's go
ahead and create the service
ngcs and then this is
command service
we are going to need a certificate
module here
as we are going to make an http call
in service
let's inject so it's private
um
http
srdp inclined
and we'll call get comments
this dot
http dot get
and
written
this is the api so we'll use this
done
and let's uh do one thing i'll just put
this and let's create a table
and it's the class is table
and then we will have pr where
we will put our headers so we will have
bunch of
ph
and say this is let
command talk
comments this is the property which we
are going to use
and then we will use some tds
okay let's see how many properties we
got post id id name 1345
so let's go ahead and create an
interface
i'll call this as
comment
dot
ts
and let's create export
interface
we have
id which was
of type number
post id which is the gain type of number
is capital players
we have name which is string we have
email
which is again string and then we have a
body
we go
which is again string
let's go to service and say okay this
http get should return the comment array
and this comment remember uh there is uh
somehow there is an comment api which
exists inside inside typescript itself
so let's name it as comments just to
avoid this issue which i faced in
one of my project actually
and
let's go to component and here
we will use the service so say private
let's close this
and we'll see this is
command
service
this type of
comment
service
and then we can just say this is
comments
is equals to this
dot
command service dot get comments okay so
now we can use it here
with the sync pipe
and let's
use
comment dot
id post id
and your name
[Music]
so
okay
command of name
and then we have email
and let's not put body here and let's
apply the same id
post id
name
image
it says okay so we are missing 5 async
and
let's format this format
let's add a navigation here
and we will not apply any
[Music]
guard
and this is
comment
let's go ahead and see so we have
comments that will be here and it says
this is not available comment is not
available so
okay i made a spelling mistake somehow
comment
okay so
let's see one thing let's see a behavior
here so you can see when i click on
comments there is an empty page and then
the data is getting loaded
so
what in case uh i don't want to show an
empty page
so this is also one scenario where you
can actually use it
that okay
when my view is loaded it should be
loaded with data not without data
but remember keep one thing in your mind
you can use resolve card with
a
use case where your data will not change
after it is loaded
okay so
now let's try to fix this issue by using
the resolve card so we will create
a new
folder here
we'll call it as
guard
let's go to integrate terminal
lcng
and this is
comment
comment that so let's
and you can see i don't have any option
so i have to
at least choose one so we'll use can
activate but we'll remove it
and then
let's remove this one
and we need resolve card so
this is i think this is the one yep this
will resolve that and we have to define
what kind of data this resolve guard
will written
so we will say okay this will return the
commands
array
and here
let's there's an extra okay so you can
see right now what i'm saying is it will
uh return a
value of observable of type comments
or promise of comments or comments so we
are saying this resolve interfaces which
is coming from here
okay so resolve of type t so which type
of data you want to return
so comments of array and this is it now
let's go ahead and apply this command
card and see how it is so you can see
i'm just calling the same command
service which which we were calling from
the component earlier so
let's go and apply this guard first so
how we can do that
we can go to the card
and we can say resolve
now resolve the way a result works is it
is a key value player so you can say
comments this is the key
and then you can say okay this is the
comment resolver
right it's not available comments
coming back okay
great so now this will be returning the
comments data
and let's see how we can actually access
this
so this is the key remember this
and to access this data now we can go to
component
and here let's use
what do you think which service will be
used here
remember when we talked spoke about
router we spoke about a service called
activated route we said anything related
to data
you should use the activated route
service
so here we will of course use the same
and first try to see if this data is
available so we'll what we'll do is
activated route dot
sign
we'll say data dot subscribe and let's
see what we get here
and we comment this out or let's let let
it be as of now let's see
and we can see this comment component.ts
line number 19 which is actually giving
us sorry which is also
giving us this key so you can see it has
a key comments and then it has 500
records so let's try to access
data
dot
um
we can do something like this
and let's see so now we will get the 500
records rather than that
which
just missed the console.log
and here it is so we have all the 500
records available and we have this data
prefaced it's not like we are actually
navigating to the route
and then getting the data no we are
prefetching the data so here we can also
do something like this let's try to
use it as a stream so i can say this
comments
stream is this dot
activated route dot
data and then we can use pipe of data
and
here
we can do
by
map
data
and we can use plug
to
get
the comments let's see let's try this
out
let's see if this is the correct use
case
okay no
we can apply
lock here
uh sorry this is not the way to use it
so we can just use this plug operator
here and then we can define what key
want we want to access
this is it so we can say okay this
command
is
we are getting this comment from
activated route data dot pipe and then
we are
plugging this particular key from the
stream
and we can remove this now we don't need
it i was just writing it to show you in
case you want to subscribe how you can
do
how you can actually do that
let's see the stream now
so rather than comments i'll be using
comment and see if it works so let's
save this and save this
okay now let's go ahead and move from
comments oh sorry move from any other
route to comments you can see there is
some delay but actually data is getting
loaded without any
blank page so because the data is
already prefaced it just need to render
it generally the approach with tag is we
take is we landed on the ui and now you
have to uh wait until your ng on init
lifecycle event will be called and then
it will go ahead and call your service
and load the data now
now we what we are doing is we are just
using the activated route data to pick
uh sorry plug
this uh data which is already provided
into your route so we already added this
uh into our resolve card so we are
saying okay before you migrate or sorry
before you navigate to this route
go ahead and
preface this data so this data should be
available before my user
will navigate to this so this is another
use case for using the prefetch or you
can say resolve card so i am keeping the
same uh both the ways
feel free to use whatever fits your
scenario i have also this code available
in case you don't think that this is
something which you need
generally we should not use this let me
show you a better way to do this
you can actually do
uh something like this you can provide
the type so you can say okay this is
this will be my
comment
comments which will be type of
comments
array
something this should work
no load matches this call when so
create anonymous function
comments and
comments is type of this area
let's see if it works
somehow
hmm strange
this is the best way we can do this
let me just remove it so we can say data
and
here
you can type cast here so you can
actually create a common create a
property
comments which is type of
comments
array
is equals to this and then you can say
that this dot
in comments
is equals to data of like this so this
is how you can uh do it
and you will get the typing after this
so in case these are three ways here we
call the method to get the data after we
landed on the view this is
using the resolve method and we use the
stream we uh we have not used uh the
subscribe method we have not manually
subscribed which we did here
but uh choose when which fits your
scenario
now in this video we are going to talk
about how you can do global error
handling we have seen like how we can
do error handling for http service but
what in case we want to do it at global
level
okay so let's go ahead and try that out
so angular provides you a
class
that's a class
sorry so angle provides you a
service which which is already available
called error and handler so
what you can do is you can actually
extend that particular service and you
can provide your own info your own
implementation
so here let's uh
go ahead and do that
so i'll create a class
here called
error
handler
service parties
and we'll create this class export class
and we'll call it as global
error
handler
which extends
error
handler
and now uh you can just call the handle
error method so let's see
this must have an overwrite
okay let's see
so we have error handler implements
error handler and
handle error
which does something so i'm just
wondering what's
wrong here
that should be
okay you
looks correct to me okay sorry
implements
implements error handler and then it's
it's a actually you can see it's a class
but you can also implement it because it
provides a single method which is
just like a method definition not the
implementation so i can just go ahead
and implement it and then we are just
doing console.log right now
now to handle this to register this you
can of course go ahead and see how we
can do it so you have to go ahead and
add it into providers
like this so let's copy this
and let's go to our app module because
we want to actually handle the uh
error at global level
and we'll say okay this is provide error
handler and then
this is our global
error handler class
now we need to introduce some error
let's do that
let's verify if it is working fine right
now so
okay nothing uh no issue so what we will
do is we will go to this comment abn
command service and then we will just
make some mistake here right so this api
does not exist and it will throw an
exception
now you can see uh there is an error
handler line number of five which says
http error response and this says okay
this api does not exist right or the
status code is 404 it means it is not
able to
go ahead and catch this particular api
or
go ahead and access this particular api
so it says again it does not exist and
we are able to handle this exception at
global level by using our new global
error handler class
and
you can do more right i mean it's not uh
in our example we are just using the
console.log but you can actually send it
to your backend or you can actually send
it to your
whatever apis which you have
and you can save this error somewhere
so whenever you are revisiting your like
error logs to see if there is some
problem which
your users are facing because there are
some
edge cases right we generally miss out
so just go ahead and add error vendor
class and lock all the errors until
unless your
application becomes stable and then you
can remove it
let's
talk a little bit about testing
of course when whenever you are working
on some application you need to also
write unit test cases that's the
developer's job but there are many types
of testing which is uh
which is done so we have unit test cases
or unit testing which is written by
developers and then you also have
something known as integration test or
end-to-end test which is generally done
by the testers so
the tools are a little bit different so
for example for end-to-end test tests
you can use something known as cypress
or
other tools like playwright which is
also available you can use
and a lot of
older applications used to have
a protector so protector is discontinued
now angular team decided to drop
maintaining it so they are not
maintaining it anymore and they have
also dropped this dropped creating an
end-to-end application with
angular cli so before
before angular 12 they uh whenever used
to create a new application there used
to be a end to end application as well
which used to be created but now uh it
is not created anymore so you have to go
ahead and add any uh compatible uh
end-to-end uh
test suit to your application so cyprus
is preferred which is used by many
large
organization it is open source project
uh there are some paid features which is
like dashboard which is which which
probably you you will not need that much
but yeah it's an open source project so
you can go ahead and use it for free
so let's see what we are going to cover
here so we are going to talk about unit
test that's it so we will introduce you
to tests
and then we'll talk talk about how you
can write your first test and then we'll
see how we can test a component and how
we can test test a service
let's go ahead and do that
so angular by default gives
the setup for
unit test so remember this karma
converges and we spoke with we said
while going through the project
structure we said this is the file which
will be used by uh your task runner
that's it
but we never discussed more
more about it so
angular uses karma plus jasmine to
write the test case so you can actually
do ng test you can run this command and
it will run all the
test file which is available here which
ends with dot spec dot ds of course
right now if we execute it
you will get a lot of errors so let's
see i mean so it's starting the chrome
browser this is how it looks like
it does
there are many type of reports uh
reporter which we have available right
now this is html reporter which uses
chrome
and it it will open everything in chrome
and it will show you how many tests are
getting passed how many tests are
getting failed
so let's go ahead and see that
so it says incomplete no specs found
somehow
because there are some errors right so
you can see
there are some errors which is making
this
so let's see what this error is it says
expected to argument right now what we
will do is we will just
remove this
and let's see
so at least we get the uh feel right how
your ui looks like
once you run the ng test and how your
report looks like sorry
testing is a whole topic all together so
it says
there are because there are different
tools which are available so we are not
going to go into that much detail here
it will just we will introduce you to
the testing
and let's see
probably there are no errors you can see
right now so uh there it says there is
32 specs which
out of which 21 is failed so you can see
spec list the green ones
zoom in so this green ones
is successful and this
red ones of course it shows that this
this is a failure so this is how you can
figure out okay which test is getting
passed which can which test is getting
failed uh so here in command service
should be created so you can see okay
it's not
uh it is giving me error right now so
you can just click on the test as well
to see what's going wrong
so it says okay
it says no provider for stripping line
so while testing we are not providing
the http line module so that's the
problem so we can fix it so let's see
let's try to do that so here in command
service
uh service dot spec we can do
[Music]
test
configure testing module and then we can
say import
http
client testing module so there is
something known as stupid client
skippy
testing
what's that called html
let's say the p client module let's
reclined
okay let's try to pass the stripy client
module right now and see
because this http client of course
exists inside http line module
so
[Music]
okay uh let's see specialist okay it's
green failed
and let's see failures
and now you can see there are 20
failures so earlier there was 21
failures so probably
let's go to spec list and see comment
so you can see comment service created
passed
but uh i mean this is just to show you
how the report looks like and how you
can see uh what is the error you can
just click on this line and it will tell
you uh that okay this is the actual
error and why this particular test is
getting fit so let's go ahead and try to
write a little bit
of test cases for a component and a
service
see how we can write a sample test case
using jasmine so the idea is to give you
uh
sorry
so uh the thing is uh it will give you a
little bit idea how you can actually
write adjustment test cases and let's
create a test file so i'll say this is
test test.spec.ds
so here uh generally what you do is you
write a describe block
where you will describe that what you
are trying to test
and to do this i'll create a file as
well so i'll say this is
test
dot ds
so
let's see if there is another test.dcs
so i'll say this is test
service
dot ds
so the first thing is you will write
that okay let's
let's add a class which is
uh
calculator class
and then we will have some functions
which will say one is add
and then we have subtract
and multiply
okay so there's a few uh few
implementations which we have inside
this calculator class let's go ahead and
see how we can test it so the first
thing is
uh we need to import what we are trying
to test so it's okay we are trying to
test
service
so it's okay this is describe
and we'll say this is test service
and we'll see okay this is
where we are writing the code so
your
tests should look like a story so we are
saying okay we want to test this so in
describe we are saying okay we are
trying to test this particular service
and then you will write the steps what
you are trying to achieve
so first is of course i will say uh
should
add two numbers
right so this is one of the tasks or one
of the test case uh for our particular
this particular service so i can say
okay const uh service
is equal to new
uh
test service which really
take it
uh sorry import it from here
what was the name
not calculated sorry
so we created a new calculator service
and then we can do something like this
so we can say expect
so uh we have to write our expectation
that what this test case should do so we
are saying that okay whenever we run
this test case
just go ahead and add this to number and
the
answer should be 4 that's our
expectation so similarly i can just do
it for uh should
subtract
two numbers and then we can say if this
is subtract and
we'll say answer should be zero
let's go ahead and run this so we can
just to insert test and it will go ahead
and run all the test case because this
file matches the
format which is dot
spec.ts it will open it in browser
so a lot of
projects also use something known as uh
just
for testing
which is little bit faster but right now
it's not compatible with angular 13
that's one of the issues
okay
so uh we are saying we are seeing now
there are 34 specs and let's go to spec
list and
let's see calculator one
i'm sorry we said test service right
yeah so you can see uh these two
these two tests are getting passed so
should add two numbers and should
subtract two numbers it's getting past
so this is how you actually will be
writing the test start with describe
block and then you will be writing the
story that okay what now this this
should do so it should add two numbers
it should subtract two numbers
so this is a simple test case
and see how we can
test our service
so here let's try to do a service
let's try to test this shared data
service right so we already have a spec
file available here
and
there is something known as configure
testing module which we don't need right
now but
let's see
what we can achieve using this so here
i will say it should
emit
the message basically what we are going
to do here is we are going to test the
uh send message right so if you remember
in shared data service we said
send message which actually
emits
a new message
right so
i'm sorry so if it emits a new message
so we will check this so here we will do
this dot our service
dot set message
okay and once we do this the expectation
is
we should get a hello message
in this stream so we will do something
uh simple right now so we can say
message
dot subscribe
and then we can say
uh expect this message to be hello so
sorry this will be service dot
message stream and then we'll say
message to be hello
and now let's stop this let's uh
disconnect the test we will also see
something uh ng test hyphen iphone code
coverage let me tell you about this as
well
while testing you can also test how much
code is being covered by your test cases
so
there is no hard rule i would say i mean
it depends upon how much code you think
is worth testing
sometime of course we set a hard target
that we should go for hundred percent
test for uh coverage or we can
uh go to eighty percent code coverage i
think it's it's a false uh alarm i would
say most of the time you may get a false
alarm the thing is you should
concentrate on
what logic is worth testing i mean do
you think this this should be tested if
it is not i think it's okay to skip so
here let's see what is wrong
i think there is an extra bracket here
so
message
then it should close here
and then we have
the
outer one and closed let's see
so
it's completed now tests are running
and you can see the one which we are
looking at
is
shared
let's go to the spec list first
shared so you can see shared uh data
service and
it says this was successfully so
should i meet the message it means uh
what our expectation was that whenever
we
send uh this set message whenever we
call this set message it should go ahead
and
message
whoever has subscribed to the message
should get this hello message and that's
what we tested and it worked
so here you can see uh the code coverage
is of course right now pretty bad so we
have statements which is covered at 43
lines 38 of 9 38.9 of lines are covered
and then we have functions which is like
34 percent covered
so uh now let's go ahead and see an
example of a component so we already
have some components which is getting
failed right so let's see rooms
component should create
now let's see how we can actually fix
this particular test case and you can
click on error and see what is the error
so it says okay the thing is you need to
provide an injection token
okay
let's see how we can work with this
there is
a few there are few errors so let's see
let's go to what is this
not room service but
which component was this room
it was at rooms component let's let's go
back
i think it was rooms component so let's
go back to rooms
component prospector keys okay
so we have this it says okay we we have
not provided the config service because
remember uh you have to go ahead and
provide all the services which your
component is using right now so it uses
room service it uses config services you
it uses shared service
so we can uh
go to our site
we can go to this and here
we can add providers so we can say okay
providers parry
and let's
add all those providers which are being
used so we have room service we have
config service
and we have a shared data service
and let's import each one of these
and
let's see
now uh let's see what's the error we are
getting right now it says also activated
route is not provided
and http client will see some uh the
errors will be gone one by one so it
means we need uh to import
imports that should be
client module
let's see http
i think that was testing as well
and institute
we can use the testing module rather
than actually original module we can say
okay i want to use the testing model not
the original one so
once this is done let's see
let's refresh
so
now we will see
less number of errors here so it says
now let's talk let's see http error it's
gone right so we don't have http any any
more
then it says okay uh this one from
comment component we don't need this so
let's go to the special list
look for
rooms component and let's go to should
create
and see the errors
so now the problem is it says room
service which uses injection token so we
have to provide the injection token now
let's see what how we can do that
so rooms
service
and this is the injection token which is
being used so we can actually mock this
we can do something like this here
you can say okay provide
app service config
and then you can we can say use uh value
so let's see uh what this app config is
so it has api endpoint
so we can go back to our
component.spec.ts and say okay this is
atm point
is
this dummy value so
you can
provide any dummy value you want to
and now let's see
okay it's getting disconnected
let's rerun
and let's go to specialist
rooms
component should create and let's see
the error now
so we have
now the
thing is config service also uses an
injection token
so let's see so config service
it uses injection token call config
token
let's provide the same so we can say
provide
cloud config token
and
we need the value so right title
so here
we can
go back let's
and say
use
value
title
as
booms
and
let's see
so now this this injection token should
be also resolved so you can pass uh
values like this you can also re replace
these services as well so you can create
an empty service let me show you that
example as well let's refresh this it
says it disconnected again
let's go to special list
rooms
rooms component should create and let's
see what is the error now
so it says cannot set properties of
modified undefined setting title so now
it is trying to call the
methods which is available here so you
can see it says uh here
so these are the methods which are being
called so it is trying to now execute
all those methods so here
it says uh
after viewing it line number ta130 so
line number 130 is this so it says
header component or title rooms which is
a valid failure if you remember what we
did is we have removed header component
from here
so it doesn't exist anymore so
uh it was a valid test case uh valid
failure which got
uh captured so we can actually do
something like this right so we can
actually uh enable this header component
so we we can put one header component
and see if it works
right so i can say hi and b header and
you will find now another error being
replaced
being
rendered so let's refresh
so as soon as you are like
earlier we were getting some error
because the services which we provided
were not correct so now we provide all
the services all
everything
and
it is trying to execute engion in it and
it is trying to execute ng after minute
so it will start calling all the life
cycle looks
so
looks like there is some issue with this
anyway so we can do one thing
as we know that this is not the scenario
this won't be available anyways we'll uh
save i mean replace this and comment
this out
and let's see
[Music]
so now we should get a different error
ah okay it's completed so you can see
should create so now your component is
initialized now you can go ahead and
check for the methods
right so we can add another let's say
uh
method so let's for example uh let's try
the toggle
so i'll say it
should
toggle
so uh
so uh what we need to do is we have to
say component.toggle and expect what
should we expect so we should expect
hide rooms
right so we can say uh here we can set
component
dot hide rooms
is equals to false and once we call
toggle
we should it should become true that's
what the expectation is so let's go
ahead and see if it works
again build the connection
that's why uh people use just and or we
we can also use
the reporter as your command prompt
that's also fine
and let's see so now rooms has
our
rooms should toggle right so you can see
should toggle is also completed it means
now this test is also passed
so similarly you can call different
methods and see if they are getting
completed or not in services as well we
uh
saw an example how we can work with
observables
so you can just call the method and see
if this observable is limited or not so
this is just a basic understanding of
testing because as i mentioned testing
is a huge topic in itself and
there are some courses which are i mean
we can probably go ahead and create
another course covering all those
scenarios so this is it from this
particular course
this video we will see how we can
deploy our application
on netlife so there are many providers
many cloud providers where you can
actually go ahead and deploy your
front-end application network being one
it's it's really simple to use so let's
go ahead and see how we can
do that
right so first thing which we need to do
is we need to push this code on github
we have not done that let's do it
so i'll go ahead and create an account
uh sorry my repository first thing which
you have to do is you have to create
your account that's the that's the step
one
and now i can go to my repositories and
i can create a new repository from here
and here i am going to name it as
hotel
in
mandatory
let me just zoom in
yeah so hotel inventory this is the uh
and
let's see
i'll keep everything as
as it is
let's see if we have
hmm
right now i have made this repository
public but
we'll move it to private
as the netlify
will charge me for deploying
and repository which is private so i'll
just use it try public right now
and once this is done i need to actually
push the existing code base so i'll do
this
here
get this as a branch this is final
code
and you get
i'll commit this changes git commit and
we'll say
first let's add all make sure that all
files are added
and then we'll add a commit
and we will say this is
final code
and let's move back to the master
okay so this somehow this change was
left
add
means changes
and let's move back to
the main branch and as we already have
the code available so
our repository available on my local
machine we'll be using this one this
command
so let's add
then we need to do is
push
actually this command was to change the
branch name domain but we already
were using the branch name as main and
now let's push this code
and look let's refresh this
and then right so we have this this
repository available now let's go back
to netly file
sorry let's go to netlife if i login i
already have my account available in
case you don't have it just go ahead and
create one so just login
and
in package.json i am going to add a
command
which will be build rod so to build the
broad uh
plot bundle we have already seen the
command so we we use ng
uh
build
hyphen c is equals to production
so this will this command will be used
so i'll just add get add
get comment
add
pod
build
okay somehow this file was not staged
properly
okay
so let's see if latest changes are
available
and this
okay i have to push
okay so i pushed i have post all the
changes here and now it should be
available
so add plot build the list commit is
available here let's go to the nutley
file and you we can what we can do is we
can go ahead and say
uh
add new site
import an existing project from github
and it will uh i'm already authorized
and let's uh
find this repository
hotel inventory
select
and the branch to deploy is main
okay
and uh
it says okay if you if you are using uh
something else i mean some
if you're using monorepo this base
directory is useful right now it's not i
mean we are just uh having a single
project
then we need to provide
this plot build command here so i'll say
npm run build plot and publish directory
is something which you can get from
angular.json so if you go to the
production sorry build and here
configuration production you will find
what is that
some somehow it is not available here
but generally when you create a
production build the file goes to dst
slash your application name
so
this tst slash your
hotel inventory amp so this is where my
files will be available so i want to
publish this directory
and let's click on deploy site
and now your deployment has started
and let's see it is building you can see
the log here so it will start
deploying the application it says it is
using node version 16 which is now
available and
somehow i already have back i also have
package log file available i can remove
this if i want to we will remove it
and
and uh nutify also has this great
functionality where you can actually
play a game until unless your code is
getting deployed right so this is like
card match
you can
play
let's see uh it is taking some time
if it doesn't work we can actually
yeah it's done so build command from
netlify app and vm run build prod which
it is actually generating the bundle
right now and once this is done you will
be able to see uh a link
okay so it says
preview deploy
and you can see uh this is the master
code right i mean um we have we don't
have anything available in our master
code so this is how it looks like i mean
this is the default page which we had so
now
all our changes are actually in this
file final code folder
so what we can do is we can actually
raise a pr so i'll just do one thing
i'll just push
uh this branch
so you can see it says okay you have to
push this particular branch i mean
so i'm pushing this branch right now
let's go to the github
and let's
raise a pull request so it goes to the
final code to the fro to main let's
create a pull request
and the only thing which we have to do
is now it will fail so you can see
uh right now
i we did nothing so whenever you will
raise a pull request
it will auto
deploy it will auto deploy your changes
on netlife so this is what csd means
right so you you should be able to do
continuous integration and deployment so
you don't have to wait
till your code is merged into the main
branch to see the latest changes here we
are saying okay
as soon as you open the pull request
it will deploy it will merge and give
your temporary url so right now it is
failing because we don't have the
publish uh sorry build command
which is available here so if you
remember we
made that change in master so we can
actually go ahead and add that
particular command here and then we'll
push it again
to make it work and then we'll see how
your temporary
url looks like
right so i will say this is
move it
and
build
command
okay somehow get ad is not working right
now
so let's space changes from here and
let's push
and as soon as we do push let's go back
to
our branch
and it will try to build this code again
right so it started the build again and
once this is done it will you can see
this is the depaul deploy preview
processing so
it will give you a link once you click
on this details link it will open the
page it will open the application which
will be having a temporary url so
netlify gives a random generated url
to every application so this is our
random generated url for this
application but our preview branches
will have a different url
so let's see
it will take few minutes uh sorry few
seconds to complete this deployment
and once done we can see this code is
available i mean
the latest changes are available here
i mean once you merge it right so once
we merge the code back to the main
we'll not merge this pr so you can go
ahead and see the difference between
your master code main code which was
just uh
like
a startup or you can say start template
using angular cli and the final changes
so you can see click on deploy url and
this is this is the application which we
created right so we have this booking
form available we have this login which
was available earlier right so
admin
and we
can to admin and you can see
you have your view available here you
can just click on send message which is
available here rooms
where this message is available also so
you can see deploy preview condensing so
this is your preview branch so this is
how you can actually set up your ci cd
for using netlify
uh go ahead and deploy your application
netlife is free for open source i mean
right now i'm just going to make this as
private so
uh you you you can go ahead and get the
access to this code later on
so
in this video we will see how you can
also use utilize github action to build
your application so remember we are just
talking about building because we have
already have cicd available with
your netlife so github actions is
something which can help you to automate
the stuff
so here we what we are going to automate
is on every pull request
a new
build should be or your build should be
done right so
here we can just go to node.js we will
use node.js to build our application
and it gives you a nice template so it
says okay which branch
to
on push to this branch build on pull
request go ahead and build
which server to use so we are saying
okay we will be using ubuntu which node
version to use we will be using only 16
because we don't
want to utilize much of resources
remember for open source net uh this kit
of actions is free i i have the pro
license so it it is uh it gives me some
3000 minutes if i am not wrong 3000
minutes worth of
build time for free and then we have
this uses so it uses some github actions
to check out my code so checkout is some
term which we use in
github in git
to
copy the code and make our own version
so we check out this code and then we
use this
node version which is 16
and then we are caching
the npm version and here
we are running npm ci npm ci is
something which will install all the
node packages
so we already have let's go and check if
we have this package lock file available
yes it is available so
we can use npmci if
and package lock is not available you
can just do npm install
and then we are saying
that
in case the build command is available
just go ahead and build so we do have uh
the build command
which is
built broad so we'll copy this command
and we'll post it put it here and team
run build and we'll remove if 500
present because we know that it is
available and we will call it as uh
build dot primal and we'll start a
commit
we will create a new branch because we
want to see how github actions triggers
the changes right
and we'll say okay added
github
action to
build
and let's propose a new file
and let's create a pull request on pull
request it will start building your code
right so here let's go ahead and see
now you can see there is a new step
which is added here node.js ci and you
can click on details to see
what is happening here so you uh it
started a new job starting a new job and
it is setting up your job and it is
executing all the step which you
mentioned in that one yml file
so you don't have to become like a
devops devops expert to do this
git of action make it really easy for us
so we just need to choose right template
and then give the right commands
to
execute or to build your code base you
can also run your tests on ci so you if
if you want to run the test you can just
say npm run test and that will run your
test on your ci so you you can verify
all the changes before you go ahead and
merge your code remember netlife is good
it will
uh it will check if your build is
completed and it will give you deploy
url but what in case we want to do more
we want to run the tests we want to run
the end to end tests so github actions
can help you with those you can just run
go ahead and run that con
give those commands in sequence and it
will run all those right now it is
building the project it is saying okay
uh i am running this command ng build
type and c equals to production if this
is completed i mean it will just
complete the step and then it will give
us green signal that your code is good
too much
that's it
so this is how you can use github
actions as well very useful in case you
are like working on your site project
and you want to make sure that
everything goes fine before you merge
changes or you are collaborating on a
project with someone else and
of course
every time you cannot go ahead and
verify everything right so in case you
have tests you can actually go ahead and
verify it using github actions and it's
free for open source projects so go
ahead and utilize it